ALLEN. SHE LED A ATKINS. BATES
BELL BURGESS BRADFORD CAPPIELLO
CHAIN DALY DODD. TORONTO
GALGIANI. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO YOUR TOTAL
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCKED.
MORALE NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE
NUMBER BY KELSEY WINNER WILK.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND GUESTS BE
ON THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SYSTEM MACHEL GORMAN
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AS WE WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
FLAG. BY SENATOR PAM. LET US
CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. THE FOLLOWING POEM BY
RUMI IS DEDICATED TO THOSE WHO
SOMETIMES GET TIRED OF BEING
GOOD. PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
YOUR MAIN THOUGHT. THAT'S
SOURNESS MAY BE A BLESSING AS
AN OVERCAST DAY BRINGS RAIN ON
THE ROSES AND RELIEF TO DRY
SOIL. DON'T LOOK SO SARLI ON
YOUR SOURNESS. IT MAY BE THAT
IT'S CARRYING WAS YOU MOST
DEEPLY NEEDS AND WANTS. WHAT
SEEMS TO BE KEEPING YOU FROM
JOY MAY BE WHAT LEADS YOU TO
CHOI. DON'T CALL IT A DEAD
BRANCH CALL IT THE LIVE MOIST
ROOT. DON'T TO ALWAYS BE
WAITING TO SEE WHAT'S BEHIND IT.
THAT'S WAYS AND SEE POISONS
YOUR SPIRIT. RICH FOREST'S HOLD
YOUR MAINTENANCE TO YOUR CHEST
AS A HEALING ROUTE. AND BE
THROUGH WITH WAITING. CREATOR
OF ALL THAT IS HELP US TO KNOW
TODAY DOES YOUR DEEPEST DESIRES
ARE BEING ACCOMPLISHED IN AND
THROUGH US AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME
INSULATING OUR NATION'S FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU
SYSTEM. GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES.
BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE WE LAST
MET. THERE ARE NO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN SUBDIVISION DE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
FILE ITEM THIRTY SB TWO SIXTY
EIGHT. FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE SB
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN AND FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX SB SIX NINETY FIVE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI. MAN MAN
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO MOVE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE THAT'S FILE
ITEM SEVENTY THREE AS WELL AS
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WHICH IS
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE UPON THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU CENTER
WHITE HOUSE KEY THERE WILL BE
SO NOTED. ANY OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SEEING
NONE WE WILL GO TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
THE SECOND READING FILE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
SECOND READING FILE ASSEMBLY
BILL. FORTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE SIXTY EIGHT ELEVEN SIXTEEN
AND ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY ONE.
THE SECOND READING FILE HAS
BEEN READ UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS SENATOR WILL THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVEN COLLEAGUES
WHEREIN FILE ITEM SEVEN SENATOR
WILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF DAVID CAME AS
SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT
MISTER KIM WAS VICE PRESIDENT
OF GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS AT
HYUNDAI MOTOR COMPANY HE ALSO
SERVED AS DEPUTY ADMINISTRATOR
OF THE US DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION'S FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION HE WAS
APPROVED UNANIMOUS FIVE OVER BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
FOURTH SEPTEMBER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT BAIT OR DISCUSSION.
CENTER BATES ON THIS ITEM YES.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MEMBER
HAS AND I JUST LIKE TO. ADD MY
STRONG STRONG ENDORSEMENT OF US
MR CAM HE IS WITHOUT A DOUBT
ONE OF THE MOST QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION. A RENO THAT WE
COULD POSSIBLY HAVE OB I WOULD
CONSIDER IT AND I DON'T USUALLY
GO ON NOW. WITH ALL OF THE
ACURA WITH ALL OF THE ACCOLADES
FOR SOMEONE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL SPENT
MUCH OF HIS LIFE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION ARENA AND NOSE
Là CERTAINLY THE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE THERE SO THAT WE HAVE
BALANCED MOBILITY AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND CERTAINLY IN
THE NATION SO. HARDLY I ENDORSE
HIM AND ASK FOR A VERY STRONG I
VOTE FOR OUR NEW SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
IS YOUR MIKE UP. IT IS NOT TO
ALL RIGHT. OTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
CONFIRMATION. OF THIS
NOMINATION TODAY BUT I DO JUST
WANT TO KNOW THAT. UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT TURNED ON THE
SECRETARY IS CALTRANS AND
CALTRANS IT IS A BROKEN AGENCY
IN NEED OF DRAMATIC REFORM I
CALTRANS IS AN AGENCY THAT IN
MANY WAYS IS TILL LIVING IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES IN TERMS
OF TRANSPORTATION POLICY. AND
CALTRANS NEED TO MOVE INTO THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IN
PARTICULAR WHEN IT COMES TO
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION ON
RECOGNIZING THE MANY PEOPLE GET
AROUND NOT BY DRIVING A CAR.
BYE BYE BYE GAME OR WALKING OR
USING PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION OR
WHAT HAVE YOU CALTRANS IS NOT
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE A AGENCY
FRANKLY AT TIMES IS ACTIVELY
HOSTILE TOWARDS THE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. ANDERSON AND
THAT THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
IS INCREDIBLY IMPROPER IN AND
IT IS HARD AND WE DON'T DEVOTE
ENOUGH MONEY TO IT BUT WE HAVE
TO MOVE THIS AGENCY INTO TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND- THE
SECRETARY THIS NOMINEE WHO ALL
BE SUPPORTING TODAY. NEEDS TO
BE PART OF THAT SOLUTION. BUT I
WILL BE GOING TODAY THANKS.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS APPOINTMENT. STING HEARING
NONE CENTER WILL CAN MAKE
CLOTHES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES
AND I HARDLY ENDORSE WHAT WAS
SHARED BY MY FRIEND FROM ORANGE
COUNTY THIS IS A WELL QUALIFIED
PERSON THAT'S GONNA I THINK DO
A GREAT JOB TRANSFORMING THAT
AGENCY SO WITH THAT. AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I'LL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED
ON THIS ITEM MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES HI
BILL BY BURGESS. HI BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TADO I JACKSON HI I
JONES BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL I NIELSEN. BY
PAN. PORTANTINO HI ROTH BY
RUBIO. RUBIO HI AND I. BY STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG. OUR
CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILK HI
VICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM. SIXTY ONE
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE SENATOR
SKINNER. THIS IS THE SENATE
THIRD READING. WE ARE GOING TO
FOLLOW THIS ITEM WITH FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO SO THE NEXT AUTHOR IF
YOU'D PASS ON IT WHILE THAT'S
ON FILE AND FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO SENATOR
ALAN. NOT AT HIS DESK WE WILL
FILE OF. PASS TEMPORARILY ON
THAT ITEM AND THEN MOVED TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WE ARE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE.
SENATOR WIENER FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE. PASS ON FILE RIGHT WITH
GOD I'M GOING TO LIST THE NEXT
FIVE ITEMS THAT ARE PROPOSED TO
BE TAKEN UP TODAY UNDER
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING SO IF
YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE PLEASE BE
PREPARED FILE ITEM. SIXTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TO EIGHTY EIGHTY TWO
AND EIGHTY FOUR OF THE NEXT
FIVE ITEMS SHOP ON FILE ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT. SENATOR MCGUIRE
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM SEVENTY
TWO FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO
SENATOR TO ROSS SO ARE YOU
PREPARED ON FILE ITEMS PASS ON
FILE. PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM.
SENATOR ALLEN DO YOU WISH TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO.
ALRIGHT WE WILL GO BACK TO FOR
TWO. SENATE THIRD READING
COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL NUMBER
ONE BY SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HOUSING
PROJECTS SENATOR ALLEN MATTER
PRESENT MEMBERS I'M VERY
PLEASED TO JOIN WITH MY SEAT
MATE. AND FRIEND CENTER FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO PRESENT SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT ONE WHICH
IF PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD. PLACE THE MEASURE ON A
FUTURE STATEWIDE BALLOT ASKING
VOTERS TO REPEAL ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR OF CALIFORNIANS
CONSTITUTION IN ITS ENTIRETY.
THE PROVISION WHICH WAS PASSED
BACK IN NINETEEN FIFTY REQUIRES
MAJORITY APPROVAL BY THE VOTERS
OF A CITY OR COUNTY FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
ACQUISITION OF A PUBLICLY
FUNDED LOW RENT HOUSING PROJECT
THE MEASURE WAS A DIRECT
RESPONSE TO. THE FEDERAL
HOUSING ACT OF NINETEEN FORTY
NINE WHICH IS PART OF HARRY
TRUMAN'S FAIR DEAL. THAT SOUGHT
TO HELP POST WAR LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES MOVE OUT OF THE SLUMS
AND INTO A BETTER LIVING
SITUATIONS. SO. IT WAS A IT WAS
A- VERY PROBLEMATIC. MOVED BY
BY OUR FELLOW CITIZENS AT THE
TIME BUT THE GOLDEN STATE HAS
CHANGED A LOT SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTY OUR SOCIETY HAS HAD VERY
DIFFERENT ATTITUDES ABOUT RACE
AND ETHNICITY CLASS AND POVERTY
BUT IN ADDITION THERE ALSO A
LOT MORE TOOLS FOR FOLKS WHO
WANT TO ALTER A BLOCK PLANS FOR
NEW HOUSING THAT DID NOT EXIST
BACK IN IN NINETEEN FIFTY THERE
WAS NO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT BACK THEN THERE WAS NO
BROWN ACT THERE WAS NO COASTAL
ACT THERE ARE FAR FEWER
LAWSUITS. SO THE GAME IS
CHANGED A LITTLE BIT WITH
REGARDS TO CITIZENS RIGHTS TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT HOUSING IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS AND SO NOW
AS A RESULT ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
REALLY DOES STAND AS AN
ANACHRONISTIC CONSTITUTIONAL
BARRIER THAT SUBJECTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO A COSTLY WEBER
REGULATIONS IN ELECTIONS
DRIVING UP THE PRICE. OF
BUILDING PUBLIC ANSWER FOR THE
HOUSE. AND THE THING IS THAT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR THE
PAST FEW YEARS CALIFORNIA'S
VOTERS HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THEY
WANT US AS LEADERS. SUDDENLY TO
FIND. AND IF FOR HOUSING THERE
BEEN STATE AND LOCAL BALLOT
MEASURES UP DOWN THE STATE.
THAT HAVE DEDICATED NOW
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. TO TACKLING
OUR HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
CRISIS AND WE REALLY DO OWE IT
TO THESE TAXPAYERS AND THE
VOTERS WHO STEPPED UP. TO
SUPPORT THESE KINDS OF MEASURES
TO USE THIS MONEY AS COST
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY THE REALTORS
WHO ARE ACTUALLY BEHIND THE
ORIGINAL. YOU KNOW PUTTING THE
ARTICLE THIRTY FOR THE
CONSTITUTION BACK. IN NINETEEN
FIFTY HAVE COME ON IN SUCH
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT. OF SCA
ONE TODAY THEY RECOGNIZE THE
STATE'S CHANGE THEY RECOGNIZE.
THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
ASSIST WITH BUILDING HOUSING.
AND THEY ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
REALLY ARE GOING TOWARD. THE
CONSTRUCTION HOUSING AND NOT. I
ENDING UP IN IN UNNECESSARY
FIGHTS. SO VOTE FOR THIS IS IN
IN SUPPORT. OF GIVING VOTER
PARTICULARLY TO THE KNOBS. OUR
CONSTITUTION CURRENTLY
UNDERMINE BELIEVER THEIR THEIR
ELECTED LEADERSHIP. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S ACUTE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. CHALLENGES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. JOINT AUTHOR WITH THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA MONICA AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT IN FINALLY
REPEALING. AND DELETING ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. JUST TO BE VERY
BLUNT ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR IS A
SCAR ON THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION IT IS THIS CAR ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS
MORTIFYING. THAT WE HAVE THIS
PROVISION IN OUR CONSTITUTION
AND WE NEED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR DUDS.
IT TAKES ONE CLASS OF HOUSING.
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
AND SAYS THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
DOT HOUSING CAN BE APPROVED IF
IT AS ANY PUBLIC FUNDING AND
IT. IS TO GO TO A VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE. NO OTHER OF HOUSING IS
SUBJECT TO THAT REQUIREMENT
ONLY. SUBSIDIZED HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT THAT IS
OUTRAGEOUS AND IT SENDS A VERY
VERY CLEAR SIGNAL. THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE IT HARD. THE CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO MAKE IT HARD. TO PUT
LOW INCOME HOUSING HOUSING FOR
OUR RESIDENTS MOST IN NEED OF
HOUSING IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA PUT THIS
GIGANTIC ROADBLOCK. IN FRONT OF
THAT HOUSING FOR OUR LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORS BUT NOT IN FRONT OF
ANY OTHER KIND OF HOUSING. IT
IS OUTRAGEOUS THAT THIS WAS
EVER PLACED INTO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION IT SOUNDED VERY
CLEAR SIGNAL THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE ECONOMICALLY DIVERSE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND IT IS LONG
PAST TIME TO REMOVE TO EXCISE
THIS CAR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR NEEDS TO GO. WE SHOULD
SEND THIS TO THE VOTERS AND
FINALLY MOVE FORWARD TO A
BRIGHTER HOUSING FUTURE WHERE
EVERYONE CAN HAVE HOUSING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED
MORE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS. AND THIS WILL
HELP US DO THAT I HEARD AND I
GO. CENTER WINNER CENTER DOLLY.
DO YOU THAT A PRESIDENT TO
QUESTION THE AUTHOR. WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION THAT FROM
FROM MY GOOD FRIEND ABSOLUTELY.
ONLY PLEASE PROCEED REALLY TO
ASK A QUESTION BUT I WANTED TO
SO IS IT PURELY JUST GONNA AT
REPEAL AND THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE
ANYTHING ELSE ON THE BALLOT
THAT ADDS ANY OTHER DIFFERENT
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WOULD BE A CONCERN
FOR ME. IF YOU WERE GONNA ADD
OTHER LANGUAGE I THINK THE
REPEAL IS A GREAT AYE. BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
LAST REPEALING THAT I WE'RE NOT
PUTTING SOMETHING ELSE IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT. REPLACES IT
WITH. SOME OTHER STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE I LIKE TO LAUGH IT
ALWAYS BE WHERE WHEN. WHEN AN
AUTHOR BECAUSE THEIR BILL
SIMPLE. BUT I WILL SAY THIS IS
REALLY A SIMPLE IT IS AS SIMPLE
AS THAT IT REPEAL THAT
PARTICULAR ARTICLE. FROM THE
CONSTITUTION. AND. AND I DON'T
I THINK IT'S ONE REASON WHY
THERE IS LITTLE YOU KNOW LISTEN
OPPOSITION AND THE SUPPORT IS
SUCH AN INCREDIBLE RANGE OF
PERSPECTIVES FROM. LEFT TO
RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY
HAS COME TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
NEEDS TO BE REPEALED. THANK YOU
SENATOR BILL. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SAW I STAND IN FAVOR OF
THIS CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT OF
WHEN I WHEN I WAS A STUDENT
STARTING URBAN PLANNING I
ACTUALLY STUDIED ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR AND WHEN IT WAS ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED THIS IS. ON OUR CORE-WAS PUT ON THE BALLOT IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES NINETEEN FIFTY
CORRECT AND IT WAS PUT ON THE
BALLOT SO TOTALLY BASED ON
RACIAL PREJUDICE. THIS IS A
RACIST BALLOT MEASURE WE SHOULD
ELIMINATE THIS. FROM THE STATE
CONSTITUTION. AND I URGE
SUPPORT FOR THIS. THE ONLY
REASON THIS ARTICLE WAS ON THE
BALLOT IS BECAUSE OF RACIAL
PREJUDICE WE HAVE TO LAMINATE
THIS FROM THE STATE
CONSTITUTION OURS AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR ALLEN YOU MAY
CLOSE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES AND YOU DO
REASSURED MY FRIEND FROM
NORTHEAST FORCE IN THE STATE
THAT THAT THIS IS AS SIMPLE AS
IT IS IT IS REPEALING THIS
THIS. ARTICLE THERE'S NOTHING
MORE THAN THAT EIGHT TRULY IS
AN ANACHRONISTIC PIECE OF OUR
CONSTITUTION I THINK
EVERYBODY'S COME TO RECOGNIZE
THAT. AND I REALLY DO ASK FOR
YOUR YOUR SUPPORT FOR PUTTING
US ON THE BALLOT IN GIVING. OUR
VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THIS ANACHRONISM. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALLEN ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ARE AS THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING NOW ON TO. A OR
BACK I SHOULD SAY TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE
STOPPED I BELIEVE AT FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR SENATOR SKINNER YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE SIDE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA RELATING
TO THE POLITICAL FORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB TWO TWENTY.
REMOVES THE BERRIER FOR ANYONE
WHO IS RUNNING FOR ELECTED
OFFICE TO ENABLE THEM. TO USE
THEIR CAMPAIGNS FUNDS TO COVER
CHILD CARE EXPENSES INCURRED AS
A RESULT OF THEIR CAMPAIGNING
ANYONE WHO CURRENTLY TRIES TO
USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
CHILDCARE THESIS RISK AND
UNCERTAINTY RELYING ON A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD INFORMAL ADVICE
LETTER BY THE F. PPC THE BILL
OFFERS EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO
SEE CONSERVING PUBLIC OFF
OFFICE THE OPPORTUNITY CAMPAIGN
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WILL RUN A FIVE
ALL OF OUR STATE. CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAWS. ISN'T SUPPORT AND
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR. SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I'M CENTER RISE BRIEFLY
TO I'LL BE VOTING NO ON THIS
AND JUST WANT TO GIVE A QUICK
EXPLANATION THAT THERE ARE SOME
SITUATIONS NOW IN CONGRESS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THEIR CAMPAIGN
FUNDS AND. THIS CONCERN THAT
THE THAT THIS MIGHT APPLY HERE
AS WELL AND SO I'LL BE VOTING
NO TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SENATOR MORALE YEAH
I A RISE ALSO JUST A QUICK
EXPLANATION I IT IT IT IT. HAS
I THINK BAD OPTICS IT LOOKS
LIKE ANOTHER PERK FOR
POLITICIANS AND SELL. I JUST
CAN'T GO THERE LIVE KIDS BUT I
THINK IF ARE GOOD PEOPLE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE GIVEN US MONEY
WE SHOULD BE USING I'M STRICTLY
ON CAMPAIGNS SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ. I JUST WANNA RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM I KNOW
THAT AS A MOTHER MYSELF WHO RAN
A CAMPAIGN JUST RECENTLY WITH
THE FOUR YEAR OLD CHILD
ALTHOUGH I DIDN'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THEN TO USE
CAMPAIGN FUNDS I THINK WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT THIS POSITIVELY THAT
ALLOWS MORE PARENTS TO BE
ELECTED AND IT PROVIDES MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE IN
OFFICE AND ESPECIALLY GETTING
MORE MOM SELECTED WHICH IS WHAT
WE NEED SO I THINK YOU FOR
MANAGING THIS AND- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLINGER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT I SAW THIS
BILL IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY. AND
IT BOILED DOWN TO THIS FOR ME.
LOOK WE ARE IT IS TRANSPARENT
YOU INTO THE F. PPC. YOU CAN
SEE WHERE YOU SPENT THE MONEY
IT'S NOT. IT'S ABOUT IT BEING
GIVEN A PARENT THE OPPORTUNITY.
TAXI RUN FOR OFFICE. AND WHILE
YOU'RE RUNNING. BEE SEMI THEY
CAN WATCH YOUR CHILDREN I THINK
THIS IS GOOD FOR FAMILIES I
THINK IT'S GOOD FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY. AND I THINK IT IS
TRANSPARENT I THINK IT SHOWS
WHERE THE MONEY'S GOING LOOK IF
YOU'RE- CAN YOUR DONORS. DON'T
APPROVE OF YOU SPENT ON SOCCER
THEY WON'T GIVE YOU THE MONEY.
I THINK IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE CHILDREN.
TO ACTUALLY RUN FOR OFFICE AND
I THINK THAT WOULD BE GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWENTY AS A
SINGLE WORKING WOMAN WHO DID
USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
CHILDCARE AS A CANDIDATE TEN
YEARS AGO THE REPORTING AGENCY
HAD A LETTER ON FILE THAT GAVE
PERMISSION BUT THAT THERE WERE
PRIMARILY WOMEN CANDIDATES WHO
WERE SCARED TO CHALLENGE THAT
THEY DID WANT TO TAKE A RISK.
AND SOMETIMES YOU BACKS AGAINST
THE WALL YOU HAVE TO TAKE A
RISK AND I USE THEM ALL
EXPLAINED IT TO MY DONORS CAN
FEEL IT WAS A COMPLETELY
APPROPRIATE EXPENSE. I'M NOT
SURE WHAT PARKS ON SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES PERCEIVE ABOUT THESE
JOBS I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
REST OF YOU BUT- LAST TIME I
CHECKED WE DON'T GET PENSIONS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE REST OF
YOU BUT I TOOK A 50% PAY CUT
FOR THE PLAY A PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING MY CONSTITUENTS. AND SO
I THINK THIS IS REASONABLE IT'S
TRANSPARENT IT'S FAIR AND AS A
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS NOTION SO
WE CAN. HOPEFULLY AT SOME POINT
IN THE FUTURE REACH PARITY AS
WE ARE IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION BUT WE CAN REACH
PARITY IN ELECTED OFFICE AND SO
I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT. AS
IN A STANDING EXAMPLE OF THE
DENTIST AS A BENEFICIARY OF
WHAT AB TWO TWENTY IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SENATOR SKINNER
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU THE I.
DISCUSSION SO FAR IN THE FLOOR
AS ALWAYS IS VERY ILLUMINATING
THIS MEASURE BENEFITS ALL
PARENTS THOUGH LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES AND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH I
THINK THAT OUR MOTHERS ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED. BY
TRYING TO JUGGLE THE BURDENS OF
THINGS LIKE CHILDCARE THEIR
WORK AND ALL OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES WHEN THEY'RE
ALSO TRYING TO RUN FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE AND UNDER OUR CAMPAIGN
FINANCE RULES THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ALLOWABLE EXPENSES
THAT ARE EXPECTED UNDER THE
NORMAL COURSE OF THE CAMPAIGN
WELL CERTAINLY A DOZEN COPPER
ONES LIVING COSTS. THERE ARE
TRAVEL AND OTHER EXPENSES THAT
ARE ALLOWED AND SO GIVEN THAT.
ANY CANDIDATE. IS OBVIOUSLY HAS
NEW OR MORE RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR BEING OUT AND ABOUT IN THE
PUBLIC WHEN THEY ARE
CAMPAIGNING THUS NEEDING IF
THEY HAVE CHILDREN TO NEED
CHILDCARE IT JUST MAKES SENSE
FOR US TO INCLUDE THIS IN ONE
OF THE ALLOWED EXPENSES IT IS
NOT A PERK AND WITH THAT I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE. I'M SORRY WELL CLOSE WE
HAVE HAD A CLOSE WHAT FOR WHAT
PURPOSE TO RISE SIR. I WAS IS
BECOME THE BILL WELL WE'VE
ALREADY HAD THE CLOSURE OKAY ON
THE BILL I DON'T THINK I SAW IT
WAS UP AYE AYE BY WILL LOOK
MORE CAREFULLY IN THE FUTURE
BUT I BELIEVE WE HAD INVITED
THE SENATOR TO CLOSE. AND ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. OF MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS
BATES. BELL I PORGES HI. I
CABALLERO. I CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO
I JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. HI MONNING
HI MORE LUCK WELL NO NIELSEN. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER. IOWA CASKEY BY
WINNER BY WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS BATES.
GROVE MORE LOCK HI. ICE THIRTY
FORD KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES A COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
AND EIGHTY TWO OF FILE ITEM
EIGHTY WAS A MEASURE THAT WAS
PASSED SENATOR JONES WE PASSED
THIS PREVIOUSLY WHEN YOU WERE
NOT AT YOUR DESK ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS ITEM.
YES IT IS VERY GOOD FILE ITEM
EIGHTY COLLEAGUES MISTER SECTOR
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND
HALF REALLY DARK COLORED
BEVERAGES. SENATOR JONES. MADAM
PRESIDENT I WILL MAKE THIS
PRESENTATION VERY QUICK. I AM
PRESENTING AB THIRTEEN OH WAIT
FOR A CINNAMON CUNNINGHAM IT'S
A GREAT BILL ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT THE BILL IS. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS.
EIGHT HI BILL I PORSCHES ARE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG BY DALY AYE DODD AYE
DRAWS AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO HI. JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONEY I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL. HI NELSON USUALLY JUST
GIVE AYE PAN. AYE PORTANTINO.
IF YOU NEED ROTH. I RUBIO.
SKINNER IN THE NEXT ROOM I
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR
COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS. GROVE
PORTANTINO. RUBIO. HIGHS THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO SENATOR
DORADO ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP THAT ITEM. PASS ON FILE.
ALRIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
NEXT FIVE ITEMS FILE ITEMS.
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE NINETY
TO NINETY FIVE AND NINETY SEVEN
FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT. CENTER
MCGUIRE ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT.
PASS TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR LEYVA.
SENATOR LEYVA ARE YOU PREPARED
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM
NINETY TWO SENATOR WILK. PASS
ON FILE FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE
THE SENATOR MCGUIRE IS JUST
ANOTHER PASS TEMPORARILY ALL
RIGHT. AND FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN. SENATOR ARCHULETA.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A WINNER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AN
ACT RELATING TO VETERANS
CEMETERIES SENATOR ARCHER
LETTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY IS AN A. B. THREE
SIX EIGHT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
AND AS CHAIR THE VETERANS
COMMITTEE I'M SO PROUD TO
PRESENT THIS MYSELF THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE
INVOLUNTARY COLLABORATION WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES IN IN
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE TO DEVELOP
CONSTRUCT ANY QUICK A STATE
OWNED AND STATE OPERATED
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY. TO BE LOCATED AT THE
FORMER MARINE CORPS AIR BASE EL
TORO CALIFORNIA. THIS HAS BEEN
A LONG LONG HARD EFFORT. FOR SO
MANY FOR SO MANY YEARS AND I'M
PRO SO PROUD TO PRESENT THIS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR THEY WERE
FINALLY TAKING ACTION TO GIVE
OUR VETERANS A FINAL RESTING
PLACE. THAT THEY DESERVE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOSING OUR LAST OF THE
WORLD WAR TWO VETERANS. AND IT
IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT
PRUDENTLY AND SWIFTLY TO ENSURE
WE HAVE A FITTING PLACE FOR THE
TWO AND TURN THEM. THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR TO CITE STUDIES FOR
CONSIDERATION THE ARTIST SITE.
AND THE FORMER KNOWN AS A GOLF
COURSE SITE. BOTH ARE LOCATED
ON THE FORMER EL TORO MARINE
BASE AND BOTH ARE LOCATED ON
WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE PROVIDE
GREAT PARK. IT WILL BE UP TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS TO EVALUATE WHICH OF
THE TWO SIDES IS MOST VIABLE
AND WHICH WOULD BE THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE AND WILL MEET
THE TIME LINES. TO BE
COMPETITIVE. WE OWE IT TO OUR
VETERANS TO FINALLY PUT THIS
MATTER TO REST AND I SIMPLY
ASKED. I VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR OF THE
VETERANS COMMITTEE THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN QUITE CONTENTIOUS
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEBATE
LOCALLY HAS BEEN INFECTED WITH
INVECTIVE BUT I APPRECIATE
CENTER ARE TO LET AS DILIGENCE
HIS DETERMINATION TO ENSURE
THAT WE DO HAVE A VETERANS
CEMETERY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IT IS SORELY NEEDED AND I WANT
TO AGAIN THANK AND CONGRATULATE
YOU FOR ALL YOUR EFFORTS AND I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG SENATOR MORE
LOCK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES IN SUCH A
HIGHLY POPULATED AREA AS ORANGE
COUNTY ARE VETERANS. SHOULD
HAVE A LOCAL CEMETERY. LOS
ANGELES IS FULL. SAN DIEGO IN
RIVERSIDE OUR DISTANCE. THE
FORMER EL TORO MARINE AIR
STATION IS A GOOD LOCATION DUE
TO ITS MILITARY HISTORY HOWEVER
IT'S NOT THE OPTIMUM LOCATION.
THE ORANGE COUNTY CEMETERY
DISTRICT HAS JUST RECEIVED A
WONDERFUL SITES IN THE NEARBY
ANAHEIM HILLS AREA. A FORMER
IRVINE COMPANY LANDED IN THE
SANTA ANA MOUNTAINS. BEAUTIFUL
SITE AND THIS BILL SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT ALL THREE SITES NOT
JUST TO. THE ORANGE COUNTY
CEMETERY DISTRICT WOULD HAVE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AN ADEQUATE
SPACE WITH THE CIVILIAN
COMPONENT FOR RELATIVES OF
VETERANS TO BE LAID TO REST
NEARBY. NOW FOR THE TWO OPTIONS
THAT ARE BEFORE YOU THE AMENDED
AND RESTATED DEVELOPED
AGREEMENT SITE ARE TO. AND THE
GOLF COURSE SITE. SINCE THE
VETERANS ONE A PLACE. THE GOLF
COURSE SITE IS THE MOST
ACHIEVABLE PERMITS COST
STANDPOINT IT'S COLLEAGUES A
BIRD IN THE HAND BUT IT WILL BE
MANAGED BY CALVET A DEPARTMENT
THAT IN YOUR SEVERE BUDGET.
CUTS DURING RECESSIONS. THIS
BILL IS ALSO MENTIONED AS A
POLITICAL FOOTBALL. A GOLF
COURSE FIGHT IS PREFERRED BUT
FORCES WANT THE ARTIST SITE SO
HERE WE ARE THIS BILL REMAINS
IN FLUX EITHER WE PUT UP WE
EITHER JUST TO THE STUDY ON THE
GOLF COURSE SITE. OR MAKE IT TO
YOUR BILL OR WE ADD A THIRD
SITE DO JUSTICE FOR ALL THE
ALTERNATIVES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU A CENTER
MORLOCK ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
ARCHULETA YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH THE FACT THAT. IT
HAS BEEN A MULTITUDE OF YEARS
THAT THIS STUDY HAS BEEN GOING
ON. IT IS NOT AN OVERNIGHT
THING THE TWO SIDES HAVE BEEN
LOOKED AT I PERSONALLY HAVE
BEEN THERE. MEMBERS OF MY A
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN THERE I
HAVE MET WITH THE CITY COUNCIL.
EVERYONE HAS LOOKED AT THE TWO
SIDES AND THIS IS WHERE IT'S AT
LAYS THEY WILL DECIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY BETTER
TO FAIRS. WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
IT WHEN THEY FINISH THEIR STUDY
THEN THE DECISION WILL BE MADE
SO THIS WILL TAKE US FORWARD.
TO I APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED ON THE
SIDE OF MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. BELL
FIVE LARGEST BY BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG I DALY AYE
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
TACO. JACKSON HI I JONES. LEYVA.
I'M MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MOORLACH MORALE
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER OUR
COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK.
SENATOR ARCHULETA MOVES A CALL
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO ON TO OUR
NEXT FIVE ITEMS. NINETY EIGHT
ONE OH THREE ONE OH SIX ONE
ELEVEN EXCUSE ME WHICH HOSTED
NO. A ONE ELEVEN AND ONE TWELVE
SO FILE ITEMS. NINETY EIGHT ONE
OH THREE ONE OH SIX ONE ELEVEN
AND ONE TWELVE FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT. SENATOR MCGUIRE. PASS
TEMPORARILY. FILE ITEM ONE OH
THREE. SENATOR BATES DO YOU
WISH TO TAKE UP THIS ITEM
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
AND ACT REALLY TO PUBLIC
TRANSIT SENATOR BATES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SIGN
INTRODUCING OFFER DISCUSSION AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY IT WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TO
CONSULT WITH PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATORS TO ASSESS THE
PROCEDURES AND ADMINISTRATION
OF RIDE SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL. AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IT
CAN TAKE NEARLY A MONTH BEFORE
A PERSON WITH A DISABILITY CAN
USE AND AGENCIES PARA TRANSIT
SERVICE WHEN CONSIDERING THE
ENTIRETY OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS MOREOVER THE PROCESS
CAN BE STRENUOUS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
WHO NEED A RIDE IN A
JURISDICTION OUTSIDE OF THEIR
REGIONALLY APPROVED SERVICE
AREA FOR EXAMPLE IF AN
INDIVIDUAL WAS DEEMED ELIGIBLE
FOR SERVICE IN SACRAMENTO.
VISITING THE LOS ANGELES AREA
SERVICE AREA THEY WOULD HAVE TO
GO THROUGH A LENGTHY PROCESS TO
PROVE THEIR ELIGIBILITY THE
BILL INITIALLY IT'S A HOLISTIC
REVIEW TO IDENTIFY GAPS IN THE
DIALER RIDE IN A TRANSPOSITION
WHICH WILL STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
PHYSICAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
ABILITIES USE THE FREE LEE HAS
I PART IN SUPPORT IN RECEIVED
ZERO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. AYE VOTE YOU SENATOR.
DEBATE. HI BILL I PURCHASED BY
BRADFORD I KELLY AT ALL I
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD. AYE
DORADO AYE GALGIANI. AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. I HILL
AYE HUESO BUYER TADO. JACKSON I
JONES BY LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL BY MONEY BY MORE LOCK
I'M REAL. AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK BY SENATOR
BATES MOVES TO CALL WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK COLLEAGUES TO FILE
ITEM OF ONE A ONE FOUR SENATOR
HERTZBERG FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLANS SENATOR HERTZBERG
COLLEAGUES SHIFT CONVERSATIONS
NEED TO BE HAD PLEASE TRY TO
TAKE THEM TO THE BACK OF THE
ROOM. CENTER HERTZBERG FLOOR IS
YOURS. GIVEN THE PRESIDENT THIS
LEGISLATURE IN MANY DEPARTMENTS
OF OUR GOVERNMENT HAVE. BEEN
DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
FIND AS MANY INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES TO CONTAIN THE
SKYROCKETING HEALTHCARE COSTS
IT HAS BEEN A GIGANTIC PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
OUR ARMS AROUND THIS MEASURE
TODAY SETS UP TO NEW PILOT
PROGRAMS TRYING TO. ATTACK THAT
ISSUE IN THE MOST INTELLIGENT
WAY POSSIBLE ONE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ONE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO OPERATE FOR A
PERIOD OF FIVE YEARS. THESE
PILOTS WOULD INCLUDE RISK
BEARING PROVIDERS OF THAT ARE
MONITORED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED CARE FOR FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY OPERATION
EFFECTIVENESS THEY WOULD BE
SELF FUNDED EMPLOYER PLANS
WOULD UTILIZE RICH BASS OR
CAPITATED PAYMENT MECHANISMS
WITH THE HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
FOR THEIR SERVICES RATHER THAN
PURE. FEE FOR SERVICE
COMPENSATION DOES IT WORK WHO
KNOWS IS IT WORTH A SHOT
ABSOLUTELY IF IT DOES THEIR
PILOT PROJECTS I ASK YOUR RIVAL.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE A
ONE. SENATOR PAN. I THANK YOU
ADDRESS A CENTERS I TO RISE AND
SUPPORT OF THE THIS BILL I KNOW
THAT WHEN THINGS IT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN IT CAME TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE IS THAT WE
WANT TO BE SURE WE PUT IN.
MEASURES TO. PROTECT THE PEOPLE
ARE BEING COVERED BECAUSE SAYS
BUT THIS IS AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH THAT HOPEFULLY WILL
BEAR FRUIT IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO. CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
TO. ELEVATE IN TERMS OF COSTS
THEY KEEP CARE MANAGEMENT AND
SO FORTH OF BY HAVING THEM WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE EMPLOYERS AND
INCLUDING THE UNION TRUSTS THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THIS. SO
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RESULTS OF THIS. THIS EFFORT
AND RESPECT YES WHEN I BUT. ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES BELL
FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD HI BY
CARRIER. I CHIANG NO DALLY.
DODD I DORADO. GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE DORADO. HI GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO. HIGHER TITLE
JACKSON HI I JONES NO LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL. MONEY
HI MORE LOCK MORALE. NO NIELSEN
NO PAN. HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
I RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN AYE
STONE. BY. NUMBER FIVE A COUNTY
BY WINNER BY WILK. BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG MOVES A CALL MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OH SIX
SENATOR MITCHELL. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ BUT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NO TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US AN
ACT RELATING TO HOMELESSNESS
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT A MEANS OF
SEVENTEEN ELVES TO. SHAKE
STANDS ON A BILL I HAVE THE
HONOR OF CARRYING A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO THIRTEEN EIGHTY WHICH
CREATED THE HOMELESS
COORDINATED AND FINANCING
COUNCIL WE BASE IT ON. A MODEL
THAT WE DISCOVERED ON IN THE
STATE OF UTAH. THE POINT OF THE
COUNCIL'S OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING FIRST
GUIDELINES AND IDENTIFY AND
COORDINATE STATE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE. I
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE RECEIVE
INFORMATION FROM THE CAPITAL
THAT WILL ALLOW THE STATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW POICIES
AND PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE
STREAMLINED. TO RESPOND TO THIS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AS A RESULT
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
COUNCIL TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT THE REPORT. ON
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT WE
SHOULD CONSIDER TO STREAMLINE
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICES AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IT HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
CERTAINLY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM ONE OH SIX SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES HI BILL.
HI ARCHULETA BY GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD. BY CARRIER I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD I DRAWS SO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. HI TADO JACKSON HI HI
JONES. HI LEYVA BY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. I MONEY I'M MORE LOCK
I AM A REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG HI MY COUNTY I
WINNER. BY WILK HI SENATOR
MITCHELL MOVES A CALL WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ONE ELEVEN AND MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEMS. ONE THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN. FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN. SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU
PREPARED. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
IMPLEMENT. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE EIGHTY NINE.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS ANY
EMPLOYER FROM AN IMPOSING
PENALTIES FOR WITHHOLDING AND
EMPLOYEES LEGAL DOCUMENTATION.
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE IS A
PRACTICE OF AN EMPLOYER
WITHHOLDING A WORKERS
IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS FOR
PURPOSES OF MANIPULATING THE
EMPLOYEE THIS INCLUDES BUT NOT
LIMITED TO WITHHOLDING THEIR
PASSPORTS IDENTIFICATION CARD
OR WORKS WORKER PERMIT. THIS
BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A WORKERS
BILL OF RIGHTS REGARDING
FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT AND PAYMENT
OF WAGES. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
URBAN INSTITUTE STUDY FOUND
THAT MANY VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING WERE SUBJECT TO A
VARIETY OF PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL TACTICS MEANT TO
CONTROL AND ENSLAVE THE VICTIMS
INCLUDING THE USE OF DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE ACCORDING TO
STATISTICS BY THE US NATIONAL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HOTLINE.
CALIFORNIA HAD APPROXIMATELY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED REPORTED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAVE THE
MOST REPORTED CASES THAN ANY
OTHER STATE WITH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF LABOR TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS BEING IMMIGRANTS IT IS
VITAL THAT CALIFORNIA PROTECT
THESE WORKERS. THE WORKER BILL
OF RIGHTS LATE IN THIS BILL
THAT IT IS EXTREMELY VALUABLE
BECAUSE INFORMS THE WORKERS OF
THEIR RIGHTS IN THEIR LANGUAGE
AND THAT'S BETTER PREVENT
THEMSELVES FROM BECOMING
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE WOULD BE
ANOTHER TOOL FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYSAND CITY ATTORNEYS TO
USE. TO COMBAT UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS WHO SEEK TO BENEFIT
FROM WITHHOLDING THEIR
EMPLOYEES IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR YOUR
RIFLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES NOBEL I PURCHASED
BRADFORD I CABALLERO HI CHIANG.
DELHI NO DODD. HI DORADO AYE
GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROW HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO I TADO JACKSON HI I JONES.
NO LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LARK. HIGH MORALE. NO NIELSEN
NO PAN HI MOORLACH. I DON'T
KNOW. PORTANTINO BY ROTH. RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN. I STONE NO
BURKE. OUR COUNTY OUR WINNER HI
WILK HI. SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FOURTEEN SENATOR CAFIERO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN
ACT RELATING TO CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWO NINETY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ ATTACKS KNOWN AS
GASSING WERE IN INMATE ASSAULTS
ANOTHER PERSON WITH A BODILY
FLUID OCCURS MUCH TOO OFTEN
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES.
GASSING ATTACKS ARE DANGEROUS
AND CAN EXPOSE THE VICTIM
EMPLOYEE TO A COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE AND CAN CAUSE
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA AB TWO
NINETY FOUR CO DEFIES
RECOMMENDATIONS PUT FORWARD BY
THE STATE AUDITOR THERE WILL
PROVIDE CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
STAFF WITH ADVOCATE ADEQUATE
TRAINING TO MITIGATE THE HARMS
OF THESE ATTACKS. LONG PORT
EMPLOYEE HEALTH PERMISSION AND
ENTITLEMENT. THE MEN AND IN
THAT WORK IN OUR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES WORK HARD TO
SAFEGUARD OUR COMMUNITY EVERY
DAY WE MUST DO WHAT WE CAN TO
KEEP THEM IN GOOD HEALTH I
THINK YOU AND ESPECIALLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
EIGHT FIVE BILL. I PURCHASED BY
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG.
I DALY AYE DODD. I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO
JACKSON BY JONES. JONES I LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL. HI
MONEY BY MORE LUCK I'M A REAL.
I NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK
HI SENATOR CAFIERO MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
SENATOR MONNING ARE YOU
PREPARED TO BRING UP FILE ITEM.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
SENATOR BRADFORD. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ NOT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN HUNDRED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AN ACT
RELATING TO DISCOVERY SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED IS
A MEASURE THAT WILL HELP ENSURE
GREATER ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
BY ALIGNING PITCHES MOTIONS
TIME LINES WERE REGULAR
CRIMINAL DISCOVERY NOTICE
TIMELINE SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD
REDUCE THE TIME PERIOD OF
PITCHES DISCOVERY MOTION FROM
SIXTEEN DAYS THE NOTICE BEARD
FOR DISCOVERY MOTIONS TO TEN
DAYS IN CRIMINAL CASES. IN
DOING SO THIS WILL HELP BOUNCER
RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS WITH THE
RIGHT OF A SPEEDY TRIAL
SECONDLY IT WOULD ALLOW RICHEST
TEENS TO BE FILED FOR RECORDS
OF SUPER ZORI OVER RECORDS. IN
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES. IT IS
PRUDENT TO THE DEFENDANT'S
RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN AND SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY WHICH REMOVED OPPOSITION
FROM PORAC. POLICE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
IN THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AS A
RESULT WE'VE OT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE. TOM BY
MAKING THESE MODEST CHANGES
CALIFORNIA CAN MAKE PITCHES
PROCEDURES WHAT SUPPORTERS TIME
AND THE TIME CONSUMING WHILE
INCREASING FAIRNESS IN CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. OUR DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS FOR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
HI ARCHULETA. NO ATKINS BATES.
NO DEL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO. JANE NO DOLLY DODD.
BY DORADO BY GALGIANI. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TACO
JACKSON BY JONES. NO LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL AYE MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK TIME REAL. NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH I RUBIO. SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER OUR
COUNTY. WIENER BY WILK HI.
CENTER BRADFORD MOVES OF CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN CENTER ARCHULETA ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN. PASS ON
FILE WE'RE NOW MOVING TO THE
FOLLOWING FIVE ITEMS COLLEAGUES
IF YOU WOULD BE PREPARED WHEN
THEY ARE CALLED FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTEEN ONE TWENTY. ONE TWENTY
ONE ONE TWENTY THREE AND ONE
TWENTY EIGHT IF YOU WERE ONE OF
THOSE PLEASE BE PREPARED TO
TAKE UP YOUR ITEM AT THAT TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO GO NOW TO FILE
ITEM IN EIGHTEEN SENATOR RUBIO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OR NINE BY
A SEVEN MEMBER NECESSARY IN AN
ACT RELATING TO INSURANCE
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU UP
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB TWELVE OH NINE THIS BILL
PROHIBITS INSURERS FROM USING
RATE SCHEDULES BASED ON
ATTAINED AGE WHEN OFFERING LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE POLICY. AND
LIFE INSURANCE POLICIES THAT
PROVIDE LONG TERM CARE BENEFITS
THE AMENDMENTS MAKE CLARIFYING
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO POLICY
LOANS AND WITHDRAWALS AND
REPLACE THE MANDATORY OFFER OF
A NO LAPSE GUARANTEED WITH A
DISCLOSURE TO INFORM CONSUMERS.
OF THE STRESS AND OTHER
AVAILABLE OPTIONS THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. BELL BY PORGES. BRADFORD
BY CARRIER I CHIANG. BY DAILY
BY DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ BY GROW IT'S
BURKE. I HILL I WITH SO. HIGHER
TITLE JACKSON HI JONES. LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK MORALE. I
NIELSEN. BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. I AM BURKE OUR
CASKEY. WIENER I WILK HI.
TWENTY MILLION DEAL SENATOR
RUBIO MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SENATOR MITCHELL. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL A FORTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THE MON AN
ACT RELATING TO CHILD NUTRITION.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MON A. B.
EIGHT FOUR TWO LOW INCOME
CHILDREN ATTENDING PUBLIC
SCHOOL WHO HAVEN'T REACH
KINDERGARTEN REMAIN THE ONLY
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS NOT
GUARANTEED ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS
AFFORDABLE MEAL HOW COULD THAT
BE YOU MAY SAY BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE REGULATIONS
WERE DEVELOPED THAT CREATED
ACCESS TO A FREE OR LOW COST
MEALS. EACH DAY FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS AS ALL OF THE
SNOW ON AS A RESULT FROM
RESEARCH DONE BY THE NUTRITION
POLICY INSTITUTE WE ESTIMATE
THAT ABOUT 15% OF CALIFORNIA
STATE CALIFORNIA'S PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
SERVING MEALS WE NOW THAT WE
CANNOT ALLOW CHILDREN TO GO
HUNGRY. WE EXPECT THEM TO AB
SCHOOL READY AND TO SUCCEED NOW
I SAID IT WE WANT TO EXPAND THE
EXISTING K. THROUGH TWELVE
PROGRAM THE PICK UP PRE SCHOOL
STUDENTS WERE ON SCHOOL SITES
GUARANTEE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO AT LEAST ONE FREE OR LOW
COST MILITARY. I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS BATES SO GIVE ME THOSE
THREE REASONS HI BILL. I
PURCHASED AYE BRADFORD. AYE
KALLIO. I CHIANG BY DALY AYE
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI BY
THE WAY GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW HERTZBERG A LOT OF OPTIONS
HI HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO.
JACKSON HI BY JONES I MEAN I
LIVE A- BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY HI MORE LOCK I'M RAIL.
BY NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI HI ROB. I RUBIO
I SKINNER. SKINNER BY STERN AYE
STONE. BY AMBERG OUR CASKEY.
WIENER BY WILK. OKAY SENATOR
ROUTE EXCUSE ME SENATOR
MITCHELL MOVES A CALL MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE.
SENATOR MITCHELL YOU PREPARED
TO TAKE UP THE SIDE OF THAT I
AM MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL A SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER CARE.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF
THE US OF THE MORASS OPPOSITE
AB EIGHT SIX FIVE A BILL WHICH
EXPANDS TRAINING PROVIDED TO
FOSTER YOU FAMILIES TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON COMMERCIAL AND
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION THE F. B.
I. CURRENTLY ESTIMATES THAT
THERE ARE OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILD VICTIMS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING ANNUALLY. AND
FOSTER YOUTH MAKE UP 60% OF
THESE VICTIMS THE REST OF THE
POPULATION IS CLEAR BUT CARE
GIVERS WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THESE YOUTH ARE NOT PROVIDED
WITH PROPER TRAINING TO BETTER
PROTECT IN SUPPORT THIS
POPULATION THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THESE CONCERNS BY PROVIDING
RESOURCE FAMILIES WITH THE
EDUCATION NEEDED. TO UNDERSTAND
HOW TO PROPERLY CARE FOR. THE
INTERESTS OF COMPASSIONATE
APPROPRIATE MANNER I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL. GORGEOUS AYE BRADFORD AYE
KALLIO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD. HI DORADO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO JACKSON. I JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK.
MORALE I NIELSEN. BY PAN BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG OUR COUNTY. WIENER
HI WILK. SENATOR MITCHELL MOVES
TO CALL MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM OF ONE TWENTY. ONE THREE
ONE TWENTY THREE. SENATOR
MCGUIRE ARE YOU PREPARED TO
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE WE WILL GO TO FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR SENATOR
WIENER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING
SENATOR WIENER FLOORS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAMPRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES NUMBERS ANY AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO WHICH IS
A REGIONAL BILL FOR THE BAY
AREA TO ADDRESS THE REGION'S
HOUSING CRISIS. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE. IN A BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS WHICH IS OUR CALL
AUG AND THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I
WITH NEW TOOLS TO RAISE FUNDS
FOR THE PRODUCTION
PRESERVATION. AND PROTECTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THESE TOOLS
WILL BE NESTED UNDER
ORGANIZATION THAT WILL BE
CALLED THE BAY AREA HOUSING
FINANCE AUTHORITY. THE BILL
WILL ALSO ENABLE THE REGION TO
SUPPORT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ADDRESS INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OTHER NEEDS ASSOCIATED. WITH
NEW RESIDENTS BY THE INTENT OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS TO ENABLE
THE BAY AREA TO HELP ITSELF. BY
PROVIDING OUR NINE COUNTY
REGION WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
RAISE FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SIMILAR TO HOW THE
REASON CURRENTLY HAS
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY. TO GO TO
THE VOTERS TO RAISE FUNDS FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND RESTORATION
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY. THIS
BILL IS CRAFTED THROUGH
COLLABORATIVE ENGAGEMENT WITH
AND AMONG LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO ENSURE THAT IT
SERVES THEIR NEEDS. HI THE BILL
IS SUPPORTED OVERWHELMINGLY BY
THESE OFFICIALS BY A VOTE OF
TWENTY THREE TO THREE AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS ON A VOTE OF
THIRTEEN THREE. AT THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND OF COURSE NO
REVENUE CAN BE GENERATED UNLESS
THE GOES TO THE VOTERS WITH A
TWO THIRDS VOTE. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL MAJOR DECISIONS
RELATED TO REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS WOULD BE
MADE BY BOTH A BAG AND THEN TO
SEE. WITH A BG ACTING AS THE
LEAD AGENCY. THE BAY AREA IS
EXPERIENCING A DEEP HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THIS BILL
SIMPLY EMPOWERS OUR REGION TO
HELP OURSELVES AND DEFINING
CRITICALLY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS ARE
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. HI
BATES NO BELL HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD I CABALLERO HI CHIANG.
NO DALY NO DODD. DORADO. HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO AYE AUTO HI JACKSON
BY JONES. LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK. MORRELL NO NIELSEN. PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER. BY KATHY WIENER
BY WILK NO. SENATOR WIENER
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY EIGHT. SENATOR DODD
ARE YOU PREPARED TO BRING UP
THE SIDE OF. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL SENATOR DODD. BETTER
PRESENT MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE IS THE ASSEMBLY IS
GEO COMMITTEE BILL THAT MAKES
NON CONTROVERSY OLD CHANGES TO
CURRENT LAW MY UNDERSTAND THIS
IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS. BATES BY WELL HI
PORGES I BRADFORD. CUP I HAVE A
HERO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD.
I DRAWS SO. HI GALGIANI. BY
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROW.
HERTZBERG HI. HILL AYE HUESO
BUYER TADO. HI JACKSON BY JONES.
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. I'M
REAL BY NELSON. PAN BY
PORTANTINO. BY ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG CASKEY. WIENER AYE
WILK HI. SENATOR DODD MOVES SO
CALLED COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO FILE ITEM OF ONE
TWENTY SEVEN FOR MADAME PRO
TâM. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ FILE ITEM ONE TWO SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO TENDENCY SENATOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES EVERY SESSION THERE
ARE A HANDFUL OF BILLS THAT
REALLY STAND OUT. BECAUSE OF
HOW BADLY THEY'RE NEEDED AND
HOW MUCH GOOD THEY WILL DO FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO THE
TENANT PROTECTION ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS.
AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA'S FACING
THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS WE HAVE WORK TO
ADDRESS THIS BY PASSING THE
HISTORIC TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HOUSING PACKAGE PROVIDING SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN BONDS FOR
NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. AND PROVIDING
OVER ONE BILLION TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN EMERGENCY AID
FOR THE HOMELESS. DESPITE THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS A QUESTION THAT
CONTINUES TO KEEP MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS UP AT NIGHT. IS
HOW WILL I STAY IN MY HOME
AFTER THE NEXT BIG RENT
INCREASE. THE REALITY IS THAT
ALMOST HALF OF THE STATE IS
MADE UP OF RENTERS. AND MANY OF
THESE RENTERS ARE THREATENED
WITH HAVING TO MAKE THE
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE BETWEEN A
ROOF OVER THEIR FAMILIES HEAD
OR PAYING FOR BASIC NECESSITIES
LIKE FOOD AND MEDICINE.
CONSCIENTIOUS LAND RECOGNIZE
THIS AND THEY'RE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN AN
ESSENTIAL PARTNER WITH US ON
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE HOUSING
OF THE STATE'S HOUSING SUPPLY.
YET UNLESS YOU LIVE IN ONE OF
THE FIFTEEN CITIES WITH RENT
CONTROL THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
PROTECTION AFFORDED TO YOU. IF
YOUR LANDLORD WANTS TO RAISE
YOUR RENT BY FIFTY A 100% TO
UNDER PERCENT. ARE KICK YOU OUT
ALL TOGETHER THOSE STORIES ARE
REAL. AND THAT'S WHERE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO COMES IN.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO SETS A
RENT INCREASE CAP AT 5% PLUS
INFLATION NOT TO EXCEED TEN
PERCENT. AND THAT ALLOWS AMPLE
ROOM FOR LANDLORDS TO RAISE
RENTS TO COVER COSTS WHILE
PROTECTING TENANTS FROM THE
KIND OF RED GALGIANI. THAT LEAD
TO DISPLACEMENT AND
HOMELESSNESS. AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO PROTECTS TENANTS BY
REQUIRING A LANDLORD TO PROVIDE
A JUST CAUSE TO EVICT AFTER A
PERIOD OF TWELVE MONTHS. AFTER
THAT A LANDLORD WILL STILL BE
ABLE TO AFFECT A BAD TENANT FOR
ANY REASONABLE REASON ONE MIGHT
EXPECT FAILURE TO PAY RENT
VIOLATING THE LEASE AGREEMENT.
BEING A NUISANCE TO OTHER
TENANTS AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS
THOSE ARE READ. THOSE ARE
ALREADY HAPPENING AND THE
PROTECTIONS ARE IN PLACE
HOWEVER JUST FALLS WILL ENSURE
STABILITY FOR THE MAJORITY OF
TENANTS WHO DON'T CAUSE ANY
ISSUES. AND SIMPLY SEARCHING
FOR A STABLE PLACE TO CALL
HOME. A FEW THINGS ABOUT AB
EIGHT FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT
IT DOES NOT DO. IT DOES NOT
EXTEND BEYOND TWENTY THIRTY
THERE IS A SUNSET. DOES NOT
APPLY TO NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
BUILDINGS FIFTEEN YEARS.
MEANING THAT IT WILL NEGATIVELY
IMPACT NEW CONSTRUCTION RIGHT.
BY AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS
WE WANT TO KEEP SUPPLY
HAPPENING AS WE DEAL WITH THE
CURRENT CRISIS. IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO OWNER OCCUPIED OCCUPY
DUPLEXES OR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
THAT ARE NON CORPORATELY OWNED.
THEIR BY EXEMPTING SMALL
LANDLORDS WHO ARE RENTING THEIR
STARTER HOME OR OTHER UNIT IN
THEIR DUPLEX. AND FINALLY IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
COSTA HAWKINS. COLLEAGUES
CALIFORNIA TURNED A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE YEARS OLD THIS WEEK.
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY OF THOSE
ONE SIXTY NINE YEARS WE'VE HAD
A LAW ON THE BOOKS. THAT
PROHIBITS PRICE GOUGING ABOUT
10% AFTER AN EMERGENCY OUR NASA
NATURAL DISASTER I WOULD SUBMIT
TO YOU. THAT THIS HOUSING
CRISIS WE ARE IAN SHOULD ALSO
TRIGGER. THAT KIND OF CAP TO
PROTECT MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
RENTERS AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
IS A CRITICAL PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS. AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE Là AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO IS NOT RENT CONTROL. WITH
ITS EFFECTIVE ANTI GELDING
PROVISIONS AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WILL BE THE STRONGEST
RENTER PROTECTION LAWS IN THE
COUNTRY I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR AT
CONSENTED WILL FOR PURPOSE SIR.
FOR REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THEM
AND MATT A LOT I MEAN EXCUSE ME
IN THE **** LOUNGE. HI THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR WORK
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE ****
LOUNGE
. RETURN IF EVERYONE
WOULD PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR WE ARE UNDER DEBATE. AND
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. THE FOUR MEMBERS
WOULD PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HAS
CONCLUDED
. COLLEAGUES WE ON
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN THIS
IS THE TIME FOR DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR WIENER. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT. HE'S ME I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND I WANT
TO THANK. MY OWN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOME MEMBER TO FOR
LEADING ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
I KNOW IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT BUT I ISN'T A VERY
GOOD PLACE. WHEN IT COMES TO
THE HOUSING IT'S SUCH AS REALLY
A CRISIS FRANKLY IT'S A
DISASTER IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO. WE STARTED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS AND WE DID IT
AGAIN THIS BUDGET SIGNIFICANTLY
FUNDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
OUR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT AND WE NEED TO
KEEP DOING THAT. WE NEED TO
RAMP UP PRODUCTION DRAMATICALLY
A NEW HOUSING TO FILL OUR THREE
POINT FIVE. MILLION HOMES.
COLLEAGUES COULD WE PLEASE HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION IF YOU HAVE TO
CONVERSE PLEASE TAKE IT EITHER
OUTSIDE OR TO THE BACK OF THE
HALL THIS FOR THIS DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE. THANK YOU. ARE WE
NEED TO MADAM PRESIDENT
DRAMATICALLY RAMP UP PRODUCTION
OF NEW HOUSING BECAUSE WE HAVE
A SHORTAGE OF HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA OF THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES WE'RE DOING THAT
WORK AND WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO THERE BUT JOB NUMBER
ONE IS KEEPING PEOPLE STABLE
AND THE HOUSING THAT THEY HAVE
RIGHT NOW DOTS HOW WE STOP
HOMELESSNESS FROM GROWING.
THAT'S HOW WE STOP PEOPLE FROM
HAVING TO LEAVE THEIR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THERE'S NOWHERE FOR
THEM TO GO WE MUST KEEP PEOPLE
STABLE AND OUR HOUSING AND
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA AS THE
PRO TEM MENTIONS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF RENTERS OVER 40% OF
CALIFORNIANS RAN AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF RENTERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
ESSENTIALLY NO PROTECTION
FICTION WORK FROM HUGE RENT
INCREASES AND IT'S ONE THING
WHEN A LANDLORD IS HAS A MODEST
RATE INCREASE TO KEEP UP WITH
THE MAINTENANCE OF THE HOME AND
INFLATION. IT'S ANOTHER THING
ONE RENTERS ARE ROUTINELY
GETTING NOTICES THAT THE RENT
IS GOING UP BY. TEN TWENTY
THIRTY FIFTY A 102100% WE KNOW
IF. THE RENTERS WHO ARE GETTING
DRAMATIC RENT INCREASES.
DOUBLING TRIPLING THE RENT IN
ONE FELL SWOOP THAT IS NOT HOW
YOU ACHIEVE HOUSING STABILITY
THAT IS NOT THE WAY WE SHOULD
BE APPROACHING HOUSING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO
KEEP PEOPLE STABLE AND THE
HOUSING THEY HAVE AND AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILL HELP
TO DO THAT BY PUTTING A VERY
REASONABLE CAP IN PLACE 5% FROM
IMPORTANT PLOT BY PERCENT PLUS
INFLATION. THAT IS A VERY VERY
REASONABLE CAP FROM A LANDLORDS
PERSPECTIVE AND BASIC JUST
BECAUSE PROTECTIONS I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WARNER SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
SO I. PROBABLY JOIN WITH THE
PRO TEM PRESENTEDTHIS MEASURE
AND WOULD LIKE TO STRESS SOME
POINT SHE MADE AND ADD A FEW
NEW ONES TO THE IMPORTANT
ARGUMENTS FOR THIS MEASURE. AS
SHE SUGGESTED THE MOST BASIC
HUMAN NEEDS ARE FOOD ON THE
TABLE. AT A ROOF OVER YOUR HEAD.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THAT ROOF.
EACH OF US IN THIS CHAMBER
DEEPLY UNDERSTAND THE TASK
AHEAD OF US TO INCREASE OUR
HOUSING SUPPLY MISTER WEINER
TALKS ABOUT OFTEN. WHETHER THAT
BE THROUGH STREAMLINING
DEVELOPMENT IDENTIFYING SURPLUS
LAND FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR
GETTING CREATIVE WITH ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS THIS WE HAVE
PASSED OFF OF THIS FLOOR OR
OTHER INNOVATIVE HOUSING
OPTIONS. WELL HOUSING SUPPLY IS
CRUCIAL CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
CRISIS IS MORE IS ABOUT MORE
THAN JUST SUPPLY IT'S ABOUT
PREVENTING MORE FOLKS FROM
FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS IT'S
ABOUT PROTECTING RENTERS. THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS THE MONTHLY
COST OF RENT FOR AN APARTMENT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
INCREASED ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS 34% IN ORANGE OUNTY
AVERAGE MONTHLY RENT INCREASED
IN FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE RENT IS INCREASED
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
DOLLARS MY OWN STAFF TELL ME
THAT FIVE YEARS AGO HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THEY PAID A THOUSAND
DOLLAR A MONTH. FOR A TWO
BEDROOM APARTMENT TODAY THAT
SAME TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IN
SACRAMENTO HER COSTS ARE
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. AS RENTS HAVE RISEN
RENTERS INCOMES HAVE TO OF NOT
KEPT PACE DESPITE THE BEST
EFFORTS OF THIS BODY THE OTHER
HOUSE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
IMPROVE THE STANDARD OF LIVING
FOR CALIFORNIA'S ACROSS THE
STATE BY RAISING THE MINIMUM
WAGE. THE SAD REALITY IS THAT
THE COST OF THE FAIR HOUSING
RENT FAIR MARKET RENT. FOR A
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD REQUIRE A
SALARY OF MORE THAN TWICE MORE
THAN TWICE MEMBERS THE MINIMUM
WAGE. THAT IS WHY A MAJORITY OF
RENTERS ARE SPENDING MORE THAN
HALF. OF THEIR INCOME ON RENT.
AND ACCORDING TO OUR OWN
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S MEMBERS
HOUSEHOLDS ARE CONSIDERED RENT
TO BURDEN. IF THEY SPEND OVER
30% JUST OVER 30% OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME ON RENT. OUR
CA ARE LA FOUND THAT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA OVER HALF OF ALL
RENTERS AND OVER 80% I STRESS
OVER 80% OF EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME RENTERS ARE RED BURDEN.
EXTRAORDINARY THINK ABOUT THAT
HOW MANY HOUSEHOLDS ARE
SPENDING MOST OF THEIR INCOME
JUST TO HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD. IT IS TRUE WHEN THEY SAY
THE RENT IS JUST TOO HIGH. NOT
ONLY IS IT HIGH BUT ONLY A HUNT
ONLY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION AS
THE PROBE. FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA
IS THE PRO TEM SAID OUT OF SIX
MILLION MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
UNITS ARE PROTECTED BY SOME
FORM OF LOCAL RENT CONTROL.
THAT MEANS MEMBERS. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE VULNERABLE TO
EXCESS RENT INCREASES OR
VACATION WITHOUT COST. MANY
FRAGILE FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE STATE.
LARGE RENT INCREASES CAN BE THE
TIPPING POINT THAT PUSHES THEM
AS I SUGGESTED FROM HOUSE THE
HOMELESS THIS MEASURE OFFERS
CRITICAL STEPS TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION FOR THE NEXT TEN
YEARS THIS BILL WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING ONE AS WAS INDICATED
ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE RENT CAP
THAT IS BOTH PROTECTIVE FOR
TENANTS. IN FAIR FOR LANDLORDS
IMPORTANTLY THE CAP EXAMS
HOUSING CONSTRUCTED IN THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS SO WE DON'T
COUNTERACT EFFORTS TO ENCOURAGE
NEW HOUSING CONSTRUCTION AS THE
PRO TEM INDICATED. AND THIS
MEASURE PREVENT ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS EVICTIONS BY
REQUIRING THE TENANTS WHO HAVE
RESIDED IN THE UNIT FOR A YEAR
OR MORE CAN ONLY BE EVICTED FOR
JUST BECAUSE- IT ALSO REQUIRES
LOCATION TO BE ASSISTANCE WITH
THAT WHEN THE TENET MUST BE
EVICTED. AT NO FAULT OF HIS OR
HER OWN. THIS MEASURES THE KIND
OF CAREFULLY BALANCED. MEASURE
THE DOES THIS LEGISLATURE. AND
OUR GOVERNOR PROUD. AND FOR A
MOMENT MATTER PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY
DEDICATION ON THIS ISSUE. FOR
HIS LEGISLATIVE SECRETARY
ANTHONY WILLIAMS A ROCKSTAR.
AND FOR THE LONG HOURS HE'S PUT
IN AND MEETING AFTER MEETING
AND SEEING THIS THROUGH. MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO OUR PRO TEM
WHICH MADE THIS A TOP PRIORITY
AND I KNOW. WE DON'T LIKE TO
SAY THIS BUT FOR CHIEF OF STAFF
MCCARTY MEN WHO IS ALWAYS
ALWAYS ALWAYS WORKING HARD. FOR
US AND WHO DID SO MUCH TO MAKE
THIS MEASURE. COME TO EXISTENCE
I ALSO WANT TO DEEPLY
APPRECIATE OUR PARTNERSHIP IS
THE PRO TEM SUGGESED WITH OUR
ASSEMBLY COUNTERPARTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND TIM
GRAYSON WHAT THE OTHER PART OF
THE BILL. BOTH TENDED ADVOCACY
GROUPS AND BUSINESS LEADERS
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS MEASURE.
OFFERS BOTH PROTECTIONS FOR
RENTERS IN FAIRNESS AND
STABILITY FOR LANDLORDS. ON
THAT NOTE I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. THE BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE THE ROLE HOUSING
PROJECT ANOTHER TENANTS RIGHTS
GROUPS WHO FOUGHT SO TIRELESSLY
TO MAKE THIS TO BRING THIS
MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY FOR A
VOTE. PRO TEM INDICATED TODAY'S
AN IMPORTANT DAY THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ASK YOU TO
VOTE FOR A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR STONE. THEY
GIVE IT A PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. WHEN A WHEN IS
ENOUGH ENOUGH. I RISE IN
OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN THE TO A
BILL THAT ONE ACT THE MOST
SEVERE STATEWIDE RUN CONTROL
MEASURE OUR STATE HAS EVER SEEN.
WE TALK ABOUT A TEN YEAR SUNSET.
MY FRIENDS IN TEN YEARS MOST OF
US WON'T BE HERE ANYMORE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IT'S JUST LIKE A
TAX. WE LABEL TAXES THIS
TEMPORARY TAXES BUT THEY ALWAYS
BECOME PERMANENT TAXES THIS 5%
IS GOING TO BE THE FLOOR NOT
THE CEILING TO RENT CONTROL IN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
IN THE MANY YEARS TO COME. I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
BIGGER BUSINESS GROUPS THAT
WERE MENTIONED IF PARMON
SOCIAIS SHIN AND OTHER SPECIAL
INTERESTS HAVE CUT A DEAL. TO
EXAMINE THEIR HOUSING UNITS
FROM THIS THIS BILL. YOU KNOW
WE JUST SEEM TO ONE EXEMPT SOME
OF THE BIGGER PLAYERS SO THAT
WE DON'T GET THE OPPOSITION SO
WE CAN SAY WE DID SOMETHING
THIS RIGHTEOUS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT YOU KNOW THESE
THESE BIGGER COMPANIES THAT OWN
HUNDREDS OF NOT THOUSANDS
APARTMENTS YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
ALGORITHMS AND THEY CAN SPREAD
COSTS AND HAVE FEES AT THE
SMALLER LANDLORDS. DON'T HAVE
YOU KNOW SUCH AS A POOL FEE A
SECURITY FEE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE UP TAFFY THE LIST GOES ON
AND ON. THEY'RE GOING TO GET
THEIR RENT INCREASES AND
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THE MONEY.
AND BUT BUT BECAUSE W HAVE THE
FIFTEEN YEAR TIME PERIOD THAT
THEY'RE EXEMPT FROM THIS IT'S
STILL IS GOING TO HAVE A IN THE
IMPACT ON THEIR PERFORMANCE AS
A LOOK TO CALIFORNIA TO INVEST
IN WHICH I'M GONNA GET TO A
LITTLE BIT. BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
SMALL. APARTMENT OWNER WHO WORK
THEIR WHOLE LIFE TO GRAB A FEW
BUCKS THEY GET IN A PLAQUE SIR
TWELVE PLEX ANY UNIT THE MAYBE
TWENTY YEARS OR OR OLDER I'M
REMINDED OF A STORY ABOUT SOME
HARD WORKING ASIAN PEOPLE IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAT SOLD DONUTS
AND- WORKED HARD AS A FAMILY
WERE ABLE TO BUY TWO OR THREE
HOMES AND- IN SAN FRANCISCO
INNER ARE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
PASSIVE INCOME THAT THEY CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO RETIREMENT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY IF THEY PUT THEIR
THEIR ASSETS IN THE C. CORP
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
BEAR THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
LEGISLATION I GUESS THE SMALL
APARTMENT OWNER JUST DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH JUICE. TO CUT THEIR
OWN DEALS GET ACCEPTED YET.
LOOK WHAT THEY HAVE TO LOOK FOR
TO. EVERY YEAR IS PROPERTY
VALUES GO UP. OUR SISTER.
RAISES THE VALUE OF THOSE THE
PROPERTIES BUT UNDER PROP
THIRTEEN WHICH WE KNOW IS UNDER
ASSAULT THE CITY CALIFORNIA MAY
NOT BE AROUND FOR GOD KNOWS HOW
LONG HOW MUCH LONGER. BUT THEY
CAN MANDATORILY INCREASE THE
PROPERTY TAXES BY 2% PER YEAR.
SOME INVESTORS INVEST IN AND
CONDO TOWNHOME DEVELOPMENTS HOV
FEES RARELY GO DOWN THEY
USUALLY GO UP. AND THEN OF
COURSE IF YOU LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES AS A FRIEND OF MINE
PETER. WHO. CAME HERE AS AN
IMMIGRANT FROM HUNGRY WHEN HE
WAS TWO YEARS OLD AND HIS
PARENTS DIDN'T SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE BECAME NATURALIZED AND
GOT INTO THE REAL ESTATE
BUSINESS AND- WORK THEIR WHOLE
LIVES AND ENDED UP GETTING
FOURTEEN UNITS IN BRENTWOOD.
WHICH IS A PRETTY. YOU KNOW. HI
COST AREA. AND HIS PARENTS
RECENTLY IN THE PAST DECADE
BOTH PASSED AWAY IN HERE THOSE
PROPERTIES IN. THE CITY OF LA
NOW IS REQUIRING HIM TO.
EARTHQUAKE RETROFIT THESE
UNITS. ANY SIGNIFICANT COSTS.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME. M. BY
ENACTING A 5% CAP. HE'LL
PROBABLY EXPIRE HIMSELF BEFORE
HE EVER GETS THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT WITH THESE THROW
EARTHQUAKE RETROFITS. IN LOS
ANGELES. THERE ARE MANY REASONS
TO BE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BUT
THE FIRST I'D LIKE TO MENTION
IS THAT CALIFORNIA VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY. REJECTED RENT
CONTROL. RECENTLY. JUST LAST
YEAR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIANS VOTED NO ON PROP
TEN WHICH FAILED NOT BY A FEW
PERCENTAGE POINTS MY FRIENDS
IFILL BY NINETEEN POINTS. I
GUESS THE LEGISLATURE IS JUST
FOLLOWING THE GOVERNOR'S LEAD
AND IGNORING THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS. FIRST IT WAS A DEATH
PENALTY. NOW IT'S RENT CONTROL.
THE PEOPLE OF SPOKEN AND WE ARE
IGNORING THAT AND BELIEVE ME
THEY'RE PAYING ATTENTION. THAT
DOESN'T SOMEONE DEMOCRACY TO ME
BUT I'M GETTING USED TO THAT
PRACTICE IN THIS BUILDING. WITH
THIS GOVERNOR. AND THIS
LEGISLATURE. AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WILL ALSO CREATE MAJOR
HOUSING MARKET INSTABILITY
WHICH WILL ONLY PERPETUATE OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS EVEN
MORE. MAYBE WE SHOULD LEARN
FROM LESSONS FROM OTHER STATES.
MIKE ORGAN WHO VOTED IN A RENT
CONTROL. MEASURE THREE MONTHS
AGO. ALREADY IN THE STATE OF
OREGON THERE'S BEEN A 38%
DECREASE IN MULTI FAMILY
INVESTMENT IS THAT WHAT WE WANT
CALIFORNIA'S A DECREASE
INVESTMENT IN MULTI FAMILY
INVESTMENT ESPECIALLY BY THE
BIG PLAYERS SO WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF HOUSING AND YOU ALL
KNOW THE SUPPLY AND DEMAND
EQUATION IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPLY. THE RICH ARE GOING TO
GO UP. WE'RE GONNA GO
ESPECIALLY IN THE NEWER UNITS
THERE ARE TO BE EVEN MORE ON
AFFORDABLE ESPECIALLY WITH THE
MANDATES THAT THIS. IS A TO
SHIP PLACES ON ON BUILDERS.
HOUSING INVESTORS AND
DEVELOPERS ARE NOT STUPID
PEOPLE THEY KNOW THAT RENT
CONTROL PROVIDES NO MARKET
STABILITY AND WHO WOULD RESTORE
MONEY TIME AND INVESTMENT ON
INSTABILITY. WHEN CERTAINLY
THERE ARE OTHER PLACES THEY CAN
GO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THEIR INVESTMENTS HAMSTRING ARE
HAMSTRUNG THE WAY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS TRYING TO DO THAT.
MAYBE OUR CONSTITUENTS WILL
HAVE TO CONTINUE. TO MOVE TO
TEXAS TO ARIZONA. THE FLORIDA.
IDAHO TO NEVADA. FOR TENNESSEE
AND THAT'S JUST OUR RHETORIC
THE PROOF IS IN THE PUDDING.
FROM TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THOSE
STATES HAVE SEEN THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND NEW
HOUSING UNITS BUILT. BUT
CALIFORNIA'S ONLY SEEN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. UNITY
INCREASE. DO YOU USE THE NUMBER
OF UNITS BUILT MY FRIENDS IF
YOU PASS THIS MEASURE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILL ONLY
DECREASE IF RENT CONTROL IS
ENACTED WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR
CALIFORNIA WE'LL SEE EVEN A
GREATER HOUSING CRISIS BECAUSE
OF THE LOW SUPPLY OF HOUSING
EITHER THIS WILL FORCE OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO JOIN SIXTY
THOUSAND HOMELESS POPULATION
THAT WE SEE IN THE LA AREA
ALTHOUGH SIMPLY JUST MOVE TO
ANOTHER STATE. IF WE REALLY
WANT TO SOLVE CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS AND PROTECT
EXISTING AND FUTURE TENANTS WE
MUST PASS LEGISLATION THAT
ENCOURAGES HOUSING INVESTMENT
AND PROVIDES HOUSING CHOICE BY
REMOVING BARRIERS SO THAT
DEVELOPERS CAN BUY LAND AND CAN
BUILD AND STOP OVER IMPORTING
THEM WITH INTEREST RATES PLACE
SINCE THAT TRANSLATE INTO
HIGHER COSTS THAT HAVE TO BE
PASSED ON. TO RENTERS. AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WOULD
DISCOURAGE INVESTMENT HOUSING.
SLOW HOUSING CONSTRUCTION. AND
LIMIT TENANTS ABILITY TO FIND
HOMES. MY FRIENDS. I KNOW IT.
GOOD TO MAKE A STATEMENT THAT
YOU WANT TO PROTECT THE RENTERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ALL DO. BUT THERE'S A RIGHT WAY
TO DO IT IN A WRONG WAY TO DO
IT LIMITING THE SUPPLY AND
LIMITED THE INVESTMENT IN
PROVIDING THE SAME IS NOT THE
RIGHT APPROACH. WE LEARNED THAT
IN THE NEXT ONE ONE. I CAN TELL
YOU I'VE BEEN A PROUD INVESTOR
IN REAL ESTATE FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. I PREPARED FOR THIS
MOMENT I'M GOOD I'M IN GOOD
SHAPE. MANY OF MY FAMILY.
MEMBERS HAVE PREPARED FOR THIS
MOMENT THEY'RE IN GOOD SHAPE.
BUT THERE ARE MANY IN
CALIFORNIA THE WEREN'T AWARE.
THAT THIS TRAIN WAS GOING TO BE
LEAVING THE STATION HEARD IN
THEIR ABILITY TO. ENJOY THEIR
INVESTMENTS ESPECIALLY ARE
RETIRED FOLKS THAT WORK THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES. TO BUILD A LITTLE
BIT OF SAVINGS TO BUY A FEW
DWELLING UNITS SO THAT THEY CAN
LIVE A COMFORTABLE LIFE IN
THEIR RETIREMENT. THEY STILL
HAVE TO MAINTAIN THESE UNITS
THAT ARE OLDER. THE PLUMBING
GOES OUT THE AIR CONDITIONING
GOES OUT THE HEATING GOES OUT.
THESE THESE EXPENDITURES ARE
NOT CHEAP THEY'RE EXPENSIVE
ESPECIALLY WITH OLDER UNITS. SO
IF YOU HAVE A CAP OF 5% ON A
UNIT IS THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS
OLD MY UNCLE OWNS SOME UNITS IN
GLENDALE CALIFORNIA THE
PROBABLY FIFTY YEARS OLD. YOU
KNOW IT'S ALMOST TIME YOU HAVE
TO KIND OF REBUILD THESE UNITS
AGAIN TO MAKE THEM HAPPY DOUBLE
SO THE PEOPLE CAN ENJOY THEIR
HOMES BUT THAT COSTS MONEY WELL
IF THEY CAN'T GET A RETURN ON
THEIR INVESTMENT DO YOU REALLY
BELIEVE THEY'RE GOING TO VESTED
THESE UNITS AND MAKE THEM MY
SON HABITABLE. I THINK THE
ANSWER IS NO WE'RE GOING TO
CREATE SUB STANDARD LIVING
CONDITIONS FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
LIVING AT THE BORDERLINE OF
BECOMING HOMELESS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THIS HOUSING
CRISIS IT IS VERY MUCH.
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE POLICIES
THE COME OUT OF THIS
INSTITUTION. WE CAN DO A LOT
BETTER JOB OF REDUCING COSTS.
AND THAT'S HAVE COMPETITION.
AMONGST LANDLORDS THERE'S NO
NOT MUCH COMPETITION NOW
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T. MADE IT.
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO BUILD MULTI
FAMILY DEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE DON'T HAVE
COMPETITION. THIS IS WHAT THE
RESULT IS. AND SO WHAT'S THE
GOVERNMENT SOLUTION. LET'S JUST
CAP THE INCOME THAT THESE
ENTREPRENEURS ARE ENTITLED TO
MAKE. IT THE WRONG WAY TO DO IT
YOU NEED TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
SOMETHING WE'VE ALL TALKED
ABOUT. AND WHEN YOU INCREASES
APPLY. MANY OF THESE LANDLORDS
ARE GOING TO COMPETE. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO COMPETE IN A
ROW WHY IS HEY AND THAT'S HOW I
GOT A LOWER RENTS. AND THAT'S
HOW YOU'RE GONNA MAKE.
PROPERTIES AWFUL WE HAVE A BILL
DO WILLING IS FOR PEOPLE TO GET
BY. MY FRIENDS THESE ARE THE
REASONS WHY WE DO THIS NOTE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO IT FEELS
GOOD. BUT IT'S GOING TO HER A
LOT OF PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IF YOU PASS THIS
ORIGINAL VOTED AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AS IT HAS
BEEN SAID BY NUMBERS SPEAKERS
EARLIER. A SEVERE SHOULD
SHORTAGE OF HOUSING AND
CALIFORNIA'S IS CAUSING RENTS
TO RISE TO LEVELS THAT ARE NO
LONGER AFFORDABLE FOR A LARGE
SHARE OF OUR POPULATION. HI
THIS BILL PROMISES TO SLOW
THOSE INCREASES AND PREVENT ON
JUST ADDICTIONS. BUT IN MY VIEW
RENT CONTROL IS NOT THE ANSWER
TO OUR HOUSING SHORTAGE. WHILE
IT MAY BE NEEDED IN AN
EMERGENCY. IT MIGHT MAKE THINGS
WORSE OVER THE LONG RUN. RED
CONTROL ALMOST BY DEFINITION
MAKES THE THINGS WE NEED MOST
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW RENTAL
HOUSING LESS LIKELY. AND IT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE. ANYTIME YOU
REDUCE THE RATE OF RETURN ON
INVESTMENT YOU MAKE THAT
INVESTMENT LESS ATTRACTIVE. AND
THIS IS TRUE EVEN IF NEW
INVESTMENT IS ACCEPTED FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS HAS THIS BILL
DOES. RED CAN WROTECONTROL CAN
LEAD TO THE REDUCTION IN THE
EXISTING RENTAL SUPPLY. A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STUDY BY
STANFORD BUSINESS SCHOOL FOUND
THAT AFTER. SAN FRANCISCO
ADOPTED RENT CONTROL IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. LANDLORDS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO CONVERT
THEIR APARTMENTS TWO CONDOS. OR
NOT IS THERE TENANTS OUT BY
SPENDING LESS ON MAINTENANCE.
OTHERS MOVED INTO THE RENTAL
UNITS THEMSELVES ARE RENTED TO
FAMILY MEMBERS. AND AT A TIME
WHEN WE SHOULD BE TARGETING OUR
SOLUTIONS TO THOSE MOST IN NEED.
CONTROL HELPS THE MILLIONAIRE
AND A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR A
MONTH UNIT EVEN MORE THAN IT
HELPS THE SINGLE MOM. AND A
NINE HUNDRED DOLLAR. A MONTH
FLAT. A MORE EFFICIENT WAY TO
HELP POOR RANCHERS. IN A WAY
THAT DOES NOT REDUCE SUPPLY. IS
TO GIVE THOSE RENTERS GRANTS OR
TAX CREDITS TO HELP THEM PAY
THE RENT. WE DO THIS IN
HEALTHCARE. AND WE DO THIS WITH
FOOD. WE SHOULD DO MORE OF IT
WITH HOUSING. THE SENATE HAS
PASSED MY LEGISLATION TO CATCH
THE RENTER'S CREDIT UP TO
INFLATION AFTER HOLDEN FLAT FOR
FORTY YEARS I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND THAT MEASURE ALSO
INCREASE THE CREDIT FOR. LOW
INCOME SINGLE MOMS AND DADS.
THAT BIPARTISAN IDEAS SHOULD BE
A PART OF ANY PLANNED EIGHT
RENTERS. BUT THAT BILL WAS HELD
IN THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. I HOPE WE CAN
REVISIT THIS WERE THE PLAN NEXT
YEAR. THE ASSEMBLY ALSO BLOCKED
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION TO GIVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE SAME
RELIEF FROM SYKORA. FROM SEQUEL
LITIGATION THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE'S GIVEN THE
BUILDERS OF SPORTS STADIUMS AND
ARENAS. SO WHILE RENT CAPS IN
THIS BILL MAY PROVIDE SOME
SHORT TERM RELIEF TO THOSE WHO
HAVE A RENTAL UNIT TODAY. WE
MUST DO MORE TO HELP LOW INCOME
RENTERS AND THAT MEANS
INCREASING THE SUPPLY
INCREASING THE SUPPLY THE RENT
IS NOT JUST CAPITA COMES DOWN
OVER TIME AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR
OF THIS LEGISLATION UNDERSTANDS
THAT AND AGREES WITH THAT THAT
DESIRE TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY.
LET ME GIVE YOU ONE FACTOID IN
A CLOSE. ACCORDING TO THE-
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC FORUM THERE
ARE FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
APPROVED HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. THAT'S RIGHT
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
APPROVED HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY WITH THE
ROBUST CONSTRUCTION SCHEDULE
THAT'S PROBABLY A THREE YEAR
SUPPLY. AND SO YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF SO WHAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE WHY WHY AREN'T
PEOPLE BUILDING. RENTS ARE
GOING OUT PEOPLE MAKING MONEY
ALLEGEDLY. SO WHY ARE WE ABLE
TO BORROW WHY ISN'T THAT.
CAPITAL BEING INVESTED IN
CONSTRUCTION AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE COMPLEX ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION. WHETHER IT'S FEES.
WHETHER IT'S AVAILABILITY OF
SUPPLIES AND COST OF LABOR
THERE'S A LOT TO THAT AND IT'S
COMPLEX AND WE ALL KNOW WE NEED
TO WORK ON IT. IT HAS LITTLE TO
DO. WITH NIMBY ISM THAT SAYING
NO TO CONSTRUCTION AS WE DEBATE
A LOT ON THE FLOOR IN THAT AREA.
NEVER THE LESS THE ACUTE
CONSEQUENCES OF THESE LARGE
RENT INCREASES. IS A CRISIS
THAT WE CAN'T IGNORE. ALTHOUGH
FLAWED AND SHORT TERM IN ITS
BENEFITS THIS BILL. PUTS A
TEMPORARY BANDAID AGAINST RENT
GALGIANI. AND ACCORDINGLY I'LL
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR MORALE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. I'M
NOT GETTING OUT A WHOLE LOT I
REALLY APPRECIATE COMMENTS FROM
THE SENATOR FROM AROUND AS WELL
AS A SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE ON
THIS I THINK THEY CLEARLY
ARTICULATED VERY IMPORTANT
THINGS ABOUT THIS IS A
VIOLATION OF PROPERTY RIGHTS
YOU KNOW PERSON WORKS WATSON
TOILS AND THEY MAKE A LITTLE
MONEY THEN THEY INVEST IN AN
APARTMENT BUILDING IN OUR HOUSE
AND GOVERNMENT OVER REGULATES
THAT THAT'S DISTURBING TAMMY.
BUT HERE'S ANOTHER THING THAT I
JUST WANT TO HEAR I USED TO
HAVE A REAL ESTATE COMPANY AND
THEN I WAS ON THE BE I A BOARD
THE BILLING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SO I KNOW PEOPLE IN
REAL ESTATE I I'VE ASSOCIATED
WITH A LOT OF BUILDERS AND WE
STILL ARE AFFILIATED WITH THE
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT COMPANY
THAT MANAGES PROPERTY IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS IN
ARIZONA. AND MY CONCERN YOU
KNOW BIRDS OF A FEATHER FLOCK
TOGETHER SO I KNOW A LOT OF
BUILDERS REAL LITTERS AS WELL
AS PEOPLE IN THE LANDLORD
BUSINESS RENTAL HOUSING AND.
THE ARK SKIPPING MANY OF THEM
WERE VERY CONCERNED. PLACE LONG
TERM INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE LEGISLATION AND
SELL. MANY OF THE PEOPLE I KNOW
HAVE LEFT CALIFORNIA'S. MY
FRIEND FROM RIVERSIDE AS WELL
AS I'VE SPOKEN TO MANY MORE WHO
ARE CONSIDERING DOING THE SAME
THING. BECAUSE HOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU MAKE A GOOD INVESTMENT.
IN CALIFORNIA ON OUR PART AND
BILLING RIGHT NOW WHEN YOU HAVE
RENT CONTROL IN AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT DEBTS THIS
REALLY TOUGH. IS REPAIRS AND
CITIES LIKE DETROIT WHERE YOU
DO HAVE STRICT RENT CONTROL
THERE'S THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
VACANT HOMES FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. IN THE CITY OF
DETROIT WE DON'T WANT TO BECOME
LIKE TROY BUT SADLY PERHAPS WE
WILL BECAUSE- FOR LANDLORDS
MAKE A RETURN ON YOUR
INVESTMENT. IT'S VERY TOUGH
WHEN YOU HAVE SO MANY. HOUSING
REPAIR SOMETIMES YOU CAN GET
AWAY WITH MINOR THINGS BUT WHEN
THAT AIR CONDITIONING HEATING
BREAKS THEY COULD BE FIVE TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN CIVIL
WITH RENT CONTROL QUITE OFTEN
YOU SEE THAT THEIR CONDITIONS
OF THE PROPERTY WELL CERTAINLY.
AND SO AGAIN I THINK. I AM THE
FREE MARKET SHOULD ROLL IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT THE VOTERS VOTED
OVERWHELMINGLY TO PROTECT
HOUSING HAND WE SHOULD DO WHAT
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE VOTED ON
AND SO FOR THAT REASON I AM A
NO BUT BUT THE LONG TERM
THINKING IS THIS WILL BE IF
HISTORY IS ANY INDICATION
MODERN HISTORY THIS WILL BE
DEVASTATING TO OUR- OUR OUR
STATE SO FAR IS AT WILL HAVE
FEWER. PIECES OF PROPERTY BUT
ALSO WILL HAVE CITIES THAT WILL
DETERIORATE BECAUSE OF THE
EXPENSE THAT COMES WITH RENT
CONTROL AND YOU WON'T HAVE.
THAT MANY INVESTORS WHO ARE
WILLING TO PUT THEIR MONEY IN
TO STATE THAT OVER REGULATE
THEMSELVES. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAWS SO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND THANK YOU TO THE
PRO TEM I STAND AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. EVERY CALIFORNIAN DESERVES
A DECENT LIVING TANDARDS AND A
SAFE AND STABLE HOME. I HAVE
THE SECOND LARGEST OF THE
DISTRICT WITH THE SECOND
LARGEST HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
RENTERS IN THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA 44% OF
RENTERS ARE RAISING FAMILIES.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
FACING ECONOMIC EVICTIONS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALONE MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
LIVE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM
LOSING THEIR HOMES THEY ARE
WHAT WE CALL THE SEVERELY OVER
BURDENED. THE LARGEST GROWTH OF
HOMELESS ARE MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN THAT ARE EVEN ACTED.
WE HAVE TO KEEP OUR FAMILIES IN
THEIR HOMES WE CAN NO LONGER
ALLOW THE DEBATE TO BE IF AND
WHERE PEOPLE SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO SLEEP IN THEIR CARS. WE HAVE
TO DO BETTER THAN THAT FOR
THOSE REASONS I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU SIR
DORADO SENATOR BORCHERS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I'M NOT
GOING TO BELABOR THIS
DISCUSSION WITH. THE POINT SAID
IN PREVIOUSLY RAISED BUT IT
OCCURRED TO ME. THAT. ALL OF US
APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE IN A
HOUSING EMERGENCY. I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY THINKS THAT WERE
NOT. WE'VE HEARD IT FROM THE
GOVERNOR WE DISCUSSED AD
NAUSEAM A NUMBER OF ITEMS IT IN
IN THE MEDIA THAT CALIFORNIA IS
JUST NOT. OF IT IS NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO SATISFY ITS PRESENT
HOUSING NEEDS AND CERTAINLY NOT
ITS FUTURE HOUSING NEEDS. WITH
THE WAY THINGS ARE GOING RIGHT
NOW. AND I'VE GOING BACK TO MY
LAW SCHOOL. EXPERIENCE THERE
ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT HAPPEN
IN EVENTS LIKE EMERGENCIES. YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S HABEAS CORPUS
OR. WE HAVE MARTIAL LAW FOR.
EMERGENCY NATURAL DISASTER
DECLARATIONS THESE ARE ALL
IDENTIFIED AS TEMPORARY BUT
IMPORTANT GESTURES TO ACHIEVE
STABILITY FOR SECURITY OR
SAFETY. AND I THINK IF SINCE WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE IN A
HOUSING EMERGENCY. I WOULD
SIMPLY ASK THAT MAYBE IT WOULD
BE MORE PRUDENT IF THIS
LEGISLATION. HAD SOME SAFETY
VALVES IN IT MORE SO THAN EXIST
RIGHT NOW. IN ONE OF THEM WOULD
BE IN A TEN YEAR WINDOW FOR
SOMETHING THAT I THINK
ECONOMISTS AND FOLKS IN THE
INDUSTRY HAVE AMPLE DEBATE ON.
MAY PERHAPS A FIVE YEAR WINDOW
INSTEAD OF ITS CURRENT
EXPLORATION AT TWENTY THIRTY.
HOW ABOUT AN ANNUAL REVIEW ON
WHERE OUR HOUSING STOCK IS
GOING AND SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
ACTUALLY GAINING TRACTION. IN
ACHIEVING THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT NEEDING SO
DESPERATELY IN OUR STATE. I
THINK THAT COULD MAKE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS EVEN THOUGH I'M-
PHILOSOPHICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY OF THE OPINION
THAT RENT CONTROL IS NOT GOING
TO GIVE US WHAT WE NEED. I
THINK WE KNOW THAT THE VOTE
COUNT IN THE POLITICAL SUPPORT
WILL BRING THIS TO REALITY. BUT
PERHAPS IT MIGHT BE MADE BETTER
FOR AT LEAST MORE ACCOUNTABLE
IF WE HAD SOME SAFETY VALVES
INCORPORATED INTO THIS MORE
THAT EXISTS RIGHT NOW. I CAN
ONLY OFFER THAT IS A RESPECTFUL
RECOMMENDATION BUT JUST TO
REITERATE. INSTEAD OF IT BEING
AT TWENTY THIRTY MAKE IT FIVE
YEARS. AND REQUIRE. EXPERTS
WITHIN. THE RELEVANT FIELD TO
REPORT BACK TO US ON WHETHER OR
pTO THE WE DON'T LET TOO MUCH
TIME EXPIRE BEFORE RE
CORRECTING THE COURSE. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS BAND
THESE ARE THE TYPE OF DEBATES I
THINKER I'VE RATHER WE DON'T
DEBATE THIS IS THE TYPE OF
DISCUSSIONS THAT I THINK ARE
VERY VALUABLE ON OUR FLOOR. AND
I NOTE THAT IT WAS EITHER TODAY
OR MAYBE POSTED YESTERDAY
ONLINE THE SACRAMENTO BEE ONCE
AGAIN REPORTED THAT
CALIFORNIA'S POVERTY RATE
ACCORDING TO NEW CENSUS BUREAU
DATA IS THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION. AND WHEN YOU ACCOUNT
FOR COST OF LIVING. OUR POVERTY
RATE IS ONLY EXCEEDED BY
WASHINGTON DC. WE ARE IN THE
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE ARE IN
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT BUILT IN A
FALLACY. AND I KNOW THAT MANY
OF YOU AND I HAVE BEEN DOING
OUR BEST TO. FULLY GIVE A GREEN
LIGHT TO GET MUCH MORE HOUSING
AND TO DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT
FOR NOW DECADES WE DID NOT
BUILD ENOUGH BUT WE CAN NOT
BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
CRISIS FAST ENOUGH. AND
MEANWHILE WE HAVE MORE IN MORE.
WORKING. CALIFORNIANS FAMILIES
REGULAR PEOPLE. WHO ARE BEING
DISPLACED FROM THEIR RESIDENTS.
IN MY DISTRICT ALONE. AND I
USUALLY BUY PREVIOUSLY IN
ACCURATELY SAID THERE WAS A 47%
INCREASE IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
IT WAS ONLY 43% DON'T QUIBBLE.
BUT FORTY 3% MORE PEOPLE RIGHT
IN MY HOME TOWN AREA. OF
OAKLAND BERKELEY EMERYVILLE AND
THE SURROUNDING AREAS BECAME
HOMELESS. MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
HAVE CHILDREN THEY'RE ALL
WORKING THEY'RE NOT ADDICTED
THEY'RE NOT MENTALLY ILL THE
CHEST FACE THAT SITUATION OF AN
UNEXPECTED EXPENSE OR EIGHT
ILLNESS OR THE LOSS OF A JOB OR
SOMETHING THAT PUT HIM IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OR MAYBE AN
ILLEGAL EVICTION BUT NOT IN ALL
CASES WHERE. THEY HAD TO LEAVE
WHERE THEY LIVED AND THEY ARE
NW IN THEIR ARS WERE ON
COUCHES WERE IN THE STREET. I
DON'T WANT ANYMORE TO BE
DISPLACED MY HEART CAN'T TAKE
IT. THIS BILL GIVES THOSE
PEOPLE TEMPORARILY RID RELIEF
TEN YEARS OF TEMPORARY RELIEF
WHILE WE DO OUR BEST TO BUILD
OURSELVES OUT OF IT. AND FOR MY.
FOR THE RESIDENTS OF MY
DISTRICT THAT HAVE BECOME NEWLY
HOMELESS. I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND TO PREVENT.
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS AND TO GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STEM THIS TIDE
WHAT WE DO OUR BEST TO BUILD
OUR WAY OUT OF IT WITHOUT I
ASKED ZERO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORE LOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THANKS FOR THE
VALUABLE DISCUSSION ON THIS
TOPIC. FOR ME MISDIAGNOSIS IS
TOUGH. TO OBSERVE AND WATCH SO.
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THE
TEMPORARY HOUSING SHORTAGE.
COLLEAGUES THAT THE TWO WORDS
RENT CONTROL FOR ME IS LIKE
FINGERNAILS SCRATCHING ON A
BLACKBOARD. BUT I HAVE TO ADMIT
THAT A 5% ANNUAL INCREASE PLUS
CPI AS A CAP IS VERY VERY
GENEROUS ESPECIALLY WHEN REPORT
TENSION LATE AT THE TOP. OF A
MARKET WAY TO GO. SO WHAT DO
YOU DO WHEN YOU HAVE AN
AGREEMENT THAT MAKES SO MUCH
SENSE. HOW DO YOU PASS IT UP.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT. BUT IF IT
THIS INCENTIVIZE IS THE
CREATION OF MORE NEW HOUSING
WERE TOAST. MISDIAGNOSIS COULD
BE. HAPPENING HERE AS A FREE
MARKET PERSON THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS FOR THE PROBLEM WE
KNOW. BUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
POPULATION TRENDS. RECESSION
ECONOMIC CYCLES AND THEN
POTENTIALLY OVER BUILDING. AND
THOSE ARE THE WAYS THAT WE
CORRECT HOUSING DEMAND SO
COLLEAGUES PATIENCE PATIENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT UP
SENATOR LABEL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS WE CAN'T
HAVE IT BOTH WAYS WE CANNOT AS
A STATE AND AS A COUNTRY NOT
HOLD CORPORATIONS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE LOW POVERTY WAGES THAT
THEY PAY WORKERS AND THEN SAY
THAT THERE'S NOT A PROBLEM THAT
THAT THAT WEEK WE SHOULDN'T
SOLVE. THE RENT PROBLEM. UNTIL
WE DECIDE THAT WORKERS DESERVE
A LIVING WAGE UNTIL WE DOES
DECIDE THAT CORPORATIONS WHO
MAKE BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SHOULD SHARE SOME OF
THAT WITH THE WORKERS WHO PUSH
THE MONEY UP TO THEM. THIS IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE A
PROBLEM DO WE HAVE A HOUSING
SHORTAGE OF COURSE WE HAVE HAD
A HOUSING SHORTAGE. THAT WE
KNOW HOW TO FIX BUT HOW DO WE
FIX THE RENT AND HOW DO WE FIX.
THAT PEOPLE CAN'T PAY THE RENT
ONE OF THE WAYS IS THROUGH
WAGES BUT WE DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT WE DON'T ADDRESS THAT WE
ALLOW CORPORATIONS WHO HOLD
MORE WEALTH THAN THEY'VE EVER
HELD IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY. TO CONTINUE TO BE
GREEDY UNTIL WE HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE AND MAKE THEM FORCE
THEM TO PAY LIVING WAGES THIS
IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM. I'VE TOLD THIS STORY
BEFORE BUT I'M GONNA TELL IT
AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK IT BEARS
REPEATING AND IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS I RAN FOR OFFICE. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHEN
MYSELF AND MY HUSBAND GOT
MARRIED WE MADE TWELVE DOLLARS
AN HOUR IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT DO YOU KNOW PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW THAT BARELY MAKE THAT AND
THE ONLY REASON THEY DO IS
BECAUSE WE RAISE THE MINIMUM
WAGE WE HAVE THE LEGISLATURE
HAD TO DO IT BECAUSE
CORPORATIONS WOULDN'T DO THE
RIGHT THING. WE MADE TWELVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR WE BOUGHT A
HOUSE. THIS WAS. NINE NINE. IN
DOLLARS EIGHT TOURISTS THE TWO.
AS AN GAS WAS NINETY TWO CENTS
A GALLON FAST OVER THIRTY YEARS
THAT HOUSE IS WORTH FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
RELEASE IS SELLING FOR FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S WORTH FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS GAS IS
ABOUT FOUR DOLLARS A GALLON
EXIT THREE TO SIX DOLLARS A
DOZEN WHAT SHOULD THAT GROCERY
CLERK THAT WAS MAKING TWELVE
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BE MAKING IF IT'S GOING
TO KEEP UP WITH. EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT'S GONE UP AROUND THEM.
FIFTY DOLLARS AN HOUR TO ME FOR
EIGHT DOLLARS AN HOUR WHAT DOES
THAT GROCERY WORKER MAKE TODAY.
TWENTY ONE DOLLARS AN HOUR IF
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO LET
EVERYTHING RISE AROUND US
EXCEPT REAL WAGES. WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO FIX THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM. BUT I THINK THE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO GOES A LONG
WAY AND PEOPLE WHO NEED OUR
HELP. THINGS COME TO THIS
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE OUTSIDE OF
THIS BUILDING. PEOPLE DON'T DO
THE RIGHT THING AND WERE FORCED
TO DO THE RIGHT THING SO I'M
HAPPY TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND DO A LITTLE PART. ARE PART
IN HELPING PEOPLE REMAIN IN
THEIR APARTMENT. IN THEIR
RENTAL HOME. WE CAN'T SEE MORE
PEOPLE ON THE STREET WE CAN'T
WE CAN'T BE CONSIDERING
LEGISLATION TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
SLEEP IN THEIR CARS. ISN'T THAT
AWFUL THAT WERE THINKING ABOUT
THAT. SO UNTIL WE DECIDE THAT
WE WANT OF WORLD CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY PAY LIVING WAGES. THIS IS
THE LEAST THAT WE CAN DO FOR
PEOPLE I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN. THAT
ARE PRESENT LADIES GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE. AS IT LISTEN TO
THIS DEBATE. I'M REMINDED OF
HOW MANY YEARS I'VE LISTENED TO
THIS SAME DEBATE. QUITE A LONG
TIME. NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
THE PROBLEM HAS BEEN TINKERED
WITH. MORE OFTEN MADE WORSE. BY
OWNERS STATUTES AND REGULATIONS.
EVEN ADVOCATES FOR THE HOMELESS
OF COMPLAINT. IN TESTIMONY. THE
COST OF HOUSING FOR THE HOME
LAST THAT THEY WANT TO BE
ADVOCATING FOR IN SECURING
HOUSING FOR. SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE EXPENSE TO BUILD
THAT WILL THOSE HOMES THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE OF STATE
AND LOCAL REGULATIONS. THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO REALLY SINCERELY
FROM THEIR HEARTS AND
PASSIONATELY WANT TO SECURE
HOUSING. IT IS AFFECTED MY OWN
FAMILY. ONE OF MY DAUGHTERS AND
HER HUSBAND AND HER TWO
GRANDSONS. HAVE MOVED TO
ANOTHER STATE. LAST MONTH.
AFTER MANY YEARS SETTLING IN A
BAY AREA COUNTY. WITH VERY GOOD
JOBS THAT HIGH RANKING U. S.
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE RANGERS.
THEY CONCLUDED THEY'LL NEVER BE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO HAVE A HOME.
OF THEIR OWN. IN CALIFORNIA. SO
THEY. LIKE IN RAND'S BOOK ATLAS
SHRUGGED. THEY'VE GONE. THEY
FOUND ANOTHER PLACE ALREADY.
HOME GREATER THAN THE ONE THAT
THEY WERE READING. AND MUCH
LESS COST TO THEM THE BY THEN
WAS FOR THEM IN THAT AREA. I
GUESS WE SORT OF DESERVE WHAT
WE GET AND COMPLAINING ABOUT
IT. OVER THESE DECADES. HAS NOT
ACHIEVED VERY MUCH. MAYBE ANY
EFFORT IS WELL WORTH IT. BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FIGURES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE. AND
EVEN THE QUOTE DEAL. DOES NOT
TAKE US VERY FAR DOWN THE PATH.
WE ALSO THEN HAVE ISSUES SUCH
AS OUR FIRE IN PARADISE WHERE
THERE ARE ORGANIZATIONS.
ACTIVELY SEEKING TO DE POPULATE
THESE AREAS ANOTHER DO NOT
REBUILT. WE DON'T WANT YOU. TO
STAY LIVING HERE. THE
CALIFORNIA. IN PARADISE IN
BUTTE COUNTY. THAT IS NOT AN
ANSWER. AN ANSWER CERTAINLY IS
SUPPLY. AND I'D LIKE TO HEAR A
LOT MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
WE ENHANCE AND EXPAND. SUPPLY.
THE REGULATORY RELIEF IN PART.
BY DOING THINGS THAT PROVIDE
MORE JOBS TO CALIFORNIANS. SO
THEY CAN AFFORD TO BUY. BUT NOT
WITHOUT THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
EQUATION BEING HANDLED AND THAT
IS THE COSTS. OF THAT HOUSING
ITSELF. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THIS MAY BE A STEP. BUT I THINK
IT COULD BE SAFELY ASSURED. IN
FIVE YEARS. WE'LL BE HAVING
EXACTLY THE SAME DEBATE HERE.
AND THIS REMEDY. WE'LL HAVE
BEEN PERICA BEST. AND MORE
PEOPLE WILL HAVE LEFT
CALIFORNIA. AND FEWER. OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO STAY. WHERE THEY WERE BORN
AND RAISED. THAT'S A SAD
COMMENTARY ABOUT A GREAT STATE.
I URGE NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
IS BEEN A REALLY INTRIGUING
THOUGHTFUL DEBATE AND AS I SAID
HER LISTEN TO MY COLLEAGUES I
SAID I. REALIZE THAT I HATE
HATE HATE TO ADMIT. BUT I AM
OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER THAT MY
PARENTS PAID ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN DOLLARS A MONTH FOR A
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IN THE
MARK PARK. EITHER I'M REALLY
REALLY OLD OR THE RENT CAR
ROCKETED IN A VERY. FEW YEARS I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT OLD. AND WE ALL ARE CLEAR
THAT WE HAVEN'T BILL TODAY WE
ARE ALL CLEAR THAT OUR
POPULATION HAS GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY. BUT YOU KNOW I
WORRY ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS I
REPRESENT BALL ONE VILLAGE IN
LOS ANGELES CITY COUNTY ONE OF
THE AREAS THAT MR AMERICA
pCALIFORNIA. BUILT ON A AND
DESIGNED A HIGH END APARTMENT
COMMUNITY HI IT'S
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS THE
JUNGLE. AND IT WAS KNOWN AS THE
JUNGLE BECAUSE HE IMPORTED
TROPICAL PLANTS AND FOR ALLEGE
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD. EVERY
APARTMENT BUILDING HAD SWIMMING
POOLS WE WERE WALKING CLOSETS
AND IT WAS HIGH LIVIN AS MY
FATHER WOULD SAY IN LOS ANGELES.
ALL THOSE APARTMENT BUILDINGS
IN THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THEM
IN THIS COMMUNITY WERE BUILT
MANY OF THEM ON STILTS WITH THE
PARKING UNDERNEATH. YOU KNOW IN
THE FIFTIES. AND I WORRY ABOUT
SEISMIC SAFETY I KNOW A NUMBER
OF THOSE APARTMENT OWNERS IN
THAT COMMUNITY THEY WERE MY
PARENTS PEERS AND I WORRY THAT
IF THE WIND THE NEXT BIG ONE
COMES A LOS ANGELES AND BALLING.
IT IS HOME TO THOUSANDS OF
ANGELENOS. AND YOU KNOW THAT
WAS INTO THIS DEBATE I'M
REMINDED THAT PROPERTY
OWNERSHIP IS VERY SIMILAR TO
RUNNING A BUSINESS AND THE
DEBATE IS SIMILAR ON THIS FLOOR.
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT INCREASING
MINIMUM WAGE. TRYING TO BRING A
CLOSER TO A LIVABLE WAGE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HEARD THE
BUSINESSES COULDN'T AFFORD AND
THEY WOULD GO OUT OF TOWN THEY
WOULD BUT LEAVE THE STATE. WELL
THE SAME APPLY PROPERTY OWNERS
WHO RELY ON RENTAL INCOME. TO
MAKE A PROFIT TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGE WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE A COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT OWN
PROPERTY THAT'S FIFTY YEARS OLD
WELL YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS IF
YOU OWN PROPERTY FOR A GOOD
NUMBER OF YEARS OF WHAT EVER
WRITTEN YOU'RE EARNING THIS
PROBABLY TURNING A PROFIT FOR
YOU. SO MUCH LIKE THE
BUSINESSES THE QUESTION IS HOW
DO WE CREATE A SENSE OF
BALANCE. WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
STOP I'M NOT TRYING TO START
BUSINESSES FOR MAKING A PROFIT.
BUT ON THE BACKS OF. AND
CREATING THE SENSE OF BALANCE.
BUSINESSES ARE SUCCESSFUL WHENTHEY HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
EMPLOYEES WELL TRAINED. HAPPY
EMPLOYEES THAT DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY OF SERVICE THAT
INCREASE THE PROPERTY ON YOUR
BUSINESS. PROPERTY OWNERS RELY
ON RENTER'S BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD YOUR RENT OR YOU WILL
HAVE IN THE UNITS PHILLIPS IT'S
NOT A US VERSUS THEM IT'S A
WEAK SCENARIO. AS WE TALK ABOUT
HOW WE BUILD THE CALIFORNIA
THAT EVERYONE CAN AFFORD TO BE
HOUSED IN. OUR COLLEAGUE SAID
THAT OVER TIME THE WE'VE
TINKERED AROUND THIS ISSUE FOR
A WHILE IT'S PROBABLY RIGHT. I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR PERHAPS.
THAT WE STOP TINKERING AND
ENGAGE IN SOME RADICAL THINKING
A RADICAL CHANGE. BECAUSE WE
ARE EXPERIENCING. LIVING
CONDITIONS IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE THAT
REQUIRES RADICAL ACTION ON OUR
PART. WE WATCHED AREAS ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY IN STATE THAT
PERHAPS. PROPERTY IS LOWER THAT
HAVE LESS REGULATION AND DON'T
HAVE THIS ONEROUS ZONING
REQUIREMENTS IN THOSE ARE ALSO
AREAS THAT I'VE SEEN TEXAS
BEING ONCE THEY OR WE THOUGHT
MASS DEVASTATION. WHERE WE
LEARNED THAT PROPERTY LIFE WAS
LOST IN PROPERTY WAS LOST
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF REGULATION
AND A LACK OF ADHERENCE TO A
ZONING PERSPECTIVE. WE LIVE IN
EARTHQUAKE WE LIVE IN FIRE
COUNTRY AND SO WE DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY OF NOT BEING
THOUGHTFUL AND DEVELOPING
REGULATIONS THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO BUILD HOUSING AND STRUCTURES
THAT WILL PROTECT LIVES. AND
CAN BE SUSTAINED OVER TIME. IS
THE PER UNIT COST FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO HIGH ABSOLUTELY
DOES IT VARY WIDELY ACROSS THE
STATE YES. AND SO THOSE ARE ALL
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE TAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEBATE AND
COME TO A CONCLUSION AND HOW WE
MANAGE IT AND A HEALTHY
PRODUCTIVE WAY. TO CREATE TO
CONTINUE TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION. AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S NOT SUCH THAT
VIRTUALLY NO ONE ARE ONLY THE
1% CAN AFFORD IT. I AM A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO AND WILL BE SUPPORT IT
TODAY. AND WHAT I WOULD JUST
CHALLENGE ALL OF US TO THINK IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE COLLEAGUES TO
WAX FOR ELOQUENTLY ON THIS
FLOOR. TO GET TO A CONCLUSION
OF A NO VOTE. AND SO IF WE
CONTINUE TO SAY NO. TO THESE
CHRONIC. SITUATIONS THAT WE ALL
FIND OURSELVES IN WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO SAY YES TO ARE WE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TINKER OR
CONTINUE TO DEBATE OR WAX
FOURTH ELOQUENT ON PUBLIC
POLICY SOLUTIONS AND BRING
NOTHING TO THE TABLE AS A
SOLUTION THAT'S NOT HELPFUL TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE MINE. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I AM PROUD
TODAY TO VOTE FOR A SOLUTION AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MADAM PRO TEM.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW LET ME.
BEFORE I GET SERIES LET ME JUST
A KNOWLEDGE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALDWIN HILLS AND TELL HER I'M
NOT GOING TO ANSWER HER
QUESTION. BUT I AM GOING TO
REMIND MY COLLEAGUES SHE HAD A
BIRTHDAY ON SATURDAY AND I'M SO
SORRY. WE FORGOT TO WISH YOU A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY NOT ANSWERING
THE QUESTION HOWEVER. ON A
SERIOUS NOTE. LOOK I
APPRECIATE. THE VIGOROUS
DISCUSSION THIS DISCUSSION WE
HAVE HAD. AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM TO HIM I WAS IN HERE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. WHEN YOU
WORK BUT I WOULD SAY. OF THE
ISSUE HERE IS THAT THIS IS A
VERY COMPLICATED. ISSUE IN
TERMS OF HOW TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT OVER THE LAST TWO TO
THREE DECADES WE HAVE REDUCED
AND REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
PRODUCTION WE HAVE WE KNOW THAT
IT TOOK US TEN TO TWENTY TO
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS TO WORK
OURSELVES INTO THIS DILEMMA.
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE ADVANCING
LEGISLATION TO TRY TO IT DID
ADDRESS THE PRODUCTION ISSUE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
OVER THERE A NUMBER OF OTHER
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE HAVE TRIED TO ADVANCE.
OUR LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THE
PRODUCTION SIDE AS WELL AS THE
FUNDING SIDE MANY OF THE
FUNDING ISSUES WE'VE BEEN
SOMEWHAT SUCCESSFUL ODD. SO
WHERE ARE WE YOU KNOW I GOT
HERE IN TWENTY ELEVEN TO BEGIN
A TWENTY ELEVEN. SIZE WE
BECAUSE I WANTED TO WORK ON
HOUSING AND I SAID WE HAVE A
PROBLEM. WE HAVE A PROBLEM WE
HAVE A PROBLEM AND BECAUSE OF
THE POLITICAL REALITIES IN THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT EACH OF US
FEEL FROM DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
WE'VE HAD A HARD TIME
COMPLETELY ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM. I WOULD SAY I'D- JUST
A FEW POINTS. THE KID IN THE
ISSUE TODAY WE ARE IN A CRISIS.
AND IN STATE LAW THERE ARE ANTI
GALGIANI. LAWS THAT ADDRESS
WITH ALMOST ANY KIND OF NATURAL
DISASTER AS AS I SAID. THERE
ISN'T ONE THAT SORT OF FITS
THIS MOLD. WE HAVE TO WORK TO
FIND AN ANSWER TO ADDRESS THE
MOST EGREGIOUS SITUATIONS
SITUATIONS LIKE RENTERS WHO
WORK IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE
HOSPITALS PEOPLE WITH GOOD
CAREERS. CAREER SAID IF YOU
KNOW WHERE I GREW UP IF I HAD A
CAREER AS A NURSERY TEACHER.
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN MAKING IT IN
LIFE. THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MAKING IT. SO HOW DO YOU HAVE A
GOOD CAREER AND YOU'RE MAKING
IT AND YOU CAN'T AFFORD THE
RENT. SO WHETHER IT'S IN OUR
SCHOOLS ARE HOSPITAL SMALL
BUSINESSES EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THEY DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED
FROM AGREE JUST RENT INCREASES
AND CAPRICIOUS EVICTIONS THAT
COULD LEAD THEM HOMELESS WE'RE
SEEING THAT HAPPEN. THE PEOPLE
WHO WILL BE MOST AFFECTED BY A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
APARTMENT OWNERS AND BUILDERS.
ARE ACTUALLY NOT OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. AND THAT'S A
REACTION OF A FOLLOW UP FROM
THE BALLOT MEASURE THAT ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES REFERENCED. THIS
IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN THAT
BALLOT MEASURE. IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THOSE VERY
PEOPLE OPPOSED CAME TO THE
TABLE AND SAID LET'S KEEP
HAMMERING OUT SOME SOLUTIONS
HERE. THAT CAN GET US DOWN THE
ROAD WHILE WE DEAL IN A DRESS
IF WE CAN THE ISSUE OF
PRODUCTION. FOR THE VERY PEOPLE
OPPOSED ARE NOW NEUTRAL BECAUSE
THEY'VE WEIGHED IN AND THEY'VE
SAID. HERE'S WHAT WE THINK. AND
SO THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL OUT
WORKING WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS
HAS REALLY TRIED TO THREAD A
VERY VERY. THEN NEEDLE. AND I
JUST I HAVE TO SAY THERE ARE
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
RENT CONTROL THIS IS NOT RENT
CONTROL. THIS IS. NOT RENT
CONTROL IT IS A RENT CAP. IN
CPI. COMBINED IN ORDER TO ALLOW
PROPERTY OWNERS TO CONTINUE. TO
HAVE THEIR INVESTMENT BE REAL.
THEY'LL STILL BE ABLE TO PROFIT
FROM THEIR INVESTMENTS AND
MANAGE THEIR PROPERTIES SO IT'S
NOT EVERY DAY WHERE YOU'RE ABLE
TO GET TEN IT GROUPS AND
BUSINESS INTEREST TO COME
TOGETHER TO COMPROMISE ON
GETTING SOME SIGNIFICANT RELIEF
TO RENTERS I DO WANT TO ADD MY
THANKS TO SENATOR HERTZBERG WHO
CAME VERY CLOSE TO NEGOTIATING
AN AGREEMENT ON THIS ISSUE LAST
YEAR. BUT RAN OUT OF TIME. AND
I HAVE TO THANK THE BILL'S
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU. AND THOSE WHO'VE
NEGOTIATED THE BILL FOR
BRINGING THIS FINAL PRODUCT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY TO ME FOR A LONG TIME.
BUT I THINK YOU ALSO KNOW I'M
NOT ONE TO STAND UP AND TAKE A
LEAD ON EVERY BILL IN THIS
HOUSE EVERY BILL THE A IT'S
JUST NOT. WHAT I THINK MY JOB
IS AS THE PRO TEM OF THE SENATE.
BUT THIS BILL. IS DIFFERENT.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- MANAGING AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. IS NECESSARY FOR US
TO DO AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS NOW. TO
ANSWER A COMMON OF ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES. THERE IS AN LA TEN
YEAR REVIEW. I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED FIVE YEARS OR SAID
ELLIE TENURE REVIEW TO
DETERMINE. WHAT WERE WE ABLE TO
DO IN THE TIME. THAT WE HAVE
ALLOWED FOR THE SUNSET. BUT I
WOULD ALSO SAY TO MY COLLEAGUES
WHO CHAIR. COMMITTEES HOUSING
GOVERNMENT FINANCE OTHERS. AND
THE VICE CHAIRS. WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO LOOK AT THIS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS AND TO HAVE THE
NUMBERS COME FORWARD WE HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO KIND OF MONITOR
THIS AS WE GO AND I WOULD URGE
US. TO DO THAT BECAUSE I THINK.
IT IS PART OF REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHERE WE ARE ARE.
AND I WOULD SAY. YOU KNOW THE
MARKET DOES RESPOND TO THIS I
SEE LOTS OF CRANES IN THE AIR
IN DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO THAT I
DIDN'T SEE. FIVE YEARS AGO. THE
ISSUE IS THE MARKET IS HELPING
US TO BUILD LUXURY CONDOS AND
LUXURY APARTMENTS. AND THAT'S
PART OF THE SUPPLY ISSUE BUT IN
TERMS OF AFFORDABLE OR LOW
INCOME BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO SAY WHAT IS AFFORDABLE
TODAY. WE'RE HAVING TO PUT
MONEY FORWARD TO SUBSIDIZE
DEVELOPERS WHO ARE TRYING TO
BUILD. THIS IS A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE. THAT WILL ALLOW US THE
TIME. TO WORK ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES IN POLICY AND BUDGET BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THOSE PEOPLE
THAT WE'VE MENTIONED AND HEARD
THE STORIES ABOUT THE ONES THAT
KEEP MISS SKINNER AWAKE AT
NIGHT. THEY CAN'T WAIT FOR US
TO CONTINUE THIS DIALOGUE WHICH
IN SOME OF OUR CASES IS REALLY
THEORETICAL WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THESE
CONSTITUENTS UP AND DOWN OUR
STATE. REGARDLESS NORTH SOUTH
INLAND COASTAL OUT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THESE
RESIDENTS TO TRY TO GIVE SOME
RELIEF. TO TRY TO GET SOME
RELIEF AND IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
US TO SEE THIS THROUGH AND TO
TAKE UP THOSE ISSUES THOSE
OTHER ISSUES RELATED TO THIS
DILEMMA SO THAT WE BEGIN TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE A GREAT STATE. BUT THE
ISSUE THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH
NOW THAT WILL IMPACT OUR
ECONOMY IS THE ISSUE OF WHETHER
EMPLOYEES HAVE HOUSING OR MY
PLAYERS HAVE HOUSING FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHETHER OUR
RESIDENTS. WHETHER OUR KIDS ARE
ABLE TO LIVE HERE WHETHER OUR
PARENTS ARE ABLE TO DOWNSIZE
AND GET AN APPROPRIATELY SIZED.%
APARTMENT OR CONDO THAT THEY
CAN AFFORD THAT IS CONDUCIVE TO
THEIR THEIR LIVES AS WE AGE.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE
ACTION AND- WITH GREAT
APPRECIATION TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THE DIALOGUE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DEBATE THIS I KNOW
BUT WHILE WE CONTINUE TO DEBATE
THE SOLUTIONS. I SURE HOPE THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA LEAVE PEOPLE
HANGING IN THE BALANCE TODAY
WHO NEED OUR HELP NOW I
STRONGLY THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES THANK THE AUTHOR
AGAIN I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BELL. HI PORGES NOPE
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG NO
DALLY. DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
TITLE. JACKSON BY JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK.
MORRELL NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE
NO NUMBER. BY CASKEY. I WIENER
AYE WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
BRADFORD HI. DALY NO GALGIANI.
HUESO HI TADO. MORE LOCK.
NUMBER ONE MORE TIME PLEASE.
ARCHULETA GALGIANI TADO. MORE
LOCK NUMBER. FIVE TWENTY FIVE
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE CARRIES.
PLEASE. THIS IS GREAT ANYTHING
ELSE IS NOT THANK YOU FOLKS
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
SENATOR HERTZBERG TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. FOR SURE SIR
VASE MAYOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS CATCH MY BREATH WAKE OF ALL
VOTE DECIDES. LIKE MY FATHER
ONCE A MADE ENTIRE PRODUCES
PRESENTATION THE COURT
MUSICIAN. THE COURT REPORTER
COULDN'T QUITE GET IT. VASE
MAYOR OKAY THERE'S A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO SUSPEND JOINT
RULE SIXTY ONE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ALLOWING ASSEMBLY BILLS. AB
SEVEN THIRTY ON MAKE SURE I GET
THIS RIGHT AND AB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR TO BE AMENDED AFTER THE
DEADLINE THESE REQUESTS HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
PLEASE MISTER SECRETARY READ
THE RESOLUTION. RESULT THE
GENERAL SIXTY ONE BE DISPENSED
WITH TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN THIRTY AND SOME PEOPLE
SOME FORTY FOUR TO BE AMENDED
AFTER THE DEADLINE AS REQUESTED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MISTER CENTER
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL I PORGES
NO BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG. DALLY NOTE DODD HI
DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TADO I
JACKSON HI I JONES NO LEYVA. I
AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. NIELSEN MORRELL NO.
NIELSEN NO NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER IOWA CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK. VICE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS EIGHT THE JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED WE'RE NOW COLORS
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN. FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN YOUR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS HI BATES. GROVE TITLE.
JONES FOR TITLE II JONES II
MORE LOCK. MORRELL BY STONE.
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME ON FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN. BATES GROVE
MORE LOCK. STONE WILK. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES AT THIS POINT IN TIME A
COLLEAGUES IF THERE ARE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO BE MADE
SENATOR BAIL. ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
MEET TO IMMEDIATELY AFTER OUR
BREAK IN ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE
YEAR ONE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAIL UPON OUR RECESS WE
WILL HAVE A COMMITTEE HEARING
AND CENTER FOR A SHOW FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SIR MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE IN FIVE MINUTES FIVE
MINUTES MEMBERS. FIVE MINUTES
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. IN FIVE
MINUTES AND WE WILL TAKE A ONE
HOUR RECESS I'M SORRY SENATOR
ALLEN EXCUSE ME. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING RIGHT
AFTER WE ADJOURN WE RECESS HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWO ZERO
FOUR ZERO HOME TWENTY FORTY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
A ONE HOUR RECESS AND WE WILL
BE BACK AT TWO O'CLOCK. SHARP
WE ARE IN RECESS
. BUT ALL
SENATORS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
SENATE FLOOR ALL SENATORS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PLEASE SUITS
TO ALL THREE. WE WANT TO RE
COMMANDS ARE SENATE SESSION
THERE WAS TO START AT TWO PM.
ALL SENATORS PLEASE TO THE
SENATE FLOOR
. COLLEAGUES WE ARE
BACK ON THE FILE WE ARE WORKING
THE FILE TODAY IT WE WILL. TO
THE FOLLOWING FIVE BILLS SO
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE ONE OF
THESE BILLS PLEASE BE PREPARED
TO PROCEED. WE WILL START WITH
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE THAT
IS THE BILL BEING MANAGED BY A
SENATOR DODD. FILE ITEM.
1-291-313-1130 TWO AND THEN ONE
THIRTY THREE. 1-000-291-3130
ONE ONE THIRTY TWO AND ONE
THIRTY THREE. STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE.
SENATOR DODD. NODDED HIS SHEET
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
NOT AT HIS SHEET FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE. SENATOR ARCHER
LETTER HE WHO IS AT HIS SHEET.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
COLLEAGUES WE ARE ON FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS AN ACT RELATING TO
DISABLED VETERANS. SENATE
ARCHER LETTER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR. PASS ON FILE. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL KEEP GOING AND
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO
SENATOR MITCHELL. NOT AT HER
SHEET FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
THREE SENATOR WILK. SENATOR
WILL FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AND ACT
REALLY NEW CHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY SENATOR WHAT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. I'M GOING TO
CONNECT THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWELVE FORTY ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO INCLUDE THE
PERCENTAGE OF PUPILS WHO ESSEX
THAT'S SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED
COURSES THAT SATISFY THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ENTRANCE TO
THE UC AND THIS TO USE YOU. AS
A MEASURE OF PUPIL ACHIEVEMENT
AND THEIR LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS AND THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLES WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED COURSES
THAT SATISFY THE REQUIREMENTS.
OF C. T. E. SEQUENCES OR BOTH.
BY TREATING BOTH A THROUGH G.
COURSES AND C. T. E. COURSES AS
AN EITHER OR OPTION FOR
STUDENTS WE ARE UNFAIR UNFAIRLY
CATEGORIZE YOU STUDENTS IN A
MANNER THAT HAS PROVEN
INEFFECTIVE IN OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. TODAY'S EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS IN CALIFORNIA DEMAND
THAT WE PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
BOTH THE WORK FORCE AND COLLEGE
IN A MORE PRACTICAL WAY AB
TWELVE FORTY SUPPORTS THESE
IDEAS AND SEEKS TO ALIGN
REPORTING WITH THE GOALS OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. RECENT AMENDMENTS FIX A
CAPTURING CHATTERING OUT ISSUE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WILK IS
HER ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONCE AND THEN PLACE THE
ITEMS ON CALL UNTIL FURTHER
NOTICE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS. AYE BATES HI BILL.
BY BURGESS BY BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHAIN. DALLY I
DODD BY DORADO. GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI
TADO. HI. JACKSON HI HI JONES I
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE I'M MITCHELL.
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. I'M REAL
AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER BY STERN I STONE. I AM
BURKE FIVE A COUNTY. WIENER BY
CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE. WILK HI.
CENTER WILK MOVES TO CALL WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK AGAIN OVER THE
ITEMS THAT WE PASSED ON BECAUSE
AUTHORS WERE MANAGERS WERE NOT
AT THEIR DESK FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY NINE IS A PASS ON FILE.
WITH AMENDMENTS PENDING FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY. BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO SENATOR PORTANTINO
DO YOU WISH TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I PRESENT AB ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WHICH WILL
AUTHORIZE BEER MANY FACTORS TO
GIVE GLASSWARE DIRECTLY TO
RETAILERS RETAILERS WILL BE
AUTHORIZED TO RECEIVE UP TO TEN
GLASSES OF GLASSWARE PER YEAR.
UNDER AB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE
BEER MANUFACTURES COULD GIVE UP
TO FIVE CASES OF GLASSWARE TO
AN INDIVIDUAL RETAILER FOR
EXAMPLE A RETAILER COULD ACCEPT
FIVE EIGHT FIVE GLASSER FROM
ANY PARTICULAR VENDOR THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR BEER MANUFACTURES TO
PROVIDE GLASSWARE TO RETAILERS
BUT PLACES A REASONABLE LIMIT.
ON THAT NUMBER IT HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN OUR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL
BY BURGESS. I BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE TING AYE DALY AYE
DODD. I DRAWS SO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
I TADO I JACKSON. JONES BY.
LEYVA I'M ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY I'M MORE LUCK. I'M
REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY RUBIO.
SKINNER BY STERN AYE STONE BY
AMBERG OUR CASKEY I WIENER. HI
WILK HI. SENATOR PORTANTINO
MOVES A CALL OF FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE WAS A PASS ON FILE
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TO SENATOR
MITCHELL. SENATOR MITCHELL DO
YOU WISH TO TAKE UP FILE ONE
THIRTY TWO. ALL RIGHT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT CALLING FOR THE
CHILD'S ABILITY TO HEAR SHOULD
NOT BE DETERMINED BY THEIR
FAMILY INCOME YET HERE IN OUR
STATE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
CHILDREN'S HEARING AIDS OUT OF
POCKET. OR SIMPLY HAVE TO
FOREGO THEM ALL TOGETHER. AB
FIVE NINE EIGHT ADDRESSES THIS
GAP IN COVERAGE BY REQUIRING
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS AND
HEALTH INSURANCE POLICIES TO
INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
FEAR NAY. COVERAGE INCLUDES THE
INITIAL HEARING ASSESSMENT NEW
HEARING AIDS AT LEAST EVERY
FOUR YEARS NEW EAR MALLS AND A
NEW HEARING AID AT THE EXISTING
ONE IS NO LONGER WORKING. THE
COST OF THE HEARING AID IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BEER YOUR
APPEARANCE OBTAINING PEDIATRIC
HEARING AIDS THESE DEVICES FROM
CASA DE SIX SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FOR A PAIR AND GROWING
CHILDREN THE THESE DEVICES
REPLACE FREQUENTLY. AB FIVE
NINE EIGHT WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN REGARDLESS
OF INCOME OR BACKGROUND HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
HEARING AIDS AND. HEARING AID
SERVICES I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR STONE
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT I
PROBABLY SUPPORTED A. B. FIVE
NINETY EIGHT AND THEY HEALTH.
COMMITTEE IF YOU HAVE A CHILD
THAT CANNOT HEAR THEY CANNOT
LEARN THEY CANNOT TO LISTEN THE
COMMANDS THAT. ARE VERY
IMPORTANT IF THEY'RE CROSSING
OF A STREET WHEN THERE'S WHEN
THERE'S TRAFFIC I ALWAYS
THOUGHT THAT THESE. BASIC
MEDICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS IS
OF EQUIPMENT WOULD BE COVERED
BY INSURANCE COMPANIES AND I
WAS KIND OF SHOCKED T LEARN
THAT. THEY WOULD BE EXCLUDED
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE COST
OF HEARING DEVICES HAVE REALLY
COME DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
THAN TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A
PAIR. ACTIVE OF THE PRICE IS NO
REASON WHY ANY CHILD THAT HAVE
HEARING IMPAIRMENTS SHOULD NOT
BE GIVEN THE STATE. STATE OF
OUR TECHNOLOGY TO ALLOW THEM TO
HEAR SO THAT THEY CAN LEARN AND
TO ENJOY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEIR FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES
FOR THOSE REASONS I HOPE YOU
ALL SUPPORT. AB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR STONE
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MR
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. I ATKINS
AYE BATES. HI BILL BY BURGESS.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD. HI DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG.
I HILL. I WITH SO. I TITLE BY
JACKSON HI BY JONES I LABOR BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL BY MONNING
BY MORE LOCK I AM A REAL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. AYE RUBIO. BY SKINNER
I STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
IRA CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILK.
BURGER WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE OUR
EES FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WE WILL NOW GO
THROUGH THE ROLE TWICE AND THEN
CLOSE THE ROLE WE DO HAVE A
FULL HOUSE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM WE TOOK UP A ONE THIRTY
THREE WE ARE GOING TO GO NOW
FILE ITEMS. ONE THIRTY FOUR ONE
THIRTY FIVE ONE THIRTY SIX ONE
THIRTY SEVEN AND ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
FOUR SENATOR LEYVA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US AN
ACT RELATING TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALING SENATOR LABEL
THANK YOU MADAMPRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
2% ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
FIVE A CLEANUP BILL THAT MAKES
A NUMBER OF NON CONTROVERSIAL
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IDENTIFIED AS
NECESSARY POLICY UPDATES. SOME
OF THE CHANGES ARE IN RESPONSE
TO RECENT LEGISLATION OR MAKING
ALIGNMENTS LIKE CHANGING
FOREIGN LANGUAGE TO WORLD
LANGUAGE AMENDMENTS WERE ALSO
TAKEN RECENTLY TO ADDRESS
ADDRESS CHAPTER RING OUT ISSUES
THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND ALSO HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. TING
IMPAIRING NONE IS TURNING.
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NON ICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE
SENATORS SKINNER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL AT NINE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AN ACT
RELATING TO CALPERS SENATORSKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB NINE FORTY
TWO. REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT MEALS
PROGRAM STATE WIDE THIS WILL
FURTHER INCREASE FOOD ACCESS
FOOD SECURITY AND FOOD CHOICES
FOR THOSE OF OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WHO RELY ON
CALIFORNIA'S LIKE ARE ELDERLY
AND OTHERS DISABLED WHO MAY
HAVE LESS ABILITY YOUR OPTIONS
TO COOK THEIR OWN FOOD AT HOME.
AB NINE FORTY TWO WAS RECEIVED
NO NO. THERE'S NO BEEN WITHOUT
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS FOR ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING ON ICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX
SENATOR HER DAUGHTER WERE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE SIDE OF.
CENTER HER DAUGHTER YOU PREPARE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE FREE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AN ACT
RELATING TO CALPERS SENATOR
FURTADO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT A.
B. SIX TWELVE ON BE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. WHICH
WOULD BUILD ON DOCTOR WEBBER'S
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HUNGER ON CC COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
50% OF STUDENTS EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE FOOD INSECURITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO STRUGGLE
WITH HUNGER ARE LESS LIKELY TO
EXCEL AND GRADUATE. IN
CALIFORNIA OVER SIXTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE IN COUNTIES
WITHOUT A CAL FRESHMAN STRUCK
MEALS PROGRAM SO THEY CAN'T
PROVIDE BENEFITS ON CAMPUS. THE
PROCESS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO BECOME A RESTAURANT MEAL
PROGRAM VENDOR CAN TAKE UP TO
TWO YEARS. AND REQUIRES A GOOD
SHE XIN AGREEMENTS WITH
MULTIPLE AGENTS AGENCIES. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL WOULD TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS ALLOWED
MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE CAL FRESH BENEFITS TO
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS TO ENSURE NO
STUDENTS GO HUNGRY. THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORTED BY OVER A DOZEN
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND
DISTRICTS AS WELL AS SEVERAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS. IT HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR FURTADO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING ON ICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG
NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. SENATOR SKINNER. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY IN CHILD SUPPORT.
SENATOR SKINNER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AB TEN
NINETY TWO ELIMINATES THE
INTEREST RATE THAT IS CHARGED
TO. CHILD SUPPORT DEBT THAT IS
BOWED TO THE STATE. RIGHT NOW
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONLY FIFTY
DOLLARS OF A CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENT GOES TO A FAMILY WHO IS
ON ANY FORM OF BENEFITS THAT WE
PROVIDE THE REMAINING BALANCE.
IS TAKEN BACK AND PAID TO THE
STATE FOR THE FAMILIES
PARTICIPATION IN THAT PROGRAM.
WHAT APPEARANCE FEELS TO MAKE A
TIMELY CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS
IN THIS IS NOT THE PARENT WHO'S
ON THE BENEFIT PROGRAM THE CREW
DEBT. AND CHARGE 10% INTEREST
WHICH IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
INTEREST RATES CHARGED ON CHILD
SUPPORT IN THE NATION. THIS
RESULTS IN THAT PERIOD BECOMING
FURTHER AND FURTHER IN DEBT.
AND FURTHER AND LITERALLY I'M
ABLE TO PAY THEIR CHILD SUPPORT.
WE WANT PARENTS TO PAY CHILD
SUPPORT WE WANT THE CHILDREN TO
BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THAT
SUPPORT AND HELP THE FAMILY. BE
LIFTED OUT OF POVERTY SO WHAT
THIS POLICY DOES IS HELP US.
ENABLE THAT PARENTS TO. BETTER
PAY THERE CHILD SUPPORT DEBTS.
GETTING RID OF THEIR DEATHS SO
THIS REQUIRES THE STATE TO
CHARGE ZERO INTEREST ON CHILD
SUPPORT DEBT OWED TO THE
GOVERNMENT AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATORS SKINNER DEBATER
DISCUSSION CENTERED DOLLY. THE
MATTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JUST
WANT TO RISE ON THIS ISSUE WHO
SOMEBODY WHO HAS AN EMPLOYER
AND HAS TO HAVE HAD TO DO DOT
FROM BY EMPLOYEES TO PAY THEIR.
CHILD SUPPORT ON THEIR BEHALF
BECAUSE THEY. WEREN'T
RESPONSIBLE SO I ACTUALLY RISE
IN OPPOSITION I KNOW THE 10%
SEEMS LIKE IT'S HIGH BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF DEADBEAT PARENTS
BOTH SIDES. YOU CAN BE THE
SPOUSE OR THE OR THE IT COULD
BE THE MALE OR THE FEMALE
PARENT. THAT IS NOT RESPONSIBLE
PAY THAT PAYING FOR THEIR
CHILD'S. COST. IN WHO HAS TO
PICK THAT UP IS THE STATE AND
THE TAXPAYERS BECAUSE WE DID
THOSE FAMILIES TYPICALLY YOU IN
THAT LOT OF CASES RUN
ASSISTANCE SO. THE INCENTIVE
THE REASON THAT THE INTEREST
RATE IS HIGH IS TO FORCE THEM
TO DO IT SO THAT THEY DON'T
CARE THAT DEBT SO. YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN A WE'RE GONNA IS IN A
POSITION WHERE IT JUST REALLY
MAINLY DEPENDS ON. THE
CHARACTER OF THE PERSON IT
WHETHER THEY'RE TRYING TO
SKIRT. TAKING CARE OF THEIR
CHILDREN AND PUTTING ON THE
BACKS OF THE TAXPAYERS. AND THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA SO I
DON'T THINK THIS IS. A GONNA
SOLVE THE PROBLEM IS COULD
BASICALLY GONNA ALLOW THEM DO
NOT OCCUR THE DEBT AND THEN
CONTINUE ON. WE HAVE TO FORCE
THESE PEOPLE IF THERE IS. AN OF
AVAILABILITY OF RESOURCES TO
PAY THEIR DEBT. FOR AND BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR CHILDREN
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL GET US THERE AS SOMEBODY
WHO HAS. YOU KNOW HOW DO
DEDUCTED OUT OF SALARIES AND
WORK TOWARDS A TRYING TO HELP
THEM BE PRODUCTIVE AND TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES SO THE
GOAL IS TO. GET THOSE FOLKS TO
DO TO TAKE CARE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY NUMBER ONE WE
USED TO CALL IT DEAD BEAT DADS
BUT IN SOME CASES IT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE DAD. AND SO. I JUST.
THINK THIS IS NOT GOING TO GET
US WHERE WE WANT TO GO AND I
THINK THIS POLICIES THAT ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE. IT LESS DEBT AND
YOU AND THEM TO BE SKIRTING
AROUND I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO BRING MORE PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE TO ACTUALLY DO THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY WHICH IS TO. PAY
FOR THEIR CHILDREN RAISIN AND
NOT BE ON THE BACK TO TAXPAYERS
ARE URGING OVER ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. CHICKEN HEARING ON
SENATOR SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE
DOWN THANK YOU SO JUST A IN MY
CLOTHES I THINK A USEFUL
PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE. IN. THIS
BILL DOES NOT INTERFERE WITH
ANY OF OUR EXISTING RULES THAT
ALLOW THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE TO
GARNER THE PERSON'S WAGES IF
THEY'RE BEHIND IN CHILD SUPPORT.
I'M AS SENT BY REAP LIFT ANY
OTHER REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE
ON THAT DEADBEAT PARENT WHAT IT
DOES. IS HELP TO ENSURE. THAT'D
BE PARENT IS NOT GOES FURTHER
INTO DEBT WHICH IS I APPRECIATE
THE POINTS RAISED BY. HAVING
MORE TAX DOES NOT GIVE THEM
MORE ABILITY TO COVER THE COSTS
OF THE CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENT WE
CAN STILL GARNER THEIR WAGES WE
HAVE STILL MANY MANY MECHANISMS
TO IN A FACT. EITHER FOR SIR
DRIVE THAT PAYMENT THIS JUST
HELPS ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY PAY IT AND THAT THE
CHILDREN DO BENEFITS AND WITH
THAT I ASKED FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. BY
ARCHULETA. ATKINS HI. ARTS THAT
I BATES NOBEL HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD. HI KELLY GHETTO THE
SCREAMING CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DODD HI DORADO. AUTO JACKSON.
HI I JONES NO LEYVA. I'M
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL HI MONNING
BY MORE LARK NO MORALE NOTE
NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER. I
STERN AYE STONE NO BURKE I WILL
COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
IN COLLEGE IF YOU COULD LIFT
YOUR VOICE IS SO THERE. THE
SECTOR CAN HEAR YOU THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED AS WELL. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CABALLERO NO. RAZA I THOUGHT OF
TARA. NO RUBIO. HI I TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WE
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE SENATOR
ARCHER LETTER ARE YOU PREPARED
AT THIS POINT VERY GOOD. MR
SECTOR PLEASE RE WHERE IT FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS AN ACT RELATING TO
DISABLED VETERANS THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHER LETTER THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I STAND. TO DISCUSS
EIGHTY THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM. AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE STEM FROM
THE SENATE AUDIT RECOMMENDATION
THAT TO ENSURE THAT THE DVB EAT
PARTICIPATION DATA ARE REPORTED
ACCURATELY AND CONSISTENTLY
WARDING DEPARTMENTS SHOULD BE A
SHOULD IMPLEMENT ALL THE DATA
PUT IT UP FRONT SO EVERYONE
COULD SEE IT REVIEW IT
UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE IT IS SO
VITAL TO THE VETERANS THAT IT
REPRESENTS. AND THIS SYSTEM TO
BE ACCURATE THE BILL DIRECTS
THE AWARDING DEPARTMENTS TO
MAINTAIN ALL RECORDS OF THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY THE
PRIME CONTRACT. THE MOBILE SIX
YEARS AFTER COLLECTION ADD TO A
STAFF. REVIEW PROCEDURES FOR
THOSE RECORDS. THIS BILL WILL
IMPROVE THE MANAGEMENT AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM BY ENHANCING RECORD
KEEPING BY PROGRAM AWARDED
DEPARTMENTS FOR THIS REASON I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE OF
MANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
TURNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SITTING IN HEARING NON
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR PAN.
PASS ON FILE RIGHT THE NEXT
FIVE ITEMS COLLEAGUES IF YOU
PAY ATTENTION OF ONE OF THEM IS
YOURS WOULD LIKE YOU TO BE
READY WHEN THEY ARE INTRODUCED
THEY ARE FILE ITEMS.
1-391-401-4011 FORTY TWO AND
ONE FORTY THREE WE WILL START
WITH FILE. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW MOAN AN ACT RELATING TO OIL
AND GAS SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY TWO TO FIFTY
THOUSAND OIL AND GAS WELLS.
THIS FIGURE INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THOUSAND
IDA WELLS MANY OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN IDLE FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. AND POSE A HIGH RISK OF
DESERTION. AS ALL PRODUCTION.
GOES THROUGH ITS PHASES IN
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS HAVE BEEN
STUCK WITH THE BAG FAR TOO MANY
TIMES. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN
COMPANIES LIKE GRECO PREVENT
ECHO LEFT THEIR OFFSHORE
PLATFORMS ABANDON MAY HAVE BEEN
HIT WITH THAT BILL. THIS BILL
IS PART OF A LONG. LONG
NEGOTIATED PROCESS LED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MOAN WHO
REPRESENTS THAT REGION THAT WAS
HIT HARD BY THOSE ABANDONED
PROJECTS AND I THINK REFLECTS A
VERY REASONABLE COMPROMISE WHEN
IT COMES TO ASKING THE OIL
INDUSTRY TO PUT UP SOME AMOUNT
OF SECURITY FOR THE REASONABLE
COST. OF CLEANING UP THEIR
WELLS OR PLUGGING THEM IN
ABANDONING THEM WHEN THEY DO
DESERT THOSE WELLS. FOR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS WHICHEVER IS
LESS. SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THERE'S A LOT OF THERE'S A LOT
OF INFORMATION MOVING AROUND
ABOUT THIS MEASURE AND I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS THAT'LL
BE RAISED HERE. BUT TO BE CLEAR
THIS S NOT INTENDED TO GO
AFTER OR TARGET THE SMALLER OIL
PRODUCERS IN THIS STATE. BUT IT
IT'S NOT FAIR IN MY ESTIMATION
TO ALLOW THOSE PRODUCERS TO NOT
HAVE ANY SECURITY FOR THE
COSTUME PLUGIN ABANDONING THOSE
WELLS NOW WHAT THE REASON WILL
COST OF THAT IS REMAINS TO BE
SEEN BUT ACCORDING TO THE BILL.
THEY CAN BE BASED ON THE
OPERATORS COST ESTIMATES IT
PROVIDED TO DEPARTMENT OF OIL
AND GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES. SO WE THINK HIS BILL
REPRESENTS A FAIR COMPROMISE
BETWEEN ENVIRONMENT. INDUSTRY
AND ALSO MAKE SOME IMPORTANT
CHANGES THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
WEIGHED IN ON. THEN WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FUTURE OF DOG
WHICH IS BEEN A PLAGUED AGENCY.
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITTEES BEEN
FRUSTRATED WITH IT THERE'S
DISTRUST ALSO FROM THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND IS RESOURCES CHAIR
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIND SOME
WAY TO TURN THE PAGE WITH
DAUGHTER. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAS SUGGESTED AT LEAST
AS AN OPENING SALVO. TO ALTER
THE NAME OF THE DIVISION. TO
THE DIVISION OF GEOLOGIC ENERGY
MANAGEMENT. AND ALSO TO MAKE
CLEAR WHAT ITS MISSION TRULY
IS. HEALTH AND SAFETY YES ARE A
PART OF THAT AND THAT. THAT
AGENCY OUGHT TO BE COORDINATING
WITH OTHER AGENCIES WHEN
IMPLEMENTING OUR STATE POLICY.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION BUT WE THINK IS A
CRITICAL MEASURE TO MAKING SURE
THAT TAXPAYERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE STUCK WITH THE
BILL BUT THAT STILL GIVES
INDUSTRY A PATH TO KEEP USING
USING THEIR ASSETS GOING
FORWARD IN A RESPONSIBLE
FASHION. AND WITH THAT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. THANK YOU
SENATORS STERN HE TO WAIT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE
. SENATOR STIR
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS BILL
OVER AND WE WILL COME BACK TO
IT CHAU HOLD THAT THOUGHT
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK TO THAT BILL. OF AT SOME
OTHER POINT AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO DISCUSS IT FURTHER PLEASE
FEEL FREE BUT WE ARE GOING TO
GO ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY.
SENATOR MITCHELL. AND
COLLEAGUES GIVEN THAT WE'VE GOT
SOURCE FROM BACKGROUND MUSIC
HERE IF YOU WOULD SPEAK UP SO
THAT WE CAN ALL GO IN LISTEN
ATTENTIVELY LEAVE YOUR COMMENTS
WE CAN USE OUR- ATTENTION
WORLD. THANK YOU INDOOR BUT
LOUDER VOICES THAT A PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHEN THE CHILD WAS
FOUND TO BE WITHIN THE
DEPENDENCY JURISDICTION OF THE
JUPITER MORAL CENTER MITCHELL
MY APOLOGIES WE HAVE TO READ
THE BILL FIRST. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL A FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AN
ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES.
SENATOR MITCHELL MY APOLOGIES
OF FLOOR SHORES NOT AT ALL AT
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE IT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ONCE
AGAIN PRESENT AB FIVE EIGHT
FIVE NINE. WHEN A CHILD IS
FOUND TO BE WITHIN THE
DEPENDENCY JURISDICTION OF THE
JUVENILE COURT THE STATE
UNDERTAKE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE ALL SIGNIFICANT PARENTAL
DECISIONS FOR THAT CHILD. THE
COURT SYSTEM PLAYS A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN THIS PROCESS HOWEVER
HIGH CASELOADS OF LONGCASE
DURATION CAN SOMETIMES POSE A
BARRIER TO OBTAINING THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION TO
ACTUALLY TAKE ACTION IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE CHILD. AB
EIGHT FIVE NINE WILL REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO CONVENE A
STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO IDENTIFY
WAYS UNDER DSS HIS PURVIEW TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY THAT
COULD LEAD TO REDUCED WORKLOAD
AN EXPEDITED CASE RESOLUTION. I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE
FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ALONG TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY ONE SENATOR
BAIL. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING
SENATOR BILL. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THE RECENT TO A RAPID
INCREASE IN NUMBER HOMELESS
THOSE. PERPLEXED A LOT OF THE
PLANNERS THAT WERE TRYING TO
ESTIMATE HOW MANY HOMELESS. ARE
INDEED IN CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
PROVIDES MORE SCRUTINY ON THAT
QUESTION AB ONE THIRTY NINE
WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO IDENTIFY IN ZONE ENOUGH
SITES IN ITS EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
AND REFLECT THE MOST RECENT
HOMELESS POINT IN TIME NOW. THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED ANNOUNCED%
SUPPORT HAS NO OPPOSITION ARJUN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
BUILT ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS TURNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY TWO SENATOR BRADFORD
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ A
SOME OF THE ONE SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDI CAL. CENTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB ONE SIX SIX WILL
CREATE A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PRIVATE PROJECT TO PROVIDE
FEDERAL MEDICAID DOLLARS TORE
PROFESSIONAL VIOLENCE.
PREVENTION SERVICES. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE UNFORTUNATE
REALITY. ARE TO ME THE GUN
VIOLENCE ARE AT HIGH RISK OF RE
INJURY AND RETALIATION STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT IN URBAN AREAS
OVER 40% OF PATIENTS TREATED
FOR VIOLENT INJURIES SUCH AS
SHOOTINGS ARE REINJURED WITHIN
FIVE YEARS. IN RESPONSE TO
THESE ALARMING TRENDS RESEARCH
BECAUSE THE DENTAL FIGHT
HOSPITAL BASED VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AS ONE OF
THE MOST INNOVATIVE AND
EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES FOR
REDUCING RATES OF VIOLENCE.
VIOLENT REENTRY ME RE INJURY.
THESE PROGRAMS BRINGS SPECIALLY
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED VIOLENCE
PREVENTION SPECIALISTS INTO THE
HOSPITAL TO WORK WITH PATIENTS
WHO HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
HIGH RISK FOR A VIOLENT RE
INJURY RETALIATION THIS BILL
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OUR
RESPECT LESS FREE AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY TWO. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL HI PORGES. HI EFFORT. I
CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALLY NO
DODD. HI DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. I HILL BY WITH SO.
HI TADO I JACKSON AYE JONES NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
MONEY BY. WARLOCK MORALE NO
NELSON. PAN HI PORTANTINO. I
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY
STERN BY STONE. NO BURKE TYLER
CASKEY HI WINNER. HI WILK HI BY
SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY THREE. SENATOR GONZALEZ
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN
ACRYLATE TO LAND USE CENTRE
GONZALEZ THANK YOU AM AM
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN WHICH CREATES A
NARROW EXEMPTION FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. TO SELL
DEED RESTRICTED LAND TO
ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME HOME OWNERS
AND PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
HOUSING TO THOSE IN NEED
CURRENT LAW PREVENTS SINGLE
FAMILY LOTS FROM BEING
SUBDIVIDED HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
MONTEREY BAY HAS WORKED WITH
THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE TO BUILD
EIGHTY USE THAT ARE OWNER
OCCUPIED AND STRUCTURES THAT
ARE SHIPPED SO THAT THE LAND IS
HELD JOINTLY BY THE TO
HOMEOWNERS. EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN
CODIFIES PROGRAM ORDER TO SERVE
TWICE AS MANY FAMILIES ON THE
SINGLE FAMILY LOT IN THE MIDST
OF HOUSING CRISIS CALIFORNIA
MUST BE ABLE TO UTILIZE ALL
IMPOSSIBLE TO HOUSE THOSE WHO
NEED IT MOST AND AB FIFTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN I'M SORRY
WILL ENSURE THAT. THIS IS
SUPPORTED BY CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND HOW
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL HAS RISEN BY PARTISANS OF
A- SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY ABOUT. DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SING AND BRING NOT
BERNIE OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. EXCUSE ME WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE TIME WE
HAVE MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR AND
THEN WE'LL PLACE IT ON CALL MY
APOLOGIES MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE
BATES. AYE BILL I PURCHASED BY
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALY HI DODD. BY DRAWS A- AYE
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. I TACO. JACKSON HI I
JONES. BY LEYVA I MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL MONNING HI MORE LOCK.
BY MERRELL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER BY STERN. AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG OUR COUNTY I WIENER HI
WILK. SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES A
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM OF
ONE FORTY FOUR. SENATOR ARCHER
LETTER ARE YOU PREPARED. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME OF
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND ACT
REALLY IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I
STAND IN RISE TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY REGARDING
THE CERTIFICATION OF ANIMAL
CONTROL OFFICERS AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE ESTABLISHES A
FRAMEWORK WHICH ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICERS MAY RECEIVE STATE
RECOGNIZED CERTIFICATION IF
THEY CHOOSE TO. THIS VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM WILL FOSTER GREATER
UNIFORMITY AND PROFESSIONALISM
IN THE IMPORTANT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT POSITION AND ALSO
HELP LOCAL AGENCIES IDENTIFY
SELECT AND TRAIN QUALIFIED
PUBLIC OFFERED TO PROTECT OUR
ANIMALS. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR AL. FOR THE OTHER
WOULD YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION
CENTER ARCHULETA. YES I HAVE
ALL RIGHT SENATOR ARLEN LAWSON
WITH THESE ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICERS HAVE ANY POWER OVER
ROAD KILL. THE ROAD KILL ISSUES
A DIFFERENT ITEM BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT ONCE THE CONTROL
OFFICER GETS OFF THE HIGHWAY TO
FULFILLED HIS OBLIGATION. AND
WITH THAT I REST MY CASE. OKAY
ARE ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SO TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM. THING NON CENTER
ARCHULETA YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ASK FOR
YOUR I WILL. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CITIES SUCH AS IT WAS OUR-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL I PORGES BRADFORD BY
CARRIER HI JANE. DELHI I DODD I
DRAWS SO. GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI GROVE. HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO. I TYLO.
JACKSON HI I JONES NO LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL MONNING I'M
MORE LOCK. MERRILL. NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO BY ROTH BY
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NO BURKE OUR COUNTY BY
WINNER BY WILK. NO SENATOR
ARCHULETA MOVES TO CALL MOVING
NOW TO OF FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
FIVE BY SENATOR PAN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AN ACT
REALLY INTO MEDI CAL CENTER PAN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AT SEVENTEEN
OH FIVE BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA WHICH WOULD CREATE
A NEW INTER GOVERNMENTAL
TRANSFER PROGRAM FOR PUBLIC
EMERGENCY MEDICAL PETITION
PROVIDERS TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
DOLLARS AND COVER THE ACTUAL
COST OF EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES. AB
SEVENTY NO SIX IS AN UNATTENDED
BOB ARE YOU SURE THE. FULLY
COMPENSATE THESE PROVIDERS BY
LAW THESE PUBLIC AT THE
LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS TO
OFFSET THE COST PROVIDING
EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES. AND
THIS HAS NO IMPACT ON GENERAL
FUND THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND FORM
OPPOSITION IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. AND THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN ATTORNEY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. HI BILL. FIVE
LARGEST I BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TACO. JACKSON HI BY JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL.
AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH BY RUBIO.
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE. NO
NUMBER IOWA CASSIE. WIENER. HI
WILK HI NO NO DIE SENATOR PAN
MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY SIX SENATOR
DOLLY. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AN ACT RELATING
TO RECYCLING CENTER DOLLY THE
MAN PRESIDENT MEMBERS TO THE
IMPRISONING AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW LAST YEAR AS A
MEMBER GARCIA REQUESTED A STATE
AUDIT OF THE MATTRESS RECYCLING
COUNCIL TO DETERMINE IF THE FEE
COLLECTED WAS DONE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW AND THE
TERMINOLOGY MATCHES RECYCLING
COUNCIL. WAS USING THE FUNDING
IS A MEMBER BIGELOW HAD
CONCERNS AS WELL ESPECIALLY
REGARDING RULE AREA RECYCLING
ACCESS AUDIT HIGHLIGHTED A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THIS BILL
ADDRESSES GOVERNANCE ISSUES
INCLUDING INCREASE ACCESS TO
DROP OFF LOCATIONS OR RULE
AREAS A BRIDGE PLAN IN THE
EVENT OF THE CERTIFICATE XIN
WITH THE TRUST ACCOUNT FOR FEES
AND REQUIRE. ONLINE MATCHING
DOLLARS FOR. USED MATTRESS BY
TWO TWENTY ONE. BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL I
PURCHASE AYE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. AYE OR TACO.
JACKSON HI I JONES I LEYVA. I'M
ACQUIRE I MITCHELL. MONNING I'M
MORE LUCK. I'M A REAL I NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY.
WIENER WHEN HI WILK. HI CENTER
DOLLY MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR BRADFORD. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AND
MACKEREL INTO CLINICS CENTER
BRENT. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN
SIX TO SUPPORT MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT THROUGH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
FOUNDATION SO THEY MAY BETTER
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY THEY SERVE. THEM OKAY
JUNIOR HOSPITAL SIR SELF LOS
ANGELES WHICH REMAINS A
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AND
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREA
POSITION SHORTAGES TOTAL TWELVE
HUNDRED FOR HIM OKAY SERVICE
AREA AND THUS. ARE SUFFERING
AND THOSE SUFFERING FROM THE
SHORTAGE OR PROP PRIOR
PRIMARILY. BIRD PREDOMINATELY
I'M SORRY PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
LOW INCOME ALLOWING HIM OKAY DO
YOUR HOUSE WILL TO ESTABLISH A
MEDICAL FOUNDATION WOULD HELP
EASE THE SHORTAGE IN GENERAL
MEDICAL FOUNDATIONS ARE
MECHANISMS THAT ALLOW HOSPITALS
TO CREATE ANONPROFIT LEGAL
ENTITY THAT EMPLOYEE
PHYSICIANS. THIS MODEL OFFERS
HOSPITALS A VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER INTEGRATE
AND COLLABORATE WITH PHYSICIAN
GROUPS TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
AND EFFICIENCY. IN COORDINATION
OF CARE WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT.
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE BUT JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES AND PROVIDERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES BY BILL AYE
BURGESS. BY BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. BY CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD. DODD HI DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TADO.
JACKSON BY JONES HI LEYVA. I'M
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING I'M
MORE LOCK I'M REAL AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
AYE STONE AYE NUMBER OUR COUNTY
I WINNER BY WILK. HI SENATOR
BRADFORD MOVES TO CALL FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT SENATOR
PORTANTINO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTY NO THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AN ACT
RELATED CRIMINAL JUSTICE CENTER
PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
SUFFER FROM THE TRAGIC EFFECTS
OF GUN VIOLENCE EVERY YEAR THIS
YEAR'S BEEN PARTICULARLY HARD A
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIANS VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE BOARD OF
THE STATE OF COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. AND PROVIDES
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO CITIES
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
IMPLEMENT EVIDENCE BASED
VIOLENCE REDUCTION INITIATIVES
BUT IS NOT YET BEEN CODIFIED IN
STATE LAW AB SIXTY NO THREE
WILL DAMAGE THE CAT. VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM GRANT
PROGRAM IN STATUTE THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY I DON'T THIS HAD ANY
OP OPTION AT THIS. IT REPORTER
THE GIFFORDS LE CENTRE MOMS
DEMAND ACTION AND ELLA BAKER
CENTER AND MANY MANY OTHERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR VODA
SENSIBLE EFFORT TO STEM GONE
BY. THANK YOU SIR PORTANTINO.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT LATER
DOWN THE CENTER QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR. YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION. YES I GUESS SO TO YES
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT CENTER
NIELSEN SENATOR THE- LANGUAGE
HERE SAYS GRANTS ARE PROHIBITED
FROM CONTRIBUTING TO QUOTE MASS
INCARCERATION. NOW YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THE WORST OF THE
WORST POPULATION HERE REALLY
DANGEROUS PEOPLE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT GANG MEMBERS WHICH
USUALLY THAT MEANS A LOT MORE
THAN ONE OR TWO PEOPLE. OF WHAT
DOES MASS INCARCERATION IMPLY
HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD BE
CONSTRUED IN THAT UNIVERSE THAT
WOULD MAKE THEM A MASS
INCARCERATED POPULATION I DON'T
HAVE THAT NUMBER SENATOR BUT I
DO KNOW THE IMPETUS OF THE GOAL
IS TO HAVE COMMUNITIES OF A-
PROGRAM TO STEM THE- VIOLENCE.
THIS TO GIVE YOU ONE. WELCOME
IT WOULD BE WORTH KNOWING AGAIN
BECAUSE THIS COULD BE JUST.
THROWING MONEY AT SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK WE
DON'T KNOW IT DOESN'T SAY WHAT
KIND OF A PLAN THAT WILL BE
UTILIZED TO DEAL WITH GANGS FOR
EXAMPLE AND THERE ARE MANY MANY
ALREADY EXTANT. PROGRAMS THAT
DEAL WITH GANG BEHAVIOR SO THAT
IT AT YOUR LEISURE IF YOU GET
ME SOMETHING ON THAT SENATOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOOR SEEING AND HEARING ON
SENATOR PORTANTINO YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. STATE HAVING SEIZED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL. BY
BURGESS I BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE
DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE
I JACKSON HI BY JONES. I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK I AM A REAL.
MORRELL. BY NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG. BY OUR CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK BY. CENTER
PORTANTINO MOVES A CALL WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY NINE AND WE WILL GO
TO FILE ITEMS. 1-515-115-2150
THREE ONE FIFTY FOUR. AND ONE
FIFTY FIVE. STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY SENATOR BATES
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE
UP THAT ITEM. PASS ON FILE FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE SENATOR ON
BURKE. ARE YOU PREPARED
COLLEAGUES WILL GO FILE ITEM.
1-515-215-3150 FOUR ONE FIFTY
FIVE IF YOU HAVE ANY OF THOSE
PLEASE BE PREPARED TO TAKE THEM
UP AND SENATOR ON BURKE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES OF HIS ME
EXCUSE FOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
SECRETARY READ FIRST MISTER
SECRETARY. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
EIGHTY ONE BY US MEMBER
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS AND CLING THERE'S
THERE OF TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. NOW THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THIS IS SUCH A GOOD BILL I WAS
ANXIOUS TO GET TO THE SUBSTANCE.
THERE ARE TWO TRENDS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW WITH
RESPECT TO VOTER REGISTRATION
THE FIRST IS THAT MORE AND MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE REGISTERING
AS- NO PARTY PREFERENCE. THE
SECOND IS THAT MORE AND MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE VOTING. BY
MAIL. THIS CREATES AN ISSUE
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
REGISTERED AS NO PARTY
PREFERENCE VOTERS WHO VOTE BY
MAIL. THEY MAY NOT REALIZE
THAT. WHEN THEY GET THER MAIL
IN BALLOT THAT THEY- CAN'T FOR
EXAMPLE VOTE SEVERAL DIFFERENT
PARTIES PRIMERS PREP. PRIME.
THIS BILL X. THAT THE REGISTRAR
VOTERS BASICALLY LET THOSE
FOLKS KNOW THAT. IF THEY REMAIN
NO PARTY PREFERENCE VOTERS.
THAT THEY CAN REQUEST SO FOR
EXAMPLE THEY CAN REQUEST A
BALLOT TO VOTE THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY FOR THE DEMOCRATS THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE. BUT IF THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY MAY NOT
REQUESTED THEN THEY SHOW BUT
THE POLL THEY VOTE
PROVISIONALLY INCREASE ALL
SORTS OF ISSUES FOR COUNTY
PURPOSES ALSO FOR. THE A
REGISTRAR PURPOSES SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT AGAIN THIS
BILL. DIRECTS THE REGISTRAR'S
TO ALERT VOTERS AS TO. THEIR
THEIR THEIR OPTIONS IF THEY
WANT TO VOTE IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY. I REGION
I BOUGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
UMBERG DISCERNING DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IN A
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BILL HI BURGESS.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHAIN NO DALY NO DODD. I DORADO
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. HI TITLE I
JACKSON HI BY JONES NO LEYVA. I
AM ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER I WORK OUT SEE. BY
WINNER I HAVE WILK NO SENATOR
UMBERG MOVES TO CALL FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY TWO. SENATOR BILL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY ONE
BY A CEMENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
LENNY'S CENTER BILL. BUT
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO WE HAVE A
BILL HERE REQUIRING A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO INCLUDE A PLAN IN
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT. TO
INCENTIVIZE THE CREATION OF THE
SAYS REVEALING UNITS AND THAT
CAN BE OFFERED AT AN AFFORDABLE
RATE FOR VERY LOW LOW LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES HOUSING
COMMUTE DEVELOP DEPARTMENT. TO
DEVELOP A LIST OF EXISTING
STATE GRANTS AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO PROMOTE PLANNING
AND CONSTRUCTION. OF EIGHTY
WHOSE NO OPPOSITION THIS BILL
ARE CHEN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BILL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE WE ARE BACK TO
A FULL HOUSE WILL GO THROUGH
THIS BILL TWICE AND THEN CLOSE
THE ROLE. MISTER SECRETARY IT'S
FILE ITEM ONE SHE'S ME FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO. MISTERS. WE
HAVE FORTY THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS VERY
OBJECTION. SEEING AND HEARING
ON ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY THREE SENATOR BILL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIN SIGN AN
ACT RELATED VICTIM COMPENSATION
MAKING PREPARATION THEREFORE
SENATOR BELL. A MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF THIS THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS TO BE REIMBURSED FOR
ANY SECURITY DEPOSIT. DEPOSITOR
BOTH A THAT REQUIRED TO ENTER
NEW HOUSING IT HELPS WITH THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
HAVING THEIR PETS. IF THERE'S
SOMEONE PORTION THE VICTIMS OF
ALSO RECOGNIZES THE PADS CAN
HELP. WITH THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. SO WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ARCH
RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER BILL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. THING IN
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING AND
HEARING ON ICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR
SENATOR HILL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE FREE ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BETWEEN
NORRIS RELATING TO COASTAL
PROTECTION. SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
ARE RIGHT TO PRESENT AB SIXTY
FIVE THIS BILL WILL INVEST IN
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
CALIFORNIA COAST IN ORDER TO
COMBAT SEA LEVEL RISE SOME
EXAMPLES OF NATURAL OR GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS
INCLUDE. ONES WHICH WOULD
FLOODING OR REPLENISHED AGES
KELP THE GRASS REDUCE WAVE
IMPACT MARSHES WHICH REDUCE
FLOODING AND EROSION NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DOESN'T JUST
COMBAT SEA LEVEL RISE THIS
APPROACH CREATES BECAUSE IT'LL
HAVE ATTACH THAT OUR IMPORT FOR
CARBON SEQUESTRATION. AND BUILD
RESILIENT TO SYSTEMS ACCORDING
TO THE EPA. COLLEAGUES. A
LITTLE LATE THANK YOU CENTER
HELL MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING AND MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. YES
SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BELL I BRIDGES
AYE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG BY DALY AYE DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. I
TACO AYE JACKSON AYE JONES HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING AYE MOORLACH AYE
EMERIL HI NIELSEN AYE PAN. AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK HI. I THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
NINE SENATOR JACKSON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN
ACTOR LENA FOR PRODUCTS SENATE
JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT AB FORTY FOUR WHICH
WOULD MAKE IT UNLAWFUL TO SELL
OR MANUFACTURE A NEW FOR
PRODUCT IN THE STATE. NOW FOR
IS NOT A BY PRODUCT OF THE MEAT
INDUSTRY IT COMES FROM ANIMALS
THAT ARE FACTORY FARMED OR
TRAPPED PURELY FOR FASHION.
PERFORMING IN THE FUR TRADE ARE
LARGELY SELF REGULATED AND IN
THE U. S. THERE ARE NO FEDERAL
LAWS PROVIDING PROTECTION FOR
ANIMALS WHO ARE HELD ON THESE
FORMS AND FOR BEARING ANIMALS
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO HUMANE
SLAUGHTER LOS. TODAY THERE ARE
A VARIETY OF HUMANE
ALTERNATIVES BOTH IN TERMS OF
FULL FOR THAT IS VIRTUALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM REAL FOR
AN ALTERNATIVE TEXTILES THAT
ARE JUST AS WARM. OR
FASHIONABLE COMPANIES AROUND
THE WORLD ARE FUELING
INNOVATION IN NEW AND
SUSTAINABLE FABRICS RETAILERS
SUCH AS GUCCI MICHAEL KORS
JIMMY CHOO ARMANI AND CHANEL
HAVE MADE THE DECISION. TO GO
FOR FREE. SEVERAL CITIES AND
PUTTING LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO WEST HOLLYWOOD AND
BERKELEY HAVE ALREADY TAKEN A
STAND BY PASSING ORDINANCES
MAKING THE LEGAL TO SELL OR
MANUFACTURE FOR WITHIN THEIR
BOUNDARIES OPPONENTS CLAIM THE
FOR CAN BE SUSTAINABLY RAISED
IN A DOT ASKED US TO ADOPT. A
PROGRAM THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS
CREATED CALL FOR MARK BUT FOR
MARK IS SIMPLY A CODIFICATION
OF EXISTING ABUSIVE PRACTICES
THE FUR TRADE IS TRYING TO
LEGITIMIZE WHAT APPAREL
COMPANIES FROM PRADA BERBERIAN
TJ MAX EXAMINE THE FUR TRADE
CLOSELY THEY QUICKLY REALIZED
THERE IS NO WAY TO HUMANELY
SORT FOR. SO THEY CHOSE TO GO
FOR FREE. THIS MATTER WOULD NOT
GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE GIVING FOR MANY
FACTORS AND RETAILERS OVER
THREE YEARS TO SELL OFF AND
TORY AND MOVED TO FOR.
ALTERNATIVE CALL THERE IS
REALLY NO REASON. CONTINUE TO
PARTAKE IN ANY INDUSTRY THAT
PUTS TO ANIMALS THROUGH SUCH
SOFT. FOR NON ESSENTIAL ENDS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON'S MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
GALGIANI. AS AN ANIMAL LOVER I
HATE TO EVER SEE ANY CRUELTY
ANY ANIMAL BUT I JUST WONDER IS
THERE ANY KIND OF EXEMPTION IN
THIS BILL FOR EXAMPLE AN
ANTIQUE STORE THAT HAS OF HIS
ORIGINAL MOTHERS SOMEBODY. YES
OKAY WE TAKE A QUESTION. THIRD
JACKSON WE TAKE A QUESTION FOR
SURE THANK YOU FOR THESE
RECEIPTS. IS THERE ANY KIND OF
EXEMPTION FOR LIKE A
CONSIGNMENT SHOP FOR AN ANTIQUE
STORE THAT. TAKES ON A FOR THAT
WAS OWNED BY SOMEBODY WHO FOR
EXAMPLE PASSED AWAY AND THE FOR
IS LEFT AT THEIR STATE
SETTLERS. LIKE THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE SO IT WILL GET UNLAWFUL
TO SELL OR MANUFACTURER IT'S
JUST ACTUALLY KNEW FOR PRODUCT
IN THE STATE SO I WOULD SUSPECT
THAT A AN ANTIQUE IF YOU WILL
FOR DOES NOT COME WITHIN THE
SANCTIONS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
AGAIN REMEMBER THERE'S THREE
YEARS OF IN WHICH SHOULD. COME
INDIVIDUAL AND A DISPOSAL OF
THEIR INFANT OF IRAQ. THANK YOU.
THE USER GALGIANI MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TIE.
I DID NOT COME TO SACRAMENTO TO
SHUT DOWN LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES
OR INDUSTRIES. I THINK THE FREE
MARKET SHOULD DO THAT.
SACRAMENTO'S DOING SO EVEN
THOUGH I PROBABLY WOULD NOT
PURCHASE. SUCH A PRODUCT BUT IT
DOESN'T GIVE US THE RIGHT TO DO
SO I BELIEVE IT SENDS A
CHILLING CHILLING MESSAGE. TO
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY SOME
FUND WHICH INDUSTRY WILL BE
NEXT. BOB STORES I ENCOURAGE A
NO VOTE ON AB FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THESE ARE
MORE LIKE CENTER BORDERS. THIS
BILL WHEN IT CAME BEFORE
JUDICIARY. I POSE THE QUESTION
THAT I DON'T THINK I EVER. THE
PROPER WANTS TO THAT THERE IS
AN INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION
AND SIGNATORY ENTITIES AND
SIGNATORY STATES TO THIS
CONVENTION THAT PRESCRIBE THE
LAWFUL CENTER BORDERS IS THAT A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR OR THE
FLOOR MANAGER FOR USE MAKE IS
STATEMENT JUST. SPEAKING OKAY
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR AND- I
ASKED THE QUESTION WHY DON'T WE
INVEST IN MAKING THIS FRAMEWORK
THAT ALREADY EXISTS MORE
ROBUST. IF WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TREATMENT OF ANIMALS
AND WE WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE ILLICIT TRADE IS
REDUCED IN MEANINGFUL WAYS.
SIMPLY HAVING CALIFORNIA TAKE A
PROHIBITION APPROACH I DON'T
THINK IS GOING TO REALLY AFFECT
THE CHANGE THAT THAT PEOPLE
WANT. SO I GUESS THE REASON WHY
I WOULD BE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS. IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
THE POINTS MADE EARLIER IS THAT
WERE ATTACKING. THE WRONG
TARGET. IT'S THE PRAYER THAT
OTHERS HAVE SUBSCRIBED TO THAT
ACTUALLY WOULD IT WOULD HAVE
MEANINGFUL TRACTION TO REDUCE
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE PAST.
BUT OUTLAWING IN CALIFORNIA IS
SIMPLY JUST GOING TO PUSH IT TO
NEVADA AND ARIZONA AND
ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE. AND NOT
TO MENTION OF COURSE THE
ILLICIT TRADE WILL JUST CONVERT
INTO THE BLACK MARKET TRADE SO
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T THINK
THIS IS GOING TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF. THE PRODUCT THE
PEOPLE DESIRE NGUYEN INSTEAD
THE FRAMEWORK SHOULD BE ARE
SUING IS THE REMEDY THAT WILL
BE MOST EFFECTIVE FORCING THIS
LEGISLATION. NOT PURSUE THAT
REMEDY. THE USER BORDERS CENTER
JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. AS A
MEMBER OF THE NATURIST ARSES
COMMITTEE WE HEARD HIS BILL AND
WE HEARD SOME VERY COMPELLING
TESTIMONY FROM SOME MEMBERS OF
THE BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SOME NATIVE AMERICAN
CONCERNS ON THE BILL AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE SOME
EXEMPTIONS IN THE BILL. BUT
THAT THE- THAT THAT TESTIMONY
MADE A PRETTY GOOD CASE. OF
THIS BILL BEING PROPOSED BY.
FIGHT REALLY A LEADERS TO FOR
DECADES. THEYOR THEIR FAMILY.
MAY HAVE WORN FOR BUT SINCE
THAT IT'S NOW OUT OF VOGUE OR-
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE CAUGHT UP TO
THAT SOCIAL STANDING. NOW THEY
WANT TO STOP ANYONE ELSE FROM
WEARING THAT FOR PRODUCT. AND
I'D KIND OF FORGOTTEN MY OWN
PERSONAL STORY. ABOUT THIS
UNTIL AFTER THE TALK ABOUT
HEARING WAS OVER. AND I WAS
VERY VERY CLOSE TO MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. WHO LIVED IN A
PRESS HERE IS ON A- AND HER
HUSBAND MY GREAT GRANDFATHER
WAS A COPPER MINER IN BAGHDAD
ARIZONA. AND HE WORKED VERY
HARD HOURS HE WAS JUST A UNION
LABOR MINOR IN THAT WORKING IN
THE COPPER MINES AND HE DID
THAT FOR MANY MANY YEARS. ED HE
STROVE VERY HARD TO LIVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM DURING THE
FORTIES AND FIFTIES AND
SIXTIES. WHEN HE FINALLY WAS
ABLE TO. RETIRE ANY PASSED AWAY
IN THE EIGHTIES BUT MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER LIVED INTO THE INTO
THE NINETIES. AND I REMEMBER
HER SITTING ON HER PORCH AND
SHE DIDN'T HAVE A LOT SONOMA
LOT OF WORLDLY POSSESSIONS SHE
HAD A SMALL EIGHT HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT TWO BEDROOM HOUSE
WITH A BATHROOM THAT BARELY
WORKED IN PLUMBING THAT VERY
BARELY WORK AFTER MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER HAD PASSED AWAY BUT
ONE OF HER PRIZE POSSESSIONS.
WAS THE FIRST SHOW ALL. THAT HE
HAD SAVED UP OVER SEVERAL YEARS
TO BE ABLE TO PURCHASE FOR HER.
AND GIVE TO HER AS A-
REFLECTION OF HIS LOVE AND CARE
FOR HER AND I'M CENTER FLOWERS.
SHE WORE THAT COAT ALMOST EVERY
DAY. UNTIL THE DAY SHE DIED. AS
I SAID THEY'RE NOT WEALTHY
PEOPLE BUT THAT FOR CO MADE ALL
THE DIFFERENCE TO MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. CENTERS FOR
PRODUCTS AS HAS BEEN STATED ARE
NATURALLY. THE MARKET IS
NATURALLY DECLINING ON THESE
PRODUCTS IN ONE WE JUST LET THE
MARKET DO WHAT THE MARKET DOES.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR THIS BILL
OTHER THAN ONE CLASS OF SOCIETY
WANTING TO TELL ANOTHER CLASS
OF SOCIETY WHAT THEY CAN OR
CANNOT WEAR. AND FOR THAT
REASON I ORIGINAL VOTE THANK
YOU CENTER JONES MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
JACKSON PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DID WANT TO. A NO
TO A COUPLE THINGS TO ANTIQUE
FURS ARE NOT PROHIBITED UNDER
THIS BILL IT'S ONLY NEW
MANUFACTURER. OR PRODUCED THAT
FALLS UNDER THIS OF THE SALE OR
RESALE OR VIEWS DURANTE IS NOT
PROHIBITED IF YOUR GREAT
GRANDMOTHER WANTED TO GIVE THAT
FOR CO TO YOUR WIFE THERE'S
NOTHING THAT OUTLAWS FOR DOING
SO ALTHOUGH. I WOULD SUBMITTED
BE KIND OF WARM IF YOU WORE IT
EVERY DAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BUT- THIS BILL DOESN'T TELL
PEOPLE WHAT THEY CAN AND CANNOT
WHERE. WHAT IT DOES THOUGH IS
IT RECOGNIZES THAT TO. OUR
CONSCIOUSNESS. HAS CHANGED THAT
WE DO NT NEED FOR IN ORDER TO
STAY WARM. THAT THE PRACTICES
OF GROUPS LIKE FOR MARK AND I.
I READ THIS AND I WAS HORRIFIED
BUT. ANIMAL CRUELTY IS STILL
STANDARD UNDER THE SO CALLED
FOR MARK IN FACT THEY CONTINUE
TO ALIEN VAGINALLY ELECTROCUTED
ANIMALS. IF YOU WANT TO GET
DOWN TO WHAT GOES ON. THEY GAS
ANIMALS. THEY CAN FIND THEM IN
CAGES. THE HAVE ARCHAIC LEG
HOLDTRAPS FOR WILD ANIMALS.
WHICH OFTEN LEAVES THESE
ANIMALS FOR DAYS WITHOUT FOOD
OR WATER. THAT'S TO MAKE UP FOR
CO TWO IN A YEAR A WORLD WHERE
WE DON'T NEED FOR ANYMORE TO
STAY WARM. THIS IS A ABOUT TWO
MINUTES. FOR ANIMALS AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BY BATES.
BELL BY BURGESS NO BRADFORD.
CARRIERA. CHIANG HI DOLLY NO
DODD. DORADO. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ HI GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE AYE HILL AYE
HUESO TADO. JACKSON BY JONES NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL BY
MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. NO
NUMBER OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK BY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. BATES
BRADFORD CABALLERO DODD I.
HUESO TADO. ALLEN I. EYES
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
SEVEN SENATOR JACKSON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND ACT
REALLY THE LAND USE CENTRE
JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS A MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE WHICH
WILL REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ADDRESS THE ADEQUACY INGRESS
AND EGRESS ROUTE. AND EMERGENCY
PLANS TO IN THE NEXT UPDATE OF
THE SAFETY ELEMENTS IN THEIR
GENERAL PLAN. I DON'T THINK WE
NEED TO SPEND A WHOLE LOT OF
TIME DISCUSSING HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS JUST SIMPLY TAKE A LOOK
AT THE PARADISE FIRE AND THE
FACT THAT THERE WAS INADEQUATE
INGRESS AND EGRESS WHICH
RESULTED IN THE LOSS OF
SIGNIFICANT LIFE IN THAT SMALL
COMMUNITY. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN IN
FACT SKY WAY BOULEVARD ONE OF
THE TWO MAIN UP ON ROADS UNDER
WHAT LATE DOC FROM FORTY TWO
LANES WHICH AGAIN EXACERBATED
THEIR SITUATION. I DURING THE
CAMPFIRE RESIDENTS WERE FORCED
TO MOVE SHOP ON VIA SKY WAY
BOULEVARD AND BY TEN A. M. THAT
DAY EVACUEES WERE FORCED TO
ABANDON THEIR VEHICLES AND
PROCEED ON FORT THIS MEASURE
COLLEAGUES WILL HELP TO SAVE
LIVES BY REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROACTIVELY PLAN
THEIR EVACUATION ROUTE CAPACITY
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE UNDER OF
RANGE OF EMERGENCY SCENARIOS
THIS IS A SOLID PREVENTATIVE
MEASURE THAT SHOULD GET THE
SUPPORT OF EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM AS WE HONOR AND TRY TO
REMEMBER. THOSE WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES BECAUSE OF THE INADEQUACY
OF THESE PLANS AND MAKE SURE
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. OKAY
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE FOURTEEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. SENATE
JACKSON WAS IT FILE ITEM TO FOR
THAT YOU WANTED TO DO. WHY I
NEED A MOMENT TO GET IT
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWO ZERO FOUR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AND ACT
REALLY INTO EMPLOYMENT THE
JACKSON IS THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
I BRING THIS MEASURE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERCARILLO THIS
IS A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. HAVE THE
OPTION OF A STRAIGHT FORWARD AN
EXPEDITIOUS LEGAL PATH TO
JUSTICE IN THE CASE OF THEIR
EMPLOYERS WRONG DOING. UNDER
CURRENT LAW SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND STALKING MUST BE
PROVIDED WITH JOB PROTECTED
TIME. TO TIME OFFER OTHER TO
SEEK MEDICAL LEGAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION IN THE WORKPLACE.
I RECOGNIZE SAID I THINK IT'S A
BILL I DID BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN BUT IF THEY ARE DENIED
THESE RIGHTS THESE EMPLOYEES
ARE INDEED ABLE TO FILE A
COMPLAINT WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. OR
PURSUE A CLAIM UNDER PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT. EVER
CASES THAT ARE FILED THROUGH
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER ARE
NOTORIOUSLY SLOW TO BE RESOLVED
IN THE COURSE OF ACTION IS
TAKEN OUT OF THE HANDS OF THE
AGREED TO EMPLOYEE. UNDER PAGA.
SURVIVORS ARE ONLY ABLE TO
COLLECT THE MAXIMUM OF TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS. THIS OUTCOME IS
CERTAINLY NOT SUFFICIENT GIVEN
THAT SURVIVORS FREQUENTLY ENTER
A LENGTHY LEGAL PROCESS AND
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS IS
CERTAINLY NOT PROPORTIONATE TO
THE INJURY THEY SUFFERED IN THE
WORKPLACE. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS AND ALTERNATIVE LEGAL
PAYOFF IN THE FORM OF A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION. CODIFYING
EMPLOYEES RIGHT TO THE OPTION
OF A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
EQUIPS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS WITH THE DESERVE THE
OPTION TO ADDRESS THE
DISCRIMINATION AND MISTREATMENT
THAT THEY HAVE FACED IN THE
WORKPLACE. WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR GORGEOUS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT BY MAY POSE A
QUESTION TO THE FIELD MAN OR
THE FOR MANAGER CENTER GAS WE
TAKE A QUESTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION ABSOLUTELY FINE
PLEASE PROCEED. I THINK THIS
HAS A LOT OF MERIT BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT. THIS THE THAT
ATTORNEYS FEES PROVISION
APPLIES TO. A PREVAILING
EMPLOYEE. BUT IS DISALLOWED TO
THE PREVAILING EMPLOYER IS THAT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING UNDER
CURRENT LAW WHEN THESE KINDS OF
SUITS ARE FILED. THE PLAINTIFF
IS THE ONE ENTITLED TO
ATTORNEYS FEES IF THEY PREVAIL
THAT IS A STANDARD PRACTICE
THROUGHOUT ALL THESE KINDS OF
PROCEEDINGS. WAS IT. FOLLOW UP
IF I MAY UM IT SEEMS IN THE IN
THE INTEREST OF FAIRNESS THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE SUCH AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS CHALLENGING AN
EMPLOYER'S MISBEHAVIOR. THAT
THE EMPLOYER HAVE THE ABILITY
TO COLLECT IN THE EVENT OF A
FRIVOLOUS OR MERITLESS.
ACCUSATION OR CHARGE WAS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WAS JUST DECIDED
AGAINST IN THE CRAFTING OF THIS
LEGISLATION CAN WERE FOLLOWING
THE SAME PROCESS THAT EXISTS
FOR ALL OF THE OTHER KIND OF
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION IN
VIOLATION BEHAVIORS. THAT WE
SEE IN WORKFORCE OF THIS IS NOT
UNIQUE CONSISTENT WITH THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE LAW.
CURRENT PRACTICES ARE THE
EMPLOYEES USUALLY ARE LOW
INCOME FOLKS. WHO DON'T
OTHERWISE HAVE ACCESS TO
ATTORNEYS. AND THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THEY ARE ABLE TO SEEK JUSTICE.
WHEN THEY TRY TO ADVANCE THEIR
CLAIM TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS
THANK YOU ALL AND WITH MY
COMMENT HERE WORKERS WERE
SAYING THAT WE ARE FOLLOWING
PROTOCOL THAT EXIST ELSEWHERE
IN THE LAW. BETTER CREE PRIVATE
WRITER ACTION FOR A NEED AT A
BALLOT BUT HE'S- BUT IN HIS
BRAND NEW THAT'S NOT. IN ITS
CURRENT FORM BOB. WEIR
DISALLOWING THE PROTECTION IT
MIGHT FORTY. AND OF FRUIT
SUPPORT DOWN DIAL. I CHARGES
THAT I THINK THERE'S AN ABOUT.
ON WHAT IS OTHERWISE A
MERITORIOUS HE'S A LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
CENTER JACKSON WHICH WOULD
CLOSE THANK YOU YOU KNOW NOT
ALSO TOO FRIVOLOUS IF IT'S A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT THEN
ATTORNEY'S FEES ARE AVAILABLE
TO THE PARTY. WHERE IT IS
DEEMED THAT THE OTHER SIDE HAS
BROUGHT A FRIVOLOUS ACTION
THESE ARE CLAIMS THAT GO TO
FULLY JUDY CAYTON AND IF THE
EMPLOYEE PREVAILS THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO GET. THE FUNDING
FOR THE ASSISTANCE OF COUNSEL
THAT THEY WOULD OTHERWISE NOT
BE ABLE TO GET THIS IS A I
THINK IMPORTANT THAT AGAIN ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT A REMEDY IS NO
RIGHT AT ALL WE HAVE A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
HERE A VERY IMPORTANT POLICY.
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT WERE NOT
ABLE TO FULLY AN APPROPRIATELY
IMPACTED AND TO EFFECTUATE IT
BECAUSE OF THE DELAYS THAT
EXIST THIS JUST GIVES THE
VICTIMS OF THIS KIND OF.
VIOLATION AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THEIR DAY IN COURT AND TO TRY
TO SEEK REDRESS FOR THE WRONG
SAID HAVE KURT AGAINST THEM
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE. THANK YOU
SIR JACKSON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NOBEL I PURCHASE BRADFORD
BORDERS NO BRADFORD AYE AYE
CARRIER. CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DODD. TIRADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI GROVE. NO HERTZBERG
I HILL. HUESO I TITLE JACKSON I
JONES KNOWS LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. I MONNING HI MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE NO NUMBER OUR CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
CABALLERO DODD. GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. HILL BY TADO. I TWENTY
FOUR KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
FILE AND ONE FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR ALSO ARE YOU READY SHE
SURE IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. NINE SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. SENATOR
ALSO THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
P MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB NINE
SIXTY THREE. STUDENT CIVIC VOTE
POWER MEN ACT WE KNOW THAT YOU
VOTER TURNOUT IS IMPORTANT. WE
KNOW THAT IT MATTERS WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IT IS DISMAL. DURING
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN ELECTION
ONLY EIGHT POINT 2% OF ELIGIBLE
EIGHT INTO TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD
VOTED. LAST YEAR IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET. THAT BY. LINE
TO TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT. WITH
THIS BILL LET THE ONE THIRD OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE VOTING
IN AGES IN OUR DEMOCRACY. THANK
YOU THIS IS BIRD LESS THAN ONE.
WE HAVE TO BETTER AB NINE SIXTY
THREE WILL ENSURE THAT. IS
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES PLAY A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN ENCOURAGING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND INVOLVING YOUNG
ADULTS IN OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS. AB NINE SIXTY THREE
WILL ESTABLISH THE ROLE OF A
CIVIC AND VOTER EMPOWER MAKE
COORDINATOR ON EVERY COLLEGE
CAMPUS THIS COORDINATOR WILL
ONE DEVELOP PACIFIC AND VOTER
EMPOWERMENT ACTION PLAN
SPECIFIC TO THEIR CAMPUS. AND
COMMUNICATE VOTING DATES AND
ELECTION INFORMATION. TWO
STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY EIGHT SENATOR NIELSEN.
PATTERN PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
IT'S A CURIOSITY THAT OVER THE
DECADES ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE PASSED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. WELL THE
LEGISLATURE'S FAST I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN HERE. BUT ALL THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED TO
LISTEN TO GREATER TURN OUT OF
OUR YOUTH. DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
HAVING ANY IMPACT. MAYBE WE
DON'T NEED MORE BILLS MORE
IDEAS THE DON'T WORK. HOW ABOUT
A LITTLE BIT OF CIVIC
RESPONSIBILITY INSTILLED IN OUR
YOUTH IN THE HOME FROM THE
PARENTS AND IN K. TWELVE
EDUCATION. ONE OF THE GREAT
DEFICIENCIES. IN MY EXPERIENCE
AND K. TWELVE EDUCATION. IS THE
LACK OF CIVIC EDUCATION THE
TEACHING OF HISTORY. IT'S
OBVIOUS TO ME WHEN I MEET WITH
A YOUTH WHO COME HERE TO THE
CAPITOL I MEET WITH. AB AROUND
IN CALIFORNIA. MANY DON'T EVEN
KNOW OUR PRESIDENTS. MANY DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION. NOW THAT USED TO
BE TAUGHT. I ASSUME TO A SMALL
DEGREE AT LEAST IT'S STILL AS.
BUT I REMEMBER SPEAKING. IN AN
ORCHARD. THE LITTLE OLD GLENN
COUNTY SEVERAL YEARS AGO THE
REDEDICATION OF A CEMETERY
WHERE IN WAS REPORTED TO BE
BURIED. WILLIAM F. B. I'D. ONE
OF THE FOUNDERS OF THIS VERY
STATE. LEADER OF THE BEAR FLAG.
REBELLION AND I SPOKE. ABOUT
THE LACK. OF ANY INTEREST IN
HISTORY. AND THE DE EMPHASIZING
OUT OF IT IN OUR SCHOOLS. FOR
INDIVIDUALS CAME UP TO ME. AND
THEY ALL THANKED ME BECAUSE
THEY WERE HISTORY TEACHERS. AND
THEY SAID YOU KNOW SENATOR WE
DON'T GET TO TEACH HISTORY
ANYMORE OUR SCHOOLS. WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT. MOTIVATING OUR
YOUTH TO HAVE A REFERENCE.
ELECTORAL PROCESS. MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT OF CIVIC EDUCATION.
WOULD BE HELPFUL. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SIX THREE
BECAUSE FOR MIND READING AND
INTERPRETATION IT DOES EXACTLY
WHAT OUR COLLEAGUE SUGGESTS IT
THE ROOF SCHOOL HELPS TO
EDUCATE AND SUPPORT STUDENTS TO
BEGIN A LIFE OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IN VOTING YOU KNOW
COLLEAGUES I THINK WE'RE HAVING
TO REACH BACK WE'VE GOT BILLS
THERE'S A MOVEMENT IN MY
DISTRICT IN CULVER CITY TO. A
CREEK NUMBER TO THE FOR SIXTEEN
pI THINK WE'RE HAVING TO REACH
FURTHER BACK BECAUSE WE'VE
ALMOST GIVEN UP ON ADULTS GIVEN
THE VOTER PARTICIPATION AND
TURNED OUT. ROSS PARTY LINES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THAT BY CREATING A
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN COLLEGE CAN
HAVE FACILITATED EXPERIENCES
AND UNDERSTAND WHY VOTING IS
IMPORTANT. I TRAVEL WITH THE
SENATE LAST FALL TO THE COUNTRY
OF BHUTAN IS FASCINATING. OF
THE NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE ON THE FLOOR. IT'S A VERY
YOUNG DEMOCRACY TEN YEARS OLD.
AND WE WERE EMBARRASSED AS
AMERICANS WHEN THEY TALKED
ABOUT THEIR NINETY PLUS PERCENT
VOTER PARTICIPATION RATE. VERY
CASUALLY TURNED IN AFTER HOURS
AND WE ALL LOOKED AT EACH OTHER
IN EMBARRASSMENT DIDN'T WANT TO
CONFESS. WHAT A DEMOCRACY IS
ALL DESIRES HAVE TO DO TO GET
PEOPLE TO SHOW UP TO VOTE AND
SO BASED ON THAT I'M GOING TO
STAND PROBABLY IN SUPPORT A BE
NINE SIX THREE BECAUSE WE NEED
TO GET WHAT EVER RESOURCES
WHATEVER TOOL WHATEVER
ENCOURAGEMENT WE CAN. TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR NEXT GENERATION
VALUES APPRECIATES THE RIGHTS
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MATTER
MARK PRESIDENT A QUESTION FOR
THE A FLOOR MANAGER PLEASE
ACCEPT THE QUESTION SENATOR
DRAW SO. I'LL TRY YEAH ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD CENTER BATES
YOU MAY PROCEED I YES IN THE
ARE DIGESTED DOESN'T REALLY US
BOB POINTED OUT WHO WILL BE
APPOINTING THE OUR OUTREACH
PERSON WHO'S NONPARTISAN. HAS
THAT BEEN SET FORTH HEREIN THE
ACTUAL BILL LANGUAGE. IF NOT I
THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM. SENATE
RUSSELL MAY READ WITHOUT
OBJECTION. I'M TRYING TO SEE
TRYING TO FIND THE ANSWER HERE
OF DESIGNATE ONE FACULTY MEMBER
STAFF MEMBER ADMINISTRATIVE
PERSON. AS THE CIVIC IN VOTING
BOARD AND POWER MAKE
COORDINATOR. WHO SHALL CONVENE
A COMMITTEE OF RELEVANT
ADMINISTRATORS FACULTY THE
STUDENTS TO DEVELOP THE PLAN
FOR. TO DOUBLE DEVELOP A PLAN
FOR THE CAMPUS I DON'T KNOW
OTHER THAN THAN THAT I DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER. ON MY OWN TIME
IT REALLY DOESN'T SPECIFY WHO
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE
THAT THAT PERSON IS ACTUALLY
NONPARTISAN WILL THEY BE TAKEN
FROM THE STAFF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WITHOUT BE SOMEONE WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE
DESIGNATE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUSES WHERE THEY'RE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION
AND- OTHER RESOURCE MATERIAL
AND I TO ME THAT. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT COULD POSSIBLY
BE INFLUENTIAL ARE TO STUDENTS
WHO ARE BEING ENGAGE IN THESE
ENGAGEMENTS THAT ARE ONLY
THIRTY DAYS BEFORE THE ACTUAL
VOTERS TAKEN SO WE HAVE A
PROBLEM IN THIS STATE AND UPS
IN THIS NATION WITH LOW
INFORMATION. FOR THAT WE DO
HAVE I THINK WISH THAT WE WERE
WE DIDN'T EVEN HAVE THAT
DESIGNATION. BUT OUR SCHOOLS
AND CERTAINLY COMPARED TO MY
GENERATION I DOES NOT AS GOOD A
JOB IN ENSURING THAT WE
UNDERSTAND OUR DEMOCRACY THE
PROCESS. THE PEOPLE THAT FOUGHT
WITH THEIR LIVES TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAD A DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE AND- CONSTITUTION
AND THOSE ARE ALL ONE THING
VERY VITAL TO ENSURING THAT
WHEN WE DO HAVE PEOPLE. WHO
HAVE THE INCREDIBLE PRIVILEGE
IN THIS COUNTRY TO VOTE THAT
THE IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
THEY DETERMINE FROM HEARING
PROS AND CONS ON EACH ISSUE.
PROS AND CONS ON EACH CANDIDATE
AND THEN WE CAN BE ENSURE THAT
WHEN THAT'S HAPPENING ON OUR BY
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
IT TRULY IS NONPARTISAN SO
UNTIL THAT IS. CLEARLY STATED
AND HOW THIS WILL BE STRUCTURED
I WOULD NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
CENTER BATES ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THE
COMMENTARIES I HAVE SHOWS THAT
THIS WILL COST ONE TO TWO
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR I'M
NOT SURE IF THAT'S PER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT I'M
ASSUMING IT'S FOR ALL SEVENTY
TWO WE REVIEW THE. ANNUAL
AUDITS OF THE SEVENTY TWO
SCHOOL DITRICTS CALLER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT ONLY
TO HAVE A POSITIVE UNRESTRICTED
NET ASSETS BUT SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY AND SAN MARINO. SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY IS TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER CAPITA AND SAN
MARINO IS AT FIFTY TWO DOLLARS
PER CAPITA THAT MEANS THE OTHER
SEVENTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS HAVE AN UNRESTRICTED
NET DEFICIT. NUMBER SEVENTY TWO
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE LIST TO
SANTA MONICA WITH THE
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT PER
CAPITA OF FOUR THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS
PER PERSON WE'RE TALKING SOME
SERIOUS FISCAL CONCERNS FOR OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AIRY OUR
SPACE IN FACT IN THE IN THIS
LAST YEAR FROM JUNE SEVENTEENTH
TO JUNE EIGHTEENTH THE TOTAL
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT WENT
UP TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS FOR CALLING THREE WE
HAVE TO WATCH THIS SPACE WE
SHOULD NOT BE INCOME BRING OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND INCLUDING
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
WITH MORE CLASS UNLESS WE'RE
GONNA FIND SOMEWHERE PROP
NINETY EIGHT THE PAPER THAT AND
IS GETTING TIGHTER AND TIGHTER
AS WE SPEAK. THANK YOU
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR OKAY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
ROSS SO YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I TAKE FROM
THIS THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
UP CLEARLY A NON PARTISAN
EFFORT. IT DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU INDEPENDENT OR YOUR
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN WE ARE
FAILING IN MAKING SURE THAT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE GO OUT TO VOTE
IT'S ON ALL OF US IT'S ALL OF
OUR RESPONSIBILITY AND WE'RE
ALL. A TO SHARE IN THAT NOT
HAPPENING SO I SEE THIS AS NOT
GIVING UP ON OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
BATES ON THE COLLEGES IT'S ON
THE UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES THIS IS
THE PERFECT PLACE FOR THEM TO
ENGAGE TO LEARN AND TO SEE THAT
AS THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD AND THAT THEY WILL
ACTUALLY GAIN AND BENEFIT FROM
THEM. AND THEIR GENERATION AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A BIBLE
BIBLE THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. NOBEL BY PORCHES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HERO. I
CHIANG. DELHI NO DODD. I DORADO
I GALGIANI BY GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TADO I
JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY BY WINNER
BY WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BURGESS NO.
CHIANG GROW. NO MORE LUCK. OUR
EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS MADAM
PRESIDENT WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE MEMBERS THERE IS A
RESOLUTION OF THE DEATHS
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE.
ENJOYED RULE SIXTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING THE
FOLLOWING ASSEMBLY BILLS TO BE
HELD IN REPORTED BY COMMITTEE
THOSE ARE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
ONE EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWO ZERO AND ASSEMBLY MEASURE
ONE SEVEN ONE FOUR THESE
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE I ASKED FOR
AN ODD A VOTE. THANK YOU.
CENTER HERTZBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION RESOLVED THE JOINT
RULE SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY TO BE
DISPENSED WITH TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN
NINE TWENTY IN ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN TO BE HEARD
IN REPORTED AFTER THE DEADLINES
AS REQUESTED. THANK YOU MISTER
SECTOR THAT WAS NOT HELD BUT TO
BE HEARD IN COMMITTEE. AND WITH
THAT SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. NOBEL HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DELHI NO DODD. I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO BY TADO I
JACKSON HI BY JONES NO LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. I'M MORE LOCK. NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NO NUMBER I WORK OWSKI I
WINNER BY WILK. HI IS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE RIVER THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT MORE WORK TO
DO TONIGHT THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
ASSEMBLY BILLS AB. FORTY EIGHT.
AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR. AB TWELVE
NINETY SIX AND A. B. TWELVE
NINETY NINE TO BE AMENDED AFTER
THE DEADLINE THESE REQUESTS AS
WITH THE LAST MEASURE HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY. THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR SECTOR READ THE RESOLUTION
RESULT THE JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE
BE DISPENSED WITH TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY BILL. FORTY EIGHT
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR TWELVE NINETY
SIX AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY NINE TO BE AMENDED AFTER
THE DEADLINES AS REQUESTED. IS
THERE ANY XIN TO SUBSTITUTING
THE PRIOR ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NON ICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS EIGHT THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISS MA'AM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE SENATE RULE RULES
EXCUSE ME AS THEY RELATE TO A.
B. FIFTY FOUR. AND S. B. FORTY
FIVE. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
TO THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THAT
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED SENATOR
HERTZBERG AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR MADAME PRESIDENT PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM ONE ZERO FOUR AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE THANK YOU. SENATOR FURTADO
FOR WHAT PURPOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I'M ASKING TO A
REQUESTING TO PUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX A BEFORE
FIFTY ONE ON THE INACTIVE FILE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
WITHOUT OBJECTION SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM SEVENTY ONE AB TEN SEVENTY
THREE TO THE AN ACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU THAT WILL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. YES SO THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE A. B. FOUR FIVE
SEVEN BY DR QUIRK FROM THE
ENACT THE FILE. WOULD YOU
REPEAT THAT ONE TIME PLEASE
PLEASE REMOVE AB FIVE FOUR
SEVEN FROM THE AN ACTIVE FUN
INACTION ACTIVE IN ACT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO NOTED AT THE
DESK. ANY OTHER ITEMS UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. WE
WILL THEN GO BACK TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY NINE. SENATOR PAN DO
YOU WISH TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY NINE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACT WILLING TO PEOPLE
HEALTH AND MAKING PROVISION FOR
SENATOR PAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
EIGHT BY A SOME MEMBER
pTHAT YOU WILL USE MONEY FOR
PROP SIXTY FOUR TO FIND
SUSTAINABLE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SCHOOL
SUPPORT SERVICES. THE GRANTS
TREATED BY THIS BILL HELPS FILL
A VOID IN THE NUMBER PORTED
STATUS SIR THE STAFF LEVY THE
LOWER RIVER OF OUR TEACHERS AND
CONNECT SCHOOLS EXISTING
COMMUNITY RESOURCES THE BILL
STRUCTURE SUCH AT THE CELEBRITY
DECISIONAL FEDERAL. THIS IS THE
CIVIC WE AT THE PERCENT FEDERAL
REIMBURSED FOR MEDI CAL DOUBLE
DOUBLE SERVICES CURRENT RATIOS
OF SERVICE SUPPORT STAFF ARE
UNACCEPTABLE ONE COUNSELOR FOR
AIR SIX EIGHTY STUDENT WONDERS
FOR EVERY TWO THOUSAND HUNDRED
STUDENTS. SOCIAL EVERY NOT
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED. BUT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. THEY NEED.
THE INCREASE THE CLASSROOM
ENGAGEMENT BETTER ATTENDANCE
IMPROVES TO PASS THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND ALSO PARTLY
REDUCE DRUG USAGE RATES. THIS
PROGRAM IS MODELED AFTER SIMILE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN COLORADO
WHICH SAW EFFECTIVE HEALTH
PROGRAM. RESULT IN APPROVED
PEOPLE DISCIPLINE AND FEWER
SUSPENSIONS EXPULSIONS AFTER
IMPLEMENTATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR DIVERT. THANK YOU CENTER
PAN DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SING IN HEARING NONE
IS THIRTY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SHE STEPS ON OR. HI IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO SUCH TO
DO UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING
AND HEARING NONE OUR EYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ALONG NOW THE NEXT FIVE
ITEMS WILL BEFILE ITEMS. ONE
SIXTY ONE SIXTY ONE SIXTY TWO
SIXTY THREE AND SIXTY FOUR.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SENATOR
PARTIAL LETTER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
OH EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND THAT CLING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY LEVY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY. TO
PRESENT AB AT THREE OO EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI. AB
THROUGH A PUTS BACK INTO LAW A
TAX EXEMPTION FOR SERVING
MEMBERS OF OUR MILITARY THAT
OWN A SMALL BUSINESS BY
EXTENDING THE SUNSET DATE.
EVERY CORPORATION THAT DOES
BUSINESS IN THE STATE MUST PAY
A TAX FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF
DOING SO THAT WE KNOW. THE
MINIMUM FRANCHISED ACTED EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND FOR
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES THE
ANNUAL FEES IS THE SAME AMOUNT.
CURRENTLY OUR LAWS DO NOT
ACCOUNT FOR THE UNIQUE
SITUATION OF ACTIVE MILITARY
BUSINESS OWNERS WHEN THEY ARE
DEPLOYED TO SERVE AND REPRESENT
OUR COUNTRY. THEY ARE STILL
REQUIRED TO PAY THE EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE EVEN IF
THEIR BUSINESS OPERATES IN THE
NEGATIVE DURING THE SPAN OF
TIME THAT THEY'RE DEPLOYED
OVERSEAS. REPRESENTING OUR
GREAT COUNTRY. BUSINESSES WHO
ARE DEPLOYED OVERSEAS IN
DEFENSE OF OUR NATION. WAVING
THE MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX OR
ANNUAL FEE ON THEIR BUSINESS IN
YEARS THAT THEY DON'T MAKE A
PROFIT. IT IS ONE SMALL WAY FOR
US AS AMERICANS AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO COME TOGETHER
TO HELP THE SUCCESS OF THESE
VETERANS BECOME SUCCESSFUL WHEN
THEY COME HOME AFTER
DEPLOYMENT. FOR MANY BUSINESSES
THIS EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR FEET
IS A BACK BREAKING THE MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX HAS NOT BEEN
RAISED IN IN NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS. BUT FOR THE SERVICE
MEMBERS THAT RETURNED TO OUR
STATE AND TRY TO RESUME THE
RUNNING OF THEIR BUSINESSES IT
SEEMS RIGHT THAT WE SHOULD BE
THERE FOR THEM AND EXEMPTION
SHOULD BE GIVEN FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR APPLE. THE BAY TOWARD XIN
ON THIS ITEM IS THERE ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSS HUNDRED.
SIXTY SENATOR GROW. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I APPLY THE
AUTHOR FOR FORWARD I HAVE THE
ENERGY BILL IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE WE SHOT DOWN SO I'M
REALLY EXCITED THAT YOU BROUGHT
IT BACK SO WE CAN HELP OUR
VETERANS AND SERVICE MEMBERS
HAVE PICKED UP A WEAPON THE
DEFENSE COUNTRY AND THEY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE A
CHANCE AT STARTING A BUSINESS
AND KEEPING IT GOING BEFORE
THEY HAVE TO FILE AN. EIGHT
HUNDRED FEET. OUT MAKE TIME OF
BUT SO OKAY SIR. PERSISTENCE
PAYS OFF. ANY OTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE SENATOR
OR DO YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
BETTER PRESIDENT I APPRECIATE
YOUR VOTE AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR
OUR VETERANS IN THIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING SHE
SAYS HER ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR HILL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AN
ACT RELATING TO PEACE OFFICERS.
SENATOR HILL MADAM PRESIDENT AB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR WILL ADD TO
THE COUNTIES OF DEL NORTE MONO
AND SAN MATTEO TO PENAL COLD
PENAL CODE EIGHT THIRTY POINT
ONE C. OFFERING THEM AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO HELP WITH
THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES THESE
THREE COUNTIES WOULD BE ADDED
TO A LIST OF THIRTY TWO OTHER
COUNTIES. WHO HAVE THIS
EXPANDED DEFINITION FOR THEIR
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ADDITIONALLY ALL THREE COUNTIES
OF OBTAINED RESOLUTION FROM THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS POLICY THIS MEASURE HAS
NO OPPOSITION A REQUEST FOR
YET. RESPECT FROM THE ADS FOR
YOUR AYE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATE BILL ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSS IN ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS TURNING
OBJECTION IS SUBSTITUTING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY TWO SENATOR GLAZER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND ACT REALLY TO
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR GLAZERS MATTER PRESS
MEMBERS I UNDERSTAND THIS BILL
HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES WILL
BE BRIEF. A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. IS PART OF THE
COLLEGE ADMISSION REFORM
PACKAGE THERE BEEN NOT RECENT
ADMISSION SCANDALS INVOLVING
TOP UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND FORTUNATELY FEW OF
THOSE. WERE UNIVERSITIES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THE BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND IF ADOPTED BY
THE REGENTS UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FROM ADMITTING
STUDENTS BY SPECIAL EXCEPTION.
UNLESS APPROVED BY A MINIMUM OF
THREE SENIOR CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATORS. THE COLLEGE
ADMISSION PROCESS IS WHEN THE
NEEDS CHECKS AND BALANCES WHICH
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. AND HEARING NONE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY THREE SENATOR
MITCHELL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND NECK RELATED
TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA
SENATOR MITCHELL AT OUR
PRESIDENT CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL RECORDS
DO NOT PAINT THE WHOLE PICTURE.
MISSING INFORMATION IN IN IN IN
ACCURACY IS IN DATA UNDERMINE
THE FAIR ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE ON THE ABILITY OF
LAWMAKERS TO ESTABLISH BEST
PRACTICES FOR GOOD GOVERNANCE
REGARDING CRIMINAL JUSTICE. AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE BONTA WORKS TO
ADDRESS DATA GAPS AND IMPROVE
ACCURACY IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DATA BY REFINING THE COLLECTING
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF
STATE AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS INFORMATION. A MINUTES
WERE TAKEN IN THE SENATE TO
DELAY THE OPERATIVE DATE OF
THIS BILL UNTIL JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY. AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
CENTS COOLEY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND COURTS
TO FOLLOW IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT RELIABILITY AND UNIFORMITY
OF INFORMATION FLOWING THROUGH
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IT'S THE FIRST STEP IN ENSURING
WE HAVE ACCURATE AND COMPLETE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE RECORDS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY THREE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL I PORGES. BRADFORD BY
CARRIER. HI CHIANG. DALY NO
DODD I DORADO. GALGIANI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO. BY TADO.
JACKSON HI I JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK. BY OKAY
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER AYE STERN. I STONE
NOVEMBER OUR COUNTY BY WINNER
BY WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EIGHT GORGEOUS.
CHIANG NO. DORADO HI GALGIANI.
GLAZER BY GROWTH. NO HER TACO.
RUBIO BATES NOW. OUR EYES
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR ATKINS MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA AN ACT RELATING TO
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS. MADAM
PRO TEM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT HI RISE TO INTRODUCE
AB EIGHT NINETY THREE AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT DISTRICT BILL
THAT RESPONSE TO OVER WHAT AN
OVERWHELMING CALL FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO STOP SELLING
GUNS AND AMMUNITION ON STATE
PROPERTY IN THIS CASE. THE DEL
MAR FAIRGROUNDS WE'RE ALL TOO
AWARE THAT RARELY A WEEK IS
GOING BY WITHOUT ANOTHER
SENSELESS STRATEGY THIS TRAGEDY
EXCUSE ME INVOLVING GUNS.
FEDERAL IN ACTION ON COMMON
SENSE GUN LAWS VCTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS FEEL HELPLESS. WE
ALL KEEP RESTATING THAT
EVERYONE IS TIRED OF THE
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS DON'T GET
ME WRONG I BELIEVE THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS ARE IMPORTANT. ALL THE
TIME AND HAVE THEIR PLACE IN
TIME BUT ALL OF US UNDER THE
STONE TODAY WERE GIVEN
RESPONSIBILITY BY OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO TAKE TANGIBLE
REAL STEPS TO KEEP. ALL PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA SAFE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH AB EIGHT
NINETY THREE. THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THIS IS A BILL
THAT IS BROUGHT ABOUT BECAUSE
THREE CITIES THAT SURROUND THE
AG DISTRICT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS HAVE PASSED
RESOLUTIONS IN SUPPORT. OF
STOPPING THE SALE OF GUNS AT
THE TWENTY SECOND AG DISTRICT
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS. THE BOARD
IS A LOCAL ONE AND THEY MOVED.
TO TAKE ACTION. HI AND THIS
LEGISLATION. LOOK I'LL TAKE AN
ACT. I TO CONTROL WHAT IS DONE
ON THE DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS SO.
I WOULD ASK THIS IS A
MEANINGFUL STEP TOWARDS PUBLIC
SAFETY THIS IS SUPPORTED BY THE
SURROUNDING CITIES I WOULD ASK
MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS
AND VOTE ON. THANK YOU CENTER
ATKINS DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR NIELSEN.
PRESENTLY JOHN ONE OF THE U. S.
SENATE I WILL. REPORT TO YOU A
NOTE FROM OUR FLOOR ALERT. IT
SAYS AS SIX SIX EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN A FEDERAL JUDGE PLACED
IN JUNCTION ON THE DEL DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS DISTRICT BOARD AND
REQUIRED THAT THEY MAKE A DAY
IN THE TIME AVAILABLE FOR A GUN
SHOW. AND THAT IS NOW BEEN
TENTATIVELY SCHEDULED FOR
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHT. TWENTY
NINETEEN SO A JUDGE HAS ORDERED.
THAT THAT GUN SHOW PROCEED THE
REMINDS ME OF A LONG DEBATE
THAT WE'VE HAD HERE OVER THE
YEARS RELATED TO THE COW PALACE.
NOT HAVING GUN SHOWS AT THE COW
PALACE. NOW I DO NOT KNOW. A
VERY MANY CRIMINALS WHO EVER
WENT TO A GUN SHOW AT
FAIRGROUNDS THE BY THE GUN TO
COMMIT THEIR CRIMES. THAT IS
JUST THE ENVIRONMENT WORK
CRIMINALS GAIN THE WEAPONS TO
DO THEIR INFAMOUS DEEDS. PACKED
AS WAY TO OPEN AN ENVIRONMENT.
FOR THEM. I CAN APPRECIATE
COMMUNITIES GETTING CONCERNED.
BUT I DO NOT THINK THAT THAT
JUSTIFIES. BANNING GUNS SHOWS.
OR. GUNS BEING DISPLAYED. ED
OUR DISTRICT AGRICULTURE
ASSOCIATION FAIRS. THE PROBLEM.
OF CRIME BEING COMMITTED WITH
GUNS. ALL OF THE BILLS THAT WE
PASSED YEAR OVER THE MANY MANY
YEARS. THE PROBLEM IS STILL
HERE. MAYBE JUST MAYBE. SOME OF
THE PROBLEM. IS WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL. NOT WITH THE GUN.
THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE TWO
REASONS THIS EVENING TO VOTE NO
ON AB EIGHT NINETY THREE ONE
POLICY IN ONE FISCAL AND ALSO
THE POLICY ON SEPTEMBER SECOND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWENTY
TWO YEAR OLD DANIEL L. L. AS
OUR S. FIRED OFF A PISTOL IN
THE PARKING LOT OF THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS. IN APRIL OF THIS
YEAR EL AS OURS WAS SENTENCED
TO THREE YEARS IN PRISON. I
BRING THIS UP BECAUSE OF THE
IRONY OF THAT TRAGIC CASE AND
THE MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY.
THE SHOOTING DIDN'T OCCUR
DURING THE ANNUAL GUN SHOW AT
DEL MAR THE SHOOTING ACTUALLY
HAPPENED OUTSIDE OF A RAP
CONCERT AT DEL MAR. AND THE
SHOOTER WAS MAD BECAUSE HE
COULDN'T GET A TICKET. THE
ANNUAL GUN SHOW AT DEL MAR HAS
NEVER HAD A SORT THIS SORT OF
INCIDENT. LIKE THIS INVOLVING
THE USE OF A FIREARM. PERHAPS
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL I
TO CHANGES SO INSTEAD OF
BANNING GUN SHOWS IT WOULD
INSTEAD BAND CONCERTS AT THE
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS. AT LEAST
IN THE BILL WOULD HAVE A THREAD
AND A NEXUS TO GUN VIOLENCE.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THE ORGANIZED GUN SHOWS HAVE
THE BEST RECORD OF SECURITY
MEASURES TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE AND THE BEST RECORD OF
ENSURING THAT GUNS DO NOT GET
INTO THE WRONG HANDS. NOW ON
THE FISCAL SIDE OF THE BILL.
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS IS
CURRENTLY A DEFENDING A LAWSUIT
THE BECAUSE THEY-
INAPPROPRIATELY VOTED TO BAN
GUN SHOWS CURRENTLY AT THE FAIR
GROUNDS THAT LAWSUIT IS
ESTIMATED TO COST THEM NEARLY A
MILLION DOLLARS TO DEFEND IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE LAS
REVENUE OF BANNING GUN SHOWS IS
IN NOT MULTIPLE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER YEAR
THAT THE GUN SHOW LEGITIMATELY
BRINGS INTO THE FAIR GROUNDS.
AT THE FAIRGROUNDS IN IN TERMS
TO USE IT FOR PROPER AND
LEGITIMATE USES SUCH AS
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS AT THE COMMUNITY
ENJOYS IN AND AROUND THE DEL
MAR FAIRGROUNDS IN WITHIN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY FOR THOSE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. ON AB EIGHT NINETY THREE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
CENTER JONES ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SEEING AND HEARING NONE OF
SENATOR. AT CONTINUE CLOSE YOU
KNOW. TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR FROM
SANTEE WE SHOULD BE CAREFUL
BECAUSE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
CONCERTS AT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS HAS ALSO COME UP
THESE ARE SMALL CITIES THAT ARE
SURROUNDING THE AG DISTRICT BY
AND FOR YEARS THEY HAVE BEEN
ASKING TO STOP THE SALE OF GUNS
AS AS AS PART OF THE GUN SHOW.
HI THERE AT THE ACT MR. YOU
KNOW IT AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS
HAVE ALWAYS HAD THE RIGHT TO
CONTRACT WITH WHATEVER VENDORS
ARE TALENT THEY CHOOSE THAT'S
PART OF. STATE LAW TO OUR
SYSTEM OF AG DISTRICTS ARE
DESIGNED THEIR STATE ENTITIES
THAT ARE GOVERNED BY A LOCAL
BOARD OF DIRECTORS THESE BOARDS
OF DIRECTORS COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
THE VENTS TO HOLD ON THEIR FAIR
GROUNDS. I COULDN'T WE COULD
HAVE A WHOLE DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION YET AGAIN ON GUNS.
I'M STANDING UP TO PRESENT THIS
BILL FOR MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN. AN ISSUE
FOR THE WHOLE TIME THAT I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
SACRAMENTO NOW IT IS TRUE THAT
WE'VE HAD TRAGIC EVENTS. MORE
AND MORE AND MORE THAT PLAN TO
COMMUNITY TO BE AN EVEN MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE THERE IS
ACCESS THAT PEOPLE CAN BY FUNDS
IN AMMUNITION THAT'S ONLY
FURTHERED THEIR CONCERN TO THE
POINT THAT YOU HAVE THREE
CITIES. THEY'LL MARCELLINA
BEACH IN ENCINITAS THAT HAVE
PASSED RESOLUTIONS ASKING THE
STATE TO TAKE ACTION SO I WOULD
SUGGEST YOU THIS COULD BE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT GUN SALES IT
COULD ALSO BE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL AND A BOARD
THAT HAS ACTUALLY TAKEN ACTION.
TO RESCIND GUN SHOWS AT THE AG
DISTRICT AND I WOULD ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITIES
DECISION ON THIS. AND. TO CAST
AN AYE VOTE FOR AB EIGHT NINETY
THREE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALAN. I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL AYE
PORGES NO BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO
I CHIANG NO DOLLY NO DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO. JACKSON
BY JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M
MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI BY
ROTH. RUBIO I SKINNER. BY STERN.
BY STONE NO BURKE OUR CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS TITLE. ROTH
VICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE
SENATOR WIENER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL A NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SENATOR WIENER.
ARGUMENT MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AB EIGHT NINETY ONE
REQUIRES CITIES AND COUNTIES
WITH POPULATIONS. GREATER THAN
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
TO ESTABLISH A PARKING PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES SAFE OVERNIGHT
PARKING LOCATIONS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. LIVING IN THEIR
VEHICLES. THIS BILL PROVIDES
LOCAL PROGRAMS WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ESTABLISH RULES
AND REGULATIONS OF LOCAL NEEDS.
AS WELL AS AN APPLICATION OR
ENROLLMENT PROCESS THAT INCLUDE
CAN INCLUDE A BACKGROUND CHECK
FOR PARTICIPANTS. PROGRAMS
CREATED UNDER THIS BILL WILL
ALSO BE ENCOURAGED TO
COORDINATE WITH LOCAL
NONPROFITS AS WELL AS SITTING
COUNTY AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SERVICES. THE LEAD TO LONG TERM
PERMANENT HOUSING. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE CLARIFIED
THAT A COUNTY WITH A POPULATION
OF UNDER ONE MILLION PEOPLE I
SHALL BE DEEMED COMPLIANT WITH
THE BILL. CITY LOCATED IN I
MEAN HAS VOLUNTARILY ADOPTED A
PARKING PROGRAM THAT MEETS THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS.
FURTHERMORE AMENDMENTS EXAM TO
A CITY OR COUNTY FROM CIVIL
LIABILITY FOR EMPLOYEES COULD
PAVE ACTOR MISSION THE VALVES
TO PREVENT INJURY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO INSURE
THAT THOSE WHO WERE LIVING IN
THEIR VEHICLES HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO STAY OVER ARE YOU
WHILE THEY WORK TO TRANSITION.
TO PERMANENT HOUSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR BY BOAT.
THANK YOU SURE WINNER PAID OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE.
SIXTY FIVES MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THERE WAS A
QUESTION I BUILD ASKING
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE AND I'M
JUST WONDERING IF I COULD ASK
QUESTION OF THE- FLOOR MANAGER
THE QUESTION SENATOR WIENER.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE PROCEED FIVE
YEARS THIS OBVIOUSLY IF WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE A SPACE. BUT
WE SHOULD ALSO PROVIDE.
FACILITIES LIKE RESTROOMS AND
RUNNING WATER AND OTHER
AMENITIES SO. YOU KNOW
OTHERWISE IT'S GOING TO BE
AWKWARD I'M JUST WONDERING HOW
WILL THOSE AMENITIES BE PAID
FOR IS THE STATE PROVIDING A
FUNDING SOURCE THROUGH ITS
HOMELESS PROGRAM BUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT HESE MUNICIPALITIES
WILL HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
ACCOMMODATE. THIS PARTICULAR
OPPORTUNITY. PLEASE PROCEED ON
THE BILL PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM IT
DOESN'T MICROMANAGE IT WOULD
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF RESTROOM.
FACILITIES BUT ULTIMATELY
CITIES WILL DESIGN THEIR OWN
PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF FINDING
YOU KNOW THAT. THE. THE STATE
THROUGH THE CURRENT BUDGET AND
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE BEEN
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING WHAT WE
INVEST IN HOMES PROGRAMS WHICH
OVERWHELMINGLY OUR MONEY TO GO
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES AND SO
THIS I WOULD THINK. AND HAVE
THE TRIPLE CHECK BUT I WOULD
THINK WOULD BE AN ELIGIBLE USE
IN TERMS OF APPLYING FOR
FUNDING SO WE ARE INCREASING
WILL WE GIVE TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES FROM HOMELESSNESS AND
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT. MAYBE
ON MY OWN TIME. THAT A
PRESIDENT OBJECTIVELY IF IT
SHOULD THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THIS
BILL THAT THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE KEEP
IN MIND THAT. IT'S A
COLLABORATION IT ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT WERE FORCING
UNFUNDED OR UNDER IT TO ME
UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT THAT JUST
WOULD NOT. BE AT APPROPRIATE.
FORM IN IN ADDRESSING THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ARE CENTER
MORLOCK ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY FIVE. SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW WHEN I FIRST LOOKED AT
THIS BILL I HAD SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT IT BECAUSE I WAS I AM
MUCH CONCERNED ABOUT
NORMALIZING THE IDEA THAT WE
WANT PEOPLE TO LIVE IN THEIR
CARS AND TO THINKING THAT
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT I GOT TO
THINKING ABOUT THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE COME TO MY OFFICE
OVER THE YEARS THAT HAVE
BASICALLY REDUCED ALL OF THEIR
LIFESTYLE DOWN TO THE ONE
VEHICLE THEY HAVE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE AND
THEY'VE GOT ALL OF THE REALLY
POSSESSIONS IN THEIR VEHICLE
AND THEY JUST WANT A PLACE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEND THE- AND SO.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS HAS A
SUNSET AND THAT WERE UP
RECOGNIZING THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING UNITS
RIGHT NOW AND WE CAN'T BUILD
THEM WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WHICH IS THE SUNSET PERIOD I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE A PLACE FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE YOUR VEHICLE
OVERNIGHT AND NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE THEM SOME DIVISION THAT
THAT THE PEACE. WHEN THERE IS
AN INNER. CITIES AND SO THAT I
WOULDN'T. SPECULATE ASKED TO.
AB NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR CAFIERO ANY OTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SENATOR WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR DIED HI
IT IS A MORAL FAILURE THAT WE
ARE FORCING PEOPLE TO SLEEP IN
THEIR CARS AND THAT MORAL
FAILURE IS OUR FAILURE AS A
STATE TO CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT
AND TO CREATE LEGAL RULES WHERE
WE CAN ACTUALLY BUILD ENOUGH
HOUSING TO HOUSE EVERYONE SO
WE'RE PUSHING. WORKING PEOPLE
YOUNG PEOPLE OLDER PEOPLE INTO
THEIR CARS AND THAT IS A MORAL
FAILURE WE HAVE TO SOLVE THAT
AND NOT FORCE PEOPLE INTO THEIR
CARS TO LIVE BUT UNTIL WE GET
THERE PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN
THEIR CARS THAT IS A REALITY
TENS OF THOUSANDS IN LA ALONE
AND EXCUSE UPPER THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE THAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW AND I AGREE WITH THE WITH
SENATOR FROM US IN A SITE WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT REALITY.
BAYSHORE THAT THEY AT LEAST
HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO KEEP THE
CAR OVERNIGHT THAT IS THE LEAST
WE CAN DO FOR THEM UNTIL WE.
FIX THIS HOUSING. RESPECT
WAREHOUSE FRONT ROW. HAS CEASED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NOBEL. I PORGES NO
BRADFORD AYE AYE CABALLERO BY
CHIANG. NO DALY NO DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TITLE NO JACKSON HI HI JONES NO
LEYVA I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL.
HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER. IRAQ
OWSKI I WIENER AYE WILK. BY
HE'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MORE LUCK. VICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
COLLEAGUES THE NEXT FIVE ITEMS
ARE. ONE SIXTY SIX ONE SIXTY
SEVEN ONE SIXTY EIGHT ONE SIXTY
NINE AND ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
BE PREPARED WHEN THOSE ITEMS
ARE CLLED. FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SIX SENATOR LEYVA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SO YOU GO TO BUY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AN ACT RELATING
TO PRIVACY CENTER LEYVA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS DE FAKE
TECHNOLOGY CAN AND HAS BEEN
USED VARIOUSLY TO DEPICT POLL
CELEBRITY THE NON CELEBRITIES
AND SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIAL
WITHOUT THE CONSENT OR
PARTICIPATION. ASSEMBLY BILL SO
TO FIX IS THAT FOR EXAMPLE.
EXAMPLE OF PHOTOS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S FACE IN BE TAKEN
THE INTERNET AND SEAMLESS
CRAFTED ON PORN STARS THE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE APPEARS. TO
BE A STRONG APPETITE FOR THIS
CALL ONLINE. YOUR NOSE FATE.
THE NATURAL FEELINGS OF
EMBARRASSMENT IMPAIRING IN A
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT DEEP FAKE.
BECAUSE REPAIRABLE HARM TO A
VICTIM'S REPUTATION JOB
PROSPECTS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND MENTAL HEALTH
AB SIX OH TWO WOULD HELP
RESTORE CONTROL OVER
INDIVIDUALS IMAGE OR LIKENESS
BY REQUIRING CONSENT TO BE
OBTAINED PRIOR TO DEPICTING. A
PERSON AND DIGITALLY PRODUCED
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIAL BY
ALLOWING THAT CONSENT BE TO BE
RESCINDED WITHIN THREE BUSINESS
DAYS UNLESS CERTAIN CONDITIONS
ARE MET MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR. AYE VOTE DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
TURNING OBJECTION IS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NINE
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SEVEN SENATOR LEYVA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN OH NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I WRITE PRESENT AB
SEVEN OH NINE WHICH IT WOULD
EXPAND THE ROLES OF VOICES OF
STUDENTS SERVING ON SCHOOL
BOARDS BY ALLOWING THEM TO ALSO
SERVE ON SUB COMMITTEES ATTEND
GOVERNING BOARD FUNCTIONS AND
RECEIVED RECEIVED ALL OPEN
SESSION MATERIALS. THE OTHER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS RECEIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN OH NINE WILL ALSO
STRENGTHENED THE PARTICIPATION
BETWEEN A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE STUDENT VOICE AND THE
SCHOOL BOARD FOR GIVING STE.
MORE RESPONSIBILITY AND HELPING
THEM TO BECOME EFFECTIVE
LEADERS THROUGH THIS MAJOR
FURTHER MY. TO GROW AND TO
SERVE I WAS. ASKED I VOTE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS ARE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS FOR ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NINE
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
EIGHT SENATOR GALGIANI. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO OR THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS AN ACT RELATING TO
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
SENATOR GALGIANI THANK YOU
MADAM TO REMEMBER AB TWO ZERO
THREE WOULD HELP IMPROVE WORKER
SAFETY. AS IT RELATES TO VALLEY
FEVER BY REQUIRE INSTRUCT
EMPLOYER HI. TOWNIES I'D FACTOR
WHERE NESS AND- TRAIN. BROWN
SOIL ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO CONTRACTING
VALLEY FEVER BECAUSE THEY FACE
THE GREATEST RATE OF DUST
EXPOSURE AND ONE STUDY THAT
LOOKED AT VALLEY FEVER
OUTBREAKS IN THE US AND
WORLDWIDE BETWEEN NINETEEN
FORTY AND TWENTY FIFTEEN. IT
WAS FOUND THAT MORE THAN HALF
OF THE TOTAL OUTBREAKS WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH OCCUPATIONAL
EXPOSURE VALLEY FEVER IS
COMMONLY MISDIAGNOSED ARE LEFT
UNTREATED BECAUSE IT SYMPTOMS
RESEMBLE OTHER COMMON
ILLNESSES. NEARLY 75% PEOPLE OF
VALLEY FEVER MATH WORK OR
SCHOOL AND AS MANY AS 40% OF
PEOPLE WHO GET VALLEY FEVER ARE
HOSPITALIZED WE MAY RECALL THAT
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES LOST HER
SISTER. LAST YEAR TO VALLEY
FEVER THIS BILL IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE NO OPPOSITE
SHIN THAT WILL HELP IMPROVE
PROTECTIONS. FOR WORKERSAS IT
RELATES ALEX. ARE YOU.
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SINGING
HEARING NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY NINE SENATOR UMBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
AND IF WE COULD ASK PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN CONVERSATION TO PLEASE
KEEP THE VOICES DOWN PERHAPS
MOVED TO THE BACK OF THE ROOM
WHICH STARTING TO GET A LITTLE
NOISY. CENTER ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MISTER SECRETARY HISTORY
SOME OF THE THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO AN ACT
RELATING TO VETERANS SENATOR
UMBERG THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB TWO THREE
TITAN STATE CONTRACTING
PRACTICES RELATED TO A WIDE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM TO INCREASE.
MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT AND
PROGRAM IT'S GOOD BILLIARDS
TABLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THAT
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS VERY PICTURES OF TUNING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SINGING
HEARING NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES I THINK THAT IS
THE RECORD SENATOR UMBERG.
MOVING MOVING RIGHT ALONG TO
FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY ONE
SENATOR ARCHULETA. SENATOR
ARCHULETA EUROPE NEXT FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY ONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AN
ACTUAL INTO GAMBLING SENATOR
ARCHULETA THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY AS CO
AUTHOR OF AB SIX FORTY NINE
WHICH PERMITS A PERSON. WHO IS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY YEARS OF AGE
TO BE EMPLOYED IN A CARD CLUB
THE CARD OOM ESTABLISHMENT AS
LONG AS THEY DO NOT WORK FOR
THE DEALER FOR PERSONNEL OR ANY
OTHER EMPLOYMENT CLASSIFICATION
THAT INVOLVES WORKING ON THE
FLOOR. EITHER WAY THIS BILL
WILL PERMIT INDIVIDUALS TO WORK
AS SECRETARIES WAITERS
WAITRESSES MAINTENANCE
PERSONNEL AND DATA PROCESSING
PERSONNEL WITH IN THE CAR CLUB.
AS THE AS OF JANUARY TWENTY
NINETEEN OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN UNEMPLOYED
BUT SOME CITIES HAVE BEEN
DOUBLE DIGIT UNEMPLOYMENT
PERCENTAGES AND OF COURSE
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT OUR YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET EMPLOYED IN TRYING TO
GET EDUCATED HERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT THEM TO WORK
AS WELL. THERE ARE MANY
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE BETWEEN
THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
YEARS OF AGE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING FOR WORK AND
THESE OPPORTUNITY JR ARE THERE
AT THE CARD CLUB SOME OF THESE
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDE SINGLE
PARENTS. AND SOME COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT WORK WHAT THEIR
COMPLETING THEIR EDUCATION THE
OPPORTUNITIES CREATED BY THIS
BILL WILL HELP ESTABLISHED THE
POTENTIAL FOR CAREER GROWTH
WITHIN THESE HARD WORKING FOR
THESE HARD WORKING INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY. WITH THIS
I RESPECT. FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS FOR ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A THERE IS AN OBJECTION.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL BY
PORGES AYE BRADFORD AYE COMING
HERO I CHIANG. DALY AYE DODD I
DORADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO I JACKSON.
JONES. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. BY MORNING OR LOCK.
I'M A REAL. NIELSEN AYE PAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. HI RUBIO BY
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE EXCUSE
ME WILL GO THROUGH ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES II CHIANG. BY
GROW BY. JACKSON MONNING WELL.
PAN PORTANTINO. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE AT THE SEVENTY. TWO.
SENATOR RUBIO MR SECTOR PLEASE
READ SOME OF ELEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AN ACT RELATING
TO THE ELDERLY. SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
PACE THE PROGRAM OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
PAYS BENEFICIARIES ARE PROVEN
TO HAVE FEWER HOSPITALS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND REPORT
BETTER HEALTH AND QUALITY FIVE
THERE IS A CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF
PAGES PAGE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE IN THIS BILL WILL HELP
WITH EXPANDING PACE ACROSS THE
STATE ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND NON IS TURNING
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS FOR LOCAL. SEEING AND
HEARING NON HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING RIGHT
ALONG THE NEXT FIVE ITEMS
COLLEAGUES OR. ONE SEVENTY
THREE ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVENTY SIX
AND ONE SEVENTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY THREE SENATOR
HERTZBERG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ A SYMBOL OF A
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND NECK REALLY INTO
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY AND CLING
THERE'S THREATS TAKE AFFECT ME.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
MEASURE CONTAINS AN URGENCY
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE SUBJECT
MATTER OF THIS MEASURE IS
URGENT. THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE SLEEPING ON THE STREETS
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
THIS LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST
BUDGET ROUND IN AB ONE OH ONE
PASSED A MEASURE THAT DEALT
WITH THESE TYPES OF EMERGENCY
SHELTERS IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING
WE ARE BUILT ON GOVERNMENT
PROPERTY DON'T REQUIRE SEQUEL
APPROVAL. CITY OF LOS ANGELES
PASSED MEASURE H. THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES HHH THIS
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
GIVEN HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO FOLKS IN LA CITY IN
ORDER TO TRY TO EXPEDITE. ANY
TYPE OF HELP THAT THEY CAN GIVE
FOR PEOPLE WHO FIND THEMSELVES
HOMELESS. WITH RESPECT TO ALL
THE LAWS THAT WE PASS A
LOOPHOLE BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
THE CIRCUMSTANCES IF YOU LOOK
AT THE BILL THE ACTIONS SUCH AS
FUNDING OR PLANNING DECISIONS
TAKEN BY LOCAL AGENCIES EVEN IF
THEY ARE ON GOVERNMENT PROPERTY
AND FIT ALL THE OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE BEING
CHALLENGED. UNDER SEEK WITH US
DELAYING PROJECTS THAT'S
DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
EXPEDITING ORDINANCE IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES URGENCY IS
ADDED. I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THIS IS AN URGENT MATTER. THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU
MADAM SO PRESIDENT I'M I RISE
BECAUSE THIS I JUST I GET IT I
UNDERSTAND THE URGENCY OF THE
HOMELESS ISSUE IN LA AND I
BELIEVE IT'S PROBABLY THE SAME
URGENCY THAT CABINET ONE OF OUR
THIRTY WE HAVE HOMELESS OUR
ISSUES AND WHERE THE
OBSTRUCTION OR THE CHALLENGE
FORGETTING PROJECTS DONE ENDS
UP FOCUSING ON SECA AND THE
REASON I RISE TODAY IS NOT TO
ASK YOU NOT TO SUPPORT THIS I'M
GONNA SUPPORT IT BECAUSE IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO BUT I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
ASSEMBLY. HELD ALL OF THE
SEQUEL BILLS THAT THE SENATE
PASSED IN THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE
THERE WAS A FUNDAMENTAL BELIEF
BY THE CHAIR THAT THE SEQUEL
WAS NOT CREATING A PROBLEM IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND YET HELLO
IT WANTS AN EXEMPTION AND WHEN
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM BY USING A SEQUEL.
EXEMPTION THEN IT'S OKAY SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY. RECORD THAT I
I'M DISAPPOINTED TO BE IN THIS
POSITION I WITH MY BILL WAS
LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD IN
SOME OF THE POOREST.
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT THAT WAS HELD
AND I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ISSUE WHEN
WE MAY BE LOOKING AT SOME
BUDGET ISSUES. TO DEAL WITH
THAT. BUT IT IS ALWAYS
DISTRESSING TO ME TO SEE. A AN
ISSUE RAISED AN AN EXEMPTION
FOR A PART OF THE STATE THAT
HAS MORE LEGISLATORS THAN ANY
OTHER PART OF THE STATE AND
YET. THOSE OF US THAT LIVE IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA CAN'T CAN'T
SEEM TO GET ARE SUPER BILLS OFF
SO I AS I SAID I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT IS. THE RIGHT THING
TO DO AND THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
WE NEED TO LOOK AT SYKORA. WE
NEED TO ANALYZE WHAT IT'S DOING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS. THIS IS ONE
OF SO. I ASK YOU TO
RESPECTFULLY SUPPORT. FOR
NINETY SEVEN. ANY FURTHER
DEBATER DISCUSSION SENATOR
NIELSEN. BETTER PRESENT LAYS
DOWN THE SENATE AYE AYE RISE
AND VERY SINCERE SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION. THE SEVENTY
GALLON I HAD LEGISLATION JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO RELATED TO
REBUILDING AND BUTTE COUNTY
FROM THE TERREL PARADISE FIRE.
AND I FIND THAT THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE HERE THE ASSEMBLYMAN THIS
BILL A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
SEVEN ONE ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN
IS A IS GOOD BECAUSE AS WELL
SHE COULD EXEMPTIONS I DON'T
THINK ANYONE SHOULD BE CAREFUL
THAT WE'RE COMPROMISING SEQUEL
AND THROWING IN THE WASTE
BASKET AND HONORED NOR IT. IT'S
MEETING A NEED. THIS IS A GOOD
BILL AND I URGE MY COLLEAGUES
THE MORE I. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN SOCIAL CENTERS SENATOR
BORCHERS. I JUST LIKE TO
REAFFIRM THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPRESSED HERE. I AM
ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT OF ON
THIS LEGISLATION. AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT NGUYEN ISSUES
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD TO THIS BODY
AND TO THE OTHER HOUSE THAT
THEY'RE GIVEN THE SAME AMOUNT
OF GRAVITY AND RESPECT IN SENSE
OF URGENCY. I LOOK FORWARD TO
ABSOLUTELY UNANIMOUS VOTE ON
THIS AN IDENTICAL ONES THAT
WILL BE FORTHCOMING. HE FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SITTING IN HEARING HOUNDS
I'M SORRY SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED SO FAR AND
CERTAINLY A SEQUEL EXEMPTION
FOR A PROJECT LIKE THIS SEEMS
APPROPRIATE. THE ONE CONCERN I
HAVE BEEN AND MAYBE THE FOR
JACKIE CAN ADDRESS IN A CLOSE
IS TYING THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION
TO THE HOW HOUSING FIRST MODEL
AND I AND I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCEPT BEHIND THE HOUSING
FIRST MODEL AND THE ENERGY
BEHIND THAT. THE CHALLENGE THAT
I'M HEARING FROM SOME OF OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
THEY'RE HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
HOLDINGS SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT
ARE WE'RE TRYING TO HELP YOUR
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
IN A REMAINING IN THAT HOUSE
FIRST MODEL AND SO WHEN YOU
REMOVE THE ABILITY. OF. IN A
REALLY TRYING TO HELP THESE
PEOPLE COULD COME. RECOVER FROM
EITHER A DRUG ADDICTION OR
MENTAL ILLNESS OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT I THINK MAYBE THE
HOUSING MODEL THE HOUSING FIRST
MODEL SOMETIMES LET'S IS DOWN
AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING IF
THAT COULD BE ADDRESSED AS PART
AS THE SECRET BEING AND TIED TO
THAT. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING ON
SENATOR HERTZBERG IN MY CLOTHES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CERTAINLY TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE POINTS THAT
WERE MADE HERE LOOK THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES IS TRYING AS HARD
AS WE CAN AND WE IS PARTNERS IN
THE CITY OF LOS I MEAN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE TRYING
TO EXPEDITE THAT THAT'S WHY
THIS LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
REDUCED. I WOULD SUGGEST WITH
RESPECT TO OTHERS PARTS OF THE
STATE'S THE FACTOR THAT HAS ON
INFORMED THIS LEGISLATION IS
DIFFERENT THAN OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE IS THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF LITIGATION IN LOS ANGELES
THAT WE DON'T SEE AS MUCH IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE IF YOU
LOOK AT WHO SUPPORTING WHO
OPPOSING. THIS MAP YOU'LL SEE.
FAMILY HOUSING TO EVERY
COMMUNITY GROUP AT ALL. LOS
ANGELES AGAINST THE VENICE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE WEST MORE.
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION I THINK
THAT MAKES THE POINT. AND SO
WE'RE KIND OF IN A SITUATION
WHERE THE CITY HAS ADOPTED
NUMBER OF ORDINANCES. AND THAT
WHAT HAPPENS IS FOLKS IN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY POSSIBLY CAN.
TO SLOW UP THE PROCESS AND WE
IN THE GOVERNMENT AND EVERY
STATEMENT THAT WE MADE ON THIS
HOUSE AND THE OTHER. THE OTHER
HOUSE IN THE GOVERNOR IS TO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MOVE.
HOUSE ALONG AND SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT WHILE THIS IN
BODIES. THIS THIS VIEW AND YOU
CAN LOOK AT JUST LOS ANGELES I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE HAVE A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM KALENJIN.
MADE THIS AN URGENCY MATTER BUT
OFF THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR SEVENTY
TWO TO ZERO. THE HOUSING FIRST
MODEL IS THE MODEL THAT WE
ADOPTED IN THE MARK OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES ADOPTED. AND SO
CONSISTENT WITH THE ORDINANCE
IS INCONSISTENT THEIR OWN POP.
THIS LEGISLATION IS WRITTEN
REGARD I ASKED. I VOTE THANK
YOU SO CON ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED. SIX OR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. DOT. HI DORADO HI
GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO I TADO AYE JACKSON AYE
JONES. LABOR. BY MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. MORE LOCK
I'M A REAL NIELSEN. I PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY I WINNER
BY WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS DALY. GROVE
JONES MONNING MORRELL. OUR EYES
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. EXCUSE ME ICE THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY ICE
THIRTY FIVE ZERO ON THE MEASURE
MOVING ALONG COLLEAGUES TO FILE
ITEM OF ONE SEVENTY FOUR. FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR
SKINNER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EGGMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC RESOURCES AND MAKING
PROGRESS IN THERE FOR. CENTER
SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE AN AXE THE
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING MARKET
DEVELOPMENT ACT AND WILL HELP
BALANCE CALIFORNIA'S ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION GOALS WITH THE
MARKET REALITIES THAT WE ALL
SEE CHANGING TODAY. OUR STATE'S
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ORGANIC
WASTE VERSION GOAL OF 75% IS
RAPIDLY APPROACHING AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ESTABLISHES A
CURBSIDE RECYCLING COMMISSION.
AND ENCOURAGES MARKET
DEVELOPMENT IN TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENTS TO HELP ADDRESS
THESE MARKET CHANGES AND HELP
US MEET THOSE DIVERSION GOALS
BY EXTENDING THESE PRODUCTIVE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
CAPERS. SALES AND USE TAX
EXCLUSION PROGRAM AND THE
RECYCLING MARKET DEVELOPMENT
LOAN PROGRAM. THERE'S BROAD
SUPPORT NO NO VOTES I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION USING UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. GOSH DARN ALL RIGHT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. ARCH DOWN I.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES BY
BILL BY BURGESS I BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALY AYE
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW
BY HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT I HILL.
I HUESO I TADO BY JACKSON JONES
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
BY MORNING. I'M MORE LOCK I'M
REAL BY NELSON I PAN. DO YOU
KNOW. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG. TYLER CASKEY I WINNER.
BY WILK HI HI. REMOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR DOLLY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACT
RELATING TO FOOD HEALTH
ADVISORIES SENATE OLLIE THE
MEMBERS IT MEMBERS THE- AB ONE
SEVENTY TWO. BASICALLY ALLOWS
HEALTH OFFICERS TO POST WHERE
PEOPLE FISH WHAT CONTAMINANTS
ARE THOSE FISH IN THE CORNERS
OF FISH THEY SHOULD. CONSUME
THIS IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE PLEASE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE WAS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES. HI
BILL I BRIDGES ARE BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD I DORADO. HI GALGIANI. I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO. BY JACKSON. JONES. I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M
REAL. I NIELSEN. HI PAN. DO YOU
KNOW BY ROTH BY. AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
OUR KELSEY BY WINNER HI WILK HI
BY SENATOR MOVES A CALL ME TO
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX
SENATOR PORTANTINO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE NINETY FOUR BY A
SEMI OBERNOLTE AN ACT RELATING
TO ENVIRONMENT QUALITY CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT A MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB THREE NINETY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE IT IS A FIRE SAFETY
MEASURE THAT WILL FASTRACK
URGENCY PROJECTS. IDENTIFIED
THIS DEBATE FOR FIRE PRONE
SUBDIVISIONS WITH INSUFFICIENT
EGRESS ROUTES AB TWO NINE
ELEVEN OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN REQUIRED THE BORDER
FAR SHOULD IDENTIFY
SUBDIVISIONS OF THIRTY HOMES
ARE MORE THAT ARC SIGNIFICANT
FIERY A RISK THIS HELPS THOSE
INCIDENTS LEAVE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT. IT HAS A NARROW EXAM
HELP THESE IT IS. PROTECT FIRES
A WE DON'T KNOW WHAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THAT RICHARD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS. BATES HI
BILL. I BURGESS. HI BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROW. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TITLE I JACKSON. JONES
BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK I AM A REAL. AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG. BY LIKE
OWSKI. WIENER HI WILK HI
SENATOR MOVES A CALL ME TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN SENATOR
DODD MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND NECK RELATED FIRE
PREVENTION CENTER DOT. THANK
YOU MEDI MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY MORE SYSTEM PREVENTING
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES IN REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF HOMES DESTROYED
BY WILDFIRES EMBERS ARE SMALL
PIECES OF BURNING MATERIAL THAT
CAN TRAVEL MORE THAN A MILE. OF
A WILDFIRE ENBERG MISSIONS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
WILDFIRE HOME ADMISSIONS AB
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WILL CREATE A
STATE WIDE PROGRAM TO ALLOW
QUALIFIED FOR PARTY IN THE TO
SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA'S
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
EFFORTS THROUGH DEFENSIBLE
SPACE ASSESSMENT. THE THESE
THIRD PARTY I ENTITIES INCLUDE
THE STATE CONSERVANCY'S FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS IN CRAWFORD
CONSERVATION CORES. A NEW KEY
KQED INVESTIGATION ONLY 70% OF
THE PROPERTIES AND TERRITORY
WERE CAL FIRE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR MONITORING DEFENSIBLE SPACE
WERE ACTUALLY CHECKED BY THEIR
INSPECTORS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE
CREASE A NUMBER OF PROPERTIES
INSPECTED. AB FIFTEEN SIX IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT
HAS TO OPPOSITION AS PRIDE
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BILL HI BURGESS.
BRADFORD HI KELLY YET BY CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD. I DORADO.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO I JACKSON JONES I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. I
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK AMARILLO.
NIELSEN HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
OUR CASKEY BY WINNER HI WILK I
BY SENATOR MOVES A CALL FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY EIGHT SENATOR
HUESO. PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY NINE SENATOR
CABALLERO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT CENTER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ. UNDER EXISTING LAW
BARGAINING UNITS FOR
SUPERVISORY PEACE OFFICERS MUST
HAVE A MAP A MINIMUM OF TWENTY
SUPERVISORY OFFICERS IN ORDER
TO BE RECORD HIGHS AT THE
BARGAINING YOU. CURRENTLY FORTY
NINE K. THROUGH TWELVE I
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
THAT MAINTAIN POLICE
DEPARTMENTS BUT ONLY ONE
CURRENTLY EMPLOYS MORE THAN THE
MINIMUM TWENTY OFFICERS. IN THE
OTHER FORTY EIGHT DISTRICTS THE
SUPERVISOR REPEAT PEACE
OFFICERS OFTEN BELONG TO UNITS
THAT REPRESENT MISCELLANEOUS
NON SWORN EMPLOYEES THIS OFTEN
RESULTS IN A LACK OF
APPROPRIATE REP REPRESENTATION
SINCE PEACE OFFICERS OFTEN HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS AND INTERESTS
THAN THOSE OF NON SWORN
EMPLOYEES. AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
ONE WOULD REDUCE THE MINIMUM
NUMBER OF EMPLOYED SUPERVISORY
PEACE OFFICERS AT K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
NECESSARY FORM A BARGAINING
UNIT DOWN TO PEACE OFFICERS
REDUCING THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT WILL GIVE MORE
OFFICERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DECIDE WHETHER TO REMAIN WITH
THEIR EXISTING BAR IN UNIT OR
TO STOP BROWN EXCLUSIVE UNIT.
OF A- DAY HE SAW. FOR AN I. BUT.
THANK YOU SIR CABALLERO MEMBER
ANY DISCUSSION END OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. HERE
WE GO MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL THING IN HERE YES
THERE IS. THAT WOULD FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY NINE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ACTUALLY AYE ATKINS
AYE BATESBY BILL BY BURGESS BY
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG. I
DALY DODD. I'D RATHER I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR TADO.
I JACKSON BY JONES I LEYVA. I
AM ACQUIRE. BY MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NIELSEN. BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. NOVEMBER
OUR COUNTY BY WINNER. BY WILK
BY. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DALLY MORRELL. VICE
THIRTY SIX KNOWS TO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SENATOR DODD.
FILE ITEMS PASS ON FILE ALL
RIGHT NEXT THE NEXT FIVE OR
FILE ITEM. ONE EIGHTY ONE ONE
EIGHTY THREE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
ONE EIGHTY FIVE IN ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. WE'LL START NOW WITH
FILE ONE EIGHTY ONE SENATOR TO
ROSS SO. PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY THREE SENATOR
MORALE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SENATOR
MORALE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE NINETY THREE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
CITY AND COUNTY DEPARTMENTS TO
THE MINISTER. THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS TO ACCESS
COOLEY WAGE DATA LOCAL BOARDS
IN AGENCY SHOULD HAVE THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO EVALUATE AND
FORECAST THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THEIR PROGRAMS IS CRITICAL FOR
ASSESSING THE LONG TERM IMPACTS
OF PLACING CLIENTS INTO. PLACE
IN AN ACCESS TO THE STEP AB
FIVE NINE WE ALL POLL NAPLES
BOARDS TO MORE EFFICIENTLY USE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED I PART SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM EIGHT
OR DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY THREE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ICE FORTY KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO COLLEAGUES
SENATOR PAN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ A SOME OF THOSE
FOUR SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND ACT
REALLY INTO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS CENTER PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT CENTER PLEASED
TO PRESENT TO IT BEFORE SEVENTY
SIX BY SOME MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
THE CALIFORNIA OPPORTUNITY ACT
OF TWENTY NINETEEN CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES FOR THE LICENSURE AND
REGULATION OF VARIOUS
PROFESSIONS OF CASES BY BOARDS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND WHILE THE
APARTMENTS. IT IS PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S REGULATION OVER
SAY PROFESSION MANY FARM
TRACTOR. PULLS A FACE. FACED
SIGNIFICANT ROAD BLOCKS AND- IN
TERMS OF PROCESS TIMELINESS AND
ACCEPTANCE FORM CREDENTIALS.
THIS BILL PASSED THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONVENE A TASK FORCE TO
ASSESS KERN FOREIGN CREDENTIAL
REVIEW PROCESSES AND TO
RECOMMEND POTENTIAL STEPS TO
ENSURE FOREIGN TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
PRACTICE IN OUR GREAT STATE.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR MORLOCK THE PRESIDENT I
JUST HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
FLOOR MANAGER WOULD YOU ACCEPT
THE COURSE CENTER MORE WORK I'M
JUST CURIOUS INSTEAD OF
ESTABLISHING A TASK FORCE WHEN
WE JUST REQUEST THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO ANALYZE
THIS ISSUE. WELL I WOULD JUST
SAY IS THAT ARE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ALTHOUGH
COMPOSED OF MANY VERY TALENTED
INDIVIDUALS. I THINK THAT TERMS
OF EXPERTISE ABOUT PARTICULAR
BOARD THE BOARD REQUIREMENTS
THAT MAINLY RESIDES IN THE
DEPARTMENT AND SIMMER AFFAIRS
AND I WOULD STATE ARE YOU THAT
THAT. IS THAT'S ALSO DEPARTMENT
DON'T HAVE TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IT'S FRIDAY THE
MOST APPROPRIATE PLACE TO START
WITH ALTHOUGH CERTAINLY I THINK
WE CAN ENGAGE THE LA IS THE
TASK FOR THEMSELVES
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TERMS OF
SHIPPING ANY FUTURE LEGISLATION
WE WOULD HAVE TO BE ENGAGED IN
TERMS OF. MODIFYING THE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANY OF THE
PORTS THAT THAT MAKE. A BIRD
FROM THE SOUTH COURSE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU OTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION CENTER JONES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. ALSO BE
BRIEF I KIND OF HAD THAT SAME
CONCERN SO. IN ME. THAT I WILL
I BE VOTING NO TODAY THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. SENATOR PAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS AYE BATES. HI BILL I
BRIDGES. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
I CHIANG I DALY. DODD HI THE
RUSSELL I GALGIANI. I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TADO I DO SAN. BYE BYE.
JONES NO LABOR BY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK MORALE. NELSON. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. BY ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN. I STONE. NO
NUMBER OUR COUNTY I WINNER. HI
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME BURGESS.
DALY NO. MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO.
OUR EYES THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR
THE MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR
FOR PURPOSES OF CALLING IT
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MADDIE
LOUNGE VERY DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
IN THE MEDI LOUNGE SENATOR
GROVE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE
**** MY OWN. REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
IN THE CARTOONS
EIGHTY THREE HAS HAD MEASURE
BEEN HEARD. ONE EIGHTY THREE
ESTáN WAITING FOR IS A PASS ON
FILE SENATOR LABOR ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY FIVE. ALL RIGHT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
COLLEAGUES WE ARE BACK ON THE
FILE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FIFTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
AND ACT REALLY ANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SENATOR LEYVA THE
FLOOR WHAT YOURS WHAT THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FIFTY
THREE THERE ARE MORE YOUTH ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES NOW
AS MORE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ARE ENROLLING IN COLLEGE LEVEL
CLASSES. AS WELL AS SOME
COMMUNICABLE JUST HAVE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES ON THEIR
CAMPUSES THE CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT REPORTING ACT CAR
CAMERA. REQUIRE SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES REPORT WHENEVER THEY
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OR HAVE OBSERVED
THAT A CHILD HAS BEEN A VICTIM
OF ABUSE OR NEGLECT ALTHOUGH
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SITTING HAVING
GIVEN TRY THIS TRAINING
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HAVE NOT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
PLEASE AB ELEVEN FIFTY THREE
WILL SIMPLY EXTEND CAMERA
TRAINING AND REQUIRE CLASSIFIED
STAFF IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO UNDERGO THE TRAINING MODULE
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS. THIS
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
THERE DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE
ONE TIME AND THEN PUT THE
MATTER ON CALL IN HOPES THAT WE
CAN GET ALL COLLEAGUES BACK TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. BILL HI BURGESS BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO HI CHIANG DALLY.
DODD. THE RUSSELL HI. GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO. HI JACKSON HI I JONES BY
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONNING. I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL. I NIELSEN PAN. BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. STERN HI STONE I
AM BURKE. OUR COUNTY HI WINNER
HI WILK HI. CENTER LEYVA MOVES
A CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AN ACT
RELATING TO CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. SENATOR MITCHELL.
MADAM PRESIDENT AB ONE EIGHTY
NINE WOULD CLARIFY THAT ALL
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE CONSIDERED
MANDATED REPORTERS INTO THE
CHILL CHILD ABUSE NEGLECT
REPORTING THAT. THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE CURRENTLY
UNLICENSED PROVIDERS DO NOT
HAVE A REPORTING REQUIREMENT
I'M SURE ALL OF US ARE AWARE
THAT MANDATE REPORTERS ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE REQUIRED BY
LAW TO REPORT KNOWN OR
SUSPECTED CHILD MALTREATMENT.
CLASSIFIED ALL QUALIFIED
ARTISAN SERVICE FOR
PROFESSIONALS AS MANDATED
REPORTERS REDUCES CONFUSION
AMONG THE PROVIDER COMMUNITY
AFTER WHOSE MANDATED AND WHO
ISN'T. ALL PROVIDER TYPE SERVE
THE SAME PATIENT POPULATION IN
THERE FOR IN THE INTEREST OF A
PROTECTING THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM. ALL SHOULD BE MANDATED
REPORTERS AB ONE EIGHTY NINE
HAS BEEN CONSENT THUS FAR
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE.
PROCESS I HOPE IT GAINES
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL ATTORNEY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES HI BILL. BELL GORGEOUS. I
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO HI CHIANG.
DALY I DODD. I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO I TADO. JACKSON HI I
JONES BY LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE. HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. I'M MORE
LOCKED BY AMARILLO. MORRELL. HI
NIELSEN. PAN HI PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. I AM BURKE I
DON'T POWER CASKEY BY WINNER BY
WILK BY. THESE CALL THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. ATKINS BELL HI
THANK. HERTZBERG. DATO HI
NIELSEN BY. SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
PAT CENTER HERTZBERG FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. THE BILL
FORTY FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW AND ACT REALLY INTO
ELECTIONS SENATOR HERTZBERG. WE
HAVE ALL. EXPERIENCE IN ONE
FORM OR THE OTHER. THE IMPACT
OF DIRECT DEMOCRACY. WHICH WAS
INFORMED BY GOVERNOR HIRAM
JOHNSON MORE THAN A HUNDRED
EIGHT YEARS AGO. CHALLENGES
THAT THE PURPOSE OF DIRECT
DEMOCRACY WAS TO. CHANGE THE
GAME. PEOPLE POWER AND WHAT'S
HAPPENED HAS BEEN. THAT THE
WORLD IS SHIFTED. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT EVERY QUOTE
CITIZEN CLOSE QUOTE INITIATIVE
ON THE BALLOT UTILIZE A
PETITION MANAGEMENT FIRM. WHICH
PAYS EMPLOYEES IN A PERSECUTOR
BASES IN THE AVERAGE COST TO
PLACE AN INITIATIVE ON THE
BALLOT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WAS TWO MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO HERE'S A
PROCESS THAT WAS INTENDED TO.-DEAL WITH SUFFICIENT POWER. TO
IT POWER THE VOICE SHE'S FOLKS
DIDN'T LIKE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR DID.
AND TO DEAL WITH THE CORRUPTION
THE RAILROADS AND OTHER ISSUES
AT THE TIME. THE WORLD IS
CHANGED WE HAVE DEALT WITH THIS
ISSUE NOW THAT'S IN THIS
MEASURE DOZENS OF TIMES IN THE
LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS BUT AS
I'VE SAID BEFORE ON THE FLOOR
TOOK FORTY FIVE TIMES BUT THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT TO PASS
CONGRESS IMPORTANT MEASURES ARE
CONTINUE TO NEED TO BE. BROUGHT
FORTH FOR CONSIDERATION. SO
WHAT IS AB FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE
DO. IT PROHIBITS THE PAYMENT OF
SIGNATURE GATHERERS ON A PER
SIGNATURE BASIS. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE 10% ONLY 10% OF
SIGNATURES TO QUALIFY
INITIATIVE WERE GATHERED BY
VOLUNTEERS ARE NONPROFIT
EMPLOYEES WHOSE MAIN JOB OUR
DUTY IS NOT SIGNATURE GATHERING
THE WORD SOMETHING THAT HAS
SOME REALITY IN A POLITICAL
MOVEMENT. AND UNDER THIS
MEASURE SIGNATURE GATHERS COULD
STILL BE PAID HOURLY OR TO
STIPEND. WILL ELIMINATE THE
INCENTIVE FOR PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERS TO APPROACH INDIVIDUALS
AGGRESSIVELY OR SPREAD
MISINFORMATION. THAT'S WHAT THE
BILL DOES BEGINS TO TRY TO PICK
UP TO CHIP AWAY AT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACED. IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S TRANSPIRED
LEAST LAST ACTUAL SIGNATURE
GATHERING DOT DRIVE WAS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
VOLUNTEERS. IN PROP THIRTEEN
WITH THAT I ASKED YOU I BILL.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR STONE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES WHEN
HEARING JOHNSON WAS GOVERNOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
DIDN'T HAVE FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE LIVING HERE WE PROBABLY
HAVE A LEGISLATURE THAT WAS
TRULY REFLECTIVE OF THE
ELECTORATE. HEY IT'S A
DIFFERENT DAY WHERE IN ORDER
FOR US TO DO SOMETIMES WHAT IS
RIGHTEOUS FOR THE CITIZENS OF
THE STATE. WE HAVE TO GO TO THE
BALLOT. IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
SEEMS TO BE A PRETTY VERY WILL
USE ROUTE. TO ENSURE THAT
CITIZENS VOICES ARE HEARD. PROP
THIRTEEN WAS PASSED HOW MANY
YEARS AGO THIRTY YEARS AGO AS
A- AS A STATE PEOPLE WERE
REBELLIOUS OVER THE HIGH
PROPERTY TAXES OVER PRODUCT
PRICING PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
HOMES. IT IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT THAT WE CAN EMPLOYEES
SOMEONE TO GET SIGNATURES TO
GET SOMETHING ON A BALLOT. SO
THAT CAN HAVE A LAWFUL ELECTION
AND BE CONSIDERED AT THE BALLOT
BOX. NOW THE LEFT PROBABLY
DOESN'T LIKE THAT WE USE
SIGNATURE GATHERERS BECAUSE OF
THE PART OF THE LEGISLATION YOU
CAN HAVE NONPROFIT SECOND STEP
UP TO THE PLATE. AND DO THAT
MANY THOSE SAME NONPROFITS ARE
BENEFICIARIES OF LEGISLATION
THAT HAPPENS HERE AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE SO CREATES A LITTLE
BIT OF AN IMBALANCE. AND I CAN
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD MOVE TO TRY
TO BAN THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
ACTIVITY SO I THINK WE SHOULD
RESERVE THE RIGHT FOR OUR
CITIZENS TO CHALLENGE WHAT WE
DO UP HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
THIS CONTRARY TO. HOW THEY LIKE
TO SEE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RUN AND IT IS CONSTITUTIONAL TO
PAY A COMPANY TO DO THE LEGWORK
TO GRAB THE SIGNATURES TO GET
ON THE BALLOTS ARE CITIZENS CAN
VOICE THEIR OPINION ON ISSUES.
BEFORE THIS STATE THAT ARE PAST
ARE NOT IN AGREEMENT WITH A
MAJORITY OF THE CITIZENS AND
FOR THOSE REASONS. WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY SAY NO AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE FLOOR MANAGER IF YOU TAKE A
QUESTION SENATOR HURT I WILL.
PLEASE PROCEED. I AM I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE HAVE NON
PROFITS AND UNIONS EXEMPTED.
ARE FROM IN THIS BILL AND COULD
YOU EXPLAIN THAT BECAUSE THERE
IS A QUESTION ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY ABOUT. WELL I
THINK IT HAS TO DO. WITH THE
NATURE OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THE
EASE OUR EMPLOYEE BASE GROUPS.
INDIVIDUALLY BASED GROUPS.
MEMBERSHIP BASED GROUPS. AND I
THINK THAT THERE'S IN THE
CONSTITUTION THE IDEA OF THE
RIGHT TO ASSOCIATION. IT IS
FOUNDATIONAL IN THE BILL OF
RIGHTS. SO THESE ARE MEMBERSHIP
GROUPS. THAT ARE FORMED BY A
COMMON SET OF IDEAS THOSE COULD
BE A SOME OTHER GROUPS THAT
EXIST IN THE NONPROFIT WORLD
THE ESSENCE OF THIS BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND I DID THE SPEAKERS
COMMISSION ON INITIATIVE
REFORM. AND WASN'T ABLE TO GET
PUSH IT THROUGH BECAUSE WE HAD
THE ENERGY CRISIS AND
REDISTRICTING AND THIRTY FIVE
OTHER THINGS AND TRUCKS RUNNING
INTO THE BUILDING. THE
DISRUPTED US A LITTLE BIT. YOU
KNOW ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS WE
CAME UP RECOMMENDATIONS THESE
BEING SOME OF THEM. THE NUMBER
OF BILLS I'VE SEEN TWENTY OF
THEM AT LEAST THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE THAT TRY TO STOP
AND MAKE IT ONLY VOLUNTEER IN
THE LIKE BUT THIS IS A 10%
PERCENT THRESHOLD IS ALMOST
LIKE. PROPER LABELING THAT AT
LEAST IT'S TRUTH IN LENDING IF
YOU WILL THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY
SOME REAL PEOPLE BEHIND THE
MOVEMENT RATHER THAN AND AN
INITIATIVE RATHER THAN JUST A
GIGANTIC PAYCHECK A BIG BIG
GIGANTIC CHECK WE'VE SEEN
INITIATIVES BEING FUNDED BY ONE
INDIVIDUAL THIS REQUIRES THAT
AT LEAST YOU'VE GOT TO GATHER
SOME THRESHOLD A QUORUM IF YOU
WILL SOME LEVEL OF. THE
DEMOCRATIC LEGITIMACY BEYOND
THE NOTION OF THE CHECK AND THE
UNIONS ARE NOT FOR PROFITS
THEIR MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
UNDERSTAND THE POLITICAL AGENDA
I'M NOT GOING TO DENY THAT. BUT
THEY'RE FUNDAMENTALLY DRIVEN BY
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE AND EVERY INDIVIDUAL
IN THOSE MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE A RIGHT TO
VOTE AND THEY CAN VOTE FOR THE
FIRST 10% OF THE VOTERS THOSE
ARE VOTERS AND IS DEMOCRACY
THAT. IS THE RIGHT TO
ASSOCIATION THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
INCLUDED. BEN RESIN ON MY OWN
TIME I JUST LIKE TO REFER TO
SOMETHING IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
I THINK GOES TO THE HEART OF
THE QUESTION REGARDING. HI
EQUAL ACCESS SAYS THE PROVIDED
IN THE CONSTITUTION. I'D LIKE
TO READ I MIGHT. VOLUNTEERS
THIS MAY BILL MAY ALSO VIOLATE
THE EQUAL PROTECTION AS
IDEOLOGICALLY EXAMS UNIONS AND
OTHER NON PROFITS FROM THIS
REQUIREMENT. AND EVEN ALLOWS
ARE PAID CIRCULATORS TO USE
PETITIONS STATING THAT THEY ARE
NOT BEING PAID TO CIRCULATE
PETITIONS. I THINK THE POINT
HERE IS THAT YOU CAN HELP. MANY
ORGANIZATIONS AND I'D LIKE TO
REFER TO ONE THAT HAPPENED IN
LAGUNA MIGUEL FOR MANY YEARS WE
FIND AN AIRPORT WAS ABOUT TEN
YEARS. AND WE HAD TO FILE OF
PETITIONS FOR BALLOT MEASURES
THAT WOULD STOP THAT WE USED
PAID WE HAD MANY VOLUNTEERS WE
YOU'D PAID CIRCULATORS BUT WE
ARE ALSO A NONPROFIT. SO
BASICALLY YOU COULD HAVE AN
EMPLOYER WHO HAS A PARTICULAR
INITIATIVE THAT ARE A BILL IS
COMING OUT TOMORROW. ASIAN
THAT'S COMING OUT THEM SO THEY
CAN ACTUALLY FORM A NONPROFIT
SAY THAT THEIR EMPLOYEES OR
MEMBERS BECAUSE IT AFFECTS ALL
OF THEM AND THEN THEY WOULD BE
EXEMPTED TO I ASSUME. IT SEEMS
TO BE THAT CONVOLUTED SO THE
VERY PROCESS OF THE INITIATIVE
BEING. THERE FOR PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY AFFECT THEIR
GOVERNMENTS IN THE LAWS THAT
IMPACT THEM. SO I THINK THAT
THIS REALLY DESERVES A VERY
STRONG NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BASIS FOR ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
HERTZBERG YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. ARTS LETTER I
ATKINS BATES. NO BELL HI PORGES.
NO BRADFORD. I CABALLERO I
CHIANG NO DALLY NO DODD I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL WITH SO. I TADO HI
JACKSON. JONES NO LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LARK NO RAIL NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN STONE. NOVEMBER OUR
CASSIE. I WIENER AYE WILK NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME ALLEN. ATKINS
GLAZER HILL NO JACKSON STERN.
OUR EYES TWENTY THREE KNOWS
TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR. HERTZBERG UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THANK
YOU MADAM. PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THERE'S A RESOLUTION ANOTHER
RESOLUTION THIS IS A RESOLVING
TIME OF THE OUR SEASON THERE'S
A RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULES SIXTY ONE
AND SIXTY TWO AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY
REQUESTED BEEN APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE RESOLUTION
RESOLVED THE JOINT RULES SIXTY
ONE AND SIXTY TO BE DISPENSED
WITH AS THEY RELATE TO ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SEVENTY AS REQUEST.
SENATOR HERTZBERG **** FOR AN
AYE VOTE SENATOR GROVE S. FOR A
NO VOTE. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES NOBEL
I PORGES NO BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI. AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO AYE
OR TACO I JACKSON HI I JONES.
LEYVA. I AM MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. I'M MORE
LUCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN. I
STONE. NO AMBERG OUR COUNTY I
WINNER I WILK. PLEASE. TWENTY
EIGHT NINE THE JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. BACK ON FILE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. WE ARE ON
FIRE I'M SORRY IT INTO MY DOWN
WE ARE BACK ON FILE. FILE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY NINE SENATOR
HILL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AN ACT RELATING TO
PREVAILING WAGE. SENATOR HILL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
PRESENTED AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE
WORKERS ARE PAID FAIRLY FOR
THEIR WORK BY PROVIDING
CLARITY. TO WIN THE PREVAILING
WAGES REQUIRED ON
PRECONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES
CURRENTLY THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION BETWEEN AWARDING
AGENCIES CONTRACTORS AND LABOR
GROUPS AROUND WHEN AND WHERE
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS
APPLY ONE PRECONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES. AB SEVENTY SEVEN
SIX SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
CLARIFY THAT PRE CONSTRUCTION
AS IT RELATES TO PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS ALSO INCLUDES SITE
ASSESSMENTS FEASIBILITY STUDIES
TO ENSURE WORKERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY ARE
RECEIVING THE PREVAILING WAGE
THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL COLLEAGUES. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY NINE THAT IS FOR ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OUR. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES
NOBEL AYE PORGES NO BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO BY CHIANG. DELHI NO
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON HI I JONES.
LABOR. HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
BY MORNING I'M MORE LARK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN. HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NO BURKE HI IOWA CASSIE I
WINNER. I WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
CHIANG. BY JONES. OUR EYES
THIRTY. ICE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY AND THE NEXT FIVE ITEMS
COLLEAGUES OR FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY ONE NINETY ONE OR NINETY
TWO ONE NINETY THREE AND ONE
NINETY FIVE FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SENATOR DOLLY. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY SENATOR
DOLLINGER THE MAN PRESENT
MEMBERS SAID TODAY I AM
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN. AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO USE 10%
OF THE SELF GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FUNDS FROM
TWENTY TWENTY TO BE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
TO INSTILL FACILITIES IN HIGH
FIRE THREAT DISTRICTS. THESE
INCENTIVE FUNDS. FUNDS FROM
THIS BILL COULD SUPPORT MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE LARGE
FACILITIES SUCH AS WATER
SUPPLIERS WASTE WATER AGENCIES.
AND CAMPUSES AND MORE THAN A
HUNDRED SMALL PHILLIES LIKE
SCHOOLS AND FIRE STATIONS THIS
BILLS RECEIVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
TO RESPECT THAT FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR DAHLE DEBATER
DISCUSSION IS FOR ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
STERN. WHERE THE MEN PRESENT
VERY BRIEFLY STRONG SUPPORTER
THE BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I JUST
WANT TO KNOW TO MEMBERS THOUGH
THAT THIS SMALL. SELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE IN THE
FIRE ZONES WILL BE A CRITICAL
STEP BUT- IT IS FAR FROM
SUFFICIENT TO DEAL WITH THE
LOSS OF POWER FROM PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF FOR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. YES
YOUR PROGRAM IS STILL NOT FULLY
FUNDED. THIS IS A SMALL AMOUNT
THEIR SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET BUT THERE
NURSING ASSISTED FACILITIES
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
EVEN REFINERIES BUT EVEN YOUR
GRANDMOTHER POWER MAY GO DOWN
OVER THIS FALL IN THE WINDS
KICK UP IN THE FIRES KICK AND
WE STILL DON'T HAVE A PLAN IN
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR HOWTO
DEAL WITH THAT. SO I'LL BE
STRONGLY SUPPORTING THE MEASURE
TODAY BUT WE HAVE GOT TO SOLVE
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A SENATOR STERN SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D SUPPORT THIS BILL
AS I HAD THE HONOR OF AUTHORING
THE US SHIP EXTENSION AND THE
REQUESTING OF ITS TO FOCUS ON A
STORAGE SB SEVEN HUNDRED WHICH
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW. LAST YEAR
I DO WANT TO KNOW TO IN TERMS
OF WHAT THE CENTER FROM LOS
ANGELES. COUNTY TO SAID ON THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HAS NOT COMMITTED TO
EVEN FULLY FUNDING THE ESTá
PROGRAM AND THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ARE TRYING TO
SABOTAGE THE FULL FUNDING
ARRESTED SO 10% OF A SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY WILL BE VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY IS IN ALL
OF OUR INTERESTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CPC DOES ITS JOB. AND
THE AND AN AXE. OUR INTENT AND
FULLY FUNDS YES SIR PROGRAM.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE CENTER DAHLE
YOU MAY CLOSE I THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL BY BURGESS AYE BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG. I
DALY AYE DODD. BY DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO I
JACKSON BY JONES BY LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK. I'M A REAL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE. STONE BY.
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY I WINNER
HI WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS GROVE. HI.
OUR EYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE WE'RE
GOING TO START THE PRESENTATION
AT THE BEGINNING SENATOR STERN
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE AB
TEN FIFTY SEVEN. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THE MON AN
ACRYLATE OIL AND GAS. SENATOR
STERN FLOORS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESENCE WE'RE BACK WITH
A MEASURE I PRESENTED YOU
EARLIER TODAY REGARDING.
BASICALLY AN INSURANCE POLICY
TO MAKE SURE THAT TAXPAYERS ARE
NOT STUCK WITH THE DIME IF NO
OIL OR GAS COMPANY GOES
BANKRUPT. FOR THE COSTA
PLUGGING IN ABANDONING THEIR
WELLS ALREADY THE TAB HAS RUN
OUT ON ON HOLLY PLATFORM WHICH
WAS A FORMER EXXON SITE THAT
WAS THEN SOLD TO VAN ECHO
INVENTED CO WENT BANKRUPT AND
THE BILL I BELIEVE IS OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AT THIS
POINT. TWO HUNDRED. THIS BILL
DOES NOT CAP THE LIABILITIES
FOR OIL COMPANIES ON THE BACK
END OF WHAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
DO WHEN IT COMES TO REAP
REMEDIATION OR DE
COMMISSIONING. SO MAKE NO
MISTAKE THIS IS NOT A FREE PASS
TO OIL. BUT IT DOES REQUIRE
OPERATORS IN THIS STATE TO HAVE
SOME SKIN IN THE GAME. TO SAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO PUT UP SOME
REASONABLE COST OF PLUGGING IN
ABANDONING THAT WELL OR THOSE
WELLS. PRIOR TO WORKING THOSE
WELLS. THE COSTS ARE CAPPED A
RIGHT NOW FOR THAT REQUIREMENT
IT'S THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR THE REASONABLE COSTS OF
PLUGGING IN ABANDONMENT
WHICHEVER IS LESS. SO WE THINK
IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
MEASURE BUT THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER COMPONENT THAT YOU
SHOULD KNOW. THE GOVERNOR WAIT
IN. A COUPLE WEEKS AGO IN THE
PROCESS AND IN LIGHT OF SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WE'VE BEEN
FACING A DOG OR- WHETHER IT'S
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. OR DEMI
PERMITS THAT HAVE MADE THEIR
WAY THROUGH THE SYSTEM. FOR A
GENERAL GENERAL. FRUSTRATION
BOTH FROM INDUSTRY AND FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS WITH THEIR
ABILITY TO DO PROPER OVERSIGHT
AND PERMITTING IN THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY. CHANGES ARE BEING
MADE AND AN OVERALL WILL BE
UNDER WAY. THIS FALL AND INTO
NEXT YEAR. ENTITIES KICK OFF
THAT PROCESS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED A RENAMING OF THE
AGENCY. I BELIEVE THE ACRONYM
NOW WILL BE CAL JAM. BUT IT
WILL BE THE GEOLOGIC ENERGY
MANAGEMENT DIVISION WITHIN THE
RESOURCES AGENCY. BUT ALSO IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THE
MISSION IS BEING CLARIFIED IN
THIS LEGISLATION. TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
THAT ALIGNMENT WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES. IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE WORK
THAT. THE FORMER DOGGER HAS TO
DO THAT THEY'RE NOT ON AN
ISLAND THAT THEY MUST
COORDINATE WITH OTHER AGENCIES
IN THEM PLAN IMPLEMENTATION A
STATE POLICY. SO LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DISCUSSION I KNOW THAT
THERE'S SENSITIVITIES
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
OPERATE IN IN CERTAIN AREAS
WITH SMALLER INDEPENDENT
OPERATORS. BUT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL IS NOT TO PUT ANY
INDEPENDENT OPERATOR IN THE
STATE OUT OF BUSINESS. THE
REASONABLE COSTS A PLUGIN IN
BANNING A WELL THOUGH. SHOULD
BE REQUIRED AS SOME KIND OF
SECURITY SO THAT WHEN THESE
COMPANIES. DECIDE TO CHANGE
COURSE LIKE GRECO JUST DID WHEN
THEY WENT BANKRUPT OR LIKE VENN
ECHO DID WHEN THEY LEFT THE
HALL THE PLATFORM BEHIND THE
TAXPAYERS WILL GET STUCK WITH
THE TAP. SO THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR. THANK YOU CENTER STERN
DEBATER DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT BECAUSE I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY ON
THE FLOOR EXCEPT FOR MYSELF AND-MY COLLEAGUE FROM KERN COUNTY
THAT REPRESENT THE THREE MAJOR
OIL COMPANIES CHEVRON AND C. R.
C. AN ERA. BERRY IS NOW PART OF
THAT WHICH REPRESENT AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED WITH CPAP.
AND WE ALSO REPRESENT ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT SMALL
OPERATORS THAT ARE IN THE SAID
BY THE OR THE I. O. PA OF
INDEPENDENCE. SO I KNOW THAT
SOME OF YOU HAVE EITHER THE
MAJORS OR SOME OF THE SMALL
ONES BUT I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
BUT MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
REPRESENT BOTH ENTITIES SO THIS
IS A HARD DEBATE TO SPEAK OUT
ABOUT IN THIS BILL IS BECAUSE-
WE DO REPRESENT JOBS AND BOTH
OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
JOBS IN OUR DISTRICT. WE
REPRESENT THE CHEVRONS HUNDRED
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR
CORPORATION AND WE REPRESENT
THE RONNIE BRACKINS THE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR A YEAR
ORGANIZATION. EVERYTHING ELSE
IN THE MIDDLE AS WELL. SO THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT AUTHORIZES THE DIVISION OF
OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES DAUGHTER UNDER ITS
NEW NAME WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF MONEY FROM
THE OIL AND GAS OPERATORS NOT
TO EXCEED DAUGHTERS ESTIMATE
ESTIMATE TATIAN OUR ESTIMATION
OF THE REASONABLE COST. OF
PLUGGING IN ABANDONED WELLS.
THERE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED PLUS
COMPANIES THAT ARE NOT
CONSIDERED BIG OIL. AND THESE
OIL COMPANIES THAT ARE
CONSIDERED WHAT WE WOULD CALL
OR YOU RECALL BIG OIL ON THESE
COMPANIES HAVE OVER TEN
THOUSAND WELLS EACH THAT THEY
OPERATE IT'S MUCH IT'S HIGHER
THAN THAT BUT YOU CAN
DEFINITELY SAY IT'S OVER TEN
THOUSAND WHEELS WITH DECEPTION
TO BURY THEIR ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND MILES. THOSE ARE THE
WHISPER MEMBERS IN THE HOUSE
MEMBERS ARE THE SMALLER
OPERATORS. AND WHAT REALLY
FRUSTRATES ME ABOUT THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION IS AT THE
SMALLER OPERATORS WERE CUT OUT
OF THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND A DEAL. I UNDERSTAND LET ME
SAY THAT Y. WHISPER MEMBERS
MADE THE DEAL. THE EXPOSURE FOR
PUTTING THAT MONEY FOR EVERY
WELL THAT YOU HAVE WITH THE
VOLUME OF WELLS THAT ARE
WHISPER MEMBERS HAVE AGAIN JOB
CREATORS IN MY DISTRICT. THE
EXPOSURE THAT THEY HAVE IF YOU
CALCULATE IT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR SKEWS ME A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ENSURE CAP ON A WELL WHICH IS
THE ESTIMATE THE NUMBER'S BEEN
FLOATING AROUND THAT'S A SIX
BILLION DOLLAR. EXPOSURE TWO
ONE COMPANY AND THAT'S PRETTY
SCARY. SO I GET WHY THEY WANTED
A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR CAP I
GET IT. IT MAKES SENSE FOR
THEM. BUT FOR A SMALL GUY THAT
HAS TO PUT UP. ALMOST THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS BUT THAT AGAIN
THE BILL DOES SOME DISCRETION
THAT DOG CAN HAVE THE
DISCRETION OF THAT PIECE OF
THAT OF THAT. UP TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS SO IT'S NOT TO
SAY THAT BRACKEN WOULD HAVE TO
PAY THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IT'S
GOING TO BE A DOCTOR'S
DISCRETION. AND THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO UNDER THE LANGUAGE
TO THE LESSER OF THE TWO. WHAT
IS AFFORDABLE AND WHAT IS THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR CAP.
SMALL PRODUCERS LIKE I SAID
THAT HAVE YOU KNOW FIVE AND TEN
WELLS. LIKE RUNNY BRACKET THAT
I JUST TALKED ABOUT FOR EIGHTY
HE'S EIGHTY YEARS OLD HE'S GOT
OUT CHECKED AS WELL AS EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND FOR HIM QUALIFY
FOR THIS IT WOULD PAY TAKE HIM
YEARS TO PUT AT THAT TYPE OF
REVENUE. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE NEED TO GO
AFTER BAD ACTORS THE ONE TO
ABANDON THESE WELLS. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM VENTURE THAT
SAID THAT THERE IS NO DOUBT IN
MY MIND THERE ARE SOME BAD
OPERATORS OUT THERE AND I
AGREED. THAT WE SHOULD GO AFTER
THEM AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE COMPLYING WITH THAT. AND
THE TAXPAYER SHOULD NOT BE ON
THE HOOK. BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
THE ANSWER. THIS BILL HURTS OUR
SMALL OPERATORS AND IT ONLY
BUYS MAYBE A YEAR. FOR OUR
LARGE OPERATORS WHEN THAT C. C.
S. T. REPORT COMES OUT. AND IT
ESTIMATES THE COST OF PLUGGING
IN ABANDONED WELLS IN UPWARDS
OF THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH MONEY IN
THE ORPHAN WILL FIND TO BE ABLE
TO SECURE. THAT TYPE OF
LIABILITY AND I GET IT BUT
THAT'S PARTIALLY OIL AND OUR
FAULT AS LEGISLATORS. IN THE
HISTORY OF THE CALIFORNIA OTHER
THAN THE DA'S WILLIAMS BILL A
COUPLE OF YEARS. FORGIVE ME
BECAUSE I DON'T REMEMBER THE
NUMBER. THAT WOULD ONLY BE
REQUIRED OPERATOR TO GO BACK
FLOOD OR DRESS ABANDONED OR
ORPHANED WHAT ELSE. THAT
PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. AFFECTED ORPHANED
AND ABANDONED WELLS WITH
COLLEAGUES WHEN PEOPLE. STARTED
LOOKING AT THIS ABANDONED WELL
PROCESS. WELLS IN THIS STATE
THE WERE ORPHANED OR ABANDONED
SINCE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE. SO
TO REQUIRE SO THINK ABOUT THIS
TO REQUIRE OIL COMPANIES. TO
IMMEDIATELY ELIMINATE ALL THESE
ABANDONED WELLS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. THE COST NUMBER ONE IS
ANSWER ASTRONOMICAL AND
SUSTAINABLE. IT NEEDS TO BE A
PROCESS IN ORDER TO ABANDON
THESE IDA WELLS. BECAUSE YOU
COULD EVEN FOR EVERY OIL WORKER
I BET YOU I BET AND I DON'T
HAVE ANY STUDY TO PROVE IT BUT
BASED ON THE INDUSTRY AND BASS
WHAT I KNOW. AND HOW LONG IT
TAKES IN THE PROCESS. I BET YOU
CAN EMPLOY ALMOST EVERY IF NOT
EVERY OIL WORKER WORKING SEVEN
NAY DOUBT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY. FOR
THE NEXT TEN YEARS AND STILL.
NOT BE ABLE TO PLUG OR
ABANDONED ALL OF THESE WELLS. I
REALIZE THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM. BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
THE WAY TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM. HOWARD K. WOULD IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN MY- ACTUALLY WE
SHARED THAT AREA. WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HIS TEN WELLS. TEN WELLS
AND HE'S GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO
UP TO. A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
BONDING. RIGHT NOW HE PAYS
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO. IT'S A TREMENDOUS REACH TO
THINK THAT ANY COMPANY IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO ABSORB THESE COST.
SO EVEN IF THE COMPANY IS TO
MITIGATE DOWN THESE COST IF
THEY APPLY FOR THIS AND
DAUGHTER ON THE NEW DIVISION.
ISSUES ASK THEM TO MITIGATE
DOWN THEIR COST YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
THROWING AROUND AS THIS NUMBER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
THEY'D HAVE TO MITIGATE THEIR
COST BY 90% TO EVEN COME UNDER
THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
THRESHOLD. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THAT THAT'S ABOUT SIXTY WELLS
SO ANYBODY ABOVE SIXTY WELLS IS
GOING TO BE AT THAT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR THRESHOLD
EXCEPT. SOME OF THE ONES THAT
ARE IN THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
RANGING THINGS BUT THE MOST
PROTECTION IT'S OFFERED IN THIS
BILL IS FOR THE LARGE
OPERATORS. AND I. THIS IS A
HARD BILL LIKE I SAID BECAUSE I
HAVE LARGE OPERATORS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT PROVIDE JOBS. BUT
MY PROBLEM IS THAT THE SMALLER
OPERATORS WERE CUT OUT OF THIS
DEAL. I CAN TELL YOU THAT. LIKE
I SAID THE ESTIMATES IT'S
ROUGHLY ABOUT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IF YOU MULTIPLY TWELVE
THOUSAND MILES FOR ONE
ORGANIZATION HERE IN THIS
STATE. AND YOU APPLY A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
ESTIMATE FOR COSTS TO BE. TO
ABANDON A WELL WHICH IS A
NUMBER THAT'S BEING THROWN
AROUND. AGAIN THAT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE HAVE A PROBLEM AND I'M
WILLING TO WORK ON A SOLUTION
FOR PROBLEM BECAUSE- AND I KNOW
MY COLLEAGUE IS AS WELL A
SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM. TO THE
FIX THIS PROBLEM. BUT WE HAVE
TO FIX IT APPROPRIATELY AND
THIS IS NOT THE ANSWER THIS
BILL IS NOT THE ANSWER. AND SO
I'M ASKING YOU GUYS TO PLEASE
VOTE NO. OR OBSCENE SO THAT WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER ON A REAL
SOLUTION. AND I GIVE YOU MY
WORD OF SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENT
75% OF THE STATE'S OIL. WE WILL
COME UP WITH A GOOD SOLUTION.
THAT DOES NOT. SHUT DOWN THE
OIL INDUSTRY MUCH LESS THE
SMALL OPERATORS AND I ALSO TELL
YOU THAT. IT'S GONNA HURT
WORKERS WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT.
WHEN I DRIVE DOWN SIXTY FIVE ON
MY WAY HOME I PASSED JERRY
JERRY IS A GUY THAT WENT TO
FULL SOME PRISM HE'S GOT A
TATTOO ON HIS HEAD THAT THE
TARGET HE'S GOT TO DROP SENATE
SIGN IS AND NOW HE'S THE PTA
PRESIDENT FOR A SEVENTH GRADER
OR SEVEN YEAR OLD. IN FIRST
GRADE. THE OIL INDUSTRY CHANGES
PEOPLE'S LIVES THEY PROVIDE
JOBS TO SECOND CANCERS. TWO
WOMEN TO VETERANS. TO UNION
WORKERS. AND SO WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO. WORK ON
THIS PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS STATE WITHOUT SHUTTING
DOWN THE INDUSTRY AND THIS BILL
FRANKLY STARTS WITH SHUTTING
DOWN THE SMALL OPERATORS
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MATTER. WHAT
KIND OF LIMIT YOU HAVE IF THE
LIMIT IS TOO HIGH TO ATTAIN YOU
CAN'T MAKE IT SO IF YOU'RE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR CORPORATION
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
BOND FOR THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
AT THE CAP EVEN IF YOU COULD.
SO I WOULD ASK YOU FOR A NO
VOTE SO WE CAN PROVIDE A- A
GOOD SOLUTION AND I REALIZE
RENDERED AGAIN BECAUSE AT CCS
HE REPORT IS COMING OUT AND I
REALIZE THERE'S A PROBLEM IS
STATE WITH IDLE AND ABANDON AN
ORPHAN WELLS. BUT LET'S FIX IT
RIGHT AND NOT AN INDIE JERK
REACTION TO WOULD SATISFY A
POLITICAL LEFT I ASK YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR GROCER
JACKSON THANK YOU SO LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES. IT
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY THE ABILITY
OF A GUY WAS IMPRISONED TO RUN
A. OR PARTICIPATE IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY HERE'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. WHEN OIL COMPANIES FINISH
DIGGING OIL. AND THEY ABANDONED
THEIR WELLS. THE QUESTION IS
WHO IS LEFT CLEANING UP THE
MESS. WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
WE'VE SEEN THIS IS A RESULT OF
THE OFFSHORE WELLS IT IS THE
TAXPAYER. WHO ENDS UP CLEANING
UP THE MESS SO LET ME SHARE
WITH YOU AS WAS INDICATED BY
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM LA WHAT
BROUGHT THE OUR ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE. IN MY DISTRICT WE
HAVE SOME OFFSHORE FACILITIES
THAT HAVE CLOSED DOWN. WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IS THE COMPANIES
WHICH HAVE BEEN MAKING MILLIONS
IF NOT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DRILLING THE SOIL. ULTIMATELY
DECLARING BANKRUPTCY. AND
HANDING THE DEED BACK TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THE ONE
YOU WANT ME AS TAXPAYERS WHO
HAVE HAD TO PAY TO DECOMMISSION
THESE WELLS. THAT'S WHO'S
PAYING THE TAB. THE REASON FOR
THIS BILL. IS TO TRY TO PUT
SOME OF THAT RESPONSIBILITY
BACK ON THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DRILLED THE WELLS WHO HAVE MADE
THE MONEY BY REQUIRING THAT
THEY BOND. BUSINESSES ARE
REQUIRED TO BELONG. THIS TRUST
ASSURES THAT AT THE END OF THE
LIFE CYCLE AND NO ONE SAYING
WHEN THEY HAVE TO LEAVE IT'S
WHEN THEY ARE DONE. DRILLING
THEY CAN'T JUST WALK AWAY
LEAVING US THE TAXPAYER WITH
THE BILL. AND WE ARE PAYING THE
BILL IN MY DISTRICT RIGHT NOW
WITH PLATFORM HOLLY. WE HAD TO
HIRE THE COMPANY TO COME BACK
IN TO RUN IT WHAT WE DO
COMMISSION. THE TAXPAYER OF
CALIFORNIA'S PAID OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SO FAR
TO DECOMMISSION THIS WELL.
THAT'S YOUR MONEY IN MY MONEY.
BECAUSE THE OIL COMPANY WAS NOT
PROPERLY BONDED SO THAT THE
COST WOULD BE PAID BY THE BOND
IN BY THE COMPANY THAT HAD BEEN
MAKING THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
DRILLING OIL WE HAVE HUNDREDS
OF ABANDONED WELLS IN MY
DISTRICT. THE COMPANIES ARE
LONG NOT A BUSINESS THEY ARE
ORPHANED WELLS THERE'S NOBODY
LEFT TO PAY THE TAB. EXCEPT THE
TAXPAYER. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS ALL ABOUT. THE SMALL PERSON
ISN'T GOING TO GET HIT THEY CAN
COMBINED TOGETHER THE ESTIMATE
WILL BE MADE AS TO WHAT THE
COSTS WILL ULTIMATELY BE. SO
THAT THE TAXPAYER DOESN'T GET.
GET STUCK HOLDING IN PAYING THE
TAB. THAT'S WHY THIS IS A GOOD
BILL. IT IS A MODEST BILL. IT
IS A BILL THAT SAYS YOU GOT TO
LET US KNOW. AND YOU GOT A BOND.
UP TO A CERTAIN AMOUNT SO THAT
WHEN AND IF YOU WERE GOING TO
LEAVE WITHOUT CLEANING UP. THE
AREA AROUND THE WELL WITHOUT DE
COMMISSIONING THE WELL. AT
LEAST THE TAXPAYER ISN'T GOING
TO BE ON THE HOOK FOR IT AND
WITH THAT. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER JACKSON SEEING NO
FURTHER SENATOR BOARD YES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING ON
THIS ISSUE I KNOW A LOT OF US
HAVE SOME TORN INTERESTS. MAYBE
WE REPRESENT AREAS WERE
DRILLING OCCURS WITH THE FOSSEL
INDUSTRIES PRESENT. BUT I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE CAN WE
SHOULD BE MISLED BY SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE HERE. I
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. ALL
THE INDUSTRY PLAYERS. ARE
WILLING. TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM. AND MY COLLEAGUES WHO
SPOKE JUST A MOMENT AGO HAS
BASICALLY SAID THAT. THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE CREATED
PROBLEMS AND HAVE WALKED AWAY.
I BELIEVE THAT PROBABLY HAS
OCCURRED IN SOME INSTANCES BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS THAT WE
ARE PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S RIGHT
IN TO USE THE WORDS OF SOMEONE
ELSE A PARTIAL SOLUTION IS NOT
A SOLUTION AT ALL. IN THIS
EXACTLY THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE SEEING RIGHT HERE. THIS
IS A PARTIAL SOLUTION THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE ALL THE RELEVANT
PLAYERS. IN A MORE SERIOUS
ABOUT GOOD POLICY AS WE'VE
HEARD THAT WE ARE. THIS IS NOT
RIGHT FOR PRIME TIME. THIS IS A
HALF BAKED PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE MOST
RELEVANT PLAYERS IN THE
INDUSTRY IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
MAKING OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
INTERESTS PARAMOUNT THEN YOU
CAN'T JUST SIMPLY HAVE A
PARTIAL SOLUTION. I WOULD
RECOMMEND RESPECTFULLY. THERE'S
A LOT OF MERIT IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT INDIVIDUALS IN
THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY NEED
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE INTEREST
P. RESPONSIBLE PLAYERS IN
STEWARDS OF OUR ENVIRONMENT
WHILE STILL KEEPING OUR YOUR
OUR ECONOMY MOVING FORWARD
LET'S BE REALISTIC HERE. BUT
WE'RE PICKING WINNERS AND
LOSERS WHEN WE HAVEN'T WE'VE
NOT EVEN EXHAUSTED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO ABSTAIN ALLOW THIS TO GO
BACK TO THE PROCESS BE
REINTRODUCED IN JANUARY AS A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION ONE THAT
ACTUALLY WILL BE SUSTAINABLE IT
DOES NOT DRIVE OUT SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZE FIRMS. FROM THIS
ENTIRE INDUSTRY. BECAUSE THAT
IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN HERE PEOPLE
LOSE THEIR JOBS COMMUNITIES
WILL BE DISRUPTED. AND
ULTIMATELY YOU'RE STILL NOT
GOING TO HAVE A SOLUTION TO TAX
PAYER FUNDED OVERSIGHT OF
ABANDONED WELLS. BE REALISTIC
PLEASE. ALLOW THIS TO COME BACK
BUT IN A MORE MATURE AND
SOPHISTICATED IN SUSTAINABLE
WAY. THANK YOU SIR BORDERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
STORAGE LIKE TO CLOSE SURE.
THANK YOU FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION MEMBERS I WANT TO
JUST MAKE A FEW POINTS OF
CLARIFICATION IN MY CLOTHES
HERE SO. WHATEVER SECURITY HAS
TO BE PUT UP FRONT I DOES NOT
HAVE TO BE CASH SO IT DOES NOT
IT CAN BE IN THE FORM OF SELF
INSURANCE LETTERS OF CREDIT. SO
IT DOES NOT ACTUALLY REQUIRE
CASH BE PUT UP FRONT THE
REASONABLE COSTS. WHICH WILL BE
THE FRAMEWORK THAT'S USED FOR
THE SMALLER OPERATORS INCLUDES
THE OPERATORS COST ESTIMATES
THEMSELVES. SO THE ONLY LOSERS
RIGHT NOW OUR TAXPAYERS AND
STATE IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS
BILL IS DEFINITELY NOT INTENDED
TO PICK WINNERS ACT YOU GO TO
PAY NINETEEN OF THE BILL UNDER
G. ONE. IT ALLOWS THAT ANY TWO
OR MORE OPERATORS MAY ELECT TO
ENTER INTO A LIABILITY SHARING
AGREEMENT. SO THEY CAN PULL
RISK AS WELL BETWEEN MULTIPLE
OPERATORS SO WITH WITH DUE
RESPECT TO THE TO THE SMALL YOU
KNOW THE THOSE WHO STAYED FOR
WELLS TEN TWELVE FIFTEEN WELLS-THEY'LL STILL BE. ALLOWED TO
USE NON CASH SECURITY TEXTED TO
BEAT TO PROVIDE THAT INSURANCE
IN BE ABLE TO ALIGN WITH THEIR
OPERATORS SAID THEY WON'T BE
PUT OUT OF BUSINESS NOW THEY
WILL BE LINKED TO EACH OTHER'S
PRACTICES TO SOME EXTENT AND I
KNOW THAT THERE IS SOME
MEDICINES MAY BE WITHIN
INDUSTRY TO SAY WELL I DON'T
WANT. THE DESTINY OF MY
OPERATION TO BE LINKED TO MY
NEIGHBORS OPERATION IN THE SAME
AREA BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW HOW
WELL THEY'RE OPERATING BUT WE
ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY TO ENCOURAGE ALL
OPERATORS IN A GIVEN AREA TO
ALIGN WITH OTHER GOOD OPERATORS
IN TO SAY WE'RE ALL GOING TO
COLLECTIVELY. BY TO SECURE OUR
OPERATIONS IN THE TAXPAYERS.
DON'T GET STUCK WITH THE BILL
SO. WITH DUE RESPECT CONSIDER
THIS QUITE FULLY BAKED IN FACT
IT'S BEEN BAKING ALL YEAR AND-
IF WE ONLY HAD THIS IN PLACE A
FEW YEARS BACK WE WOULDN'T BE
ON THE HOOK FOR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BUT IT'S
HIGH TIME THAT WE GOT. GOT TO
WORK SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ALL OF YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER STERN WHICH SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES. BELL HI
WE'RE JUST. BRADFORD KELLY AT
ALL. HI JANE. DALY DODD. DURAZO
HI GALGIANI. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
BY GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HILL
WITH SO TITLE. JACKSON HI JONES
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL HI MONEY I'M MORE LARK.
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE. NO NUMBER.
BY CASKEY. WIENER AYE WILK.
CENTER MOVES A CALL. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM. ONE NINETY. ONE
NINETY ONE. SENATOR BELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AN ACT
RELATING TO. SENATOR BILL.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS
BILL. THIS PROBABLY FROM MEMORY
BECAUSE WE CAME THROUGH LAST
WEEK BUT THEN WE HAD TO GO BACK
AND DO SOME ADDED AMENDMENTS IS
FOR THE TAMI DONATION
REGULATION AND THEY HAVE
CLEANED UP SOME HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODES AND MAY THESE
AMENDMENTS IN AND BROUGHT THE
BILL BACK TODAY. I REQUEST A
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR BILL MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL. BUT WE CAN.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY TWO
SENATOR PAM. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AN
ACT RELATING TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES. CENTER PAN THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS ON
PLEASE 2% EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER EVAN LOW
WHICH MAKES NUMEROUS REFORMS
IMPROVEMENTS STATE'S
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MONITORING
PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
YOURS. THIS BILL AS A RESULT OF
I'M GOING STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS REGULATORS AND
PATIENT ADVOCATES AB FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT CHANGES THE TIME A
PHARMACIST HAS REPORT TO CURES
FROM SEVEN DAYS TO ONE WORKING
DAY THIS CHANGE PREVENTS DOCTOR
SHOPPERS FROM VISITING MULTIPLE
PRESCRIBERS OVER THE COURSE OF
A WHOLE WEEK. TO OBTAIN
MULTIPLE PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
DRUGS LIKE OPIOIDS THIS ALSO
ADD SCHEDULE FIVE DRUGS CURES
WHICH ALLOWS THE STATE'S TRACK
OPIOID. OFFICER UP DOES SPEAK
ONLY STOLEN AND ABUSED FINALLY
THIS BILL WOULD STREAMLINE
ACCESS TO THE SYSTEM FOR
POSITIONS ANOTHER PRESCRIBERS
TO ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM CAN
BETTER BE INCORPORATED INTO
PRACTICE SETTINGS. WITH THIS
BILL JURORS WILL FUNCTION EVEN
BETTER TO HELP COPY COMBAT THE
OPIOID CRISIS BY EMPOWERING
STATE PRESCRIBING I STRICTLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM CENTER
STONE THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT I
STAND INS THE GREAT SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO YOU
CARE SYSTEM IS BEEN A GREAT.
TRACKING DEVICE FOR PHYSICIANS
AND PHARMACISTS TO. REALLY SEE
THE PATTERN OF PRESCRIBING AND
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO DOCTORS AND A CALL
DOCTOR SHOPPING GETTING
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR OPIOIDS AND
GOING DIFFERENT PHARMACIES AND-
HAVING THEM. JUST. I MEAN THE
WORK SO THAT WE CAN TRACK OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT LESLIE TRYING
TO GET CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
INCLUDING SCHEDULE FIVE DRUGS
WHICH MIGHT INCLUDE COATING
CONTAINING COUGH SYRUPS. WHICH
CAN ALSO BE ABUSE SO THIS IS
REALLY GOOD LEGISLATION AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR RIVAL IN AB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
OTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE CENTER PAN YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM TEMECULA HIS
HIS EXPERIENCE AS A PHARMACIST
AND SUPPORT I ALSO MAKE NOTE I
THINK HAS BEEN RAISED AT ACLU
ELECTRONIC FUND FRONTIER
FOUNDATION HAS EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS I THINK THEY ARE
GENERALLY WARY OF SOME OF.
THESE DATABASES THAT DOES
CONTAIN YOUR PERSONAL
PRESCRIBING INFORMATION HOWEVER
I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT THE
USERS OF CURES AND WE ARE ALL
OBLIGATED TO FOLLOW HIP
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH LAWS
REGULATIONS TO SAFEGUARD THAT
INFORMATION INCLUDING BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL OF PRIVACY
LAWS AND THIS DATA IS ESSENTIAL
FOR OUR STATE BILL MONITOR.
PRESCRIBING AND ALSO FOR
PRESCRIBERS AND- AT SPENCER'S
TO ALSO KNOW THAT WE CAN
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES FROM.
FROM THE- ABUSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I FELT. ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES HI
BILL HI BURGESS I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CHIANG. I DALY AYE
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO
TADO BY. HUESO AYE JACKSON
JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK. OUR MORALE BY NIELSEN AYE
PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER. IOWA CASKEY BY
WINNER I WILK. WILK HI PLEASE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE CALL GO BACK ONE MORE
TIME CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS BRADFORD. HI GROWTH. BY
JACKSON NO NO JONES HI STONE I.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG NOW
TO. FILE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE
SENATOR LABOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AN ACT RELATING TO
PEACE OFFICERS CENTER LEYVA
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS I RISE TO
RESENT AB ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PEER SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDE FOR CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN BETWEEN
TRAINED PEER SUPPORT TEAM
MEMBERS. AND THE FELLOW POLICE
OFFICERS IN A TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN BURKE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
STUDY ROUGHLY 75% OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS REPORTED
EXPERIENCING A TRAUMATIC EVENT
BUT LESS THAN HALF OF THEM
HOLDER AGENCY ABOUT IT EVEN
MORE TROUBLING ABOUT HALF OF
THE OFFICERS REPORTED-PERSONALLY KNOWING ANOTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. WHO
CHANGED AFTER EXPERIENCING A
TRAUMATIC EVENT AND ABOUT HALF
REPORTED NO AN OFFICER WHO
COMMITTED SUICIDE. PEACE
OFFICERS ARE OFTEN RELUCTANT TO
UTILIZE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF FIRST
JOB IMPACTS THE STATE SIGMA
SURROUNDING MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND THE PERCEPTION AMONG
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY MUST
SHOW NO SIGN OF WEAKNESS. YOUR
SUPPORT IS A PROVEN
INTERVENTION THAT LEVERAGES
SHARED EXPERIENCE TO FOSTER
TRUSTS DECREASED IMAGE STIGMA A
CRITICISM WILL FORM FOR SEEKING
HELP AND SHARING INFORMATION
ABOUT SUPPORT RESOURCES AND
POSITIVE COPING STRATEGIES. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN IS FIRST AND
FOREMOST ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO LOVE PEACE
OFFICERS TO SUFFER IN SILENCE
BY ENCOURAGING THEM TO ACCESS
QUALIFIED CONFIDENTIAL SUPPORT
SERVICES WE CAN ENSURE THAT OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE NOT AFRAID
TO SEEK HELP. AND ULTIMATELY
SAVE LIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN. WHEN I SERVED IN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO. WHEN WE WOULD COME
BACK FROM A TERRIBLE NIGHT. THE
GUYS WOULD GATHER AROUND AND
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE THE ONE
WHO IS. HE THE RACING IN THE
CAR THAT ALMOST GOT IN THE
ACCIDENT FOR THE ONE WHO HAD A
JUMP OVER THE FENCE TO CATCH
THE BAD GUY WHATEVER YOU DID.
AND WE GOT THE CALL FROM THE
FAMILIES IS THE OKAY. IT WAS
THE BODIES THE FRIEND THAT
GATHERED WITH THEM SO. DID WE
HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL TO
DO THAT I DON'T KNOW BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY HELP BUT THIS WILL
OPEN THE DOOR TO GIVES
ADDITIONAL TRAINING THAT WOULD
BE AUTHORIZED BY ANY
MUNICIPALITY OR CITY HIGHWAY
PATROL WHATEVER IT IS SO WE'RE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE
THERE'S NOTHING BETTER. DAD
THEN PEERS COME TOGETHER TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING TOGETHER FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD TO
MANAGE THIS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO THANK THE AUTHOR AND I
URGE AND I BOTH THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SEN ARCHULETA SENATOR
NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE
THESE ARE INDEED PERILOUS TIMES
FOR THOSE WHO ARE LONG FACE
FORSMAN PROFESSIONALS. NEVER
BEFORE HAVE THEY BEEN SO AT
LEAST IN MY LIFETIME SHOW AT
RISK FOR MULTIPLE REASONS WHICH
I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO. BUT
THEY ARE. AND THE RISK THAT
THEY ARE SUFFERING. AND THE
INJURIES AND THE DEATH. AND
I'VE BEEN GOING TO WAY TOO MANY.
GENERAL'S IN LIVE CELEBRATIONS
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. THEY
NEED ALL OF THE PEER SUPPORT
THAT THEY POSSIBLY CAN HAVE.
THE HARDEST THING FOR SOMEONE
IN A JOB LIKE THERE'S- IS TO
NOT TAKE IT HOME. TO NOT TAKE
IT HOME. TO THE FAMILY. AND IN
YOUR OWN ACTIONS WHEN YOU GET
HOME. THIS AT LEAST GIVE SOME
SOME COMFORT SOME ASSURANCE I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SENATOR LEYVA YOU
MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASE
DISCERNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ALL EYES. THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE
SENATOR UMBERG. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AN ACT
RELATING TO THE CENSUS SENATOR
ON BURKE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IN SEVEN
MONTHS CITY CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS ALL THE OTHER STATES OF THE
UNION WILL BE ENGAGE AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
COUNTED. PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE IS COUNTED
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD AN
UNDERCOUNT. IN OTHER SENSES.
THIS YEAR THE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY WE HAVE A CHALLENGE WE
HAVE A CHALLENGE BECAUSE SOME
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MAY
NOT WANT TO SEE CALIFORNIA HAVE
A COMPLETE COUNT. BUT INDEED I
KNOW WE DO. WHAT AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY THREE DOES IS IT WOULD
PROHIBIT A PERSON FROM FALSELY
REPRESENTING THEMSELVES. TO BE
A CENSUS TAKER WITH THE INTENT
TO INTERFERE WITH THE OPERATION
THE CENSUS. WOULD ALSO INCREASE
AWARENESS OF A PERSON CENSUS
RIGHT RIGHTS UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW CALIFORNIA. IS IN A
POSITION WHERE WE COULD LOSE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
FOR TRANSPORTATION FOR
HEALTHCARE FOR EDUCATION FOR
ALL SORTS OF THINGS. THERE IS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE A COMPLETE COUNT IS AN
EXCELLENT BILL AND I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THE STICKER THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG DEBATER
DISCUSSION SENATOR PAN. I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS I
TO RISE AND SUPPORT THIS BILL
I'M I THINK MY GOOD FRIEND UP
FROM SANTA ANA FOR TALKING THE
BILL IS ALSO. WE'RE BOTH CO
CHAIRS ARE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE CENSUS IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE HAVE TRUST IN THE
CENSUS WE- CERTAINLY I THINK
THERE ARE CONCERNS THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME EFFORTS. BY TO
DISCOURAGE PARTICIPATION AND
CREATING CONFUSION AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE LAWS IN
PLACE TO ALLOW OUR STATE TO ACT
IS THERE PEOPLE MISS
REPRESENTING. THEMSELVES ARE
CREATING CONFUSION IN A WAY
THAT MAY DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
HAVING TRUST IN THE NUMERATOR.
SO OUT THERE WHO NEED TO DO
THEIR JOBS SPECIALLY ASKED WHEN
I VOTE. ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE CENTER ON
BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
UP THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED.
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL BY
BURGESS BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CHIANG. I DALY DODD AYE
TERRAZZO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TADO. JACKSON I JONES.
LEYVA. BUY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK.
MORRELL NOPE NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER FIVE LIKE US HE. HI
WINNER BY WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES.
GORGEOUS BY SALLY. GROWTH. TADO
BY JONES NO MORE LOCK. STONE.
OUR EYES THIRTY THREE KNOWS TO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SIX FOLLOW
BY. ONE NINETY SEVEN ONE NINETY
EIGHT ONE NINETY NINE AND TWO
HUNDRED FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SIX SENATOR HUESO YOU PREPARED
TO BRING UP THIS ITEM. ONE
NINETY SIX. PASS ON FILE. ONE
NINETY ONE NINETY SEVEN SENATOR
WIENER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AN ACT RELATING TO
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE HOUSING
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS THIS BILL
CREATES AN OPT IN STREAMLINED
PROCESS OUGHT TO BUILD FARM
WORKER HOUSING ON AGRICULTURAL
LANDS. IT SETS QUALITY
STANDARDS TO ENSURE THAT THE
NEW HOUSING IS DIGNIFIED AND
FAMILY FRIENDLY. AND PUT
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT. AB SEVENTY
THREE WILL INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION FOR FARMWORKERS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE ADEQUATE
DIGNIFIED AND QUALITY HOUSING.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
FARMWORKERS FROM HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND DISPLACEMENT
AND HELP TO STABILIZE
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL WORK
FORCE THE HOUSING SHORTAGE IS
NOT JUST AN URBAN PROBLEM. IT
AFFECTS OUR RURAL AGRICULTURAL
AREAS AS WELL. WE KNOW ALL TOO
WELL THAT ARE FARMWORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES FACING CREDIBLY
HIGH RENTS AN UP AND A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE QUALITY HOUSING.
OFTEN LEADING TO UNSAFE FOR AN
ADEQUATE LIVING CONDITIONS OR
EVEN HOMELESSNESS. CURRENTLY I
RECALL CHILDREN PLAYERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE IT'S TO A
TEMPORARY GUEST WORKER PROGRAM.
BURNERS HOUSING BY RENTING
HOUSES OR APARTMENTS TO
ACCOMMODATE THEIR WORKERS. THIS
PUTS PRESSURE ON THE EXISTING
HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR OTHER INDIVIDUALS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WE ARE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN.
SENATOR MONNING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WANTTO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANKS IMPORTANT POINT
OUT THIS DOESN'T PRECLUDE.
OTHER TYPES OF HOUSING THAT
MIGHT BE CONSTRUCTED BUT IT
DOES SPECIFICALLY ARM FILL A
GAP THAT WE FACE RIGHT NOW AND
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THERE'S
FARMWORKER FAMILIES THAT HAVE
NOT HAD ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER. THANK
YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
AND CERTAINLY I AGREE WITH THE
SPONSORS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AVAILABILITY OF FORMER FOR
HOUSING BUT THERE'S TWO AREAS
IN THIS BILL THAT I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT AND I'D LIKE TO
ASK THE FLOOR MANAGER TO
ADDRESS THEM THAT THE IF I MAY.
ARE THESE QUESTIONS TO JUST
LIKE TO ADDRESS WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THEM SOON ALL RIGHT
PLEASE PROCEED. THE FIRST
QUESTION I HAD IS THE- THE
CONCERN THAT THIS HOUSING WOULD
NOT BE AVAILABLE. TO THOSE WITH
H. TWO A. VISA IS NOT THE WORDS
THERE'D BE DISCRIMINATION AND
THE AVAILABILITY THIS HOUSING
BASED ON. A FARMWORKERS
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED
STATUS COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT.
SURE WHAT THE BILL DOES IS IT
PRECLUDES THE USE OF STATE
FUNDS THE PAPER HOUSING FOR
EACH TO A WORKERS OUT
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IT DOES. YOU
CAN USE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO PAY FOR HOUSING FOR
A TO A WORKERS AND THE REASON
IS ACTUALLY QUITE SIMPLE THE H.
TO A AUGUST WORKER PROGRAM IS A
PROGRAM WHERE AN EMPLOYER.
BRINGS IN WORKERS FROM OUTSIDE
OF THE COUNTRY. AND IS GIVEN
ALLOW THE TO HAVE VISAS FOR
THOSE WORKERS AS GUEST WORKERS
AND IN EXCHANGE UNDER FEDERAL
LAW THAT EMPLOYER IS REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE CERTAIN BASIC LIVING
NECESSITIES FOR THOSE WORKERS.
INCLUDING HOUSING AND SO IN
ORDER TO THE EMPLOYER BENEFITS
BY BRINGING IN TEMPORARY GUEST
WORKERS AND IS REQUIRED TO
AMONG OTHER THINGS PROVIDE
HOUSING. ON I DON'T THINK
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS SHOULD BE
PAYING FOR THAT OBLIGATION THAT
THOSE EMPLOYERS HAVING HEARD
UNDER FEDERAL LAW IN EXCHANGE
FOR BRINGING IN. THOSE GUEST
WORKERS I THINK WE SHOULD NOT
BE FOCUSING OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE
THERE'S EMPLOYERS HAVE THAT
OBLIGATION AND THEY SHOULD BE
PAYING FOR THAT OBLIGATION. AND
SO I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY. QUITE
STRAIGHTFORWARD WHY WE HAVE THE
RESTRICTION IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND MY SECOND
QUESTION. THIS IS LAND THAT
FARMERS ON THEMSELVES BUT UNDER
THIS LEGISLATION IT IT SEEMS TO
REQUIRE THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
BUILD THIS HOUSING. THAT
ACTUALLY THE FARMERS THEMSELVES
CAN'T BUILD IT THEY HAVE TO.
RETAIN A- ANOTHER ENTITY
ACTUALLY. TO CONSTRUCT THE
HOUSING ON THEIR OWN PROPERTY
IS THAT IS THAT I READ THE BILL
CORRECTLY IT'S MORE ABOUT
MANAGING. THE PROPERTY I THINK
THE THINKING IS THAT YOU DON'T
WANT SO YOU DON'T WANT THE BOSS
TO ALSO BE THE LANDLORD. YOU
ALWAYS WANT TO HAVE THAT
SEPARATION IF YOUR BOSS IS ALSO
YOUR LANDLORD. THAT CAN CREATE
HUGE PROBLEMS YOU LOSE YOUR JOB
THAT MEANS YOU CAN
AUTOMATICALLY LOSE YOUR
HOUSING. AND SO WITH THE FIGURE
IN THIS BILL AND WE HAVE TO
WORK LAST YEAR WHEN I CARRIED A
SIMILAR BILL WE WORKED ON THIS
ISSUE EXTENSIVELY. TO WHINE AND
OUTSIDE THIRD PARTY TO BE THE
ONE WHO ACTUALLY MANAGES THE
PROPERTY SO THAT YOU DON'T.
HAVE THE BOSS AND THE LANDLORD
BEING THE SAME PERSON. GREAT
AND THEN I AM MY OWN TIME SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXPLANATION
AND I THINK. THOSE QUESTIONS
HIGHLIGHTS SOME CONCERNS THAT
THAT MANY HAVE ABOUT THIS BILL.
HI DAD. ARE WE REALLY GOING TO
BE IN THE POSITION OF CHOOSING.
SOMEONE IS HERE A DOCUMENTED OR
UNDOCUMENTED. I AM MAKING THIS
TYPE OF HOUSING AVAILABLE. AND
IF THE FARMERS GOING TO PROVIDE
THAT HOUSING ON THEIR PROPERTY
SHOULD THEY HAVE SOME RIGHTS. I
IN TERMS OF BEING THE LANDLORD
MAKING SURE IT'S- IT'S BEING
RUN CORRECTLY. AND SO WITH THAT
MEMBERS AT CONCERNS RAISED INTO
AND FOR NOW AT LEAST FOR ME I'M
GONNA LAY OFF ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
WOULD TO RISE IN OPPOSITION
SOME OF THE SAME REASONS WHY IT
CALLING FROM ALAMEDA BROUGHT UP
DURING QUESTIONING SO WE HAVE
YOU MAY NOT KNOW BUT IN MY
DISTRICT WE RAISE ABOUT 95% OF
THE WORLD'S STRAWBERRY PLANTS
NOT THE BERRIES BUT THE PLANTS.
AND WE RELY ON. THOSE AGE TO A
FARM WORKER HOUSING PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE IN ARE
VERY RULE COMMUNITIES AND THIS
BILL WILL ACTUALLY WORK AND ADD
IT BE AN ADVERSARY TO WHAT THE
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
NOW TO TRY TO AND WE'RE
STRAPPED FOR HOUSING FOR THESE
WORKERS. SO I THINK THERE'S
SOME PROBLEMS WITH HIS BILL
BECAUSE IS A THIRD PARTY AND
NOT ALLOWING THE ACTUAL. SOME
OF THESE ARE. BIG CORPORATIONS
LIKE DRISKELL STRAWBERRIES TO
HAVE AS STOP IN. THE MONTEREY
AND THEY BUT THE OTHER PLANS OF
THEIR AND SO WE WE'RE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THE H. TO A
PROGRAM AND HOUSING. IN MY
DISTRICT FOR SOME TIME TRY TO
SUPPLY GOOD DECENT HOUSING AND
WORKING WITH THE COMMIES AND H.
TO A PROGRAM. AND THIS. ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT. WHICH EMPLOYEES ARE WHICH
CATEGORIES I THINK WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT SO I THINK THIS BILL
NEEDS A LITTLE MORE WORK AND
SO. FOR THOSE REASONS I WILL BE
A OPPOSING BUILT. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SO I RESIDENTS
SUPPORTER THIS BILL WHEN WE
WHEN WE WROTE THE HOUSING BOND
MEASURE WHICH WAS PROPOSITION
ONE ON THE BALLOT. ONE OF
THINGS WE DID IT IS REMINDED ME
OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE
HAD. MANY MANY MANY YEARS AGO
WITH OF A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
NAMED JOE SERRANO. AND JOE
SERVICES SUPERVISOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND JOE WAS A
CHAMPION FOR FARMWORKERS
HOUSING CONTINUOUS TALKED ABOUT
THE IDEA OF NOT JUST PROVIDING
THE FARM WORKERS WITH HOUSING
BUT THE FAMILIES OF THE FARM
WORKERS IN A SAFE SANITARY
HOUSING AND SO WHEN WE WROTE.
THE PROPOSITION THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS THIS
LAST NOVEMBER WE PUT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IT TO
THE SERRANO HOUSING PROGRAM FOR
FARMWORKERS AND THE ODDS OF
HOPEFULLY GOING TO BE USED TO
BUILD. MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FARM WORKER HOUSING AND ONE OF
THE REASONS I SUPPORT THIS BILL
IS BECAUSE THIS WILL EXPEDITE
THE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION THE
HOUSING PROGRAMS THAT WE
DESPERATELY NAY WERE SO FAR
BEHIND IN IN THE AREA OF
HOUSING. FOR FARMWORKERS AND
NOW LET'S GET THIS PROGRAM THAT
WE APPROVE THE VOTERS APPROVED
JUMPSTARTED BY APPROVING THIS
BILL AND GETTING SOME OF THIS
HOUSING GOING SO WE CAN HAVE
GOOD SANITARY HOUSING FOR. THE
FAMILIES JUST AS JOE STARTED
TALK TO ME ABOUT OVER TWO
DECADES AGO AND I KNOW THAT HIS
SON PHIL WHOSE ACCOUNTING
SUPERVISOR HERE. AND SACRAMENTO
WHAT ALSO SUPPORT. SENATOR TO
RAZA. OUR FAMILY MY FAMILY I
COULD HAVE LIVED IN INSTEAD OF.
THE GROWERS BARN. OR A TENT OR
IS SOME OTHER ONE OR TWO ROOM
LITTLE SHACK. THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THAT'S WHY I
BELIEVE IN SUPPORTING THIS SO
MUCH BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE I WOULD HAVE MADE IN
MY FAMILY. OF HAD SOME PLACE TO
LIVE. AND WE ARE NOT
UNDOCUMENTED. WE'RE IMMIGRANT
FAMILY WORKING. HARD IN THE
FIELDS THE ENTIRE FAMILY. ONCE
YOU LEARN HOW TO WALK YOU START
WORKING WHERE THE CREW. AND WE
WERE NOT PROVIDED WITH ANYWHERE
NEAR THE KIND OF HOUSING HUMANE
HOUSING THAT WE SHOULD HAVE HAD.
AND I'LL END WITH THIS LITTLE
STORY ABOUT HOW. SIXTEEN THE
LANDLORD WITH THE EMPLOYER
SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE. WHEN MY
LATE HUSBAND AND HIS FAMILY GOT
INVOLVED WITH THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION AND SAYS OUR JOB
IS. THEY THEY WENT ALL THE WAY.
THEY EVEN HAD TO GO OUT ON
STRIKE TO TRY TO GET BRING SOME
DECENT WORKING CONDITIONS TO
THE FEELS. AND ONE DAY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. THE GROWER
SHOWS UP IN HIS CAR TO THE
SHACK WERE MY HUSBAND AND HIS
PARENTS AND FIVE BROTHERS WERE
LIVING. MANY CALLS ABOUT ANY
TELLS MY HUSBAND'S FATHER WHO
DON'T. YOUR THE BEST WORKER I
HAVE HERE. BUT YOU'RE A CHUBBY
STUFF FEAR GOING TO HAVE TO GO.
ANY VICTOR THE WHOLE FAMILY
RIGHT THERE THAT MOMENT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. THAT'S WHY
A LANDLORD SHOULD NOT BE YOUR
EMPLOYER BECAUSE THE POWER THAT
IT BRINGS TO YOU. SHOULD NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE TO ANYONE I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR DORADO ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SENATOR WIENER YOU
MAY CLOSE. MADAM PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMON SAID I THINK ONE
THING THAT WE NEED TO REALLY
REMEMBER ABOUT THIS BILL. THIS
BILL DOES NOT MANDATE THAT AN
EMPLOYER BUILD HOUSING THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM THIS IS AN OPT IN
pWE'RE SAYING IS IF YOU WANT TO
STREAMLINED PROCESS WHERE YOU
CAN BUILD A HOUSING ON YOUR
AGRICULTURAL LAND AND OVER
RIDE. SOME LOCAL APPROVAL
PROCESSES IF YOU WANT THAT
PRIVILEGE. AND THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS YOU HAVE TO DO
YOU CAN'T HAVE BARRACKS AS YOUR
HOUSING YOU HAVE TO HAVE ACTUAL
HOUSING. YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SEPARATE ENTITY BEING A
LANDLORD YOU CAN'T BE BOTH THE
BOSS AND THE LANDLORD AND I
THINK THERE'S A REASONABLE
THINGS TO ASK FOR THIS
STREAMLINED PROCESS. AND THERE
IS NOTHING STOPPING THESE
EMPLOYERS FROM PROVIDING OR
BUILDING HOUSING FOR THEIR AGE
TO A WORKERS IMPACT UNDER
FEDERAL LAW THEY ARE REQUIRED.
TO PROVIDE DOT HOUSING ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS YOU CAN'T USE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS DOLLARS TO
FILL YOUR LEGAL OBLIGATIONS OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO
PROVIDE THAT HOUSING WHY ON
EARTH. CALIFORNIA. SUBSIDIZE
AND HE FOR EMPLOYERS FEDERAL
LEGAL OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
HOUSING TO THEIR AGE TO A
WORKERS IT MAKES NO SENSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AIBO
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. NOBEL BY PORGES. NO
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
NO DALY NO DODD. DORADO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO BY TADO I JACKSON AYE
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK NUMBER RAIL. NOTE NIELSEN
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN.
BY STONE NO NUMBER I WORK OWSKI
I WINNER BY WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS DOT. GLAZER
WILK ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
EIGHT SENATOR MCGUIRE. PASS ON
FILE FILE ITEM ONE NINETY NINE
SENATOR DODD. PASS ON FILE FILE
ITEM TWO HUNDRED SENATOR LEYVA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION AND ACTUALLY TO
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION SENATOR LEYVA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE IS THE
TWENTY NINETEEN K. TWELVE
EDUCATION OMNIBUS TECHNICAL
BILL ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE SPONSORED BILL THIS
BILL MAKES TECHNICAL AND OTHER
NON CONTROVERSIAL REVISIONS TO
NUMEROUS PROVISIONS OF THE
EDUCATION CODE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
TURNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING RIGHT ALONG NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO FILE NUMBERS
TO A ONE TWO OR TWO TWO OR
THREE. TWO OH FIVE IN TWO OH
SIX FILE ITEM TO A ONE SENATOR
STERN ARE YOU PREPARED TO BRING
UP THIS ITEM. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE BY THE.
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND ACTUALLY TO
PROTECTION. SENATOR STERN. FILE
ITEM TWO OH ONE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
THREE IS AN ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES BILL WHICH PROVIDES
IMPORTANT CLEANUP LEGISLATION
THAT PASSED LAST YEAR. TO SB
NINE NO ONE IN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN INCLUDING DEFINING AND
CLARIFYING THE DUTIES. OF THE
FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE
SENATE ADDING ADDITIONAL
CRITERIA FOR THE FIRE RISK.
REDUCTION CMMUNITY LIST. THIS
BILL DID HAVE A PRISON DEALING
WITH MANAGEMENT OF FOREST
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS WHICH
DID HAVE SOME OPPOSITION BUT
THOSE PROVISIONS WERE REMOVED
FROM THE BILL. SO THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION NOW AND IS
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS FOR
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NON ICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG.
TO FILE ITEM TO SENATOR TO
RUSSELL. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA AN ACT RELATING TO
DETENTION FACILITIES SENATOR TO
RAZA. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. A
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT A.
B. THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA WHICH ELIMINATES ALL FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION IN
CALIFORNIA. AB THIRTY TWO
PROHIBITS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. FOR ME NEW IN
ARE ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT
WITH A FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISON FACILITY BEGINNING
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY I
WILL COMPLETELY PHASE OUT THEIR
USE BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. FOR
PROFIT PRISON COMPANIES HAVE
NOT LIMITED THEIR BUSINESS
VENTURES. TO PROFIT PROFITING
FROM THE CAR SERRATION OF
CALIFORNIANS CONVICTED OF
CRIMES. DAVID PRISON
CORPORATIONS ALSO PROFIT FROM
INCARCERATING CALIFORNIANS IN
CIVIL DETENTION. AB THIRTY TWO
WAS AMENDED TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROTECTED
INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS SUBJECT TO
CIVIL DETENTION. AS FOR PROFIT
AS FOR PROFIT CORPORATIONS
THESE COMPANIES HAVE A
FIDUCIARY DUTY TO MAXIMIZE
PROFITS FOR THEIR SHAREHOLDERS
THEY'RE ABLETO ACCOMPLISH THIS
BY INCREASING THEIR INMATE
POPULATION AND CUTTING
OPERATIONAL COSTS WHICH IS BOTH
DANGEROUS AND DETRIMENTAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN HELD IN THESE
FACILITIES. IN MY VIEW THIS
DUTY IS IN CONFLICT WITH THE
INVESTMENT IN THE
REHABILITATION OF PEOPLE THE
REDUCTION OF RECIDIVISM RATES
AND THE MAINTENANCE OF SAFE AND
HEALTHY CONDITIONS OF
CONFINEMENT. IT ALSO CONFLICTS
WITH OUR VALUES AS A STATE AND
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
THE WELFARE AND THE WELL BEING
OF OUR RESIDENTS. THERE ARE
NUMEROUS DOCUMENTED ABUSES OF
PEOPLE HELD IN FOR PROFIT RUN
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL PROTECTS CALIFORNIANS BY
PROHIBITING THE OPERATION OF
NEW. PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
DETENTION FACILITIES IN OUR
STATE AND PHASES OUT THOSE WITH
CONTRACTS IN EXISTENCE PRIOR TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION MANY MANY MANY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS FOR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM TO. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NOBEL HI PORGES. BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG. DALY. NO
DODD I'D RATHER I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO. JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. I
MONNING AYE MOORLACH NO MERRELL.
NO NIELSEN. PAN BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN BY STONE HI. NUMBER
OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE TIME PLEASE
GORGEOUS. BY JANE. BY GLAZER.
HI GROWTH NO YOUR TOTAL.
NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE. ICE THIRTY
THREE NO SIX THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO OH THREE IS THERE
ARE TWO OR THREE IS NEXT UP OF
SENATOR TO ROSS SO YOU PREPARED
TO TAKE UP THIS ITEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACRYLATE INTO COURT HOUSES
SENATOR TO RUSSELL YOUR
ARGUMENT AND CHAIR. MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIX EIGHT
WOULD PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS
FROM CIVIL ARREST AT A
COURTHOUSE WHEN THE INDIVIDUAL
IS ATTENDING A COURT PROCEEDING
OR HAS LEGAL BUSINESS IN THE
COURTHOUSE ALTHOUGH TRADITIONAL
CIVIL ARREST AND COURT HOUSES
MAY HAVE DECLINED THEY HAVE NOT
DIG THE ENTIRELY DISAPPEARED
FEAR WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
INCREASES ONE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE ENTANGLED WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT. THIS MAY RESULT IN
HESITANCY BY COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO INTERACT WITH STATE AGENCIES
REPORT VIOLATIONS OF STATE LAWS
OR REGULATIONS OR MENTALLY TO
SERVE AS WITNESS IS TO RAIMES.
CALIFORNIA MUST PROTECT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO VISIT THE
COURTS AND PARTICIPATE IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS WITHOUT FEAR OF
ARREST THIS BILL SEEKS TO
REMOVE THE THREAT OF CIVIL
ARREST AT COURTHOUSES. TO
ENCOURAGE MEMBERS OF THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AND ALL
OTHERS TO ENGAGE AND
PARTICIPATE IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS WHICH SERVES THE
PUBLIC INTEREST OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUSSELL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
BORDERS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT PART OF ME COULD
UNDERSTAND THAT AS A MATTER OF
PUBLIC POLICY YOU DON'T WANT TO
SWEET INDIVIDUALS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN A JUDICIAL
PROCESS EITHER DIRECTLY OR AS A
WITNESS IN DIRECTLY BUT I THINK
THIS BILL GOES FURTHER THAN
THAT IT'S NOT JUST LIMITED TO
IMMIGRATION ISSUES. IT'S
EVERYTHING IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
AND IF AN INDIVIDUAL IS THE
SUBJECT OF A WARRANT AND HERE
SHE HAPPENS TO BE AT THE
COURTHOUSE. WHY WOULD WE
DISSUADE THE SHERIFF FROM
EXECUTING THEIR OBLIGATIONS OR
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT DOING THE
SAME. IT JUST KIND OF FLIES IN
THE FACE THIS IS NOT A CHURCH.
THERE ARE NO SANCTUARY
PROTECTIONS OF THIS NATURE OF
COURTHOUSES THE JUDICIAL
BUILDING. AS SUCH IT IS PART OF
THE STATE SO I'M UNAWARE THAT
WE SHOULD BE THAT WE HAVE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN PLACE
THAT PROVIDE SANCTUARY THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ASKING. IF
THAT WERE THE CASE THEN I THINK
WE COULD BE LOOKING AT A WHOLE
SLEW OF GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
INSTITUTIONS AND BUILDINGS THAT
ARE GIVEN THE PROTECTIONS THAT
USED TO EXIST IN AN OLDER
PERIOD OF CIVILIZATION AS IF
THEY WERE HIDING IN A MONASTERY
OR CHURCH AND THAT'S JUST. NOT
UP TO DATE. ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
TO ROSS SO YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU AGAIN I JUST WANT TO REPEAT
THIS IS TO AVOID CIVIL ARREST
WHILE IN THE- INDIVIDUAL IS IN
THE COURT AND IT REALLY IS TO
PROTECT THE TRUST. OF THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES AND THE
ABILITY OF. SOMEONE TO. MEET
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY FOR
WHATEVER THEIR BUSINESSES IN
THE COURTHOUSE. AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL I PURCHASE. NO BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER ALL I CHIANG. DALY.
NO DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
NO HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO.
BY TITLE. I JACKSON HI I JONES.
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN. BY
PORTANTINO. HI. ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY I WINNER HI
WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES. NO CHIANG NO.
JONES NO OUR EYES TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO OF
THREE EXCUSE ME THAT WAS TWO OR
THREE WILL GO TO FIVE. SENATOR
HUESO ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP THE SIDE. PASS ON FILE FILE
ITEM TWO OH SIX SENATOR HILL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION SENATOR
HILL THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
FORTY WHICH WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS FROM OVER
PRICED INEFFECTIVE CAREER
TRAINING PROGRAMS BY PROVIDING
EAST CENTRAL DATA. TO
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS AND THE
PUBLIC ON EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES
AT PRIVATE FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
THIS BILL CLOSES A MASSIVE GAP
IN OUR STATE OUTCOMES DATA FOR
THESE PROGRAMS BY GIVING
STUDENTS THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO MAKE AN INFORMED CHOICE
FOR THEY ARE NOT SETTLED WITH
MOUNTAINS OF DEBT. AND FEW
CAREER PROSPECTS THIS BILL
COMPARE STUDENTS MEDIAN ANNUAL
EARNINGS TO MEDIAN DEBT PROGRAM
BY PROGRAM AT EVERY PROPRIETARY
INSTITUTION IN MAKES THAT DATA
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM TWO OH
SIX. SEEING AND HEARING NON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES HI BILL.
GORGEOUS. BY BRADFORD AYE COVER
HERO I CHIANG BY DAILY. DODD
I'D RATHER I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO AYE
OR TADO. I JACKSON HI I JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING AYE MOORLACH AYE
MORRELL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE AYE
HAMBURG IA CASKEY HI WIENER AYE
WILK. PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO OH SEVEN SENATOR PAN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NINETY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS
RICE PERCENT EIGHTY SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE BY SUMMER CREO
WHICH MAKES NECESSARY REFORMS
TO THE NURSING HOME INDUSTRY
WHEN A CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
OCCURS TO ADDRESS IS THE
ADDRSS ISSUES WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS BILL ALSO
ENSURE CUT NEW CARE FOR NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS AS WELL AS A
PLANET PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS
IN THIS PROCESS AB SIXTY NINETY
FIVE REQUIRES A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY TO GIVE WRITTEN NOTICE
TO ALL RESIDENTS OF THE
FACILITY NINETY DAYS PRIOR TO
TRANSFER OF MANAGEMENT FOR A
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
ALL EMPLOYEES TO BE TEN FOR
SIXTY DAY TRANSITION EMPLOYMENT
PERIOD AS PATIENTS HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS THE EMPLOYEES ARE
TAKING CARE OF THEM. THIS BILL
IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
A STRICTLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
DEBATE OR. DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BY
BATES NOBEL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD I CAPPIELLO I CHIANG.
I DALY NO DODD I DORADO. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO I JACKSON
AYE JONES. NO LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL HI MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NOTE NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY I
WINNER. HI WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURGESS. NO
ICE THIRTY TO NOTATE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG TO
FILE ITEM TWO OO EIGHT SENATOR
HER TITLE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRILLO AND ACT
RELATED TO FAMILY PHYSICIANS
SENATOR FURTADO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO WHICH SEEKS
TO PROTECT PATIENT ACCESS AND
BETTER UTILIZE CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION WORKFORCE BY MANY
STATUTORY LANGUAGE TO MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECT. THE
TRAINING AND EXPERTISE OF OUR
FAMILY PHYSICIANS THE
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING THEY
RECEIVED MIXED FAMILY
PHYSICIANS UNIQUE IN THEIR
PRESS OF KNWLEDGE AND ABILITY
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY CARE TO
PATIENTS ACROSS ALL SAID IN
SETTINGS REGARDLESS OF A
PATIENT'S GENDER AGE OR
AFFECTED ORGAN SYSTEM FROM
PEDIATRICS IN. THE TO A
GERIATRIC SOME BEHAVIORAL
MEDICINE WITH THE SKILLS AND
TRAINING TO CARE FOR THE WHOLE
FAMILY FAMILY MEDICINE
ENCOURAGES CONTINUITY OF CARE
AND HAS BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE
COSTS AND IMPROVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES. UNFORTUNATELY A LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING OF FAMILY
MEDICINE HAS RESULTED IN THE
UNDER UTILIZATION OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS LIMITING ACCESS TO
CARE. RESTRICTING PATIENT
CHOICE AND DISRUPTING
CONTINUITY OF CARE AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY TWO. HOW THIS FIX THIS
PROBLEM. I WITH THE
INCONSISTENCY OF THE LAW TO
MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
TRAINING AND EXPERTISE OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND TO
IMPROVE PATIENT ACCESS THIS
BILL INTEREST BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NAY ABOUT. THANK YOU OF SENATOR
FURTADO IS OR ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ALL ICE THIRTY
NINE AT NO ZERO. FORTY EXCUSE
ME ICE FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING RIGHT
ALONG TO FILE ITEM TWO OH NINE
SENATOR GLAZER DO YOU. CENTER
GLAZER YOU PREPARE TO TAKE THIS
UP. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AN
ACT RELATING TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS SENATOR GLAZERS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AB
FOR NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMAN
LOVE MAKES VARIOUS TECHNICAL
CORRECTIONS AND CHANGES TO THE
BNP CODE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EITHER. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THE SIDE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO. TEN
SENATOR RALPH SO YOU PREPARED
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AN
ACRYLATE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SENATOR ROBB THING ABOUT
PRESIDENT THIS BILL EXTENDS
COLLEGE AND CAREER ACCESS
PATHWAYS PROGRAM OR CAPS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL YEARS AND
SIMPLIFIES THE PROCESS TO
ESTABLISH THESE PARTNERSHIPS.
AS YOU KNOW THESE PROGRAMS
INCREASE ACCESS TO COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITIES PROMOTE CAREER
READINESS AND IMPROVE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR THE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS ARE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM TO TEN.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
TURNING OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM TO
ELEVEN SENATOR WIENER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AN ACT
RELATING TO TEACHERS. SENATOR
WINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M
PRESENTING A BEFORE NINETY
THREE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A MORE SUPPORTIVE AND
SAFE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR
LGBTQ STUDENTS BY PROVIDING
TEACHERS WITH THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED. TO SUPPORT OUR LGBTQ
YOUTH ARE BOTH AT SCHOOL AND IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY THIS PLAN
OVERWHELMING INCREASE AND
HARASSMENT MANY LGBT Q.
STUDENTS DO NOT REPORT THEIR
TROUBLES TO SCHOOL STAFF.
BECAUSE THE QUESTION WHETHER OR
NOT EFFECTIVE INTERVENTION
WALKER THIS IN RETURN CREATES
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE STUDENTS
DO NOT FEEL SAFE AND ARE UNABLE
TO BE THEMSELVES. THIS IS WHY
IT'S CRITICAL THAT TEACHERS AND
STAFF THE EQUIPPED WITH THE
TRAINING AND TOOLS THEY NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR LGBT Q. U. A. B.
FOR NINETY THREE EQUIPS
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND SUPPORT
STUDENTS BY ENCOURAGING
TRAINING FOR TEACHERS. IN GRADE
SEVEN TO TWELVE AND ALL. OTHER
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES AT THOSE
SCHOOLS. THE TRAINING WILL
INCLUDE SCHOOL CITING COMMUNITY
AS WELL AS TO. AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR
SUPPORTING LGBTQ STUDENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM MANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AYE BATES. BELL BY BURGESS.
EFFORT I COVER GYRO I CHIANG.
DALLY DODD. I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. HI TADO I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK WELL. NIELSEN AYE
PAN. BY PORTANTINO. I ROH BY
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER. BY CASKEY BY
WINNER. WILK. PLEASE WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE
ONE MORE TIME PLEASE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
GORGEOUS. CHIANG DELHI. GROVE
JONES. MORE LUCK MERRELL STONE
NUMBER I. WIENER BY. WILK WILL
CRACK OUR EYES THIRTY NO ZERO
.
OUR EYES THIRTY ONE AT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. IF YOU WAIT
ONE MOMENT PLEASE
. COLLEAGUES
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM
TWO THIRTY EIGHT FILE ITEM TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. SENATOR TO
RUSSELL ARE YOU READY. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR.
SENATOR ALSO THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AB FIVE. LAST APRIL
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
GAVE US A TOOL THE COUNTER THE
DECADES OLD PROBLEM OFGROWING
MISS CLASSIFICATION WHEN THEY
ISSUED THE LANDMARK DYNAMIX
DECISION. AGAINST THE DELIVERY
COMPANY THAT WAS MISS
CLASSIFYING ITS DRIVERS THIS
DECISION WAS UNANIMOUS DRAFTED
BY THE REPUBLICAN CHIEF JUSTICE
AND SIGNED ON TO BUY EVERY
REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT ON THE
COURT. THE RULING STATED THAT A
HIRING ENTITY MUST MEET THE
CRITERIA LAID OUT IN THE A. B.
C. TEST IN ORDER TO CLASSIFY AN
INDIVIDUAL AS A CONTRACTOR. THE
TEST AS IS USED IN SEVERAL
OTHER STATES SIMPLY REQUIRES
THAT TO BE CLASSIFIED AS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR AN
INDIVIDUAL MUST FIRST BE FREE
FROM THE DIRECTION AND CONTROL
OF THE COMPANY. TO PERFORM WORK
OUTSIDE OF THE COMPANY'S USUAL
COURSE OF BUSINESS AND THREE
HAVE INDEPENDENTLY ESTABLISHED
AS A SEPARATE BUSINESS IN A
DIFFERENT TRADE THAN THAT OF
THE HIRING ENTITY THE COURT
MADE IT CLEAR IT WAS NOT
REFERENCE SEEN MOST BUSINESS
CONTRACTS. THE PACKAGE DELIVERY
COMPANY COULD CONTRACT WITH AN
ELECTRICIAN TO FIX THEIR LIVES
BUT IT COULD NOT CALL THEIR
WORKERS WHO DELIVERS PACKAGES
AND DO THE MAIN WORK OF THE
BUSINESS. INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. DYNAMAX HAS BEEN
THE LAW OF THE LAND FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF WHICH HAS LEFT SOME
UNCERTAINTY FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
INDUSTRIES. IF THERE WERE NO
LEAD LATE IN DYNAMIC CONTINUE
TO BE THE LAW. HOWEVER WE AS
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY CAN BE
PROACTIVE AND PROVIDE WORKERS
IT BUSINESSES CLARITY ON HOW
THIS DISEASE DECISION APPLIES.
ULTIMATELY WORKERS THIS IS ON
THE STATE WILL BENEFIT WHEN
THERE IS A CLEAR AND CONSISTENT
STAND TO DETERMINE EMPLOYMENT
STATUS. PROMOTES CLIENTS AND IS
EASILY ENFORCED. AB FIVE
REPRESENTS A COMPROMISED
APPROACH WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IT CODIFIES THE
DYNAMICS DECISION AND
DISTINGUISHES BETWEEN WORKERS
MOST VULNERABLE TO MISS
CLASSIFICATION. FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE GONE INTO
THIS FOR THEMSELVES. AND HAVE
TRUE INDEPENDENCE IN THEIR WORK.
A LARGE THE EXEMPTED
PROFESSIONS UNDER THE BILL TEND
TO OPERATE WITH SIGNIFICANT
AUTONOMY. AND BARGAINING POWR
IN THE WORKPLACE AND HAVE
HISTORICALLY EXISTED OUTSIDE
TRADITIONAL WAGE ORDERS IN
OTHER WORDS MOST OF THESE MEN
AND WOMEN MAKE OVER TWICE THE
MINIMUM WAGE WHICH IS OUR
STANDARD IN EXISTING LAW FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO BE EXEMPTED FROM
OVER TIME MEAL AND REST PERIOD
REQUIREMENTS. AB FIVE DOES NOT
GO AS FAR A SOME HAVE HOPED.
BUT IT GOES A LONG WAY TO
ENSURING THAT WHERE THERE WAS
NOT A PROBLEM BEFORE DYNAMICS
THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
THE CASE. THE BILL PROVIDES
CERTAINTY FOR A NUMBER OF
PROFESSIONALS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
OPERATIONS UNDER THE PREVIOUS
BOROUGH LOW STANDARD. THE BILL
EXAMS DOCTORS DENTISTS
INSURANCE AGENTS FINANCIAL
ADVISORS AND MANY OTHER
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS THE BILL
EXEMPTS WORKERS WHO HAVE PRE
EXISTING LAW THE CONFLICTS WITH
DYNAMICS SUCH AS REALTORS
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN AND
PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS. THE BILL
EXEMPTS MANY OCCUPATIONS WERE
INDIVIDUALS OPERATE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENJOY
INDEPENDENCE A TRAVEL AGENTS
HAIR STYLIST AND GRAPHIC
DESIGNERS. THE BILL EXEMPTS
MANY BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
CONTRACTS INCLUDING
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS
CONSTRUCTION TRUCKING REFERRAL
AGENCIES MOTOR CLUB CONTRACTS
WITH TOWING COMPANIES AND
BUSINESSES CONTRACTING WITH
OTHERS TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE BUSINESS. AGAIN AB FIVE
DOESN'T ADDRESS EVERY ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN RAISED BUT THE
BILL HAS GONE A LONG WAY TOWARD
THE DRESSING THE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED IN
THE WAKE OF THIS DECISION. THE
AUTHOR AND BILL SUPPORTERS HAVE
PLEDGED TO CONTINUE TALKS WITH
INDUSTRIES THAT PRESENTED MORE
COMPLEX CHALLENGES WITHOUT
HALTING THE CERTAINTY AWAITING
MANY INDUSTRIES. MEMBERS LET'S%
NOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TODAY WITH
THIS BILL WITH ONE CLEAR TEST
ACROSS OUR STATE LABOR LAWS WE
WILL RAISE THE STANDARDS FOR
MILLIONS OF WORKERS AND ENSURE
THEY GAIN ACCESS TO CRITICAL
RIGHTS AND BENEFITS WE CAN MAKE
CALIFORNIA A GLOBAL LEADER IN
PROTECTIONS. BRIGADE WORKERS
JANITORS CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
AND SO MANY WORKING PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T EVEN PAY THEIR RENT. THE
ISSUE OF WORKER MISS
CLASSIFICATION IS NOT NEW AND
IT'S NOT EXCLUSIVELY A PRODUCT
OF THE MODERN DAY QUOTE UNQUOTE
GIG ECONOMY. COMPANIES HAVE
EXPLOITED MEN AND WOMEN FOR
DECADES BY USING UNLAWFUL
PRACTICES IN INDUSTRIES LIKE
CONSTRUCTION JANITORIAL AND
TRUCKING TODAY THE SO CALLED
GIG COMPANIES PRESENT
THEMSELVES AS THE INNOVATIVE
FUTURE OF TOMORROW. A FUTURE
WHERE COMPANIES DON'T PAY
SOCIAL SECURITY OR MEDICARE
WORKERS COMPENSATION OR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE NOW
THAT'S A TIME BOMB THAT WILL
MAKE UNFUNDED PUT PUBLIC
PENSIONS LOOK LIKE SMALL
POTATOES. THIS MODEL COST
CALIFORNIA SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOST TAX REVENUE
FUNDING. ALI THE OUGHT TO BE
PUT TOWARDS IMPROVING PUBLIC
SAFETY HEALTH CARE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE
AT CETERA ET CETERA. LET'S BE
CLEAR IS NOTHING INNOVATIVE
ABOUT UNDER PAIN SOMEONE FOR
THEIR LABOR OR BASING ON ENTIRE
BUSINESS MODEL ON MISCLASSIFIED
WORKERS UNDER THE GIG ECONOMY
BUSINESS MODEL WORKERS ARE NOT
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
COMPANY SO FORGET WORKER GETS
INJURED OR SICK OR CAN EVEN
WORK TO SUPPORT HIMSELF HERSELF
FOR THE FAMILY. THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
THAT WORKER FALLS ON THE
TAXPAYER. MEANWHILE COMPANIES
LIKE UBER COMPENSATE EXECUTIVES
NEARLY A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR. AND THEY'RE
WORTH NEARLY A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS. AS THEIR DRIVERS WHO
MAKE THE BUSINESSES RUN. SLEEP
IN THEIR CARS. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO FIFTY THREE FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES REAL
COMPANIES WHO FULFILL THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS AN EMPLOYER
AND WHOSE EMPLOYEES MAKE UP
CALIFORNIA'S TAX PAYING MIDDLE
CLASS WHY SHOULD WE EXEMPT
QUOTING QUOTE GET COMPANIES
FROM THE VERY SAME LAWS WE
REQUIRE OUR LOCAL MOM AND POPS
TO BUY BY. BY MISS CLASSIFYING
THOSE WORKERS THESE BAD ACTORS
FORCE BUSINESSES THAT ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THE RULE OF THE LAW
FORCE THEM TO SHUT THEIR DOORS.
TODAY WE ARE DETERMINING THE
FUTURE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY WE CAN EITHER CHOOSE TO
BE COMPLICIT IN THE
EXPLOITATION OF HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS OR- WE CAN CHOOSE
TO REBUILD. THE WORKING AND
MIDDLE CLASS PROTECT TAXPAYERS
AND HELP RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES
THRIVE IN THE STATE COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
SENATOR GROWTH WHAT PURPOSE AT
THE MINUTES OF THE DESK.
SENATOR. GROVER IS OFFERING
SOME AMENDMENTS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE SET
OF AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR GROVE SET ONE. EXCUSE
ME PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT IN APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND AND IGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT ISSUED
A DECISION TO CHANGE THE WORK
LIFE OF MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS TO THAT
DEPARTED FROM A THIRTY FROM
THIRTY YEARS. OF CALIFORNIA
LINE CREATED A NEW TEST TO
DETERMINE WHO IS NOT AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR THE
TESTS THE A. B. C. TO US IS A
RIGOROUS TEST WHICH IN AN
INDEPENDENT COMPROMISED MEET
ALL THREE OF THE CRITERIA IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THEIR
EMPLOYMENT STATUS. PART EIGHT
OF THE TEST REQUIRES THE WE'RE
GOING TO BE FREE FROM THE
CONTROL AND DIRECTION OF THE
HIRING ENTITY IN CONNECTION
WITH THE PERFORMANCE OF THE
WORK BOTH UNDER THE CONTRACT IN
FOR THE PERFORMANCE OF WORK IN
PART B. OF THE TEST REQUIRES
THE WORKER THAT THEY PERFORM
THE WORK THAT IS OUTSIDE. THE
USUAL COURSE OF THE HIRING INTO
THESE BUSINESS AND PART C. OF
THE TEST REQUIRES A WORKER THAT
IS MERELY ENGAGED IN THE
INDEPENDENTLY ESTABLISH TRADE
OCCUPATION OR IS OF THE SAME
NATURE OF THE CONTRACT THE WORK
IS PERFORMED. THIS RULING
ESTABLISHED THREE THE FORM OF
THE APPOINTMENT. TING READ THE
WAGE LAWS FOUND ANYWAY THE CAT.
THERE ARE ON THE ENDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO CHOOSE TO WORK
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WE
HAVE MOMS WHO WORK DRIVING UBER
WHILE THEIR CHILDREN ERIC
SCHOOL AND THEY SET THEIR OWN
HOURS. THE COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
WORK AS DOOR DASH AFTER CLASS
TO AFFORD HIGH COST OF LIVING
IN ADD TO THEIR INCOME. THE
MANICURIST TO SET THEIR OWN
APPOINTMENTS RENT THEIR OWN
BOOZE AND SHE'S WORK. A TO WORK
AS THEIR OWN BOSS THESE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ARE
TRUCKERS OUR THERAPISTS ARE A
TOM INTERESTS. ARE CATERS ARE
FORESTERS INTERPRETERS ARE
MEDIA INDIVIDUALS AND
REPORTERS. IN FACT NEARLY HALF
A MILLION OF MILLENNIALS
CURRENTLY FREELANCE AND 79% OF
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
PREFERRED THIS WORK. OVER
TRADITIONAL EMPLOYMENT. INSTEAD
OF HELPING ALL OF THESE
CALIFORNIANS THIS BODIES
INTRODUCED AB FIVE WHICH ISSUES
CARVE OUTS TO CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES. THIS LEGISLATURE
SHOULD NOT BE IN THE BUSINESS
OF PICKING FAVORITES WHICH IS
ACTUALLY WHAT THIS LEGISLATION
DOES. A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
EMPLOYMENT TEST SHOULD NOT AND
CANNOT. APPLY TO THESE
CALIFORNIA'S TO DEPEND ON THEIR
INCOME FROM INDEPENDENT
CONTRACT WORK. THIS IS WHAT
MANNER TO SEE THE AMENDMENTS TO
AB FIVE WHICH WOULD MATCH
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT TESTS
TO THE FED'S STANCE. THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED WITH
BOBBY IN COHESIVENESS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STANDARD IN
THERE WOULD NOT BE A SEPARATE
TEST. FOR A PEOPLE THAT OPERATE
IN THE FEDERAL STANDARD AND THE
STATE CAN'T STANDARD THE PEOPLE
WHO WILL FALL UNDER THE BROILER
TEST AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
PART OF THE CARVE OUT. THIS
BENEFIT BOB THIS BENEFITS BOTH
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
ACROSS INDUSTRIES BY ASKING
WHETHER THE WORKER IS
ECONOMICALLY DEPENDENT ON THE
HIRING ENTITY. THIS TEST
ACCOUNTS FOR DIVERSITY OF WORK
PLACES AND WILL ONCE AGAIN MAKE
A SIDE GIG INDEPENDENT CONTRACT
WORK A FREELANCE JOB IT WILL BE
THE OPTION FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AGAIN IN LIKE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES CHOOSE.
MEMBERS I URGE YOU FOR THE SAKE
OF ALL INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
AND THE ONES THAT ARE NOT
COVERED UNDER EIGHTY FIVE WE'VE
PUT AMENDMENTS ACROSS THE DESK
IN THIS BILL IS A BEEN AMENDED
SEVEN SEVERAL TIMES. BECAUSE WE
KNOW ALL OF THE FACT THAT THESE
WILL HAVE ON THE DISC WILL
COVER WE'VE EXCLUDED REALTORS
DOCTORS LAWYERS THERE'S BEEN A
MINUTES ACROSS THE DESK FOR
JUST NEWSPAPER DELIVERY
COMPANIES TODAY. JUST TO DELAY
IT FOR ONE YEAR BUT THERE IS I
MEAN THERE ARE SO MANY
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE NOT PART OF
THIS BILL THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GET A CARVE OUT. THIS
BILL IS GOING TO AFFECT AND
IT'S NOT JUST THE GIG ECONOMY
THAT YOU'RE AFTER. SO I WOULD
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. SENATOR HERTZBERG
FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
DARYA. MOVED TO A LADY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE THANK
YOU THIS MOTION IS NON
DEBATABLE A MAJORITY VOTE IS
REQUIRED. SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE SENATOR
GROVE IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE
MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL I PORGES
NO BRADFORD I COME A YEAR AGO I
CHIANG. NO DALLY NO DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG.
HILL. GUY HILL AYE HUESO I TADO
I JACKSON HI I JONES. NO LABOR
HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LARK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN. BY
PORTANTINO BY ROSS FIVE RUBIO I
SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE. NO
NUMBER IOWA COUNTY BY WIENER
AYE WILK. NO OUR EYES TWENTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE. SENATOR JONES FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS FOR AB FIVE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
JONES SET TO. SENATOR JONES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS DESIGN PROFESSIONALS
ARE SKILLED INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THE DESIGN OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS SUCH AS
BRIDGES ROADS DAMS RAIL AND
HOSPITALS ETCETERA UNDER AB
FIVE TODAY ARCHITECTS AND
ENGINEERS ARE EXEMPT FROM THE
A. B. C. A. B. C. TEST. THE
FOLLOWING DESIGN PROFESSIONALS
SHOULD SIMILARLY BE EXEMPTED
THE LAND SURVEYORS GEOLOGISTS
GEOPHYSICISTS LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS CONSTRUCTION
MANAGERS AND THE PLANNERS.
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS ARE NOT
MISCLASSIFIED IN DOING SO
WOULDN'T EVEN MAKE FISCAL
SENSE. IS USUALLY MORE
EXPENSIVE TO HIRE DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS AS CONTRACTORS
RATHER THAN FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
SINCE CONTRACT RATES ARE HIGHER
THAN THOSE IN HOUSE FOR THIS
REASON THE DESIGN INDUSTRY USES
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ON
SHORT TERM PROJECTS AND A
LONGER TERM PROJECTS PREFER TO
HIRE THE INDIVIDUAL IN HOUSE
INSTEAD. DESIGN PROFESSIONALS
ARE HIGHLY SKILLED HIGHLY PAID
PROFESSIONALS ARE CONTRACTED
DESIGN PROFESSIONAL MAKES ON
AVERAGE FIFTY TO ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER HOUR. A COMMON
INSTANCE OF AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR DESIGN PROFESSIONAL
IS THAT OF A RECENT RETIREE WHO
HAS A SPECIFIC SKILL SET AND
THAT IS NEEDED ON A PARTICULAR
JOB FOR WHICH THERE AREN'T
OTHERS WITH THAT SKILL SET
LOCALLY AVAILABLE. THE DESIGN
INDUSTRY IS HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
IN WHICH YOU MAY NEED ONE TYPE
OF ENGINEER OR SURVEYOR FOR ONE
PARTICULAR JOB AND SOMEONE WITH
ANOTHER. SAYS SUBSPECIALTY OR
EXPERIENCE FOR ANOTHER JOB.
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO CONTRACT
WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS PROJECTS
WILL SUFFER DUE TO THE LACK OF
QUALIFIED PROFESSIONALS MEMBERS
I ASK DO YOU SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENTS AND VOTE I ON THE
MINUTES. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I MOVE BUT TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE AGAIN
THIS MOTION IS NON DEBATABLE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING THE PREVIOUS ROLL
CALL THERE IS AN OBJECTION
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS
EACH TIME ALL RIGHT. MISTERS.
APPARENTLY SENATOR JONES
INDICATED OBJECTION SO WE WILL
GO THROUGH THE ROLE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE SENATOR JONES IS
ASKING FOR AN OVAL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL. BY
BATES NO FORGES NO BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG NO. DELHI
NO DOT. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROW.
NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TADO BY JACKSON HI I
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIREAYE
MITCHELL HI MONNING BY MORE
LUCK. NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO BY ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN. BY
STONE. NOVEMBER OUR COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK. NO OUR EYES
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE SENATOR DOLLINGER THE
MAN'S FIGURE A RISE TO.
AMENDMENTS TO AB FIVE AT THE
DESK PLEASE INDICATE WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE I'LL TRY TO DO
THIS LITTLE DIFFERENT DONALD
CALLING IT THIS IS THIRD SET OF
AMENDMENTS YES OKAY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE THIRD
SET OF AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR DALLY SET THREE.
SENATOR DOLLINGER MEMBERS FOR
THE FOLLOWING FOR OCT FOR THE
FOLLOWING OCCUPATIONS LICENSE
TIMBER OPERATORS WHO HOLD A
LICENSE ISSUED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION AS AUTHORIZED UNDER
THE Z. BURKE. NEW JERSEY FORCED
PRACTICED. ACTRESSES ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE CHAPTER
EIGHT COMMITTEE WITH THE
SECTION FORTY FIVE ELEVEN A
PART TWO OF THE DIVISION OF
FOUR OF THE- PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE PURSUANT TO ARTICLE SIX
COMMENCING WITH SECTION FORTY
FIVE SEVENTY OF. CHAPTER EIGHT
APART TO. OF DIVISION FOR OF
THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE BE
REGISTERED PERFECT FORSTER'S
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE FOR SALT
TO THE PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS
LAW ARTICLE THREE COMMITTING
WITH SECTIONS SEVEN FIFTY OF
CHAPTER TWO POINT FIVE OF
DIVISION ONE. OF THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE. GEOLOGIST AND
PHYSICIST LICENSE PER SONG TO
THE GEOLOGIST AND PHYSICIST AT
CHAPTER TWELVE FIVE COMMITTEE
WAS. SEVEN HUNDRED A DIVISION
THREE OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE. DE LAND
SURVEYORS LICENSE PRASANTA
PROFESSIONAL LAND SURVEYORS ACT
CHAPTER FIFTEEN COMMITTING WITH
SECTIONS EIGHTY SEVEN HUNDRED
OF DIVISION THREE OF THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
HE CONTRACTORS LICENSE. PURSUIT
TO CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
LAW CHAPTER NINE COMMIT SEEMS
WITH SECTIONS OF SEVEN THOUSAND
OF DIVISION THREE OF THE
PROVISION THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE. ENGINEERING
LICENSE FOR SALT TO THE
PROFESSION ENGINEERING ACT
CHAPTER SEVEN COMMITTEE WAS
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN HUNDRED A
DIVISION THREE OF THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE. SENATOR
HERTZBERG WHAT PURPOSE SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMEND
PRESIDENT I MOVE TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE MOTION
IS TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. CENTER
DOLLY IS ASKING OFFER NO VOTERS
ERNIE OBJECTION TO USING THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NON I'M SORRY THAT I
MISSED THAT. IS THERE OBJECTION.
NO VICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE LAID
ON THE TABLE SENATOR NIELSEN
FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR. THE
PROPER AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY
FIVE MADAM THIS WOULD BE SAID
FOR SENATOR NIELSEN PARDON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YEARS
SUBMITTING SET FOR OF A MEN'S
CORRECT THIS IS MISTER
pFOR OF THE AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR NELSON
SEPT FOUR. THANK YOU SENATOR
NIELSEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THIS. CIRCULAR
AMENDMENT. WORLD DEFINED AS
DEFINED HEALTH FACILITIES IN
SUBDIVISIONS AID AGENT CLOSER
INSPECTION TWELVE FIFTY OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE WHICH
CONTRACT WITH COMPANIES THAT
EMPLOY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
WHO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
PATIENTS AND THEIR FACILITIES.
AMENDMENTS TO THREE FOUR AND
FIVE OUR TECHNICAL AND
ASSOCIATED AMENDMENTS. THAT I
WILL ARGUE THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL AREAS OF ALL. THAT
NEED TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS ONEROUS
DECISION. WE HAVE A PAUCITY OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS OF ALL
SORTS. IN CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR
IN OUR RURAL AREAS. THIS
PARTICULAR PROVISION. WILL BE
VERY VERY ONEROUS A GREAT
BURDEN. TO ALL OF US AND I WILL
BE JEOPARDIZING THE QUALITY OF
HEALTH CARE AVAILABLE TO US. I
ASKED AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT MOVED
TO LAY THE AMOUNT OF TABLE
RIGHT THIS IS NON DEBATABLE
ATTORNEY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING THE PRIOR ROLL
CALL. ALL EYES TWENTY NINE IT
KNOWS ELEVEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
LAID ON THE TABLE SENATOR BATES.
YES I'M SET FIVE MADAM
PRESIDENT THING I HAVE AN
INTIMATE OUT THE DESK VERY GOOD
SENT TO MISTER SECTOR PLEASE
READ THE AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS
BY SENATOR BATES SEPT FIVE
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
FORESHORES HI THIS IS AN
AMENDMENT TO ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
AS AMENDED AND SENT SENATE
SEPTEMBER SIXTH TWENTY NINETEEN
PAGE SEVEN. BETWEEN LINES
THIRTY ONE AND THIRTY TO INSERT
A NEWSPAPER CARRIER OR
NEWSPAPER DISTRIBUTOR AS
DESCRIBED IN SECTION FORTY
THREE OH FOUR DASH SIX OF TITLE
TWENTY TWO OF THE CALIFORNIA
CODE OF REGULATIONS SO LONG AS
THE CONDITIONS FOR EXCLUSION
FROM EMPLOYMENT IN THE
NEWSPAPER DISTRIBUTION INDUSTRY
UNDER THAT SECTION. OF THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
ARE MAPPED I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS AMENDMENT IN NOW
STATED OF THE BILL THREATENS TO
RIP THAT PIECE OF DEMOCRACY
ROUTE OUT RIGHT OUT OF OUR
GROUP. PER THE SACRAMENTO BEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
BATES SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
MOVE TO LAY. THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE VERY CROWDED TABLE. GOOD
THANK YOU THE- AND THIS ALSO IS
NOT DEBATABLE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING THE PRIOR ROLL
CALL SEEING NONE ICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE. SENATOR WILL THE NEXT
SET OF AMENDMENTS IF YOU WOULD
BANKING THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GO AHEAD. FILE THIS
IS NUMBER SIX MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE SIX FEDERAL
MA'AM. AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
WILKES THAT SIX SENATOR WELCOME
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THE TABLE'S
ABOUT TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
CROWDED. SO MY MINUTES ON PAGE
SEVEN BETWEEN LINES THIRTY ONE
AND THIRTY TO PLEASE INSERT
NUMBER SEVEN AND OWNER OPERATOR
AS DESCRIBED IN SECTION THIRTY
FOUR SIXTY FOUR. THE VEHICLE
CODE IF ALL THE FOLLOWING ARE
MET. HI THE OWNER OPERATOR OWNS
OR FINANCES A POWER UNIT AS
DESCRIBED IN SUBDIVISION A. B.
F. G. OR K. A SECTION THIRTY
FOUR FIVE HUNDRED OF THE
VEHICLE CODE. DOUBLE LIED THE
HIRING ENTITY OR BROKER OF
TRUCKING SERVICES SHOW NOT OWN
LAND OR HAD ANY OTHER FINANCING
INVESTMENT LEAN HOLD INTEREST
IN THE POWER UNIT. I II THE
OWNER OPERATOR SHALL HAVE THE
SOLE ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE AND
SET THE CONTRACTED RATES FOR
THE USE OF THE POWER UNIT OR TO
ACCEPT OR DENY THE WORK BASED
ON THE OFFERED RATE OR FOR ANY
OTHER REASON INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO THE ROUTE.
DESTINATION OR MATERIAL TO BE
HAULED IN SECTION FOUR THE
OWNER OPERATOR HAS VALID MOTOR
VEHICLE PERMIT IN CARRIER
DENNIS TAKE CATION NUMBER AS
DESCRIBED IN SECTIONS THIRTY
FOUR SIX TWO OO. THIRTY FOUR
FIVE OH SEVEN POINT FIVE OF THE
VEHICLE CODE. A CODE SECTION
SEVENTY FOUR OH FIVE SIX. AND
OPERATES THE POWER UNIT
EXCLUSIVELY UNDER THE PERMIT IN
CARRIER JENNIFER CATION NUMBER
ARE OPERATES PURSUANT TO AN
AGREEMENT WHICH IS A SUBJECT TO
PART. THREE SEVENTY SIX OF
TITLE FORTY NINE OF THE CODE OF
FEDERAL REGULATIONS IT SHOULD
BE NOTED THAT THE COURT ITSELF
EXCLUDED OWNER OPERATORS FROM
BEING PART OF THE CLASS. IN
DYNAMICS OPERATING WEST VERSUS
SUPERIOR COURT THAT'S PROTECT
OUR INDEPENDENT TRUCK OWNERS
AND OPERATORS BY PASSING THIS
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT I MOVE TO LAY
THE AMENDMENTS ON THAT TABLE.
THIS IS NOT DEBATABLE SURE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING THE
PRIOR ROLL CALL SEEING NONE I
IS TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS SET SEVEN THAT WE
HAVE. RECENTLY THIS PIECE THIS
AMENDMENT SAYS IT I CENTER
GROVE WE HAVE GUESTS AS THE
THANK YOU WE HAVE TO LET THE
SECRETARY INDICATE THAT THIS IS
THE SEVEN SAID THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY. FOR SHORES
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR GROVE
SAID SEVEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROW THE FLOOR'S YOURS SORRY I
GOT A LITTLE ANXIOUS TO LOAD AT
THE TABLE. OKAY NO PROBLEM SO
AND THESE AMENDMENTS. APPLY TO
OUR FRANCHISEES AND I'VE BEEN
OUR FRANCHISE DOORS SO
BASICALLY THIS AMENDMENT IS A
FRANCHISEE SHALL NOT BE DEEMED
AN EMPLOYEE OR A FRANCHISE OR-
TO THE FRANCHISE OR AND SHALL
BE CONSIDERED. AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR UNLESS THE COURT OF
COMPETENT JURISDICTION
DETERMINES THE FRANCHISE OR
EXERCISES A TIGHT OR DEGREE OF
ACTUAL CONTROL OVER THE
FRANCHISEE. THE FRANCHISEES
EMPLOYEES AND THAT IS NOT CAST
MILLER EXERCISE BY THE
FRANCHISE OR- AND FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROTECTING THE
FRANCHISER'S TRADEMARKS SERVICE
MARKS OR TRADE DRESS. FOR
PURPOSES THAT INCLUDE BUT ARE
NOT LIMITED TO QUALITY CONTROL
OF PRODUCTS AND SERVICES. SO
THE AMENDMENT ADDRESSES ON PAGE
FIFTEEN LINETHIRTY TO STRIKE
OUT. ITEM H. WITH INSERT AND ON
PAGE SIX MM AT THREE IS TO TAKE
ON PAGE SIXTEEN LINE TO STRIKE
OUT THE I. IN INSERT AN UNPAID
SIXTEEN THE LINE EIGHT TO
STRIKE OUT THE INSERT. IN AN
UNPAID. SIXTEEN LINE FIFTEEN TO
STRIKE OUT I IN THE INSERT.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
FRANCHISEES LIKE MCDONALD'S
OWNERS AND OTHERS WILL BE FREE
FROM THIS BILL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT I MOVE TO LAY
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
NON DEBATABLE ATTORNEY
OBJECTIONS SUBSTITUTING THE
PRIOR ROLL CALL TWENTY NINE I
ELEVEN KNOW THE AMENDMENTS ARE
LAID ON THE TABLE SENATOR
GORGEOUS. MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
IS SET NUMBER EIGHT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR BOARD
JUST SET EIGHT. SENATOR
BORCHERS THE FLOOR'S YOURS. IS
LIKE A PAINFUL FILIBUSTER. I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AN
AMENITY BE FIVE OR TO EXEMPT
THE LANGUAGE SERVICES INDUSTRY
WHICH EMPLOYS THOUSANDS OF
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS IN
CALIFORNIA INTERPRETERS
TRANSLATORS IN LINGUISTS SHOULD
NOT BE INCLUDED I SUBMIT. IN
THE GARY CONNERY. MANY THEM
UNDERGO SPECIALIZED TRAINING
INSTRUCTION FROM ACCREDITED
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES.
INTERPRETERS AND TRANSLATORS
PROVIDE A VOICE TO UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY IN THE COURT SYSTEM.
81% OF ALL INTERPRETERS AND
TRANSLATORS IN THE U. S. WORK
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. AND
FIVE HUNDRED LANGUAGE SERVICES
COMPANIES ARE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR STATE ECONOMY WITHOUT AN
EXEMPTION FOR LINGUISTS AB FIVE
WILL HAVE A SERIOUS IMPACT ON
OUR ECONOMY. IT CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE STATE HOME TO A VAST
VARIETY OF LANGUAGES AND
DIALECTS THE NEED FOR
INTERPRETERS AND TRANSLATORS IS
INCREASING EVERY YEAR TO THE
EVER CHANGING AND GROWING
DIVERSITY IN OUR STATE.
LANGUAGE SERVICE COMPANIES TO
DEPEND UPON INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS DUE TO CLIENTS
NEEDS TO FOR A RANGE OF
LANGUAGES LOCATIONS IN VARIOUS
DEGREES OF EXPERTISE. WITHOUT
AN EXEMPTION FOR INTERPRETERS
IN AB FIVE HUNDREDS OF BUSINESS
WILL BE FORCED TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA OR CLOSE THEIR DOORS.
ECONOMIC AND TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES HAVE SPURRED THE
CREATION OF DIGGING ECONOMY
GIVING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
TO FOLKS OUTSIDE THE
TRADITIONAL WORKPLACE. AB FIVE
WILL NOT ONLY LIMIT INDIVIDUALS
ABILITY FOR FLEXIBLE EMPLOYMENT
BUT WILL DESTROY ENTIRE
INDUSTRIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I MOVE TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON A SECOND TABLE
THERE'S NO MORE ROOM ON THE
FIRST ABLE. AND MORE TO COME.
ANY OBJECTION IS SUBSTITUTING
THE PRIOR ROLL CALL SEEING NONE
ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN.
SAID EIGHT TO ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE SENATOR MORE MARK THANK
YOU BETTER PRESIDENT SET NUMBER
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
MORLOCK SET NINE. SENATOR MORE
LOCKED THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IT JUST
WOULD NOT BE THE LAST WEEK OF
SESSION WITHOUT SOME FRIENDLY
AMENDMENTS ON THE FLOOR. SO IN
HONOR OF FORMER COLLEAGUE
SENATOR JOE ANDERSON HERE WE
ARE FOR FUN WELL MY GOODNESS
ALL MY GOODNESS I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER AN AMENDMENT FOR TEA AND
SEES AND SET NINE COLLEAGUES.
TO ME THE GIG ECONOMY.
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES SO IF YOU WANT TO BE
A TAXI DRIVER YOU WANT TO DO IT
YOUR SPARE TIME AFTER YOUR
REGULAR JOB AND YOU JUST DO IT
FOR SOME SPARE CHANGE AND- FROM
SOME EXTRA MONEY TO MAKE ENDS
MEET PAY THE RENT. THEN YOU
SHOULD REALLY BE AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR. BUT IF YOU WANT TO
DO A FULL TIME DO IS A SHIFT
AND IF YOU WANT TO WORK FROM
EIGHT TO FIVE OR WHATEVER THEN
THEN MAYBE YOUR EMPLOYEE. SO
MAYBE WE SHOULD. TAKE SOME TIME
TO FIGURE THAT ONE OUT. THERE
IS ROOM FOR BOTH INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. AND COMMON LAW
EMPLOYEES. REQUEST A ONE YEAR
DEFERRAL IT ALLOWS FOR TIME FOR
ALL PARTIES TO MUTUALLY AGREE
ON THEIR STATUS FULL TIME
SHIPPED EMPLOYEES OR PART TIME
EXTRA INCOME EARNERS I REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SIR SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M A MOVE
TO LAY THE MEMBERS OF THE TABLE.
NON DEBATABLE ACTION TO USING
THE PRIOR ROLL CALL SEEING NONE
ICE TWENTY NINE NOS ELEVEN SET
NINE IS LAID ON THE TABLE
NUMBER TWO. SENATOR MORALE
MISTER FREEZE SO INDICATING AYE
I'D LIKE TO OFFER A SET NUMBER
TEN NUMBER TEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR MERLE SET TEN MISTER
MORALES OKAY REAL THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MEMBERS I RISE
TO THE MAN AB FIVE TO EXEMPT
THE PROFESSION OF PHYSICAL
THERAPY FROM THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS THIS AMENDMENT WOULD
ALLOW PHYSICAL THERAPISTS TO
MAINTAIN THE NECESSARY
FLEXIBILITY A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR STATUS TO SERVE
THEIR PATIENTS. THEIR OFTEN
ASSIGNED TO PROVIDE PHYSICAL
THERAPY TO PATIENTS AND HOME
ENVIRONMENTS FOLLOWING
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH ADVANCE THEY
ARE ALSO REFERRED BY HOSPITALS
ARE AND THEIR AGENCIES TO
PATIENTS FOR THEIR SERVICES AS
AUTHORIZED BY THEIR LICENSE AND
SCOPE OF PRACTICE THE
INDEPENDENTLY EVALUATE ASSASSIN
DEVELOP A TREATMENT PLAN FOR A
SPECIFIC PATIENTS NEEDS. THEY
SCHEDULE APPOINTMENTS STRICTLY
WITH PATIENCE THEY BRING AND
USE THEIR OWN MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
AND WORKING WITH THE PATIENT
THEY EVEN BILL INSURANCE
COMPANIES ONE RELEVANT DIRECTLY
FOR SERVICES SAME IS TRUE IN
NURSING HOMES WHICH OF FISCAL
PURPOSE MAY HAVE A PATIENT
MULTIPLE PATIENTS BUT NOT
ENOUGH FOR A FIRST TERM WAY A
FILM CALLED THERAPY. THESE ARE
JUST TWO OF MANY EXAMPLES IN
THIS INDUSTRY DEMONSTRATING
COMPLETE INDEPENDENCE PEOPLE
WHO'VE CHOSEN THE BOB FOR THE
LOVE AND HELPING OTHERS WARNING
THE EXEMPTION NIGHT FROM THE
DINING THRILLING IT IS
IMPORTANT TO THEM MAINTAIN
PRIVATE CONTRACTING ABILITIES
IN ORDER CAN CONTINUE TO PER I
TREATMENT TO PATIENTS OF ALL
DIFFERENT SOME LOCATION.
INCLUDING PHYSICS. THERAPISTS
IN A BLANK MAP. AS A CAR ABOUT
BILL THANK YOU. SENATOR
HERTZBERG YOU'RE MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT I MOVE TO LAY THE SET
TEN OF THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE NON DEBATABLE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING THE
PRIOR ROLL CALL SEEING NON ICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN. TEN
OF THE AMENDMENTS IS LAID ON
THE TABLES SENATOR STONE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU'RE
DOING A FINE JOB. I'D LIKE TO
BRING FORWARD SAT NUMBER ELEVEN
OF THE MOMENTS MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR STONE SET ELEVEN.
SENATOR STONE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M VERY
HAPPY TO PRESENT THE AMENDMENTS
AB FIVE THE OLD EXEMPT.
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS FROM
THE DYNAMAX APPLICATION THIS
AMENDMENT IS NECESSARY TO ALLOW
FOR THOUSANDS OF NON PROFITS I
KNOW THAT MANY OF. WHICH ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU. THAT THE
STATE CONTINUES TO OPERATE
WITHOUT FEAR OF HAVING TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS. AND CEASING TO
HELP OTHERS. NONPROFITS PROVIDE
VITAL SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE. AND MY FEAR
IS THAT THE DYNAMAX DECISION.
WILL DRIVE MANY OF THESE NON
PROFITS OUT OF BUSINESS. SOME
EXAMPLES OF THE NONPROFIT SOME
MIGHT BE IMPORTANT SOME MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE. THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES FOUNDATION. THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS THE NATIONAL
AUDUBON SOCIETY ST JUDE'S
CHILDREN'S RESEARCH HOSPITAL
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL PITA. SAN DIEGO ZOO
GLOBAL MARIO CLINIC. THE AL'S
ARMORS ASSOCIATION. BREAST
CANCER CARE CENTERS HOMELESS
SHELTERS WOMEN SHELTERS REFUGEE
HUMANITARIAN CENTERS. IMMIGRANT
LEGAL SERVICES FOOD BANKS
PLANNED PARENTHOOD ROTARY. AND
A BIG CONCERN OF MINE. IS
RABBIS. TO PERFORM BABY NAME IS
OF COURSE AND BRACES. I ASSET
TO VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT CARVE
OUT FOR THESE VERY IMPORTANT
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS A
PARTNER WITH GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE NEEDED SERVICES FOR THE
CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I REQUEST THAT YOU.
EXCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU CENTER STONE SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SAUDI MOVED TO LADY A
SET NUMBER ELEVEN OF THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NON
DEBATABLE ATTORNEY OBJECTION TO
USING THE PRIOR ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN. SAID
ELEVEN. IS OF THE AMENDMENTS
ARE LAID ON THE TABLE AND
FINALLY I BELIEVE SENATOR JONES.
THANK GOD I'M PRESIDENT CENTER
GROVE HAS AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE SET TWELVE THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT SENATOR EXCUSE
ME SET MISTER SECTOR PLEASE
READ. SEPT TWELFTH. AMENDMENTS
BY SENATOR JONES SAID TWELVE
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES ONLY
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PER SHEET THAT I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT THEIR MEMBERS
TO EIGHTY FIVE. EARLIER TODAY
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS ATTEMPTED
TO EVEN THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
ALL INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
THEN THIS BODY IGNORED THE
PLEAS FROM HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES THE DESIGN INDUSTRY
INCLUDING LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS.
GEOLOGISTS GEOPHYSICISTS THEN
VETERINARIANS ACCOUNTANTS
LANDIS SURVEYORS FRANCHISE
DOORS AND FRANCHISEES PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS INTERPRETERS AND
TRANSLATORS. NEWSPAPER CARRIERS
AND DISTRIBUTORS TRUCK OWNER
OPERATORS FORCED ENGINEERS AND
LICENSE TIMBER OPERATORS. NOW I
BRING BEFORE THE SENATE AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD HELP WITH
THOSE DEAL WITH THE REPUTATIONS
OF THIS BILL THAT YOU'VE AGREED
TO KEEP IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
THIS AMENDMENT AB FIVE WOULD
DELAY THE EFFECTS OF THE
DYNAMICS DECISION FOR TWO
YEARS. SO WE CAN GIVE THOSE WHO
REFUSED TO HELP TIME TO PREPARE
FOR THE IMPACT OF THIS IS OF
THE DECISION. IT WILL ALSO HELP
PREPARE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CREATE FURTHER SOLUTIONS TO
THIS DECISION WATCH OUR BODY
HAS ADMITTED WILL COME IN THE
NEXT SESSION. THIS IS A
COMPROMISE THAT WE SHOULD ALL
AGREE IS ONLY FAIR THAT THIS
BODY IS GOING TO PICK WINNERS
AND LOSERS THEY SHOULD ALSO
HELP THOSE WHO ARE HURTING TO
BE ABLE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SUCH LAWS. I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE
MINUTES SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MOVED TO
A LADY I BELIEVE THE FINAL THIS
NUMBER TWELVE SET OF AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE. NON DEBATABLE
ATTORNEY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTE IN THE PRIOR ROLL
CALL SEEING NONE ICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE. AT THIS POINT. IN TIME
SENATOR DRAWS SO. THESE PRESENT
EXCUSE ME HAVE YOU PRESENTED
YOUR BILLING CHIEF AT THIS
POINT THERE THAN WE ARE OPEN
NOW FOR DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
ON THE BILL IN CHIEF. STARTING
WITH SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU
ARE MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED THE AUTHOR
LEADERSHIP THAT UP PUTTING SO
MUCH TIME TO. THE BILL THAT'S
BEFORE US TODAY BUT- I IN ALL
HONESTY I DO SO RELUCTANTLY.
UNLIKE WHAT MANY OF YOU HAVE
HEARD THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
CHANGING THE LAWS. IT GOVERN
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
EMPLOYERS IN THEIR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. HI THAT WAS DONE
BY THE DYNAMICS DECISION. MORE
THAN A YEAR AGO. WHAT THIS BILL
DOES FOR THE MOST PART. IS
GRANT EXEMPTIONS TO THAT COURT
DECISION. BUT IN MY VIEW THE
BILL GOES ABOUT THIS TASK IN
THE WRONG WAY. WE SHOULD BE
WRITING SMART BROAD BASE RULES.
THAT PROTECT CALIFORNIA WORKERS
FROM EXPLOITATION. FOR GIVING
PEOPLE THE FREEDOM TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN HOURS PAY. AND WORK
PRODUCT IF THEY WISH TO DO SO.
WE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING
INNOVATION AND EMPOWERMENT. NOT
FORCING PEOPLE INTO EMPLOYMENT
ARRANGEMENTS THAT THEY DO NOT
WANT. THE RATHER THAN OFFERING
SENSIBLE RULES THIS BILL
PROVIDES A LIST OF SPECIFIC
JOBS AND PROFESSIONS THAT ARE
EXEMPT FROM DYNAMAX. THEY ARE
THE CHOSEN FEW. WE HAVE DECIDED
THAT THEY GET TO CONTROL THEIR
OWN FATE. THE DOCTORS AND
LAWYERS AND ACCOUNTANTS ARE
EXEMPT. BUT PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
ARE NOT. TUTORS TO TEACH THEIR
OWN CURRICULUM OUR EXAM THE
TUTORS TO HELP STUDENTS MASTER
OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CURRICULUM.
ARE NOT. FULL CLEANERS DOG
GROOMERS AND PICTURE HANGERS
YOU GET THEIR JOBS THE
REFERRALS ARE EXAM. BUT HOUSE
PAINTERS ARE PLUMBERS ARE NOT.
INDEPENDENT TRUCKERS WHO DRIVE
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
OUR EXAMS. BUT THE SAME DRIVERS
TO HAUL FREIGHT ARE NOT. THIS
LAST ISSUE IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ONE. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDEPENDENT TRUCKERS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS. OR BORROWED AGAINST
THEIR FUTURES THE BY HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS AND EQUIP THEM WITH
ENGINE CERTIFIED AS CLEAN BY
OUR AIR QUALITY REGULATORS.
HE'S TRUCKERS DECIDE WHEN THEY
WANT TO WORK. HOW MUCH THEY
CHARGE AND WHERE THEY GO. THEY
ARE INDEPENDENT BUSINESS OWNERS.
BUT BY DENYING THEM AN
EXEMPTION IN THIS BILL WE ARE
FORCING THEM TO WORK FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE. IT STOPPING
EXPLOITATION WERE THE ONLY
ISSUE HERE. INSTRUCTORS. WHO
ARE BEGGING FOR THE FREEDOM TO
MANAGE THEIR OWN AFFAIRS WHICH
SURELY QUALIFY FOR AN EXEMPTION.
THESE ARE SELF MADE BUSINESS
OWNERS. MANY OF THEM IMMIGRANTS
USING THEIR BUSINESS TO MOVE UP
THE ECONOMIC LADDER. DENYING
THEM AN EXEMPTION FROM DYNAMAX
WILL CAUSE MAY DISTRICT
DISRUPTION TO THEIR LIVES AND
TO OUR ECONOMY. AND I PROJECT
WILL BACK WILL BE BACK HERE
DEALING WITH THESE CONSEQUENCES
NEXT YEAR. WE WILL ALSO BE
FIELDING COUNTLESS REQUESTS
FROM OTHER INDIVIDUALS AND
GROUPS. WHO WERE NOT SAVVY
ENOUGH TO HIRE A LOBBYIST TO
WIN AN EXEMPTION IN THIS BILL.
AND FOR YEARS INTO THE FUTURE.
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO CREATE A
SERVICE THAT DOESN'T EVEN EXIST
TODAY WILL HAVE TO WIN THE
LEGISLATURE'S APPROVAL FIRST.
FOR MANY PEOPLE TO PAY THEM AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. WILL
LIKELY BE BREAKING THE LAW. SO
I SUGGEST WE PASS THIS BILL
TODAY TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN LUCKY
ENOUGH TO WIN AN EXEMPTION TO
THE DYNAMICS RULING. WITH THE
PROVISION IN THIS BILL. BUT OUR
WORK DOES NOT END WITH THIS
VOTE. IN MY VIEW IT'S ONLY THE
BEGINNING. YOU MUST RETURN IN
JANUARY AND CONSIDER A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE. BALANCE REFORMS.
THAT PROTECT WORKERS FROM
ABUSE. WITHOUT PICKING AND
CHOOSING WHICH CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE ALLOWED TO WORK FOR
THEMSELVES. AND WHICH WILL BE
FORCED TO WORK FOR THE MAN.
WITH THAT RIGHT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE AB FIVE IS
ABOUT STRIKING A BALANCE
BETWEEN PROTECTING WORKERS WHO
NEEDED AND PROTECTING
LEGITIMATE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
IT'S ABOUT TIME. AND HONEST
BUSINESS CANNOT COMPETE WITH
BUSINESSES THAT DON'T PAY
MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS
COMPENSATION OR PAYROLL TAXES
THE VAST MAJORITY OF BUSINESS
OPERATE ON AND EMPLOYMENT MODEL
NOT ONLY PAID WORKERS BUT ALSO
CONTRIBUTED TO THE STATE AND
FEDERAL SAFETY NET THAT WE ALL
ENJOY EVERY DAY. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
DON'T HAVE EXPENSIVE LAWYERS TO
ADVISE HIM ON HOW TO SKIRT THE
LAW OR DEFEND AGAINST LAWSUITS
THEY NEED CLEAR RULES AND
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT TO ENSURE
A LEVEL OF PLAYING FIELD.
DYNAMAX AB FIVE PROVIDE A CLEAR
OBJECTIVE STANDARD. AS A
REALTOR AND THOSE IN THE REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY WE'RE SO PROUD
IS WHAT HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED
HERE I WAS CONCERNED THE
DYNAMICS WOULD IMPACT THE
INDUSTRY IN THE WHOLE BUT THE
AUTHOR WORK WITH US AND THOSE
IN THE INDUSTRY TO RECOGNIZE
THAT REALTORS AND PEOPLE LIKE
REALTORS HAVE A UNIQUE
STRUCTURE AND LEGAL FRAMEWORK.
THEY DID THE SAME FOR MANY MANY
OTHER CONSTITUENTS WHO WORK AT
DIRECT SELLERS LIKE MARY KAY
AND MANY MANY OTHERS. LET
PROVIDE CLARITY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT CONTRACT FOR
HR. PAYROLL AND OTHER SERVICES
LET PROTECT DOCTORS ENGINEERS
THAT PROTECT THE REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY AND THOSE WHO WORK
EVERY SINGLE DAY TO SERVE AND
REPRESENT US. LET'S ALSO
PROTECT THE WORKERS. AS WE
COMPLETED LABOR DAY LET'S GO
AHEAD AND HONOR AB FIVE BECAUSE
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT'S DOING
HONORING LABOR I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
ARCHULETA SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM PRESIDENT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR VERSUS
COMMON LAW EMPLOYEE WE'VE BEEN
FIGHTING THIS ISSUE FOR DECADES
MORE THAN THREE I CAN STILL
REMEMBER THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO
OR SO I WROTE AN ARTICLE ONE OF
MY FIRST. THERE WAS PUBLISHED
IN A NATIONAL PUBLICATION ON
THE VERY SUBJECT ARE OUR CLERGY
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS OR THEY
COMMON LAW PLEASE OF THEIR
CONGREGATIONS OR SYNAGOGUES.
AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT THEY ARE
EMPLOYEES AND SHOULD BE
RECEIVING A FORM W. TWO. BUT
THE IRS IS HAD CRITERIA FOR A
LONG TIME ON WHETHER YOU'RE
INDEPENDENT OR IF YOUR COMMON
LAW. AND THE MAJOR FACTORS
ALWAYS BEEN WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE FIGHT GO
WITH HELD WHICH WAS THE MAIN
REASON FOR SO MANY TRYING TO
MAKE PEOPLE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. BUT AB FIVE. AND
DYNAMAX. STARTS TO GET INTO AN
INTERESTING AREA. IT PICKS
WINNERS AND LOSERS WHEN IT
SHOULD BE PROVIDING A FRAMEWORK
ON HOW YOU ARE DETERMINED TO BE
A COMMON LAW EMPLOYEE OR AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. SO NOW
WERE WERE BRAGGING ABOUT
EXEMPTIONS. SELECTING
INDUSTRIES IS NOT AN
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION. IF YOU
WANT TO BE A FULL TIME. UBER
DRIVER OR A LIFT DRIVER AT AND
THEN YOU KNOW WE HAVE TAXI
COMPANIES THAT YOU'RE YOU ARE
NOW IT TAXI DRIVERS AND THEY
ARE EMPLOYEE. HI A RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE NO VOTE ON AB FIVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORALE YES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I DO
RAISE TODAY AND HIGH OPPOSITION
AB FIVE YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S
A SAYING I SAID A ONE TIME ON
THE FLOOR VOTE FOR THAT. THE
DUTY THE LEGISLATURE. YES TO
GIVE OPPORTUNITY FOR ON
FAVORITISM TOWARDS NOT. WE
CANNOT CLAIM THIS AT ALL ON
THIS BILL THIS DOES GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS PICKING WINNERS AND
LOSERS AND WHAT'S DIFFICULT
ABOUT THAT IS WE CUT THE LEGS
OUT RIGHT FROM UNDER THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER WHO IS TRYING TO
GET STARTED. IT'S INTERESTING
THAT BILL GATES APPLE DELL
COMPUTER EVEN WHILE THIS AND HE
STARTED OUT OF THEIR GARAGE
MOST BUSINESSES START ON A
SHOESTRING AND THEN YOU.
HOPEFULLY GROW AND IF YOU
SUCCEED. WHICH 85% OF SMALL
BUSINESSES I'VE READ DOWN. WELL
THEN YOU KNEW YOUR BUSINESS
GROWS AND YOU START ADDING
POLICE BUT YOU KNOW IN THIS
STATE A CEO MAGAZINE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS IN A ROW EACH
YEAR THEY SEND OUT A- THE
QUESTIONNAIRE TO SOME OF THE
TOP FIVE HUNDRED CEOS IN. AND
AGAIN THIS YEAR CALIFORNIA FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS IN A ROW IS
RATED THE MOST HOUSE STYLE
PLACE TO DO BUSINESS AND THIS
IS AGAIN JUST GONNA BE. ANOTHER
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT AND X. THE
STENCH OF THREAT. TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND I THINK THE
THING IS ONE WHEN I. MY ITEM
THAT I HAD MY MA'AM AND I
BROUGHT FOR WERE WHICH WAS FOR
PHYSICAL THERAPIST YOU KNOW.
SOME NURSING HOMES DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO HIRE FULL TIME.
PHYSICAL THERAPIST SO MANY OF
THESE THERAPISTS WORK FOR
DIFFERENT FACILITIES AS WELL AS
A DOZEN DIFFERENT DOCTORS AS
WELL AS A HANDFUL HOSPITALS.
AND SO DO YOU RECOGNIZE AND SEE
HOW DIFFICULT THAT IS FOR THEM
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO TO
THOSE DOZEN DOCTORS THOSE
COUPLE HOSPITAL CELLS. SENIOR
NURSING HOMES AND ASK TO BE PUT
ON THEIR PAYROLL LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN IS GOING TO BE
COMPLICATED I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT SAME WITH THE
TRUCKERS IT WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE. SOME OF THESE
INDEPENDENT TRUCKERS WORK FOR.
KERRY FREIGHT FOR TWENTY
DIFFERENT COMPANIES SO IMAGINE
THE HOW COMPLICATED THE
SITUATION THAT IS SO AGAIN. YOU
KNOW IT THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
ASSAULT ON THE FREE MARKET. IN
AGAIN I A IT IS A SLOUCH TORSO
TOOK SOCIALISM WHEN GOVERNMENT
CONTROLS. WITH BUSINESS STATUS
SO WITH THAT. I'M A NO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THAK YOU I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE AND
UNFORTUNATELY I KNOW THIS ISSUE
ALL TOO WELL AS THE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER OF LONG BEACH
APPOINTED CHAIR TO THE HARBOR
IN THAILAND'S COMMITTEE WITH
THE LARGEST PORT IN MY BACKYARD
BOTH IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
PORT OF LA AND LONG BEACH WITH
THOUSANDS OF TRUCK DRIVERS ARE
EMPLOYED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
TO BE EXACT IN TOTAL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
80% ARM IT'S CLASSIFIED.
THEY'RE FORCED TO FINANCE THEIR
TRUCKS WITH ONE COMPANY PAY OUT
OF POCKET FOR LEASE FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE AND ADDITIONAL
OPERATING EXPENSES AS WELL AS
ASSUME LEGAL RISKS THIS IS
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING WHEN OUR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PORTS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS A RECORD
NUMBERS OF CARGO AND THE DRY
IT'S COMPANIES PULLED REVENUE
UPWARDS OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS
YET OVER FOUR HUNDRED TRUCKING
COMPANIES AT THE PORT HAD BEEN
CITED WITH MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN JUDGMENTS FAVORING TRUCKERS.
USA TODAY PUBLISHED ARTICLES
ABOUT THIS LITIGATION'S ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LA
CONTINUED. ON BEHALF OF THE
TRUCKERS AND IT MANY OF THESE
TRUCKERS WERE EXPECTED TO WORK
OVER TWENTY HOURS A DAY.
REASSIGNED TO THE LOWEST PAYING
GROUPS MANY OF THESE ROUTES
WHICH OFTEN TRANSLATED INTO
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS. OR LESS
FOR OVER ONE HUNDRED HOURS OF
WORK WHICH RESULTS AT THREE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. BUT LET'S BE
CLEAR DYNAMICS IN AB FIVE DOES
NOT FORCE OWNER OPERATORS TO
BECOME EMPLOYEES IF THEY ARE
NOT BEING MISCLASSIFIED. SIMPLY
EMPOWERS INDEPENDENT OWNERS
OWNER OPERATORS BY REMOVING THE
MIDDLE MAN OR BROKER AND ALLOWS
DRIVERS TO SET THEIR OWN RATES
WHICH IS THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE.
CONSTRUCTION TRUCKING ALSO HAS
A VERY LIMITED EXEMPTION THAT
RECOGNIZES THE PATTERN OF
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTORS WE
HAVE SOME EMPLOYEE DRIVERS AND
OCCASIONALLY HIGHER INDEPENDENT
OWNER OPERATORS. THE AUTHOR IN
THE SPONSORS OF AB FIVE ARE
ALSO COMMITTED TO PROVIDING THE
SMALL TRUCKING COMPANIES.
BUSINESSES SUCH AS A TRULY TO
TRULY ACHIEVE INDEPENDENCE BY
PROVIDING THEM WITH ASSISTANCE
TO START THEIR OWN BUSINESSES.
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE THIS INVOLVED
AND ENSURE THAT PEOPLE. IF THEY
ARE MISCLASSIFIED ARMS ARE IF%
THEY ARE TRULY INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THAT THEY HAVE A
DIRECTION TO BE SO AND AS THE
DAUGHTER OF A TRUCK DRIVER WHO
GAVE THIRTY YEARS TO HIS LIFE
MAKING ABOUT ONE IN THE
MORNING. TO BE ABLE TO. PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR MY
BROTHER AND I. PERSONAL TO ME.
BUT I'M ONLY THAT HE WAS ABLE
TO RETIRE. AT THE AGE OF FIFTY
NINE HE'S NOW FISHING. SMOKING
CIGARS HAVING A GREAT TIME
TAKING CARE OF HIS GRANDCHILD.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE- HE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN A UNION AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU. SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATOR NIELSEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN OF THE
SENATE MADAM PRESIDENT. WE WERE.
IN A MANNER WITNESSING THE
DASHING OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA THE
LAND OF FREEDOM THE LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY. EVER SINCE THE
FIRST. PHIL GRAMM'S SETTLED
HERE. ACTUALLY WAY BEFORE THAT.
WHEN THE INDIGENOUS INDIAN
TRIBES FEDERAL THIS LAND. THEY
HAD AMBITION. THEY HAD DREAMS.
UNFETTERED DREAMS OTHER THAN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHICH THEY
HAD TO LIVE IN. LIKE THE
WEATHER. THE ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THEY LIVE WHICH IS CHALLENGING.
BUT AS A NATION. WE'VE GROWN.
BY INSTILLING AND NOURISHING
THE ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT. THE
SPIRIT THE STRIVE TO BETTER
ONESELF. IF THAT MET WORKING
FOR SOMEONE ELSE. WONDERFUL.
BUT CHAU OVER MANY OVER THE
HISTORY OF THIS GREAT LAND.
HAVE A SPIRE AND FOR THEIR OWN
LITTLE PLEASE PIECE IN THE SUN.
PLACE IN THE SUN. THEIR OWN
LITTLE BUSINESS. HOW MANY
WONDERFUL STORIES OF THESE
COURAGEOUS ENTREPRENEURS THESE
DREAMERS. WHO FASHIONED THEIR
DREAM. AND A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEMSELVES FOR
THEIR FAMILIES FOR THE
GENERATIONS. AND FOR TENS
HUNDREDS ZIP THOUSANDS HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS. OF THEIR FELLOW
CITIZENS AMERICANS WHO HAD JOBS.
BECAUSE OF THEM. THE UPWARD
MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THIS GREAT NATION OF FREEDOM.
HAS PROVIDED. HAS NOW. DURING A
BIT OF A SETBACK. THOSE WHO
ASPIRE IN FACT THE SPIRE IS NOT
GOING TO BE MUCH OF AN AMERICAN
WORD ANYMORE AFTER THIS
DECISION. THEN THE ANSWER TO IT
FRANKLY IS NOT. CARVE OUT. IN
FACT IF WE'RE GOING TO DO SOME
CARVING OUT I WOULD HOPE WOULD
SPEND MOST OF ALL OF NEXT YEAR
CARVING EVERYTHING OUT WE COULD
POSSIBLY. CARVE OUT OF THIS.
BAD DECISION. MY POINT AGAIN.
THIS LAND OF OPPORTUNITY. IS
NOW EXPERIENCE A GRAVE SETBACK.
AND THE ASPIRATION IN THE HOPES.
FOR THE FUTURE. OF THOSE WHO
CAME BEFORE US. THOSE OF US NOW
STRIVING. AND THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO COME OUT BEFORE US OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN
CHILDREN. WHO WOULD LIKE TO DO
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE. HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF THEIR OWN PEACE.
BUT THE SUN. AT THE OPPORTUNITY
THIS GREAT NATION PROVIDES. THE
NOW A DARK CLOUD DESCENDS UPON.
THIS CANNOT BE LEFT TO STAND
THIS IS ONE THING ONE DECISION.
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
CHANGED. FOR THE FUTURE AMERICA.
THANK YOU SIR SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS MINUTE TAKE ISSUE WITH
THE CHARACTERIZATION OF THIS
BILL AS THEIR BUREAUCRATS
PICKING AND CHOOSING WINNERS
AND I WANT TO REMIND YOU. THAT
THIS ISSUE DIDN'T START WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IT STARTS IT
STARTED IN THE COURTS. AND IT
STARTED IN THE COURTS. BECAUSE
THE COMPANY DECIDED THAT THEY
WANTED. TO BE GREEDY. AND THEY
DECIDED THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEIR WORK
FORCE. AND THEY TOOK ACTION. TO
DEPRIVE THEM OF THE BENEFITS
THAT ALL WORKERS ARE ENTITLED
TO THE BENEFITS FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION THE BENEFITS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
FOR RETIREMENT AND SICK LEAVE
AND VACATION LEAVE. AND MADE
MISCLASSIFIED THEM ON PURPOSE.
AND THE COURTS WHEN THEY HELD
THEIR HEARING DETERMINED THAT
THIS MISS CLASSIFICATION WAS.
ILLEGAL OR MORE CORRECTLY WAS
NOT APPROPRIATE AND THAT DAY
THIS MISS CLASSIFICATION HURT
THE EMPLOYEES AND SO THEY SET
UP A NEW STANDARD AND THAT NEW
STANDARD IS WHAT WE HAVE TODAY
IF WE DO NOTHING TODAY THAT NEW
STANDARD THE DYNAMIC STANDARD
THAT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED ENDS
UP AFFECTING ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
OF THE DIFFERENT AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PROPOSED. AND SO IS
THIS THE PERFECT SOLUTION NO
IT'S NOT BUT I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF THAT
SHE'S HAD WORKING WITH HER THAT
HAVE GONE AND LISTENED
DILIGENTLY TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
INTEREST GROUPS IN AN ATTEMPT
TO PUT SOMETHING TOGETHER THAT
IS EFFECTIVE THIS YEAR TO BE
ABLE TO HELP INDIVIDUALS
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY NEED TO
BECOME EMPLOYEES OR WHETHER
THEY NEED TO CHANGE THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL IN A DIFFERENT
WAY. SO IS THE BILL FINISHED.
NO IT'S NOT YOU HEARD THE
AUTHOR COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS IN THE
NEXT YEAR BUT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BECAUSE IT'S
BETTER THAN THE DYNAMICS.
DECISION THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US
THAT WE CAN'T CHANGE WE WERE
NOT IN A POSITION TO BE ABLE TO
CHANGETHAT TODAY SO I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER HARD
WORK IN THIS AND TO REMEMBER
THAT WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO DO. IS TO BE TO PROTECT THE
WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED AND THERE'S
MORE WORK TO BE DONE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND FELLOW MEMBERS I.
HAVE BEEN THINKING A LOT ABOUT
THIS BILL. I WANT TO SPEAK TO
SOMEBODY WHO IS A BUSINESS
OWNER. FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE. THE FACT THAT THE
DYNAMAX CORPORATION. WAS A 100%
WRONG IN THE COURTS TO GOT IT
RIGHT THEY WERE EMPLOYEES. AND
A TEN NINETY NINE AND THAT'S
WRONG. BUT THE TRUCKS THEY WERE
DRIVING WERE TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND GVW AND UNDER. THAT
MEANS THAT ANYONE OF YOU IN
THIS BUILDING THAT DOESN'T HAVE
A COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S Là
COMMERCIAL LICENSE CAN DRIVE
THOSE TRUCKS. I HAPPEN TO BE AN
OWNER OF A TRUCKING COMPANY.
AND I BELIEVE I'M THE ONLY ONE
ON THIS FLOOR THAT HAS A CLASS
ONE LICENSE. THE DRIVE EIGHTY
THOUSAND POUND VEHICLE IN
CALIFORNIA I MAY BE WRONG I
STAND CORRECTED IF THERE IS
SOMEBODY THAT HAS ONE. LET ME
TELL YOU WHAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE.
DO YOU HAVE THAT A LICENSE TO
DRIVE THAT TRUCK AND THEN WHAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE TO OWN THAT
TRUCK. YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SEE A
NUMBER. UNDER NINETY FIVE
DOLLARS A YEAR. PERMITTED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YET TO
BE ENROLLED IN A DRUG PROGRAM
YET TO BE TESTED RANDOMLY.
WHATEVER YOUR NUMBERS DRAWN YET
TO BE THE PULL NOTICE PROGRAM
WHICH MEANS IF YOU HAVE A
DRIVER THIS DRIVING YOUR
VEHICLE AND GETS PULLED OVER
YOU'RE NOTIFIED THAT THEY GOT
PULLED OVER AND YOU'RE AWARE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE CHURCH
IN THE TRAFFIC. YOU HAVE TO BE
A BIT INSPECTION WHICH IS
ANOTHER HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS A YEAR AND YOUR BI
ANNUALLY INSPECTED EVERY NINETY
DAYS YOU HAVE TO OF YOUR TRUCKS
BED INSPECTED BY. A COMMERCIAL
OFFICER. IT COST ABOUT SET BACK
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO LICENSE A TRUCK IN A
COST ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS WITH LICENSE AND
INSURANCE TO ENSURE A TRUCK.
THE PEOPLE THAT DRIVE TRUCKS
THAT ARE OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND GVW ARE IN BUSINESS.
FOR REAL. NOW I WANT TO. SHARE
A LITTLE MORE ABOUT. WHAT I'VE
SEEN IN THIS BILL. WE TALKED
ABOUT PICKING WINNERS AND
LOSERS AND WE ARE PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS WE WANT TO
DO THE RIGHT THING FOR.
BUSINESS PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
BUSINESS WE WOULD EXEMPT
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS. THAT'S
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN HERE. I
GOT INVOLVED IN AS MANY YOU
KNOW I'M A FARMER. MY FAMILY
HOMESTEAD HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I.
HAVE LESS THAN TEN EMPLOYEES
I'VE NEVER HAD ACTUALLY OVER
FIVE THAT I'M AWARE OF. AND
I'VE HEARD OF THE LAST SIX AND
A HALF YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN
THIS LEGISLATURE. JUST RECENTLY
TO THE SENATE BUT YOU KNOW WE
HAD THE MINIMUM WAGE BILL AND I
GOT UP AND SPOKE ABOUT HOW IT'S
GONNA AFFECT MY WORKERS. AND I
HEARD THAT THE MINIMUM WAGE WAS
YOU CAN AFFORD TO RAISE A
FAMILY AND ALL THE MEN WHICH
AND I AGREE HOW 2% BUT THE
MINIMUM WAGE WAS NOT DESIGNED
TO RAISE A FAMILY IT WAS A
STARTING LEVEL WAGE. AND THEN I
HEARD. THAT YOU FARMERS GET THE
AG OVERTIME EXEMPTION HOW. IT
AND THERE WAS A SPEECH ON THE
FLOOR IN THE SEMI THAT REFERRED
TO US AS SLAVE OWNERS. NOW WE
USE THAT AG OVERTIME EXEMPTION
FOR WHEN WE HARVEST AND WE
PLAN. AND YES I WILL SURE
THERE'S PROBABLY SOME. BAD
APPLES OUT THERE THAT ABUSE
THOSE SITUATIONS AND THERE'S
BAD APPLES IN EVERY SINGLE
PROFESSION. BUT THERE ARE
LITERALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO BE IN
BUSINESS AND WANT TO BE THAT
INDEPENDENT. TRUCK DRIVER FOR
THAT. ANESTHESIOLOGIST WHO GOES
FROM HOSPITAL HOSPITAL THAT
PHYSICAL THERAPIST. SO I WAS
THINKING ABOUT. SO MANY BILLS
WHEN I THOUGHT OF THIS BILL AND
I THOUGHT AM I GONNA MAKE AN
IMPACT ON ANY INDIVIDUALS ON
THIS FLOOR. WITH THE SPEECH
FROM MY HEART. I'M NOT LEAVING
CALIFORNIA. I WILL RUN MY
BUSINESS UNTIL THIS BODY OR
THIS LOW POLICY MAKING BODY
RUNS BE OUT OF BUSINESS AND I'M
NOT LEAVING BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE BUSINESS ON
ON THIS FLOOR AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH TO
OPERATE A BUSINESS AND GIVE A
JOB TO. THE MIDDLE CLASS OF
THIS STATE. WE HAVE A PARK
EXEMPTION FOR. UNION
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES BUT NOT
EVERY BODY IN CALIFORNIA GETS A
BUG IS IT BECAUSE THE TRIAL
ATTORNEYS WANT OTHER BILLY TO
GO HAMMER ON OTHER PEOPLE THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE SO WE DO PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS HERE. WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD THAT. TOOK THE TRUCK THAT
I HAVE. AND SAID IT WASN'T.
COULD BE ON THE ROAD CHAPTER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BECAUSE OF AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS. WHEN I
BOUGHT IT MET THE MEETING OF
THE LAW I BELIEVE THAT'S A
TAKING DOWN THE CONSTITUTION
BUT NOT HERE CALIFORNIA. WE CAN
WE CAN WE CONTROL BE FOR THE
BETTER OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR QUALITY.
WE CAN MAKE YOU. RETROFIT YOUR
VEHICLE. WE DID MAKE EVERYBODY
THAT OWNED A CAR RETROFIT
THERE'S BEEN JUST PEOPLE OWNS
TRUCKS. OR CONSTRUCTION
EQUIPMENT. HI PAUL UNDER ALL
THOSE RULES AS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IN CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT THIS SPEECH IS NOT
GONNA CHANGE THE MINDS OF ANY
PERSON ON THIS FLOOR. IS I'VE
GIVEN IT MANY TIMES. SO I
THOUGHT WHAT WHAT WOULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA WHAT
WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE MY STORY
RESIGNATION. WITH THIS BODY AND
THE BODY IN THE OTHER HOUSE.
AND I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING
ELSE TO SAY. BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THIS MAYBE IT'S TIME. THE
DAIRY MEN IS GETTING REGULATED
BY GROUND WATER. THE FARMER THE
TRUCK DRIVER. THE END IS TO
MAYBE WE NEED TO ORGANIZE MAYBE
IT'S TIME THAT. WE ORGANIZE.
YOU KNOW WHAT AND WE AND WE SAY
WE'RE GOING TO NOT GIVE YOU YOU
KNOW GET YOU YOU GET YOUR GLASS
OF MILK AND YOUR LOAF OF BREAD.
WHEN I GET THROUGH THIS. HELLO
THE PERMIT PROCESS TO GIVE IT
TO YOU. MAYBE WE SHOULD
ORGANIZE MAYBE UBER LIFT SHOULD
JUST TURN OFF THEIR- APP. IN
LOTUS DEAL WITHOUT THEIR
SERVICES THAT THEY GIVE. MAYBE
THAT'S A SOLUTION MAYBE WE NEED
TO. BRING A REALITY CHECK TWO
PEOPLE WHO JUST WANT TO PROVIDE
A DECENT JOB PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE FOR CALIFORNIANS. SO FOR
ALL THE THINGS I JUST STATED
MEMBERS I LOVE YOU ALL I'VE
INVITED YOU TO MY DISTRICT I
TRY TO SHARE MY LIFE WITH YOU.
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT WE DO IN
BUSINESS. I'M ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING. NOW
IN THIS ECONOMY TURNS IS GOING
TO BE EVEN WORSE. PLEASE STOP
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS
LET'S DO THE RIGHT THING LET'S
MAKE JUST LAWS. THAT ARE TRYING
TO MAKE A LIVING IN TRYING TO
PROVIDE A JOB FOR INDIVIDUALS.
LET'S NOT GETTING BETWEEN ME
AND MY EMPLOYEES. I DON'T NEED
TO ME I DON'T NEED A BARGAINING
UNIT BETWEEN ME AND MY
EMPLOYEES I LOVE MY PLACE I
WANT THEM TO PUT THEIR KIDS
THROUGH COLLEGE I WANT TO BUY A
HOME I WANT TO LIVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM AS WELL. BUT
THIS BODY. ISN'T AND- THE
POLICIES ARE COMING OUT HERE.
ARE NOT WORKING FOR MY LITTLE
SMALL BUSINESS. SO I PLEAD WITH
YOU. GIVE US SOME GRACE. GIVE
US A BREAK. HIS WERE STRUGGLING
IN IT IS DIFFICULT AND PLEASE
LISTEN TO OUR STORY I URGE NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
LISTING. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
ANY OF YOU BUT SOMETIMES I FIND
MYSELF I CAN FALL DOWN A RABBIT
HOLE. A RELATIVE RECENT RABBIT
HOLE I FEEL DOWN WAS BASED ON
SOMETHING I READ AND IT WAS IN
INTRODUCED ME TO THIS CONCEPT
OF CONFIRMATION BIAS.
CONFIRMATION BIAS CONFIRMATION
BIAS COLLEAGUES. IS WHEN YOU'RE
DRAWN TO DETAILS THAT CAN FOR
CONFIRM YOUR OWN EXISTING
BELIEF. CONFIRMATION BIAS AM I
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT I QUITE
FRANKLY THOUGHT ABOUT ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HERE AND HOW WILL WE
STAND UP AND TAKE THE MY. OUR
MESSAGES ARE SPEECHES ARE QUITE
FRANKLY VERY PREDICTABLE.
BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL SUFFER
FROM CONFIRMATION BIAS. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA
FEED. OF WHAT COMES ON YOUR
FEET. THE SOCIAL MEDIA FOLKS TO
FIGURE IT OUT YOU I GET
ARTICLES THAT CONFIRM TYPICALLY
WHAT I ALREADY BELIEVE. SO
RARELY ARE WE CHALLENGED TO
STEP OUTSIDE OF OUR OWN LIFE-EXPERIENCE OUR OWN COURSE SET
OF BELIEFS HOWEVER THERE WAS
DOUBTLESS THE THINK DIFFERENTLY.
WELL THE RESULT I'M WORKING
VERY HARD. TO PUSH OUTSIDE MY
OWN COMFORT ZONE MY OWN LIFE
EXPERIENCE TO BREAK THROUGH
THIS CONFIRMATION BIAS. AS A
RESULT. I CONSCIOUSLY CHOSE TO
WATCH A NEW DOCUMENTARY THIS
WEEKEND. BY THE OBAMA
FOUNDATION THEIR NEW FILM
PROJECT CALLED AMERICAN FACTORY.
AND IT IS THE STORY OF A FORMER
AMERICAN AUTO FACTORY IN OHIO.
THAT CLOSES IN A NEW BUSINESS
OPENS. AND THE STORY OF THE
IMPACT OF GLOBALIZATION HAS ON
THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS. WAS
SHOCKING. AND MY TAKE AWAY. WAS
THAT WORKERS ARE AT RISK.
WORKERS ARE AT RISK BE IT
AUTOMATION BE A GLOBAL OF
GLOBALIZATION. OUR LIFE
EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF WHAT
WORK LOOKS LIKE AND WHO DOES
WORK AND WHAT WORKERS CAN
EXPECT. COULD VERY WELL BE
CHANGING BEFORE OUR VERY EYES.
AS A FORMER EMPLOYER. OF AT ONE
TIME FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AS
A NONPROFIT LEADER I
EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND. THE
PROCESS THAT THE FLOOR JACQUI
TALKED ABOUT BY WHICH A
EMPLOYER RESPONSIBLY CLASSIFIES
EMPLOYEES THERE ARE CLEAR
GUIDELINES. PEOPLE CAN
SOMETIMES DECIDE TO BE CONFUSED
ABOUT THEM BUT IT'S NOT ROCKET
SCIENCE THEIR CLEAR GUIDELINES
AS AN EMPLOYER BY WHICH YOU
CLASSIFY EMPLOYEES. I'M FINE
AND OF MY COLLEAGUES SAID
MOMENTS AGO THE DECISION QUITE
FRANKLY COLLEAGUES HAS BEEN
MADE DYNAMAX IS THE LAW OF THE
LAND. AND THIS BILL FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS GOOD NEWS.
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES PROTECTIONS
AS APPROPRIATE. REPEATEDLY ARE
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE REFERENCE TO
THE NOTION OF PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS IT'S A PHRASE WE USE
OFTEN HERE. I HAVE TO ADMIT.
THE MULTIPLE SETS OF AMENDMENTS
THAT I HEARD READ THAT WERE
LAYING ON THE TABLE DID THE
SAME THING. IT WAS THE POLLS
ALL TO PICK ADDITIONAL WINNERS
AND LOSERS. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP I TIP MY
HAT TO THE AUTHOR AND ALL OF
THOSE WHO WORK TIRELESSLY. TO
THE FLOOR JACQUI TO TAKE THE
MEETINGS TO DO THE HARD WORK OF
FIGURING IT OUT I TIP MY HAT TO
YOU AND I'M ALSO CLEAR THAT
THIS. WILL VERY LIKELY NOT BE
THE LAST TIME WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION ON THE FLOOR.
THERE WILL BE MORE WORK TO DO.
THAT COLLEAGUES HOWEVER SHOULD
NOT STOP US. FROM DOING THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT'S IN FRONT
OF US TODAY WHICH IS TO CAST A
VOTE IN SUPPORT. OF AB FIVE.
WHICH I'LL BE PROUD TO DO AT
THE APPOINTED TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I WASN'T BORN INTO
A WEALTHY FAMILY I WAS BORN.
TWO TWO WONDERFUL PARENTS BLUE
COLLAR WORKERS MY DAD WAS A.
SPREE PAINTER HAD A BUSINESS IN
LOS ANGELES. PRESTIGE
COMMERCIAL REFINISHING WAS
NEVER A BUSINESS AT WHAT MADE
MY DATA A MILLIONAIRE. HOW MY
MOM WAS A DENTAL ASSISTANT WORK
TWO NIGHTS A WEEK. REMEMBER MY
DAD USED TO LEAVE A CHECK FOR
MY MOM EVERY WEEK FOR TWO
HUNDRED BUCKS. TWO HUNDRED
BUCKS. SHOULD PAY THE HOUSE
PAYMENT SHOULD PAY THE UTILITY
PAYMENTS. SHOULD CLOSE MY
SISTER MYSELF. THEY HAD TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. AND I'LL TELL YOU WE
NEVER TOOK A FAMILY VACATION.
MY ENTIRE LIFE BECAUSE WE CAN
EVER FOR IT. BUT MY SISTER AND
I WERE. SMOTHERED LOVE. AND MY
PARENTS MADE THE COMMITMENT
THAT THEY WOULD DO EVERYTHING
IN THEIR POWER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAD A BETTER LIFE. THEN
THEY DID. EMPLOYEE TODAY. MY
MOM IS A TRAVEL AGENT. WORKED
HER TAIL OFF. PUTTING ME
THROUGH THE USC SCHOOL OF
PHARMACY WHICH IS NOT A CHEAP.
UNIVERSITY TO GO TO LEFT ME
WITH NO DEBT. MY DAD COULD MAKE
ANY CONTRIBUTIONS BECAUSE HE
BARELY KEPT THE FOOD ON THE
TABLE. MY MONEY RAN OUT WHEN I
WENT TO YOU SEE I AS AN
UNDERGRADUATE AND- CALL MY
GRAMMA. FASTER IF I COULD LIVE
WITH HER LOS ANGELES I COULD
TRANSFER TO UCLA TO THE COULD
AFFORD THE HOUSING ON CAMPUS.
AND SHE SAID YES. MY
GRANDFATHER HAD JUST PASSED
AWAY SEVEN YEARS BEFORE. HE WAS
AN IMMIGRANT IN THIS COUNTRY
FROM RUSSIA. SEOUL CHOOSE. WORK
FOR MULTIPLE SHOE STORES TO
SAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO OPEN HIS
OWN SHOE STORE. OPENED EDWARDS
FAMOUS BRAND SHOES. AND IT WAS
NOW THE SANTA MONICA PROMENADE
I'D. AND ARE NEVER FORGET GOING
TO WORK WITH MY GRANDPA ON
SATURDAYS WE CAN AFFORD TO GO
A- SEGMENT ON THE GRAMMA
GRANDPA'S HOUSE ON THE WEEKENDS
AND- MY GRANDFATHER TAKE ME TO
LUNCH I CAN'T TELL YOU THE
THRILLED THAT I GOT TO BE WITH
THAT MAN. WHO TAUGHT ME. ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF GOING TO
SCHOOL IN THE IMPORTANCE OF.
GETTING AN EDUCATION. AS I WENT
THROUGH. MY DOORS AT MY
GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE AS I WAS
MOVING AND I WAS GOING TO DOORS
AND I SAW HERE BRUSH AND HAD MY
GRANDFATHER'S HERE'S A GRAMMAR
WOULD YOU SUPPORT BUT TO KEEP
THIS FOR GRANDPA'S BEEN DEAD
FOR SEVEN YEARS AGO AS WELL AS
SUCH SENTIMENTAL BUT- IT'S TIME
TO GET RID OF IT. AND THEN AS I
WENT TO THE DOOR TO EMPTY. MY
TOILETRIES AND I FOUND HIS
FALSE TEETH. AS A GRAMMAR
REALLY HAVING FALSE TEETH IT'S
TIME. THROUGH THE TRASH CANCERS
A GET RID OF IT. BUT AS I. PUT
THE TEETH INTO THE TRASH CAN I
KIND OF SAW A BRIGHT SHEEN. AND
I TURN THE TEETH OVER AND IT
WAS A SOLID GOLD BRIDGE. THE MY
GRANDFATHER HAD IT IS FALSE
TEETH AND I SAID TO MY
GRANDMOTHER SAID YOU KNOW I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THAT IF YOU
DON'T MIND I GOT A FRIEND
THAT'S A JEWELER THAT I COULD
HAVE A MELTED DOWN. BECAUSE MY
GRANDFATHER TAUGHT ME SUCH
GREAT LESSONS ABOUT LIFE AND
BUSINESS THAT. I LIKE TO WEAR
IT AROUND MY NECK AND. AND HAVE
MY GRAMPA AT IT WITH ME ALL THE
TIME. MY FRIENDS. I HAVE A GOLD
NUGGET AROUND MY NECK. MY
GRANDFATHER CAME FROM NOTHING.
MADE SOMETHING OUT OF HIMSELF.
I GOT THE PHARMACY SCHOOL AND I
WANTED TO FOLLOW MY
GRANDFATHER'S. OF COMMENDATIONS.
SO I GRADUATED PHARMACY SCHOOL
I DID WORK ONE JOB. BUT
ENDEAVOR TO JOBS. I DO WORK
THREE JOBS I WORK FOR JOBS. AND
I GOT A W. TWO FOR ONE. AND I
WAS AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
FOR THREE. AND I SAVED UP
ENOUGH MONEY. THE BY FIXTURES.
FROM PHARMACIES THAT WENT OUT
OF BUSINESS THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER
STORE CALLED GEMCO. OR TO A
STORE CALLED FRANCO. I WANTED
TO OPEN A CHAIN OF PHARMACIES
AND I BOUGHT STORES FIXTURES
AND STORE THEM IN. STORAGE
INTEL I GUESS SAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO OPEN MY FIRST PHARMACY. MY
FIRST PHARMACY WAS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE. I AM VERY PROUD
TO SAY THAT I'VE BEEN THE PROUD
OWNER OF SIX PHARMACIES AND
I'VE DONE WELL. AND I'M VERY
PROUD THAT I'VE DONE WELL. I
FEEL LIKE I'VE A CHI THE
AMERICAN DREAM. AND LIKE MY
PARENTS WANTED ME TO HAVE A
BETTER GENERATION FOR MYSELF. I
WANT MY CHILDREN HAVE A BETTER
GENERATION. THEN I HAD. WHY AM
I BRINGING ALL THIS UP. IS
BECAUSE THERE NEEDS TO BE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE SEEING
THE SICK THESE THESE
ENTREPRENEURIAL OPPORTUNITIES
DISAPPEAR RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A SUPREME
COURT DECISION NINE TO STAND
THAT WE NEED TO. DO WE CAN TO
COMPLY. BUT MY FRIENDS WE ARE
THE LAWMAKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT IS THE LAWS THAT
WE MAKE ON THE SENATE FLOOR
THAT ARE INTERPRETED BY THE
COURTS OF THIS LAND. AND WHILE
MANY OF YOU HAVE SAID THAT THIS
IS NOT ABOUT PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS. I HAVE TO STRONGLY
DISAGREE. BUT I THINK WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW I'VE. MARKED UNIONS
OVER THE PAST WEEK AND.
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE INFLUENCE
THAT LABOR HAS OVER. OUR
DECISIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT TWO OF THE PHARMACIES THAT
I OWNED. HI UNIONIZED. I MADE
THEM UNION PHARMACIES. BECAUSE
I WAS TREATED VERY WELL AS A
UNION PHARMACIST THE WORK FOR
THRIFTY DRUG NOW WRITING THE
WORK FOR GEN COLIN I WORK FOR
THEM AS A EMPLOYEE I GOT GREAT
BENEFITS SO I GOT GREAT WAGES
AND I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
I HAD GREAT PEOPLE WORKING FOR
ME THAT WERE. THAT WERE WELL
TREATED. BUT MY FRIENDS. THIS
BILL. IS THE UNION CAUCUSES
MAIN EVENT OF THE YEAR. WE'VE
ALL HEARD THE PROTESTS. WE ALL
OF SEEING THE HORRIBLE EFFECTS
OF PASSING THIS BILL. WILL HAVE
ON THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. BY
BASICALLY ENDING THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR MODEL
FOR HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
TELLING FAMILIES YOU CAN NO
LONGER WORK ON YOUR TERMS. AND
YOUR CONDITIONS. THE STATISTICS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MY
FRIENDS ARE NOT GOOD. THE U. S.
CENSUS. DATA. US CENSUS CAME
OUT TODAY WITH DATA SHOWING
THAT. WE HAVE EIGHTEEN POINT 2%
POVERTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE IN SIX PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LIVE IN
POVERTY. GUESS WHAT. WERE
SECOND ONLY TO WASHINGTON DC IT
HAS TWO TENTHS OF A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF POVERTY THAN WE
DO. MY FRIENDS WERE NOT DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I'VE ALWAYS
BELIEVED IN THE TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN OFFICE
SO WE NEED TO TAKE AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL APPROACH TO
RUNNING GOVERNMENT. MORE
REGULATIONS ISN'T ALWAYS GOOD.
WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR WORKERS
WHO WANT TO PROTECT PEOPLE
WORKING IN THE WORKING
ENVIRONMENTS BUT UNFORTUNATELY
I HAVE STRONG CONCERNS EVEN MY
COMPOUNDING BUSINESS IT AS THE
REGULATIONS GET TOUGHER AND
TOUGHER. THERE MAY BE A TIME
THAT WE MAY HAVE TO CLOSE OUR
DOORS IN CALIFORNIA. AND WORRY
ABOUT ACCESS FOR PEOPLE TO
TRULY NEED COMPOUND AND
MEDICATIONS. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. I HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PROCESS IF I COULD.
THE QUESTION TO THE FLOOR
TALKING PLEASE. WE'LL ACCEPT
THE QUESTION. I'LL TRY YES.
THANK YOU MY FRIEND FROM FROM
LOS ANGELES AND. I HAVE IN
FRONT OF ME IF I CAN DISPLAY
THIS IT'S A. AB FIVE FOUR
EXEMPTION REQUEST FORM IT WAS
DOWNLOADED. CAL MATTERS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
FORM GIVEN TO GROUPS SEEKING
EXEMPTIONS. I LOVE I CAN BRING
IT TO YOUR FOR YOU CAN SEE IT
TODAY. DOES THAT SOUND FAMILIAR
TO YOU. HI I HAVEN'T SEEN OKAY.
DO YOU TO HAVE A QUESTION SIR
YES I DO LEASE.WHO THIS
APPLICATION GO TO GARNER THE
EXEMPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN SO
GRANTED UNDER THIS BILL. OKAY.
WHO EVALUATED THE POTENTIAL TO
GET AN EXEMPTION. I DON'T KNOW
ALL THOSE DETAILS BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
AUTOMATICALLY WHISPER TO THE TO
AUTHOR. IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION THERE'S
YOU'RE NOT UNDER OATH AND
YOU'RE NOT IN A COURT OF LAW
THE QUESTION ASKS YOU IF YOU
KNOW IF YOU DON'T. OKAY WELL I
DO KNOW THE ANSWER BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY IT SAYS ON THE
BOTTOM LEFT HAND CORNER OF THE
FORM. THE AFL CIO SO. I CAN
ONLY OPINED THAT. THESE
APPLICATIONS WERE REVIEWED BY A
LABOR UNION. NOT NECESSARILY
EARLY BY THE AUTHOR TO DELIVER
THESE EXEMPTIONS. I MEAN DO YOU
THINK. IF THE LABOR UNIONS ARE
REALLY GONNA PICK WHO'S GETTING
EXEMPTIONS WAS NOT GETTING
EXEMPTIONS A LEASE WOULD TAKE
HER NAME OFF THE APPLICATION
FORM. BUT IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF TRANSPARENCY I GUESS IT'S
GOOD THAT WE KNOW. I HAVEN'T
BEEN. IN THE STATE CAPITALS
LONG AS MANY OF YOU BUT I HAVE
TO TELL YOU. I FIND IT VERY
OFFENSIVE. THAT THE AUTHORS
OFFICES TURN THIS BILL INTO A
CHRISTMAS TREE FOR LABOR
UNIONS. THAT MIGHT AS WELL HAVE
AN OFFICE RIGHT HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL. I MIGHT BE NAIVE
BUT I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
INAPPROPRIATE TO HAVE DOCUMENTS
HANDED OUT TO PEOPLE REQUESTING
AN EXEMPTION. FOR AB FIVE THAT
ARE PLAINLY PREPARED BY
ORGANIZED LABOR THE AFL CIO TO
BE SPECIFIC. BUT EVEN THOUGH
THE PROCESS THE GODDESS HERE
STINKS. I THINK THE BILL ITSELF
IS FATALLY FLAWED. AB FIVE WILL
MEAN THE END OF THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR STATUS FOR HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
SUPPORTERS WILL ARGUE THAT THIS
BILL PROTECTS WORKERS. BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE FRANCHISE OWNERS WHO
LOSE THEIR FRANCHISES AND THEN
HAVE TO FIRE THE WORKERS WHO
DEPEND ON THEIR JOBS TO FEED
THEIR FAMILIES. BUT WHAT THE
MAN OR THE WOMAN WHO WORKS A
FEW HOURS ON THE WEEKEND FOR
UBER LEFT OR DOOR DASH TO MAKE
A FEW BUCKS ON THE SIDE TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. I HAVE TENANTS THAT
WORK FOR UBER LEFT. A COUPLE OF
THE MAKE OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT'S THEY DO A GREAT JOB OF
SUPPORTING THEIR FAMILIES. THAT
WORK WHEN THEY WANT TO WORK AND
DON'T WORK WHEN THEY DON'T WANT
TO WORK. IT'S BEEN A GREAT
GREAT MODEL FOR SINGLE MOMS.
FOR SINGLE DADS. FOR PEOPLE THE
NEED TO MAKE A FEW EXTRA BUCKS
SO THEY CAN FEED THEIR KIDS PUT
THE KIDS IN POP WARNER FOOTBALL
LITTLE LEAGUE BASEBALL. OR WHAT
ABOUT THE TRUCKER WE'VE HEARD
SO MUCH ABOUT TODAY. WHO SPEND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO BUY THEIR OWN TRUCK.
SO THEY COULD DECIDE WHAT LOADS
TO HAUL IT WOULD JOBS TO TAKE.
IF THIS BILL GOES THROUGH. AND
THEY HAVE TO BECOME EMPLOYEES
OF LARGE TRUCKING COMPANIES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO GET FOR THEIR TRUCKS. IF
YOU'RE GONNA GET TOP VALUE FOR
IT. WE'LL BE LUCKY IF THEY CAN
SELL THE TRUCKS FOR WITH A. BY
REQUIRING THESE PEOPLE TO
BECOME EMPLOYEES THEY WILL
BECOME. LIKELY. FORMER
EMPLOYEES THE AUTHOR AND
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL SAY
THEY'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
PEOPLE FROM BEING EXPLOITED.
SUPPORTERS ARE CLAIMING TO BE
FIGHTING FOR PEOPLE THAT. MAKE
THE LEAST THE MINIMUM WAGE WELL
MY FRIENDS LET ME BE CLEAR. IN
THIS CASE THE MINIMUM WAGE IS
NOT TEN DOLLARS AN HOUR IT'S
NOT FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
IT'S ZERO. THAT'S RIGHT BECAUSE
A PERSON WITHOUT A JOB MAKES
ZERO. AND WILL BE MANY JOBS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE LOST. WITH
YOUR BROAD BRUSH FIVE VOTE. ON
AB FIVE. JUST CONSIDER A FEW OF
THE PEOPLE WILL BE HARMED BY
THIS BILL GOING INTO EFFECT.
THE TRUCKERS WHO WANT TO DECIDE
WHAT THE HALL WHEN THE HOLIDAY
WILL BE SHUT DOWN UNLESS THEY
WANT TO BECOME EMPLOYEES
SOMETHING. MANY DON'T WANT TO
DO THE SINGLE FATHER WHO WANTS
TO MAKE A FEW EXTRA BUCKS
WORKING NIGHTS AND WEEKENDS
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK FOR A
COMPANY LIKE UBER LIFT BECAUSE
LEAVE BIG LABOR WANTS TO HAVE
BAD BE A MEMBER. OF THE UNION.
PHYSICAL THERAPIST TO HELP
PATIENTS AT REASONABLE RATES
WON'T BE ABLE TO FIND WORK
UNLESS THEY BECOME FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES. OF A HOSPITAL OR A
REHAB CENTER. THEREBY LOSING
THE FLEXIBILITY THE BROUGHT
MANY OF THEM INTO THE
PROFESSION. NOW I DON'T BLAME
THE PEOPLE. WHO FELT FORCED TO
CUT THEIR OWN SPECIAL DEALS.
WITH BIG LABOR AND THIS AUTHOR.
I DON'T BLAME THAT THE
ARCHITECTS GOT THEIR CAR ABOUT
FROM THIS POORLY DESIGNED BILL.
I DON'T BLAME INVESTMENT
ADVISORS WHO MADE SURE THEY
WERE GOING TO BE SUED BY GREEDY
TRIAL LAWYERS LOOKING TO MAKE A
QUICK BUCK. I DON'T FAULT THE
REALTORS. WHO MADE SURE THEY
DIDN'T GET CAUGHT IN THE LABOR
UNIONS SPIDER WEB SPUN BY THE
BLACK WIDOW OF PUBLIC POLICY.
NOR DO I THINK IT'S A BAD THING
THAT THE TWENTY EIGHT OTHER
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS TO PAY
THEIR TOLL TO THE LABOR UNION
BOSSES GOT THE EXEMPTIONS.
ALTHOUGH I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT
COSTS THEM BUT I'M SURE. IT
WASN'T FREE. THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
BUT PERHAPS THE BIGGEST REASON
IS IT OPENS THE DOOR TO
THOUSANDS. THOUSANDS OF
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS TARGETING
BUSINESS OWNERS. AND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN PLAYING BY THE RULES.
HERE'S WHAT I HAVE TO PRESUME
IS THE MAIN REASON FOR THE BILL.
UNDER AB FIVE A DRIVER UBER
WILL BE ABLE TO FILE A LAWSUIT
AGAINST UBER TO COLLECT FOUR
YEARS OF BACK PAY UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE LAW. MANY OF
YOU VOTE FOR TODAY MANY THOSE
DRIVERS WHO MADE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
WORKING FOR THESE COMPANIES.
THIS RETROACTIVE CLAW BACK FOR
WAGES IT ALSO COMES WITH
MASSIVE PENALTIES WILL FORCE.
MANY COMPANIES TO CLOSE
ENTIRELY. THIS BILL OPENS THE
DOOR FOR AGGRESSIVE TRIAL
LAWYERS TO TARGET BUSINESSES
MUCH LIKE. CURRENTLY GOES ON
WITH LAWYERS TARGETING
BUSINESSES WITH FRIVOLOUS ADA
LAWSUITS WERE OPEN THE DOOR TO
A DUPLICATION. OF THIS. DURABLE
FRIVOLOUS FILING OF LAWSUITS TO
GET SMALL BUSINESS PEOPLE THAT
CAN ILL AFFORD TO PAY THE LEGAL
FEES. SO WE ALL KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN THE TRIAL
LAWYERS ARE TO SEE BUSINESS
USING INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
THE TRIAL LAWYERS CALL ONE OF
THE CONTRACTORS IN GETS AND OR
HER TO AGREE TO SOME FREE MONEY
TO FILE A LAWSUIT. THE TRIAL
LAWYER SENDS A DEMAND LETTER TO
THE BUSINESS SAYING A LAWSUIT
IS GONNA BE FILED UNLESS A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT CAN BE
MADE THE TRIAL LAWYER THEN GETS
HALF OF THE SETTLEMENT AND THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR GETS THE
OTHER HALF MINUS THE EXPENSES
OF FINDING A LAWSUIT ANY OTHER
FEES. PAID BY THE TRIAL LAWYER.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO LEARN AT
THESE SHAKEDOWN LAWSUITS
SHOULDN'T BE TOLERATED LET
ALONE BE ENCOURAGED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. AS LONG AS THE BIG
LABOR UNIONS AND TRIAL LAWYERS
KEEP PAYING RENT TO CONTROL
THIS LEGISLATURE I'M GUESSING
THE ANSWER IS NEVER. SO IN
CONCLUSION MADAMS PRESIDENT. AB
FIVE AS A WAY TO FORCE PEOPLE
OUT OF CAREERS THAT THEY LOVE
AND CAREERS AT THE ENJOY IT'S A
WAY TO FORCE PEOPLE INTO LABOR
UNIONS THEY FRANKLY DON'T WANT
TO JOIN. IT'S A WAY TO GIVE
TRIAL LAWYERS NEW TARGETS NOW
THAT THEY'RE RUNNING OUT OF
EIGHTY LAWSUITS TO FILE. IT'S A
WAY TO SEND A MESSAGE THAT
ENTREPRENEURIAL SHIP IN
INNOVATION IS DEAD IN
CALIFORNIA. LABOR UNIONS WHO
OWN THIS LEGISLATURE ARE
DESPERATE TO REPLENISH THEIR
POLITICAL WAR CHEST IN LIGHT OF
THE JANICE DECISION THAT SAID
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO PAY FOR
POLITICAL SPEECH THEY DON'T
AGREE WITH. MOST SHOCKINGLY
THIS BILL MAKES A MOCKERY OF
THIS LEGISLATURE HAVING ONE OF
AMERICA'S BIGGEST LABOR UNIONS
AND TRANSPARENT CONTROL OF
DECIDING WHO GETS EXEMPT FROM
THIS BILL IS FRANKLY. OFFENSIVE
HAVING A ORGANIZED LABOR BOSS
DECIDING WHAT'S BEST 485% OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IS
JUST PLAIN WRONG. SHOULD BE
ABLE TO WORK WHERE THEY WANT
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO WORK
FOR WHO THEY WANT TO PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO LIVE FREE.
AND NOT BE TOLD TO DO SO BY BIG
UNION BOSSES IN SMOKE FILLED
ROOMS. SENATOR STONE LET'S WRAP
IT UP AND STAY ON MESSAGE OR
DIE SHOULDN'T SAY STAY ON
MESSAGE STAY ON THE BILL IF YOU
WOULD SIR. AND LET'S WRAP IT UP
PLEASE FOR THOSE REASONS. I ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
SENATOR LEYVA. MEMBERS BEFORE I
GET INTO THE MEAT OF WHY HAVE
RISEN I WANT TO GIVE DIFFERENCE
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER ND
I THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY WITH US. AND I DID FEEL
WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY THANK YOU.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT I RISE IN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE. I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE ON
THIS FLOOR KNOWS HOW LONG.
LAWYERS HAVE BEEN MISCLASSIFIED
WORKERS FOREVER FOREVER. AND
WHEN WORKERS ARE MISCLASSIFIED
WE ALL SUFFER AND I DON'T KNOW
IF ANYONE KNOWS THE PERCENTAGE
OF WORKERS THAT ARE
MISCLASSIFIED. 70% THAT IS A
HUGE NUMBER A HUGE NUMBER SO
MEMBERS WE CANNOT IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE ALLOW THESE
BUSINESSES WHO MISS CLASSIFY
WORKERS TO CONTINUE TO PASS OUR
OWN BUSINESS COSTS ON TO
TAXPAYERS. AND RESPONSIBLE LAW
ABIDING BUSINESSES COMPANIES
THAT MS CLASSIFY THEIR WORKERS
CALL THEM SMALL BUSINESSES YET
THEY CONTINUE TO SET THE
WORKERS RATES DIRECT TELL THE
WORKER MUST TO THEIR JOB IMPOSE
DISCIPLINE UPON THEM EVEN WHILE
THE WORKERS TO THE MAIN WORK OF
THE BUSINESS. THAT MAKES THEM
AN EMPLOYEE MISS CLASSIFICATION
OF WORKERS AS CONTRACTORS IS A
FORM OF UNFAIR COMPETITION.
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES AND ALL
OF OUR DISTRICTS ARE DIRECTLY
THREATENED BY THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY AND BY COMPETITORS TO
BREAK THE LAW MANY OF US HAVE
HEARD AND NO WE LEGISLATE TO
THE BAD ACTORS THERE ARE A LOT
OF BAD ACTORS OUT THERE WHEN IT
COMES TO WORKERS. THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY AS A LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE IT CLEARER WORKERS NEED
JOB PROTECTIONS AB FIVE STRIKES
A FAIR BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA WORKERS
FROM BEING DENIED THE RIGHT FOR
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS HOLDING
BAD ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE ALLOWING
TRUE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
AND GOOD COMPANIES. TO STAY IN
BUSINESS MEMBERS. FOR ME
PERSONALLY I KNOW THAT WE HIT
WE HEAR ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
TALK A LOT ABOUT LABOR UNIONS
AND YOU'VE YOU'VE ALL HEARD MY
OPINION ON THAT. I RAN FOR
OFFICE FOR BILLS LIKE THIS I
RAN FOR OFFICE SO THAT WE COULD
HELP WORKERS BECAUSE WHEN
WORKERS THRIVE EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF US THRIVED AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE LIVE IN
THRIVES. STILL I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE MY COMMENTS WILL BE
VERY BRIEF BUT I WANT TO RAISE
A ISSUE OF CONCERN I WANT TO
FIRST COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT SHE'S
DONE TO GET US TO WHERE WE ARE
TONIGHT AND ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
COLLABORATED TO BRING FORTH
THIS LEGISLATION BUT IF IT'S
TRUE THAT CALIFORNIA IS THE
ENTERTAINMENT CAPITAL OF THE
WORLD I'M GONNA RAISE CONCERN
ABOUT THE MUSIC INDUSTRY TO
INDUSTRY THAT I'VE- BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH FOR THE LAST
FORTY YEARS AND JUST SHARE SOME
CONCERNS OF. MANY OF MY FRIENDS
WERE PROFESSIONAL MUSICIANS WHO
ARE NOT I'M PLOYS OF A LABEL OR
NOT EMPLOYEES OF A STUDIO AND
THEY ARE OUR A AND I KNOW THERE
WAS THE EFFORT. TO INCLUDE THEM
AND I JUST WOULD ASK THAT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WE REVISIT THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS THE LAST THING
WE WANT TO DO IS LOSE IS RICH
INDUSTRY THAT. HAS GROWN UP
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I AT AND FOR
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO MAKE A
LIVING WHETHER THEIR STUDIO
MUSICIANS ARE BACKGROUND
SINGERS. WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
WORK AT OUR FREELY AS THEY'VE
BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST. FIFTY
SIXTY YEARS SINCE THIS INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN GROWING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I JUST. ASK FOR
THAT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING FOR YOU WORKING WITH
YOU IN THAT EFFORT. SENATOR
BILL. I'M A PROUD SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL I THINK THAT. WHICH
WE DIDN'T HAVE A COURT DECISION
TO DO THIS KIND OF LEGISLATION
TO PROBABLY WOULD HAVE. HELPED
IF WE- CODE OF. GONE THROUGH IN
A VERY COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO
DISCUSS THE ISSUES AND DO A
GREAT GRAN PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT FURTHERS SO. A NEW ISSUE
THAT'S VERY THAT'S KIND OF BEEN
HANGING OVER CALIFORNIA FOR
QUITE A LONG TIME I'M I'M A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AND I'VE SEEN
CALIFORNIA CHANGE AND ONE OF
THINGS I'M MOST PROUD OF. OF
OUR STATE IS THE DIVERSITY WE
HAVE IN OUR STATE THE DIVERSITY
OF AREAS CULTURES THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD LIVING HERE
LANGUAGES AND MY DISTRICT AND
SALAS A WE HAVE TO SO MANY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES BEING
SPOKEN. IN THE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT I THINK YOU DO
WITH THAT DIVERSITY AND WITH
THAT THAT THAT THE ENVIRONMENT
I THINK WE HAVE A PROBLEM THAT
THIS BILL REALLY ADDRESSES AND
THAT IS THAT WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE CHEATED OR EXPLOITED OR
ARE NOT GETTING THEIR FAIR WAGE
AND NOT GETTING THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY SHOULD DESERVE. AND
IT SHOULD BE BASED ON. THOSE
KINDS OF STANDARDS THAT ARE
AMBIGUOUS WE SHOULD HAVE CLEAR
STANDARDS AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. THAT
THIS BILL DOES THE OTHER THE
OTHER ISSUE I WANT TO RAISE AND
I THINK IT'S BEEN RAISED BY. MY
COLLEAGUES IS TO CALIFORNIA
REALLY HAS. ONE OF THE HIGHEST
ON THE HIGHEST RATES OF POVERTY.
IN THE UNITED STATES WE HAVE A
SUCH A HIGH RATE OF POVERTY WE
HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE
LIVING. ADD POVERTY OR ABOUT TO
BE ON POVERTY. AND SO ARE WE
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE THIS ISSUE
WITH THIS BILL WE SHOULD PAY
VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
PROTECTING THEIR WAGES THEIR
BENEFITS. AND STANDING UP FOR
THOSE FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT IF
WE DON'T STAND UP FOR WILL SLIP
EVEN FURTHER AND FURTHER INTO
POVERTY. I THINK THERE'S MORE
WORK TO BE DONE ON THIS BILL
I'M SURE. IS SUCH A GRAND.
GRAND MOVEMENT I CALL IT. I
WANTED TO POINT OUT. SOME WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE ON
INDUSTRIES LIKE THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH
THIS CHAIR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I
POINT OUT A COUPLE THINGS HERE.
WE GOT A GOOD START WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION AMENDMENT I THINK
THERE'S MANY OWNER OPERATORS
STAT RUN FREIGHT SO OF HAULING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS DOING
THINGS YOU KNOW CLEANING UP OUR
COMMUNITIES THEM FIRES THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS BUILDING OUR
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS WITH SP ONE
FUNDS. SO THEY ARE THEY'RE ALSO
ON THE PHONE FOR A LOT OF THE-
NEW CLEAN AIR STANDARDS ARE
THEY THEY HAVE BORROWED MONEY
TO UPGRADE THEIR TRUCKS OR EVEN
BUY NEW TRUCKS. SO THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE IN DEBT
AT THIS POINT. AND WE ALSO
HAVE. OF COURSE THE TRUCKERS
PAY WAIT FEES SO ONE OF THINGS
ABOUT THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY IS
THE- FACT TO THEIR
PREPONDERANCE OF. FINDING OF
OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IS
REALLY UNDERNEATH. THE BUDGET
IT'S DEPENDED ON THOSE WEEK
FEES THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE COLLECT AND WE WANT TO
MAKE THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY IS
HEALTHY AS WE CAN. SO I'M
SUPPORT ARMS I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF. CONTINUING OUR
DISCUSSION. OVER THE RECESS
WITH THEM. AND I WANT TO I WANT
TO SAY THIS WE'VE ALL HAD
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES MY AND- MY
FAMILY WITH. THE NINE BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AND I HAD. WE'VE
HAD ALL THESE KINDS OF
EXPERIENCES WITH. OF OURSELVES
AND OUR FRIENDS AND HAD. UNFAIR
TREATMENT IN THE HIGH TECH
INDUSTRY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IN TERMS OF. THE WAY
WE WERE PAID AND TAKEN CARE OF.
AND I THINK THIS BILL SINCE THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. SO WE SHOULD
ALL CONSIDER THIS AS THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WE NEED TO GO AND
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE DIVERSE
POPULATION THAT WE HAVE AND I'M
WILLING TO WORK ACROSS SO I
WITH ANY OF OUR OUR COLLEAGUES
TO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION THAT
THAT IS BEING RAISED TODAY ON
THAT ISSUE. SO I HEARD SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL LET'S LET'S MOVE
AHEAD LET'S LET'S DO THIS FOR
CALIFORNIA OUR DIVERSE STATE
THAT NEEDS. THE NEEDS THIS
DIRECTION AND I OR CHEN AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO FIRST AND FOREMOST
LET ME SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GOOD SENATE HUNTER FROM CHINO
WHO SPOKE ABOUT THE YOUNG. MISS
CLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS TO
THE AUTHOR AND THE FLOOR
MANAGER AND CERTAINLY THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM CHINO WHO HAVE A
GREAT PASSION. TO PROTECT
WORKERS MY CONCERN WITH THE
BILL IS THAT IT DOES THE
OPPOSITE FOR THOSE WHO DO OR
WISH TO BE INDEPENDENT BOB DID
MISS CLASSIFIES SOME OF THOSE
WHO WERE TRULY ARE IN SHOULD BE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS NOW AS
EMPLOYEES AND THAT IS. PRETTY
HARMFUL ODD TO THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO'VE COME TO US ARE
FROM VARIOS INDUSTRIES ASKING
US TO GET AN EXEMPTION THE BILL
REALLY NEEDS MORE WORK I KNOW
THAT THEY'RE COMMITTED TO DO
THAT. IT NEEDS TO BE NARROWED
SO THAT IT PROTECTS WORKERS ARE
WHO ARE EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO
PROTECTS THAT HUGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PRODUCING SO MUCH
WHAT INCOME SO MANY JOBS ARE SO
MANY BENEFITS AND QUALITY OF
LIFE. THEY NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED TO AND BE PROVIDED
PROTECTIONS SO WE NEED MORE
WORK ON THE US AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE- FOLLOWING YEAR
WHERE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO
THAT BUT. FOR TO NIGHT SO I
WILL BE OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR BATES SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I WANTED TO. KIND OF SUMMARIZE
SOME THOUGHTS IN IN FIRST OF
ALL AGREE WITH OUR GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS. WHEN
SHE STATED THAT THE REASON THAT
WE'RE HERE TONIGHT AND IN THIS
SITUATION IS BECAUSE OF A COURT
CASE. IN THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT AND WHAT CONCERNS ME
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE CASE. AS
HAS BEEN EXPLAINED AND I AGREE
WITH THE DYNAMAX WAS ABOUT
OPERATOR ACCORDING TO THE LAW
AT THE TIME REGARDING EMPLOYEES
VERSES INDEPENDENT OPERATORS.
IN MY OPINION THE SUPREME COURT
AT THAT POINT TIME SHOULD HAVE
JUST DEALT WITH THE DYNAMAX.
ANNA JUDICATA WHAT THEIR
PENALTY AND WAS FOR THEIR-
MISGIVINGS AND THEY'RE BREAKING
OF THE LAW. BUT WHAT RISES TO A
HIGHER CONCERN FOR ME IS. HOW
BAD THIS DECISION REALLY IS.
BASED ON LAW BASED ON
APPLICATION BASED ON WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED. I'M AFRAID.
THERE AS THIS CASE IS STUDIED
IN LAW SCHOOLS AND IN TEXT
BOOKS AS WE MOVE FORWARD THIS
IS GONNA GO DOWN IN HISTORY OR
AT LEAST MODERN HISTORY IS ONE
OF THE VERY WORST DECISIONS AT%
THIS CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
HAS EVER MADE AND WE GET ON THE
BILL. AND I THINK A LOT OF US
ACTUALLY AGREE ON THAT. BUT
WHAT WE CONCERNS ME EVEN MORE
THAN THAT. IS THERE WAS A
UNANIMOUS DECISION. WE HAVE
SEVEN HIGHLY TRAINED COMPETENT
SINCE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES. THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THEM GOT THIS DECISION WRONG.
AND THE CONCERN FOR ME ON THAT
IS. WHERE IS THE FREEDOM OF
THOUGHT ON THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT. WHERE IS THE
DEBATE AMONGST OUR OUR CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT. BUT NOT
EVEN ONE DESCENDED ON THIS BAD
DECISION. THAT BRINGS US HERE
TONIGHT AND. AND I I'M ACTUALLY
LESS CRITICAL OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS PROCESS AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE AUTHOR I
THINK HAS GOOD INTENTIONS IN
THE IN THE EXEMPTIONS THAT THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO OFFER. BUT
YOU JUST CAN'T EXIT YOU THIS IS
NOT POSSIBLE. TO MANAGE AN
ENTIRE TWO TRILLION DOLLAR
ECONOMY FROM THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY IS NOT POSSIBLE. I DO HAVE
SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS ABOUT
THE ON INTENT OR MAYBE EVEN
INTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
BILL. SO IF I MAY MANTRAS I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR
GENUINE QUESTION REGARDING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE BILL. DO
YOU WISH TO TAKE A QUESTION
SENATOR TRYING YES I'M JUST
WONDERING IF IT HAD BEEN
DISCUSSED IN IN IT BECAUSE I
KNOW I WASN'T INANY THE
HEARINGS ON THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. BUT WHEN IT COMES TIME
FOR THE FOLKS THAT ARE THERE
THAT ARE NOW GOING TO BE UNDER
THIS BILL AND DON'T HAVE AN
EXEMPTION. BUT THE IRS
RECOGNIZES THEM AS A TEN NINETY
NINE OR AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR. IN ON APRIL
FIFTEENTH WHEN IT COMES TIME
FOR THEM TO DO THEIR TAXES HOW
ARE THEY GONNA RECONCILE STATE
LAW. THAT SAYS THAT THEY'RE
THAT THEY'RE AN EMPLOYEE AND
FEDERAL LAW THAT SAYS IF
THEY'RE AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR. OKAY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WHAT WILL
BE BY USED IS WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S A TEN NINETY NINE OR W.
TO FORM. THAT WILL BE THE
DETERMINING FACTOR OKAY BYE
PROCEED THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT WHICH OF COURSE IS
SOMEWHAT CONTROLLED BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE ON THAT WHICH
I'M ASSUMING IS COMING UNDER
THE THIS BILL. A COUPLE MEMBERS
HAVE A SHARED HOW THIS IMPACTS
THEM. PERSONALLY LET ME SHARE
HOW IT IMPACTS ME PERSONALLY. I
HAVE A REAL ESTATE LICENSE. SO
I'VE WORKED FOREVER IS A TEN
NINETY NINE. THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR GOOD NEWS FOR ME I'M
EXEMPTED. MY WIFE RUNS TWO
BUSINESSES SHE RUNS A. HOME
HOME INTERIOR DECORATING
BUSINESS AND SHE RUNS A. HEALTH
FOOD GROCERY BROKERAGE BUSINESS
WITH HER FATHER IN LAW. NO I
THINK I'VE PRETTY MUCH GOT IT
FIGURED OUT THAT ON HER
INTERIOR DECORATING BUSINESS
YEAH SHE MEETS THE A. B. C.
TEST BUT ON THE BUSINESS THAT
SHE RUNS WITH HER FATHER IN LAW
AS FAR AS BROKERAGE TO GROCERY
STORES. HEALTH WOOD GROCERY
STORES I MIGHT ADD. THAT THE
BUSINESS IS BASED IN ARIZONA.
SHE WORKS IN CALIFORNIA. THEY
CONTRACT WITH MULTIPLE
COMPANIES AROUND NOT IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA COLORADO
NEW YORK MULTIPLE COMPANIES
THAT ARE HEADQUARTERED ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY IN AND ACTUALLY THE
GLOW. WHEN IT COMES TIME FOR MY
WIFE AND I TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO OUR TAXES IN APRIL FIFTH ON
APRIL FIFTEENTH I APPRECIATE
THE EXPLANATION BUT AM VERY
FEARFUL THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE A STRAIGHTFORWARD AS ALL OF
THAT. BECAUSE SOME OF THESE
COME MOST OF THE COMPANIES THAT
SHE CONTRACTS FOR AREN'T IN
CALIFORNIA. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS HERE TO
TRY TO CONTROL A TWO TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMY. FROM THE FROM
THESE HALLS I THINK IT'S AN
AMBITIOUS GOAL. BUT WE JUST
CAN'T DO IT IS NOT POSSIBLE AND
I'D ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON AB
FIVE AND LET'S TAKE THE TIME TO
GET THIS RIGHT AND SEND IS IF
WE HAVE TO SEND STUFF BACK. TO
THE COURTS LET'S DO THAT. ANY
FURTHER DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
SENATOR GALGIANI. THANK YOU I
RISE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
BUT IT'S AFTER MUCH ANGST AND
THE AUTHOR KNOWS THAT I'VE HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH HER
ABOUT CONCERNS FROM SMALL
TRUCKERS IN MY DISTRICT THESE
ARE THE LETTERS THAT I HAVE
RECEIVED FROM INDIVIDUALS FROM
MY DISTRICT OVER TIME THIS THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ARE NOT THE SAME
ISSUES THAT THAT YOU EXPERIENCE
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LA
POURED IN THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH. AND WE HAVE MANY
TRUCKERS THAT WORK FOR OTHER
COMPANIES WHO STARTED SMALL ALL
THIS TALK ABOUT MISTER ALL
NUNES FROM MY DISTRICT TOO MANY
MANY YEARS AGO BOUGHT HIS FIRST
TRACK AND HE'S WORKED HARD AND
HE SAVED IN THE BOTTOM THE
OTHER TRUCK AND TODAY HE'S
CLOSE TO RETIREMENT HE HAS
THIRTY TRUCKS OF HIS OWN AND
WHEN IT'S TIME WHERE THAT WHEN
THE AG SEASON IS FLOWING AND
THINGS ARE GOING HE NEEDS TO
HIRE. ADDITIONAL TRUCKERS FOR A
SMALL PERIOD OF TIME HE'S ABLE
TO DO THAT AND MY FORMER
NEIGHBOR AND MERCED COUNTY
WORKED VERY VERY HARD TO BUY A
TRUCK USED TO BRING HIS TRUCK
COMMON PARK IT IN THE DRIVEWAY
NEXT TO MY HOME AND HE HE
DREAMS LIKE MANY OF OUR
DREAMERS OF GROWING AND WORKING
HARD TO START IS BUSINESS AND
BE ABLE TO HIRE SOMEBODY SOME
DAY AND BE LIKE SOME OF THE
OTHERS THAT HAVE GROWN INTO A
BUSINESS. I'VE WORRIED ABOUT
HAVING AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE
ONLY INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN ENTER
THE PIPELINE OF THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY WOULD BE EITHER
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY TO BUY A LOT OF TRUCKS
AND START A BUSINESS OR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD INHERIT.
A BUSINESS FROM THEIR PARENTS.
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS WORKED
HARD. SO I WAS PREPARED TO KNOW
TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL TODAY
FOR THAT REASON AND SOME OTHERS
BUT IN TALKING TO THE AUTHOR
AND TALKING TO BUILDING TRADES
AND TO THE LABOR FEDERATION I
RECOGNIZE THAT IN SPITE OF ALL
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE THAT
THE TIME HASN'T ALLOWED FOR
EVERYTHING TO BE ADDRESSED BUT-
THERE IS A WILLINGNESS TO KEEP
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE AND A
RECOGNITION. THAT IT ISN'T
PERFECT AND THAT WE WILL HAVE
TO KEEP WORKING ON IT AND IT'S
EASY TO ALWAYS FIND FAULT WITH
THINGS AND I'VE DONE THAT THIS
WHOLE TIME THAT WE'VE HAD THE
CONVERSATION I WISH TO SAY THE
TO THE AUTHOR TODAY THAT I
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE AND I RECOGNIZE THAT
THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS IN THE LABORS TRYING
TO ADDRESS TO. YOU KNOW HELP
THE WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN
CHEATED WHO HAVE BEEN CHEATED
OUT OFWAGES WHO HAVE BEEN
UNDER DEPLORABLE WORKING
CONDITIONS I RECOGNIZE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I
APPLAUD THAT I RESPECT THAT I
ALSO THANK YOU AND RESPECT YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH MYSELF AND OTHERS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE AN ENVIRONMENT THAT
ALLOWS THOSE WHO COME HERE TO
THAT WANT THE AMERICAN DREAM TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. AND THAT WE
HAVE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE'RE
WE'RE PROMOTING JOB CREATORS
THAT START SMALL WORK HARD LIKE
OUR PARENTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
DID AND ONE DAY THEY THEN CAN
HIRE OTHERS WHO CAN WORK FOR
THEM AND THEY WILL TREAT THEM
WELL UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF AB
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PRO
TEM ATKINS THANK YOU I'LL BE
VERY QUICK MADAM PRESIDENT
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS BEEN A MOST
INTERESTING DISCUSSION TONIGHT.
IT'S GONNA DIRECTIONS I
ABSOLUTELY NEVER ANTICIPATED. I
DO HAVE TO SAY. I'M CONVINCED
OF ONE THING I'M VERY GLAD THAT
THE SPEAKER AND I DECIDED LAST
YEAR NOT TO TAKE THIS UP AT THE
END OF SESSION. BECAUSE WE'VE
HAD AN ENTIRE LEGISLATIVE YEAR
TO DO THIS WORK. AND YET HERE
WE ARE TONIGHT WITH THIS AGAIN
I WILL SAY INTERESTING
CONVERSATION PEOPLE RAISE SOME
REALLY GOOD POINTS DURING THE
DISCUSSION AND I KNOW. THAT
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN
WORKING THROUGH THIS PROCESS
HAVE HEARD THOSE POINTS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO HEAR. AND
THERE IS MORE WORK TO BE DONE
BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY YEARS
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE BEFORE WE
BRING SOMETHING FORWARD THAT
ACTUALLY TRIES TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS. OF THE-
CATEGORIES OF WORKERS THAT WE
SHOULD ADDRESS. I'VE LEARNED A
FEW THINGS IN THIS PROCESS
BECAUSE WE ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO HAVE SOME INCREDIBLE STAFF.
BACK HERE WHO'VE BEEN AGAINST
THE WALL ALL NIGHT WHO EVERY
TIME I'VE HAD A QUESTION ABOUT
ANY CATEGORY I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HAVE THEM COME IN AND EXPLAIN
TO ME. THE ISSUES AND CONCERNS
AROUND THE BRELO CASE THAT LED
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY IN THE
CONFUSION AND THE DISAGREEMENTS
I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY AS ARE A
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
BUT I ANNOUNCED TO UNDERSTAND
IS THAT THE COURT CASE THERE
ARE THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT WE ARE ONE. AND THE
UPREME COURT HAS THE ABILITY
TO ADJUDICATE. I IN AN ATTEMPT
TO ADDRESS ISSUES AND BRING
ABOUT FAIRNESS. OF THE AUTHOR
DIDN'T HAVE TO TAKE ON ANY OF
THIS WE COULD HAVE JUST LEFT IT
AS IT WAS. AND THEN THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE. CONCERNED THE MINUTE
THE CASE CAME DOWN. THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
ALL THOSE BUSINESSES WE TALK
ABOUT SUPPORTING. GOING TO SAY
DOES THIS APPLY TO ME WE NEED
CLARITY WE NEED THE ABILITY TO
HELP CATEGORIES OF WORKERS
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY FIT INTO
THIS AND I AM JUST GOING TO SAY
I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTIONS I'VE
HAD MANY. AND I'VE WATCHED IT
AS THIS HAS PROCEEDED THIS YEAR
AND I'M JUST GONNA SAY THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU TO
THE STAKEHOLDERS ALL OF THEM
WHO ENGAGED NOT JUST FOR A WEEK
OR TWO BUT THROUGHOUT THIS LONG
LEGISLATIVE YEAR. AND LABOR.
ABSOLUTELY THE CHAMBER. ARE IT
IS THE JOB OF LABOR TO LOOK OUT
FOR WORKERS. HI IT IS THE JOB
OF BUSINESS. LIKE THE CHAMBER
TO LOOK OUT FOR CATEGORIES OF
BUSINESSES AND IF WE DID ENGAGE
IN THAT CONVERSATION. THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS IN LAWS THAT WE
WOULD NOT HAVE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT WORKERS IN BUSINESSES.
WE ARE PAID TO DO THIS
COMPLICATED WORKING TO FIGURE
IT OUT AND ARGUE AND DEBATE.
AND NEGOTIATE AND COMPROMISE
AND COME TO SOME. MEANINGFUL
SOLUTIONS FOR CATEGORIES OF
WORKERS AND WE'VE TRIED TO DO
THAT AND WE DID NOT. GET TO
EVALUATE EVERY CATEGORY OF
WORKER AND MANY OF US HAVE
PLEDGED TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION I DON'T KNOW WHAT
KIND OF COMPREHENSIVE PROCESS
WE WOULD ANTICIPATE DOING.
BECAUSE IT IT WAS FOUND TO BE
WAY MORE COMPLEX THAN I THINK
ANY OF US IMAGINED. SO OF THE
OF THE STORIES THAT CAME OUT
TONIGHT THAT WE'RE GONNA. PUT
INTO THE PROCESS OF DISCUSSION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS WHICH IS WHAT
WE SHOULD DO. THE STAKEHOLDERS
THE TENSION THE DISCUSSION
MAKES HAS COME FORWARD WITH A
BETTER PROCESS. AND SO I WILL
JUST THANK THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
REALLY DUG IN. AND MADE A
COMMITMENT MADE A COMMITMENT TO
SEE THIS THROUGH AND I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO
AND I KNOW THAT PEOPLE WOULD
LIKE IT TO BE A DIFFERENT KIND
OF PROCESS. BUT YOU KNOW IN THE
WORDS OF JOHN F. KENNEDY THERE
ARE NO WISE MEN HERE THERE'S US.
THERE'S JUST US. AND I THINK WE
DO A PRETTY DARN GOOD JOB. EVEN
WHEN WE DISAGREE AND WITH THAT
YOU KNOW AGAIN APPRECIATE ALL
OF THE CONVERSATIONS THEN
COMMIT YOURSELF TO GET ENGAGED
TO BE PART OF THE DISCUSSIONS
ON THE STAKEHOLDER WORK. SO
THAT MAYBE WE CAN DO IN EVEN
BETTER JOB. GOING INTO NEXT
YEAR BUT I IN AND- OUT WHERE I
STARTED WITH A THANK YOU TO THE
INCREDIBLE STAFF THAT HAVE
WORKED ON THIS. TO ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
INVESTED AND TO THE AUTHOR. AND
THE- FLOOR MANAGER. OF FOR
WALKING US THROUGH THIS IS CNN
MEMBERS I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS SEEING
NO FURTHER MIKE'S UP SENATOR
DRAWS SO. DO YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WELL I HAVE I WROTE A LOT OF
NOTES FROM DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WERE SAID AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH EACH ONE.
YOU BEAT ME TO WHAT I WAS GONNA
SAY MADAM PRESIDENT. BUT I DO I
DO HAVE THE SIX A COUPLE OF
THINGS VIEW BEAR WITH ME. THE
SOMEONE SAID IN THEIR REMARKS
THAT. SOME OF THESE. MEN AND
WOMEN THAT HE KNOWS ALL THEY
WANTED WAS THE CHANCE TO MAKE A
FEW EXTRA BUCKS TO PUT TO FEED
THEIR KIDS. AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY SUMS UP WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT. IS THE ABILITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE ABLE TO
RAISE A FAMILY. IN A WAY THAT
AND JOB SHOULD BE ENOUGH. AND I
LOVE THAT BECAUSE- ONE JOBS
SHOULD BE ENOUGH. IT SHOULD NOT
TAKE TWO THREE OR FOUR JOBS AND
WE SHOULD HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT
PROVIDES FOR THAT. AND YES
EVERYBODY WILL STILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY NOBODY'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL PREVENT SOMEONE FROM
STARTING THEIR OWN COMPANY
WHICH I THINK IS TO BE
APPLAUDED INCLUDING THE A TRUCK
DRIVER. SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS I THINK
THE COURTSMADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT. THEY'RE PRETTY FED UP
WITH THE BAD ACTORS IN THE
ECONOMY AND THEY WANTED CLARITY
FOR EVERYBODY. SO LET'S. SPECT
AND APPRECIATE THAT. WORKERS
YES ORGANIZED WORKERS.
FIREFIGHTERS AND CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS THE JANITORS ALL CAME
TOGETHER IN THIS PROCESS WITH
BUSINESSES AND THE STATE. AND
CAME UP WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE
I THINK VERY GOOD PROPOSAL FOR
US. AND IT DOESN'T ADDRESSED
EVERY ISSUE BUT KNOWING THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS I DO. AND
WITH THE LEADERSHIP IN THIS
HOUSE OF OUR PRO TEM I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS LEGITIMATE. CONCERNS SO
WITH THAT THIS DESERVE BROTHERS
ONE JOB SHOULD BE ENOUGH I ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. ALL DEBATE HAVING ACTUALLY
SEE STE. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BELL BY BURGESS NO BRADFORD
HI CAMBIADO HI CHIANG NO DELHI
NO DODD AYE DURAZO I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
BY OUR TITLE BY JACKSON HI I
JONES. NO LABOR I AM ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. MORE LUCK.
NO MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER. OUR CASKEY I WINNER
BY WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MONNING. MONNING
AYE AYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES. WE WILL NOW LIFT
THE CALLS ON THOSE ITEMS. THAT
ARE BEFORE US. STARTING.
STARTING WITH FILE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY NINE. AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN.
COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION WE ARE LIFTING
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM. ONE
THIRTY NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HI ARCHIE LETTER AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. NO WE'RE JUST.
BRADFORD CHIANG. DALLY DOT I
JOHNNY GLAZER. HERTZBERG. HI
HILL AYE HUESO. MURTADA MORE
LOCKED. PAN I PORTANTINO BY
ROTH. RUBIO NUMBER. BY CASKEY I
WILK. WILK AYE. PLEASE GOD
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. BURGESS. BY
BRADFORD BY CHIANG ARI DALLY.
GALGIANI. GLAZER HI WITH SO
TADO. MORE LOCK ROTH. RUBIO.
NUMBER I'M A GUY OUR EYES
TWENTY SEVEN NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON NOW STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM OF ONE OH THREE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BY
GROWTH. TADO. VICE THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BY BATES NO PURCHASE. DOLLY
GROVE. NO TADO HI MITCHELL.
MORRELL. JULY MORE LOCK NO. FOR
JUST NO FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS
SHAPE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE OH SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BY
BURGESS. BY GROWTH. BY TADO BY
VICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BY BURGESS NO CHIANG.
GROVE NO TACO. ROTH BROTHER HER
DAUGHTER BY WEISS THIRTY KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI
GROW. TADO. GROVE I OR TITLE
AYE NIELSEN HI. VICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN. ATKINS I
CABALLERO. BY DAILY. NO
GALGIANI. GLAZER. NO GROWTH NO
TADO. NO RUBIO. BY CASKEY HI.
GALGIANI NO RUBIO RUBIO. HI.
CABALLERO I DON'T KNOW VICE
TWENTY SIX KNOWS FOURTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS HI BATES BY
BURGESS. GALGIANI OUR AYE GROVE.
TADO HI JONES. MORE LOCK BY
WHAT CASKEY BY VICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY.
ATKINS HI GALGIANI. HI GROW BY
TADO BY Y. CASKEY HI ICE FORTY
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI BILL
HI GROWTH. I TADO BY MORE LOCK
BY WHAT CASKEY HI ICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD.
GLAZER NO JONES. MORE LOCK NO
NIELSEN NO NUMBER. KNOW WHAT
CASKEY HI JONES NO ICE TWENTY
SIX NOS THIRTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
FOUR EXCUSE ME ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. BY ATKINS I GROWTH. BY
JONES BY NIELSEN BY WHAT COUNTY
BY OUR EYES FORTY KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI
CHIANG. DORADO CHANG I DORADO
AYE MITCHELL. HI RUBIO. BY ICE
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HI JACKSON. RUBIO. VICE
THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO AYE AYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE FORTY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROWTH NO MITCHELL. MORE LOCK
JULY. WARLOCK NIELSEN YES NO.
MARCH THIRTY ONE KNOWS SHAPE
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG. BY
GROWTH HI TADO. BY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL I RUBIO HI GUYS FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
GORGEOUS. NO JANE. THERE ARE NO
DORADO. BY GROWTH NO TADO BY
MITCHELL. HI MORE LOCK. MORRELL.
VICE THIRTY ONE NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROWTH BY HER
TADO. HI MITCHELL. BY RUBIO HI
WHAT CASKEY. HI ICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM OF ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROWTH.
BY TADO I MITCHELL I WORK OUT
SKI. HI ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HER TITLE. HI
MITCHELL HI GUYS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD. BY
GROWTH I MITCHELL. HI ICE FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES NO
BURGESS NO GROWTH NO MITCHELL
HI EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN ON THE URGENCY ICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN ON THE
MEASURE FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CHIANG. HI JACKSON HI
HI ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. YES ATKINS HI
GLAZER. HI JACKSON AYE AYE AYES
FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA. I ATKINS BY
JACKSON I BY IN WHAT COUNTY.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES PURCHASE
NO JACKSON I BY MERRELL. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI BATES.
BURGESS. BY CHIANG BY DAILY I
DODD. OUR GROWTH BY NIELSEN. BY
SKINNER. BATES I. SKINNER I.
OUR EYES FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. HI
CHIANG BY HERTZBERG. HI
HERTZBERG RIGHT. ICE FORTY
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
SO I BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES ALL
THE ITEMS THAT WERE ON CALL.
GOING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MEMBERS IS A RESOLUTION OF THE
DESKS REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE
ENJOY A RULE SIXTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING THE
FOLLOWING ASSEMBLY MEASURE A.
B. TWELVE NINETY NINE TO BE
HEARD IN REPORTED BY COMMITTEE
IN AGAIN. THESE REQUESTED
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THEM SECTOR EXCUSE ME MISTER
SECRETARY. HE'S READ THE
RESOLUTION RESULT THE JOINT
RULE SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY TO BE
DISPENSED WITH TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE TO BE HEARD AND REPORTED
AFTER THE DEADLINES AS
REQUESTED. IS THERE OBJECTION.
WE DO HAVE TO CALL THE ROLL
HOWEVER. TRY SENATOR ROOT
GROWTH THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL BY BURGESS NO BRADFORD AYE
COVER GYRO I CHIANG. DALY NO
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. BY
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON HI I JONES.
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MORNING I'M MORE LOCK. NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. OUR CASKEY. BY WINNER
I WILK. HIGHS THIRTY NO SIX THE
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
WITH. HI WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WILL BE PLACED
ON TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEMS. NINE TEN
TWELVE FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE THIRT
353-637-3830. NINE FORTY FORTY
ONE FORTY THREE FORTY FOUR
FORTY SIX FORTY EIGHT FIFTY.
AND FIFTY TWO AS WELL AS FILE
ITEMS FIFTY EIGHT AND FIFTY
NINE. COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE UP THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THIS POINT IN TIME
YES THE SECRETARY TO PLEASE
READ THE BILLS SENATE BILL.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE ONE THIRTY SEVEN ONE
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR TO TWE FOUR SIXTY
FOUR FIVE A THREE FIVE NINETEEN
FIVE EIGHTY THREE. SEVEN A SIX
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NON ICE FORTY
KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED. SENATOR ATKINS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. SENATOR ALL I'M
SORRY I'M TERRIBLY SORRY I KNEW
THAT THERE WAS TOO GOOD TO BE
TRUE CENTER LABOR FOR WHAT
PURPOSE I'VE BEEN TRANSIT SHE
FIRST ANNOUNCED MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IF IT WOULD BE
YES OKAY I WOULD LIKE WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN RESOLUTION AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE AB
FIVE TWENTY NINE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. IT WILL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
UNDER ANNOUNCEMENTS I'D LIKE TO
LET THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
KNOW THAT WE WILL NOT BE
MEETING TONIGHT EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. GO HOME AND GET SOME
REST. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MEET
WILL MEET TOMORROW AT NINE
THIRTY AM IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NINE THIRTY TOMORROW PUBLIC
SAFETY ROOM TWENTY FORTY THANK
YOU WHETHER ANY OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SEEING NONE.
MADAM PRO TEM THE DESK IS
INDEED CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WE HAVE. COVERED
ALMOST A HUNDRED AND SWELL
HUNDRED SEVEN BILLS TONIGHT
EIGHTY TWO ASSEMBLY BILLS AND
TWENTY FIVE SENATE BLLS SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE HARD
WORK TODAY WE WILL SEE YOU
TOMORROW MORNING SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH AT TEN AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE SENATE IS IN
RECESS. EXCUSE ME WE ARE
ADJOURNED WE WILL SEE YOU
TOMORROW AT TEN AM